WHEN I START OUT WITH AN APOLOGY
IS KEEPING ALL OF YOU WAITING
THANK YOU SO MUCH?
MANY VIEW TRAVEL FAR AND WIDE TO
BE ABLE TO BE HERE IN A VARIETY
OF SUBJECTS THAT ARE IN FRONT OF
THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
WE WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT SAY
THANK YOU. FOR TAKING TIME OUT
YOUR BUSY SCHEDULE TO HAVE YOUR
VOICE HEARD TODAY.
I AND WE ALSO WANT TO FORMALLY
WELCOME IN THE CAN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE.
BEFORE WE GET INTO SOME OF THE
HOUSEKEEPING WE LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM MISS LANE
CHESTER ROLL CALL PLEASE.
WATER HERE WHERE PRESENT MORE A
LOT.
MORE LIKE PRESIDENT BELL.
THE PRESIDENT.
PRESIDENT RICARDO.
NIELSEN WIENER [inaudible]
BUT MASON GENTLEMAN A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED.
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GO
THROUGH SOME HOUSEKEEPING FOR
TODAY.
AND THEN WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
GO THROUGH OUR SPECIAL ORDER
HEARING.
HE'S IN JAIL AND WE ARE GOING TO
BE KICKING OFFER SPECIAL ORDER
HEARING IN JUST A MOMENT.
CAN BE FOCUSING ON TWO SUBJECTS
SB FIFTY AS WELL AS AS BEFORE.
TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR THERE
ARE NINE ITEMS.
I'D LIKE TO GO THROUGH THEM AND
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE A MOTION TO BE ABLE TO
APPROVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AFTER I READ OFF THE FOLLOWING
BILLS.
ITEM SIX SB.
NINETY NINE ITEM ELEVEN SB THREE
TWENTY FOUR ITEM TWELVE SB THREE
FORTY FOUR ITEMS SIXTEEN SB.
FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN ITEM
SEVENTEEN SB.
SIX THIRTY AT ITEM TWENTY TWO SB
SEVEN EIGHTY ITEM TWENTY THREE
SB SEVEN EIGHTY NINE ITEM TWENTY
FOUR SB SEVEN NINETY NINE TWENTY
FIVE SB.
SEVEN NINETY ONE WE HAVE A
MOTION BY THE VICE CHAIR.
MS LANE CHESTER ROLL CALL PLEASE.
WIRE HIGH WIRE I'M MORE A LOT
MORE LUCK I BELT.
WELL I HERTZBERG.
IT'S REGARDING HER CONDO NIELSEN
WIENER.
WIENER HI.
FIVE EARLY ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO
VOTE MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN TO BE ABLE TO ADD
ON MEMBERS AS THEY COME THROUGH.
I AND WE DO HAVE A BUSY DAY
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL WE DO
HAVE MEMBERS WERE TESTIFYING
IMPRISONING BILLS AND OTHER
HEARINGS AND THEY'LL BE COMING
IN AND OUT OF TODAY.
AT TODAY'S HEARING FIND THE
LATEST IN GERMAN WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO TALK ABOUT.
BILLS FOR MAY FIRST.
AS WE WERE DOING OUR PRE MEETING
MISS LANCHESTER SAID REPAIR TO
BRING YOUR PAJAMAS -- AS WE HAVE
TWENTY THREE TO TWENTY FIVE
BILLS THAT WILL BE ON OUR
CALENDAR BUT NEXT WEDNESDAY.
MANY THESE BILLS ARE SIGNIFICANT
I IN PLEASE PLAN ON BEING IN
COMMITTEE BETWEEN SEVEN AND NINE
HOURS -- IT NEXT WEDNESDAY AS I
SEVERAL MEDIA BILLS WILL BE IN
FRONT OF US.
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN AGAIN WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO BE A TO BE WITH US.
I WOULD LIKE TO BE REMOVED NOW
INTO OUR SPECIAL ORDER HEARING
AND WE LIKE TO BE A WELCOME --
IT SENATOR WIENER TO BE A
PRESENT ON SB.
FIFTY CENTER WINNER AND I HAVE
BEEN -- IN CONVERSATIONS IN
NEGOTIATING ON SP FOUR IN SB
FIFTY APPROACHING THREE MONTHS
NOW.
AND I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO SENATOR WIENER.
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
CONVERSATION IN COLLABORATION
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE -- TO
HAVE OVER THESE PAST NINETY DAYS.
AND LAYS IN GERMAN WE WILL
OUTLINE THIS IN JUST A MOMENT
BUT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO REACH AN
AGREEMENT.
THAT WILL ADVANCE SOLUTIONS TO
ONE OF OUR STATES TOUGHEST
CHALLENGES THAT'S ON HOUSING IS
WELL AS AN ISSUE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
WOULD LIKE TO BETTER TALK ABOUT
THE ORDER TALK ABOUT THE ORDER
OF THIS SPECIAL HEARING.
NUMBER ONE WE'RE GONNA BE
TURNING IT OVER TO SENATOR
WIENER TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT ON
SB.
FIFTY FOCUSING ON COUNTIES OF
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND POPULATION.
AND ABOVE.
I'M THEN GOING TO BE PRESENTING
ON POPULATIONS SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND BELOW -- BELL WILL
THEN BE PRESENTING A SENATOR
BELL.
IS A CO AUTHOR JOINT AUTHORS
SHOULD SAY ON SENATE BILL FOR
NOW WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO SENATOR BAIL FOR
ALL THIS WORK ON TO SIGNIFICANT
BILLS THAT ARE MOVING -- SENATE
BILL FOUR AS WELL SENATE BILL.
FIVE AFTER WE HEAR THE
PRESENTATION FROM SENATOR WIENER.
MYSELF AND SENATOR BELL.
AND BEFORE WE GET INTO TESTIMONY.
WE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO READ OUT
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN FRONT
OF THE COMMITTEE HERE TODAY.
IN ADDITION AMENDMENTS WILL
START BEING PASSED OUT NOW TO
THE COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT SO THAT THE COMMITTEE
HAS THEM IN FRONT AND AGAIN I
WILL BE.
VERBALLY READING THE AMENDMENTS
PRIOR TO GOING TO SUPPORT
TESTIMONY TODAY SO THAT EVERYONE
HAS THEM.
AND WE BE A HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE AS
WE ADVANCE.
THE LADIES AND GENTLEMAN WITH
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO WOULD LIKE
TO BETTER TURN IT OVER TO CENTER
WIENER AND I'LL BRING YOU A COPY
OF THOSE AMENDMENTS AS WELL
MISTER SENATOR.
I CENTER WIENER YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR I AND WE WELCOME YOUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND THEN
SENATOR BELL AND I ARE GOING TO
JOIN YOU AT THE TABLE AND THEN
RETURN THE GAVEL OVER. TO BUY
CHAIR MORLOCK
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN I I JUST WANT TO
PERSONALLY THANK YOU AND ALSO --
CENTER BELL. FOR WORKING --
INTENSIVELY WITH ME AND WITH MY
STAFF FOR A PERIOD OF MONTHS
[inaudible]
A RESOLUTION SO THAT WE CAN ALL.
MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER -- ON SB
FIFTY ON MY THANK YOU -- FOR FOR
WORKING WITH US AND I THINK WE
HAVE A VERY VERY STRONG.
AGREEMENT ON SB -- FIFTY THAT
WILL HELP ADDRESS OF THE DEEP
HOUSING CRISIS THAT CALIFORNIA
FACES -- I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WE TALK ABOUT WE HEAR
ABOUT THE HOUSING CRISIS A LOT.
IS.
WE KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A
HOUSING SHORTAGE OF THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION HOMES. TO PUT THAT
IN CONTEXT I THAT IS EQUAL TO
THE HOUSING DEFICIT OF THE OTHER
FORTY NINE STATES COMBINED.
SO FOR THE ENTIRE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA THE ENTIRE HOUSING
SHORTAGE IN THIS COUNTRY ONE
HALF OF IT IS IN ONE STATE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
CALIFORNIA RANKS NUMBER FORTY
NINE OUT OF FIFTY STATES IN
HOMES PER CAPITA. FORTY NINE OUT
OF FIFTY STATES HOMES PER CAPITA
THAT'S CALIFORNIA -- IT AND IF
ANYONE HAD ANY -- WONDER AS TO
WHY PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE
HEREANYMORE.
WE TALK ABOUT A LOT OF TECHNICAL.
STUFF AROUND HOUSING IN THIS
BILL IT'S ABOUT ZONING WE TALK
ABOUT STREAMLINING WE TALK ABOUT --
SEQUEL -- TECHNICAL TERMS WHICH
ARE ALL VERY IMPORTANT -- BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO FOCUS ON
PEOPLE BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE THE
ONES WHO ARE AFFECTED.
BY CALIFORNIA'S ABYSMAL FAILURE.
TO PRODUCE ENOUGH HOUSING OVER
THE PAST NUMBER OF DECADES.
WE USED TO PRODUCE IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN SIXTIES 200-500-0023
HUNDRED THOUSAND UNITS OF
HOUSING PER YEAR IN CALIFORNIA
AT A TIME WHEN WE HAD A
POPULATION OF FIFTEEN MILLION
PEOPLE.
WE NOW HAVE ALMOST THREE TIMES A
POPULATION FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
AND GROWING.
AND INSTEAD OF PRODUCING TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY TO THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND UNITS PER YEAR RIGHT
NOW PRODUCING. EIGHTY TO A
HUNDRED THOUSAND UNITS WITH GONE
DOWN BY ABOUT TWO THIRDS AS OUR
POPULATION.
TRIPLED.
AND REAL PEOPLE ARE HURTING
RIGHT NOW -- IN CALIFORNIA WE
SEE THE HOMELESSNESS IN OUR
STATE WHICH IS GROWING AT
ALTHOUGH MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDICTION ARE PARTS OF THE
HOMELESS SUBATOMIC.
MANY MANY HOMELESS PEOPLE ARE
NOT MENTALLY ILL ARE NOT
ADDICTED THEY JUST CAN'T AFFORD
HOUSING AS OF THEIR SLEEPING IN
SHELTERS OR IN THEIR CARS OR CAL
SURFING.
CULTURE BRING ONE IN -- TWENTY
SCHOOL CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
ONE IN TWENTY IS HOMELESS.
EVERYONE KNOWS A FAMILY OR MANY
FAMILIES WHO HAVE MOVED AWAY.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO
LIVE HERE THEY HAD THAT SECOND
KID AND THEY NEEDED MORE SPACE
AND THERE WAS NOTHING IN THE
COMMUNITY. FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
TO AFFORD AND SO THEY ARE NOW
COMMUTING TO OURS OR MAYBE
THEY'RE LIVING IN DENVER OR
AUSTIN.
ARE WE ARE METHODICALLY PUSHING
THE MIDDLE CLASS OUT OF MANY
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
MAKING A PROGRESSIVELY HARDER.
FOR WORKING FAMILIES TO BE ABLE
TO SURVIVE AND THRIVE.
AND WE ARE MAKING IT DIFFICULT
OR IMPOSSIBLE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
TO BE ABLE TO GET A FOOTHOLD IN
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
ABOUT BASIC BUILDING BLOCK OF
HAVING STABLE HOUSING.
YOUNG PEOPLE OFTEN DON'T SEE
WHAT THEIR FUTURE IS AND OUR
COMMUNITY AND HOW MANY PEOPLE
HAVE COMMENTED I REALLY WISH
THAT MY KID COULD MOVE BACK HOME
AFTER COLLEGE BUT UNLESS YOU'RE
GOING TO LIVE IN MY BASEMENT --
THERE'S NO WAY THEY'RE EVER
GOING TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD IN
THE TOWN IN WHICH I GREW UP. TO
THIS IT IS THESE OF HUMAN
CONSEQUENCES.
OF OUR FRANKLY DELIBERATE
FAILURE TO BUILD ENOUGH HOUSING
WITH ADOPTED WHAT I CALL HOUSING
LAST POLICY IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
WE'VE EFFECTIVELY SIDE -- THAT
IT IS NOT A PRIORITY TO HAVE
ENOUGH HOUSING FOR EVERYONE.
BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS -- THAT WE
KNOW WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO TURN
THIS AROUND AND THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK HAPPENING IN THE
LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR -- TO
INCREASE PRODUCTION OF HOUSING.
AT ALL INCOME LEVELS HI
INCLUDING SUBSIDIZED HOUSING FOR
LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND TO FIND IT.
HOW TO PROTECT OU TENANTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE CAN
ACTUALLY STAY -- IN THE HOMES --
THAT THEY HAVE.
WE KNOW WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS WE NEED TO
DO AND THERE IS NO SILVER BULLET
NO ONE BILL OR OR NO ONE ISSUE
IS GOING TO FIX OUR HOUSING
CRISIS BUT ONE BUILDING BLOCK A
FOUNDATIONAL BUILDING BLOCK.
OR ON HOUSING ZONING -- BECAUSE
CAN HAVE ALL THE FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE WORLD
ALL THE STREAMLINING IN THE
WORLD BUT IF IT'S IF IT'S
ILLEGAL TO BUILD THE HOUSING
BECAUSE OF ZONING.
THAT IT'S ALL FOR NAUGHT.
AND THE REALITY IS THAT IN 80%
OF CALIFORNIA.
IT IS ILLEGAL. TO BUILD ANYTHING
OTHER THAN A SINGLE FAMILY HOME --
IT'S TRUE IN 70% OF SAN
pFRANCISCO TO LEGAL BUILD
ANYTHING OTHER THAN A SINGLE
FAMILY HOME OR TO UNIT SAME WITH
LOS ANGELES.
AND IT'S NOT SUSTAINABLE IF
WE'RE GOING TO FILL THAT THREE
AND A HALF MILLION HOME --
DEFICIT.
THE QUESTION IS WHERE ARE WE
GOING TO BUILD THAT HOUSING --
AND I BELIEVE WE SHOULD BILL
THAT HOUSING WHERE THE JOBS ARE.
WHERE THERE'S TRANSIT AND TRY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE DOING A
AND A VERY SUSTAINABLE WAY AND
THAT'S WHAT SB FIFTY WILL ALLOW
US TO DO -- THIS BILL -- WILL
ALLOW FOR INCREASED DENSITY IN
JOB RICH AREAS NEAR PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
AND THEN LATER DENSITY INCREASES
ELSEWHERE. TO FILL THAT THREE
AND A HALF MILLION HOME --
DEFICIT -- UNDER THE AMENDMENTS
SO WE ARE AGREEING TO WITH THE
CHAIR -- TODAY -- FOR COUNTIES
OVER SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE --
THE AT THE EXISTING SB FIFTY
RAIL AND FERRY PROVISIONS WILL
SANTA FACT.
OF THE JOB RICH PROVISIONS WILL
STAY IN EFFECT ON CHANGE -- AND
FOR BEHIND THE BUS STOP
PROVISIONS WILL STAY IN EFFECT
EXCEPT WE WILL REQUIRE --
INCREASED FREQUENCY HAD WAYS
DURING RUSH HOUR OF EVERY TEN
MINUTES.
I INSTEAD OF EVERY FIFTEEN
MINUTES OF THAT WILL A SOMEWHAT
NARROW -- THE ELIGIBLE BUS STOPS
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TRULY.
A ROBUST -- BUS SERVICE AND WILL
CONTINUE -- TO REQUIRE SEVEN DAY
A WEEK ROBUST -- BUS SERVICE
SIMILAR TO ARE THE SAME AS
CURRENTLY REQUIRED -- UNDER SB --
FIFTY WE HAVE -- A AND IN
ADDITION A COUNTIES OVER SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND BY THE PARKING
PROVISIONS IN SB -- FIFTY WILL
REMAIN IN PLACE.
WE HAVE REACHED AN AGREEMENT
RELATING TO THE COASTAL ZONE --
SB -- FIFTY DID NOT TREAT THE
COASTAL ZONE ANY DIFFERENTLY --
WORDS AS BEFORE EXAM TO THE
COASTAL ZONE -- SB FIFTY WILL
APPLY IN THE COASTAL ZONE TO
CITIES OF FIFTY THOUSAND OR MORE.
WE ALSO A RECENT AGREEMENT
AROUND HISTORIC DISTRICTS -- SB --
FIFTY DEFERRED TO THE EXISTING
RULES FOR HISTORIC DISTRICTS AS
BEFORE EXEMPTED -- HISTORIC
DISTRICTS -- WE REACH AN
AGREEMENT -- THAT -- FOR
HISTORIC SINCE HER HISTORIC
DISTRICTS THAT WERE APPROVED.
BEFORE TWO THOUSAND AND TEN FIVE
A WILL BE GRANDFATHERED IN AND
WILL.
NOT BE PART OF THE BILL -- IF
FOR CONTRIBUTING STRUCTURES
WITHIN THOSE SIZE STORY
DISTRICTS -- FOR OTHER HISTORIC
DISTRICTS -- THE HISTORIC
DISTRICT RULES FROM THE STATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DENSITY BONUS
PROGRAM -- WILL APPLY TO THOSE
EXISTING HISTORIC -- RULES -- WE
ALSO -- HAVE AGREED -- THAT WE
WILL -- AND THIS IS -- TAKEN
FROM THE LARGER FROM AS BEFORE
HI THAT WE WILL ALLOW --
STATEWIDE FOR PLEXUS.
BY RIGHTS.
HI AND I WILL LEAVE THAT
AMENDMENTS ABOUT IN A LAW CENTER
REQUIRED TO TALK ABOUT.
THE RULES AND COUNTIES UNDER.
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE --
SO -- WITH THAT SAID -- MISTER
CHAIRMAN AGAIN THANK YOU --
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK GOD BEFORE WE GET TO OUR
WITNESSES.
MISTER CURRENT YES SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH CENTER WINNER WHAT I'D
LIKE YOU TO DO IS TURN THE GAVEL
OVER TO THE VICE CHAIR AND THEN
SENATOR BELL AND I ARE GOING TO
BE JOINING CENTER WIENER -- AT
THE TABLE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE A
PRESENTATION
[inaudible]
WELCOME SENATORS.
MCGUIRE I CAN ASK ONE THING IS
COULD YOU MAKE IT INTERESTING.
THE TIME HEY THERE WE GO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MISTER VICE CHAIR AND I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT. TO BE ABLE TO SAY
THANK YOU TO SENATOR WIENER.
UP FOR HIS WORK ON THIS ISSUE
OVER THESE PAST MANY MONTHS.
MISTER VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS IN
ALL WHO ARE GATHERED TODAY OVER
THE PAST SIX TO EIGHT MONTHS.
CENTER BELL CENTRE WINNER IN AYE
A PARTNER IN A SERIES OF
HEARINGS UP AND DOWN CALIFORNIA.
THE FIRST HEARING DISCUSS THE
HOUSING CRISIS IN HOW TO ADDRESS
IT FURTHER.
IN REGARD TO STATE FINANCIAL
INVESTMENTS.
OUR SECOND HEARING FOCUS ON LAND
USE CHANGES THAT ARE NEEDED TO
ENABLE ADDITIONAL AFFORDABLE
MARKET RATE HOUSING POSSIBLE.
THE THIRD DRILL DOWN ON ZONING
CHALLENGES THAT ARISE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
IN HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW.
AFTER A SERIES OF HEARINGS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA IS FACED WITH A
SERIES OF COMPLEX CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BUILD OUT OF
HOUSING.
HIGHLAND PRICES.
THE LACK OF HOUSING STOCK
ASSOCIATED WITH DEMAND.
THE LACK OF ONGOING SUSTAINABLE
FORD WILL HOUSING.
AND THAT LACK OF A SUSTAINABLE
REVENUE SOURCE.
REGULATORY HURDLES.
HI COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH BURNING
PERMITTING ANY YES.
ZONING ANY INABILITY IN SOME
JURISDICTIONS A BILL STRATEGIC
IN THE HOUSE.
LET'S NOT KID OURSELVES IT'S
GONNA TAKE TIME TO BETTER OUR
BUILD OUR WAY OUT OF THIS
SIGNIFICANT DEFICIT.
THAT'S FACING US.
AND WE MUST HAVE A LASER FOCUS
ON THE BUILD OUT OF WORK FORCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN BIG CITIES
AND SMALL.
HERE'S WHY.
AS THE GOOD SENATOR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO STATED THE TRUE CRISIS
EXISTS WITH THE WORKING POOR AND
THE MIDDLE CLASS IN THIS STATE.
BETWEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE WE ARE SHORT ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION AFFORDABLE
UNITS ACROSS THE GOLDEN STATE.
THE STATE NEEDS TO DEVELOP A
PERMANENT REVENUE SOURCE TO HELP
SUBSIDIZE THE COST OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S WHY CENTER BALLOT I'VE
ALSO INTRODUCED SB FIVE WHICH
WOULD DELIVER ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION ANNUALLY FOR WORK FORCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY.
THANK YOU TO THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM SAN JOSE FOR HIS
OUTSTANDING LEADERSHIP.
ON THIS ISSUE.
NOW WITH THE ISSUE AT HAND EVERY
CITY AND COUNTY IN THE GOLDEN
STATE NEED TO DO THEIR PART.
WHAT HOUSING?
AND AS I'VE SAID. FOR THE PAST
MANY MONTHS.
THIS STRATEGY OF NO -- NO LONGER
WORKS.
AT THE SAME TIME WE KNOW THAT WE
NEED TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
UNIQUE DIFFERENCES OF
JURISDICTIONS BECAUSE AS THE
GOVERNOR SAID JUST LAST WEEK.
A BLANKET ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH SIMPLY DOES NOT WORK
FOR EVERY COMMUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S WHY CENTER BELL AND I
BROUGHT FORWARD AS BEFORE.
I TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE STOP
PULL STRATEGIES.
AND TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF THE MANY SIZE
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE.
AND TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS IN BIG
CITIES AND SMALL.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT CENTER WIENER
WAS ON A PARALLEL TRACK.
IN IS WORKING ON HIS OWN
APPROACH.
AND WE ARE BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
BE ABLE TO PRESENT A JOINT
SOLUTION THAT COMBINES ASPECTS
OF SB FIFTEEN AS BEFORE.
SB FOUR WILL BE HELD IN
COMMITTEE TODAY IN SB FIFTY WILL
MOVE FORWARD WITH CRITICAL
CHANGES THAT ENSURES THE
DIFFERENCES AMONG COMMUNITIES
ARE DRESSED.
DINNER WIENER HAS PROVIDED AN
OVERVIEW OF WHAT SB FIFTY WILL
DO IN LARGER COUNTIES AND I'D
LIKE TO NOW BE ABLE TO PRESENT.
BUT WHAT THE AMENDED VERSION OF
SB FIFTY WILL DO IN SOME
SUBURBAN AND RURAL COUNTIES.
WITHOUT IN MIND WE'RE FOCUSING
ON THE POPULATION IS SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR FEWER.
IN CITIES WITH FIFTY THOUSAND
POPULATION IT UP.
WITHIN THE SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
POPULATION THRESHOLD. THREE DO
YOU CAN FILL HOUSING FOCUS
WITHIN A HALF MILE OF SIX
PASSENGER RAIL OR FERRY
TERMINALS WILL BE ALLOWED.
NO BUS STOPS WILL BE IN THESE.
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND POPULATION
COUNTIES.
THEY WERE NEVER IN SB. FOUR ONE
STORY OF ADDITIONAL HEIGHTS
WOULD BE ALLOWED ON THE HOUSING
ABOVE THE CURRENT ZONING PLUS
DENSITY WOULD BONUS.
BY RIGHT AROUND RAIL AND FERRY
STATIONS.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU HAVE A
THREE STORY.
ZONE OF A HOUSING YOUR MAX
STORIES.
THREE SB FOUR WOULD ALLOW YOU TO
GO TO FOUR STORIES.
REGARDING PARKING.
CITIES WITH A POPULATION OF ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND OR MORE WITH IN
A COUNTY SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND OR
LESS.
NO PARKING WITHIN A QUARTER MILE
OF A PASSENGER RAIL FERRY
TERMINAL.
POINT FIVE PARKING SPOTS A
QUARTER MILE TO FIVE POINT FIVE
MILES.
CITIES WITH A POPULATION OF ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND OR LESS WITHIN
A COUNTY OF SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
UNLESS.
POINT FIVE PARKING SPOTS WITHIN
A HALF MILE FROM PASSENGER RAIL
OR PASSENGER FERRY.
HOUSING IN THE COASTAL ZONE
HISTORIC DISTRICTS IN HIGH FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES WILL
CONTINUE TO BE EXCLUDED.
BY WRITER TO APPROVAL OF FOUR
PLEX IS TO STRATEGICALLY SPREAD
OUT HOUSING COMMUNITIES WOULD BE
ALLOWED ON LAND ZONED
RESIDENTIAL.
NO DEMOLITIONS OF HIS EX
EXISTING EXISTING STRUCTURES
WOULD BE ALLOWED.
BUT CONVERSIONS OF HIS EXISTING
STRUCTURES TO FOUR PLEX IS WOULD
BE ALLOWED AS LONG AS THEY MEET
EXISTING ZONING STANDARDS SUCH
AS SET BACKS IN HEIGHT.
IN THESE DEVELOPMENTS WOULD HAVE
TO PROVIDE POINT FIVE PARKING
SPOTS PER UNIT AS WELL.
WE KNOW THAT THE GREATEST NEED
FOR HOUSING IS WITHIN THE LOW IN
VERY LOW CATEGORIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND AS YOU HEARD CENTER WIENER
IS COMMITTED TO CRITICAL IN LO
FI HOUSING AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT.
WHERE AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS
BUILT OFF SITE?
BUT IT ACTUALLY GETS PERMITTED
IN CONSTRUCTED AT THE SAME TIME.
AS MARKET RATE HOUSING.
AND WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THE INCLUSIONARY PERCENTAGES
IN THE BILL. TO ENSURE THAT THE
BILL'S GAINS ARE FAIRLY
DISTRIBUTED AND ADDRESSING ARE
TRUE CRISIS IN THE STATE AND
THAT'S THE LACK OF WORK FORCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
ONLY DID HERE MISTER CHAIR.
I'LL SAY THAT THIS IS NOT AN
EASY BILL.
WELL THERE NEED TO BE MORE WORK
[inaudible]
YOU BETCHA.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY.
THE CHANGES IN FRONT OF THIS
COMMITTEE PROVIDES A PATH
FORWARD. FOR CATALYZING CHANGE
WITHOUT IRANIAN OVER DIFFERENCES
IN CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE SET OF
LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
IT SETS US ON A PATH BUT DOESN'T
ADOPT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH.
AND IT SURE IS THAT CHANGE DOES
COME. TO COMMUNITIES BIG AND
SMALL.
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE BUT BEFORE WE DO MISTER
CHAIR LIKE A BETTER TURN IT OVER
TO SENATOR BATTLE.
WHO HAS BEEN A PARTNER IN ALL OF
THIS AND I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE TENANTS FROM SAN JOSE FOR
ALL OF HIS WORK CENTER ABOUT?
THANK YOU THANK YOU OF MISTER
CHAIRMAN MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE THE TIME THAT WE ALL
SPENT ON THIS AND I THINK IT.
HAS RESULTED IN A PRODUCTIVE.
SAID OF LEGISLATION THAT CAN
WORK -- SO COMBINING SB FIFTY AN
S. BEFORE INTO A COMPROMISE I
THINK IS THE CORRECT THING TO DO.
IT IS A COMPROMISE.
THE THINGS IN HERE I A AM
NERVOUS ABOUT -- AND THERE'S
THINGS IN HERE I REALLY LIKE.
SO -- I BELIEVE THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN SEVENTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE WORKED.%
TOGETHER IN ESPECIALLY IN THE
SENATE HEREAND WE DEVELOP SOME
HOUSING PACKAGE LEGISLATION WE
ACHIEVED.
OF PROPOSITION ONE THAT WAS
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS --IN --
THE LAST -- NOVEMBER TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ELECTION.
AND INVALIDATED OUR EFFORTS THAT
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
ISSUE PROPOSITION.
TWO OF ACTUALLY VALIDATED IT
FURTHER BY -- SAYING THEY WANT
SOMETHING TO DO ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA SO WE
HAD TO PROPOSITIONS ACTUALLY
VALIDATED.
OF THE WORK THAT WE DID AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN MOVING FORWARD
FROM THERE WE NEED TO DEVELOP A
PACKAGE.
OF LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN OF AND TWENTY
NINETEEN WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF OUR RESTRICTIONS -- OF
DEVELOPING A MORE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY APPROACH IN TERMS OF
URBAN PLANNING CHANGING THE
PLANNING -- DESIGN OF CALIFORNIA
TO MORE SUSTAINABLE PLANNING TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
AND PRODUCE A MORE EFFECTIVE --
TRANSPORTATION SOLUTION FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND I BELIEVE THAT --
THE COMBINATION OF SB FIFTY S.
BEFORE WELL ACTUALLY DO THAT.
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT -- WE NEED
TO APPROACH THE OTHERS PRONGS OF
THE SOLUTION HOUSING.
WHICH IS FINDING VACANT LAND
FINDING LAND THAT'S AVAILABLE --
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND WE
HAVE SB SIX THE GOVERNOR IS
WORKING ON OF SURPLUS STATE
PROPERTIES WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THAT.
AND THAT SB FIVE AND OTHER
LEGISLATION DEALING WITH
FINANCING HOUSING CALIFORNIA HAS
LONG.
UNDER FINANCED HOUSING EVEN WHEN
WE HAD REDEVELOPMENT OF
LEGISLATION WE OF UNDER FINANCED.
OF THE FUNDING OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND WE NEED IT MORE
DESPERATELY NOW THAN EVER BEFORE
BECAUSE OF THE COST OF HOUSING.
IS SO HIGH FOR THE LOW AN
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
OF CALIFORNIA.
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
CALIFORNIA HAS SUCH A HIGH --
POVERTY RATE IS THE CAR THE
CONSTANT STRESS OF PEOPLE
WORKING TWO TO THREE JOBS TO PAY
FOR THEIR HOUSING.
AND WE NEED TO PROVIDE MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND FINANCE
IT I THINK THE COMBINATION OF
ALL THESE BILLS -- AS A PACKAGE
WILL RESULT IN HELPING
CALIFORNIANS -- HAVE MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND I URGE
EVERYBODY SUPPORT THE PACKAGE OF
BILLS WE NEED TO APPROACH IT
FROM A MULTI FACETED BASIS.
AND I THINK THAT'S WERE TRYING
TO DO HERE SO THANK YOU FOR
JERRY MCGUIRE CENTER WINNER AND
THE OTHER LEGISLATORS THAT.
ARE APPROACHING THIS HOUSING --
COMPLEX ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE HOPE THAT THE GOVERNOR CAN
SUPPORT.
THE EFFORTS THAT WE ARE MAKING
IN THESE IN THIS REGARD THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR BELL
AS CENTER WINNER IF IT WORKS FOR
YOU WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
READ OUT THE AMENDMENT SO THAT
EVERYONE IS IN -- ON THE SAME
PAGE WITH CENTER WINNER DID YOU
WANT TO SAY SOMETHING FOR ONE
THING.
MISTER I TERMINATE NEGLECT IN
TALKING ABOUT THE AMENDMENTS TO
AMENDMENTS ONE WHICH YOU ALLUDED --
TO THAT ARE VERY IMPORTANT I
WANT TO MENTION WE HAVEBEEN IN
THE HOUSING COMMITTEE -- WE
RECEIVED A LETTER OF CONCERN A
FROM A COALITION OF A A
PROGRESSIVE HOUSING EQUITY --
GROUPS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
INTENSIVELY WITH THE COALITION
FOR A MORE FOR ABOUT A YEAR NOW
AND WE'RE CONTINUING ABOUT WORK --
AND WE WE MADE AMENDMENTS IN THE
PAST -- AND IN RESPONSE TO THOSE
TO THAT DIALOGUE.
I N THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
GOING TO GO AND TO THE COMMITTEE --
TODAY -- TWO OF THEM I CAME OUT
OF THE DIALOGUE WITH THE
COALITION ONE YOU MENTIONED --
TIGHTENING UP THE IN LIEU OF
ALTERNATIVE FOR THE INCLUSIONARY --
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- THE OFF SITE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS BEING
BUILT NEARBY AND ABOUT THE SAME
TIME -- AS THE MAIN PROJECT --
AS THE MARKET RATE PROJECT I
SHOULD SAY -- AND THEN THE
SECOND IS ARE WE HAVE BEEN OR
MAKING REFINEMENTS TO OUR
DEFINITION OF SENSITIVE
COMMUNITIES IS OUR COMMUNITIES
WITH HIGH LEVELS OF OR HIGH
POPULATION LOW INCOME RESIDENTS.
SIGNIFICANT RISK OF DISPLACEMENT
WHAT WE PROVIDE A FIVE YEAR THE
LADY AND THEN MORE FLEXIBILITY
AFTER THE FIVE YEAR THE LIGHT ON
SO WE'RE REFINING THAT
DEFINITION WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THIS COALITION.
AND MAKE PROGRESS THANK YOU.
AND WITH ME TODAY. TO TESTIFY ON
OUR SISTER DHEAS FROM THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES -- MICHAEL
GUNNING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION --
JOHN BALLARD TO THE COUNCIL
MEMBER AND FORMER MAYOR OF THE
CITY OF EMERYVILLE.
IN ADDITION TO ANSWER --
QUESTIONS IF THEY COME UP IS
BRIAN HAMLIN FROM CALIFORNIA U.
M. B. AND ALSO PEDRO GO BY --
FROM THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION RUNNING CALIFORNIA
TWO OF OUR SPONSORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER WIENER.
BASIN GERMAN HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE E APOLOGIZE BUT WE
ARE GOING TO READ OUT THE
AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF
US ARE ON THE SAME PAGE.
ABOUT WHAT'S MOVING FORWARD I
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE THESE
AMENDMENTS IN FRONT OF THEM NOW.
I'D LIKE TO BE A START OUT IN
COUNTIES OF OVER SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND POPULATION.
SB FIFTIES ONLY PROVISIONS WITH
BUS STOP COAL SO FIRE HAS AN
HISTORIC DISTRICT MODIFICATIONS.
ARE AS STATED.
CITIES UNDER.
FIFTY THOUSAND EXEMPTS PARCELS
IN THE COASTAL ZONE.
THE BILL WILL BE RESTRICTED TO
INFILL PARCELS AND COASTAL ZONE
REGARDLESS OF YOUR JURISDICTION
SIZE.
WE'RE GONNA BE EXEMPTING VERY
HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY SO.
CAN BE EXEMPTING CONTRIBUTING
PARCELS.
IN LEGISLATIVE ADOPTED HISTORIC
DISTRICTS IN EXISTENCE AS A TWO
THOUSAND TEN N. DENSITY BONUS
GOING FORWARD [inaudible]
BUS STOPS.
SHORTEN HAD WASTED TEN MINUTES
DURING PEAK TIMES TO QUALIFY.
CLARIFY THAT EACH LINE IS GOING
IS IN EACH DIRECTION.
THESE BY STEPS MUST HAVE MET THE
HEAD WAY STANDARD FOR THE PAST
FIVE YEARS.
SB FIFTY PARKING.
SAME AS EARLIER NO PARKING
AROUND RAIL.
POINT FIVE PARKING SPACES PER
UNIT MINIMUM ELSEWHERE.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS.
COUNTIES SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
POPULATION OR LESS.
WE'RE GONNA BE FOLDING.
HOLDING THE DENSITY REQUIREMENTS
OF SP.
FOUR IN TWO SB.
FIFTY THERE WILL BE A CREATION
OF FOUR PLEXUS BY RIGHT.
IN RESIDENTIAL AREAS ON VACANT
LAND AND ALLOWS CONVERSIONS OF
HIS EX EXISTING STRUCTURE BUT NO
DEMOLITION.
EXISTING STRUCTURE DEFINITION.
75% OF EXTERIOR WALLS MUST BE
INTACT.
I KNOW MORE THAN 15% INCREASE A
SQUARE FOOTAGE.
ALSO MUST ABIDE BY ALL THE OTHER
LOCAL REGULATIONS FOR EXAMPLE
SET BACKS.
WHAT COVERAGE?
FLOOR AREA RATIO HI EXCEPT.
FOR MUST INCLUDE SB THIRTY FIVE
LIMITATIONS ON ELIGIBLE PARCELS.
RESTRICT ALL ABOVE TO INFILL
PARCELS AND EXEMPT COASTAL.
HISTORIC FIRE HAZARD FLOOD
PLAINS HER SB.
FOUR CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL EQUALITY
COMMITTEE ON IDENTIFYING A
DEFINITION OF INTO.
A DOZEN IN DO SPRAWL.
SB FOR PARKING CONTINUES TO
APPLY.
IN COUNTIES SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
POPULATION OR LESS.
THOSE PARKING REQUIREMENTS ARE
AS FOLLOWS.
NO PARKING MINIMUM WITH A
QUARTER MILE OF RAIL AND CITIES
OVER.
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND POINT FIVE
SPACES PER UNIT MINIMUM
ELSEWHERE.
WE ARE IN THE HOME STRETCH LACE
AND GENTLEMAN.
HERE'S THE FINAL CHAPTER
[inaudible]
OTHER MINUTES [inaudible]
SENSITIVE COMMUNITIES.
BUT THERE'S BEEN AN AGREEMENT ON
SENSITIVE GUY COMMUNITIES WITH
HOUSING ADVOCATES.
AND THIS COMMITTEE.
INCLUDE AT A MINIMUM THOSE AREAS
DESIGNATED HI SEGREGATE
SEGREGATION IN POVERTY AND LOW
RESOURCE.
NT CáC OPPORTUNITY MAPS. 25%
CALAVERAS GREEN SCORES.
AND WE'RE GONNA FOCUS ON THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN HAD QUALIFIED
CENSUS TRACKS.
THE COUNCIL GOVERNMENT RUN
PROCESS TO IDENTIFY SENSITIVE
COMMUNITIES WITH MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS OF OUT REACH. TO
DISADVANTAGED POPULATIONS.
OFTEN BEFORE JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE TO PLANNING PROCESS
BASED ON A PETITION WITH 20%
POPULATION CENSUS TRACKS.
SIGNING A SPECIFIED OUTREACH
REQUIREMENTS.
NEXT CHANGES TO ENSURE OXIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS ACTUALLY
BUILT.
NO CERTIFICATE OF OCCUPANCY ON
MARKET RATE WITHOUT BUILDING.
PERMIT.
IT'S REQUIRED IN HAS TO BE IN
YOUR TRANSIT IN WITHIN A HALF
MILE.
OF ORIGINAL PROJECT SITE.
THERE WILL BE SOME TECHNICAL
MEMINTA WILL BE ADVANCED ON HOW
THE DENSITY BONUS WORKS.
COMMITMENT TO INCLUDE INCLUSION
INCLUSIONARY PERCENTAGES THAT
ARE WORKED OUT WITH HOUSING
ADVOCATES AN AGREEABLE TO THE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE.
AND SB FOUR FOUR PLEXUS
PROVISION WILL BE APPLIED STATE
WIDE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE ARE NOW
GOING TO BE TURN IT OVER TO
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT.
I'VE HEARD SOME HISSING HERE
TODAY IF YOU DO NOT WANT THIS
COMMITTEE HISSING AT YOU WHEN
YOU'RE SPEAKING GOING TO ASK
THAT YOU DO NOT HI AT THOSE WHO
ARE SPEAKING NOW IT'S COMMON
COURTESY.
WHETHER YOU LIKE IT OR NOT.
SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA ASK IS THAT
YOU PLEASE.
PLEASE REFRAIN FROM HIS SEEN
BREWING CLAPPING OR RAISING OF
HANDS WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
A CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE TODAY
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT.
THOSE WHO MAY HAVE CONCERNS OR
THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED THE LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN WE NOW WOULD LIKE
TO BETTER TURN IT OVER TO OUR
SUPPORT PANEL.
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORTTHE
PRIMARY WITNESSES WE TYPICALLY
ONLY ALLOW.
TO TODAY WE'RE GONNA ALLOW THREE
ON EACH SIDE.
EACH THREE WILL HAVE A MAXIMUM
OF TWO MINUTES.
A MAXIMUM OF TWO MINUTES.
OUT WE WILL GIVE YOU A THIRTY
SECOND WARNING.
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY FOR THE THREE
WITNESSES BOTH YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT.
AS WELL AS THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED.
WE'D LIKE TO NOW BE ABLE TO TURN
IT OVER WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE A
KICK US OFF WE ARE NOW IN
SUPPORT FOR A PRIMARY WHICH IS.
MISTER DE AS YOU HAVE THE FLOOR
TWO MINUTES.
A RECENT MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
SOCIETY HAS ONLY HALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL.
ARE PROUD TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT.
I WANT TO COMMEND OF THIS
COMMITTEE YOURSELF YOUR
CHAIRMANSHIP A SENATOR B<c.cyan> OF</c>
COURSE SENATOR WIENER. FOR
WORKING TOGETHER ON THE SET OF
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU JUST
OUTLINED -- IN MANY RESPECTS THE
SENATE IS LIKE A BIG FAMILY AND
SOMETIMES A FAMILY HAS
DISAGREEMENTS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOUSING IT'S
VERY APPROPRIATE TO RELATE THAT
AS AS AS SUCH.
THE HOUSE OF THE SENATE YOU ALL
CAME TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE THAT'S AFFECTING WORKING
FAMILIES ALL ACROSS THE STATE.
AND DIFFERENT REGIONS FOR A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT REASONS.
FOR US IN THE BUILDING TRADES WE
REPRESENT WORKING FAMILIES THEY
FOR GONE A LOT OF THEIR RAISES
AND GAUNT STRICTLY TO THE RENT
OR TO THE COST OF HOUSING.
THIS FOR ME IS A VERY PERSONAL
ISSUE NOT ONLY BECAUSE I
REPRESENT CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
WHO INTEND TO BUILD THOSE HOMES
AND PROVIDE MORE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR DISADVANTAGED YOUTH.
AND A WHOLE BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
PEOPLE THAT ARE LOOKING FOR A
CAREER IN CONSTRUCTION AND TO
THE AN ENTRY INTO THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
BUT ALSO BECAUSE MY FAMILY IS
DEEPLY IMPACTED BY THIS ON A
PERSONAL LEVEL I AM BLESSED
ENOUGH TO HAVE A UNION JOB I
HAVE A HOME.
SACRAMENTO BUT MY FAMILY IN SAN
FRANCISCO IS STRUGGLING MY
MOTHER SHE'S ON SECTION EIGHT I
HAVE A BROTHER WHO IS HOMELESS I
HAVE A BROTHER WILL ALSO RENTS
HI RENTS IN THE DALY CITY AREA
PAYS FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS OR
SUCH. FOR A ONE BEDROOM
APARTMENT.
AND HE HAS BARELY STARTED
STRUGGLING HE CAN'T AFFORD EVEN
TO BUY A CAR HAD A SOULS CAR.
ANOTHER BROTHER WHO LIVES IN A
ROOM.
HE PLAYS HE PAYS CLOSE TO NINE
HUNDRED DOLLARS WITHOUT ACCESS
TO ACTUAL KITCHEN. FOR ME THIS
IS DEEPLY PERSONAL I WANT TO
COMMAND ON THE VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS THAT YOU
PROVIDED BECAUSE IN MY BELIEVE
ALL OF THESE SOLUTIONS IMPACT MY
FAMILY IN A VERY POSITIVE
POSITIVE WAY.
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
HOUSING HOUSING IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND THE SOLUTIONS THAT
YOU ARE PRESENTING HERE NOT ONLY
IN THIS.
PARTICULAR BILL BUT AS A
COMPREHENSIVE SET OF SOLUTIONS
WITH OTHER LEGISLATION IS GOING
TO DIRECTLY IMPACT THAT.
SENATE PROTECTIONS AGAINST
INFECTIONS RENT CONTROL ISSUES.
BUT ALSO THE PRODUCTION OF
HOUSING SO THAT IN THE FUTURE
WE'RE LOOKING TO ACTUALLY BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT NEED THE MOST BUT
ALSO FOR OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE.
PERHAPS IN THE INCOME AREAS THAT
THEY WANT TO GET INTO WHEN THEY
IN TURN A PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
AND EARNED ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR I CAN HAVE ACCESS
TO THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SUBSIDIES. TO FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ARE THE THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER DE AS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO GO
SECOND.
WELCOME SERVICE PERSON LAST
ORGANIZATION TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ON
MICHAEL GUNNING HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
I TOO WOULD LIKE TO CONGRATULATE
YOU AND CENTERS BELL AND WIENER
AND THE COMMITTEE.
AND STAFF FOR WORKING SO HARD TO
COME TO THIS AGREEMENT AS THE
THE ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS
OVER THREE THOUSAND BUILDERS AND
HOME BUILDERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
WHERE THE FOLKS ACTUALLY ARE
GOING TO BE BUILDING THESE
HOUSES AND THIS IS CERTAINLY A
CREATIVE SOLUTION -- TWO AND A
DESPERATE PROBLEM I'M A LOT OF
YOU HEARD MY TESTIMONY IN THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE WE HAVE
DESIGNATED SB FIFTY AS A HOUSING
CREATOR.
WHICH MEANS THAT IT INCREASES
PRODUCTION SUPPLY HOMEOWNERSHIP
AND TRIES TO GET PEOPLE HOUSE.
I THINK SIMILAR TO MY FRIEND
MISTER DE AS AS AS THE SON OF
IMMIGRANTS BOTH OF MY PARENTS
CAME HERE FROM THE COUNTRY OF
JAMAICA.
AND THEY KNEW THAT HOMEOWNERSHIP
WAS THE WAY TO SUCCEED IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AND MY MOM A THIRTY YEAR TEACHER
MY FATHER A CIVIL ENGINEER THEY
BOUGHT THEIR FIRST HOUSE IN THAT
HOUSE WAS THE MEANS TO PUT ME
AND MY BROTHER. TO COLLEGE SO
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS IMPORTANT TOO
MANY PEOPLE NOW DAYS NOT HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY AND WE CLEARLY
SEE SB FIFTY AS A WAY TO DO THAT
AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS RUNNING
GRATEFUL COUNCILMEMBER FLOOR IS
YOURS YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOHN
BOWERS COUNCILMEMBER FOR THE
CITY OF EMERYVILLE.
THE CITY'S FORMER MAYOR -- HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY
PERHAPS NOT THE MOST TRADITIONAL
SPEAKER IN SUPPORT OF A BILL
WITHOUT A ROOM FULL OF FIVE GOOD
FOLKS.
WHO ARE ADVOCATING I JUST THE I
BELIEVE FOR TEN AND PROTECTIONS
AND OTHER ISSUES ARE
PROFESSIONALLY I'VE SPENT
FIFTEEN YEARS WORKING ON
HOMELESSNESS AND OUT?
ISSUES I WAS ATTENDED TOURNEY IN
CHICAGO FOR MANY YEARS AND
WORKED -- DEFENDING TENANTS --
CABRINI GREEN -- I WORKED ON THE
PLANNING COMMISSION THE CITY OF
EMBER GO BECAME A BEFORE I
BECAME A COUNCIL MEMBER -- BUT
WE LIVE IN THE SHADOW OF
SOMETHING THAT'S MUCH BIGGER
THAN A BUILDING AND IT'S THE
SHADOW OF ASSIST SEGREGATIONIST
IS OWNING PRACTICES REDLINING IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT
MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE SITTING
BEHIND ME HAVE IS WHAT WILL THIS
BILL DUE TO ADDRESS THOSE THINGS --
AS A COUNCIL MEMBER FROM A CITY
THAT VOTED FIVE ZERO TO ENDORSE
AND SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I WANT TO SUGGEST THAT THIS IS
THE RIGHT STEP AS PART OF A A A
PANOPLY OF INTERVENTIONS THAT
ARE NECESSARY TO BRING
CALIFORNIA ON TRACK AND HOUSING.
AS I SEE IT THERE ARE THREE
PRIMARY ISSUES AFFORDABILITY
TENANT PROTECTIONS AND SUPPLY.
I'M IS A LOCAL JURISDICTION
WE'VE DONE A NUMBER OF THINGS ON
THE FRONT ON THE FIRST TWO
ISSUES.
CITY OF EMBER BILL PASSED THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BY LAST YEAR WHICH WILL
BUILD 100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR RESIDENTS ACROSS OUR CITY
WHO ARE AT RISK OF BEING
DISPLACED.
IF ENACTED LANDLORD TENANT
ORDINANCE A JUST CAUSE ADDICTION
ORDINANCE.
WE HAVE AN INCLUSIONARY ZONING
POLICY THAT IS IN OUR
DEVELOPMENT CODE.
REQUIRES THE INCLUSION OF UNITS
ALONG SIDE OF MERCURY IN ITS
BILL BY A PRIVATE DEVELOPER.
HE RECENTLY UPS OWNER TRANSIT
QUARTER SAN PABLO AVENUE.
BUILDING EIGHTY SEVEN UNIT TWO
TO FOUR BEDROOM.
ALL A 100% FAMILY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING STRUCTURE THERE AND
WE'VE JUST PUT OUT AN RFP TO
BUILD AN INTERGENERATIONAL
HOUSING PROJECT FOR SENIORS AND
FOSTER YOUTH.
PEOPLE PROPOSED ELIMINATE
PARKING MINIMUMS AND WE'VE
INCREASE THE MINIMUM WAGE TO THE
HIGHEST MINIMUM WAGE IN OUR
NATION.
WE ALSO PROVIDE A FREE TRANSIT
SHUTTLE WHY AM I SHARING ALL
THESE THINGS THESE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT LOCAL AGENCIES CAN
DO TODAY. ONE OF THE THINGS WE
CAN'T DO IS CONTROL OUR
NEIGHBORS ZONE FOR HOUSING ALONG
TRANSIT QUARTERS.
ON THE SUPPLY SIDE ALTHOUGH
SUPPLY APPEARS TO BE A MARKET
DRIVEN ISSUE IN IT IN A IN A
NARROW SPACE COULD BE CONSTRUED
AS THE THE TOTAL SCOPE OF THIS
BILL THIS IS REALLY PART.
OF A BIGGER SET OF INTERVENTIONS
THAT MAKE CALIFORNIA MORE
SUSTAINALE PLACE MAKE IT MORE
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY HELP US
TO FILL OUR CLIMATE ACTION GOALS
AND HELP CREATE EQUITY IN OUR
COMMUNITY WHERE PEOPLE WHO FOR A
LONG TIME HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
LIVE OR WORK NEAR -- FAMILY OR
JOBS HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SO AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH KANSEN NEVER
PLAYED IS IN GERMAN WE NOW WOULD
LIKE TO BE A TO GO TO THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO ASK IF THOSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO TO COME TO
THE MICROPHONE THAT IS RIGHT
BEHIND OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
AND ASK YOU TO PLEASE STAND AT
THIS TIME.
PLEASE STATE YOUR FIRST AND LAST
NAME AS WELL AS YOUR POSITION
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT TO PLEASE COME
FORWARD TO THIS MICROPHONE.
PERSON LAST NAME ORGANIZATION.
WE WELCOME YOU.
ONLY FOR MANY ON BEHALF A
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
THANKS FOR HANGING WITH US.
MORNING MA'AM MORNING TIFFANY
FAN FOR BRIDGE HOUSING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING SIR GOOD MORNING
MIKE MCLAUGHLIN VOLUNTEER THEY
ARE P. WE SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD MORNING WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE.
GOOD MORNING BOB MAILER FOR SIX
BEDS INCOME ASSOCIATION OF
ASSISTED LIVING HOMES AND FOR IT
FEELS STERN COMPANY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD MORNING SIR.
HI DAVID -- MAY HAVE THE BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE MORNING MICHELENA SILICON
VALLEY AT HOME IS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING ELLEN CHAPMAN
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE MORNING MORNING EARLY WILCOX
SACRAMENTO INDIVISIBLE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS ALSO
WEBSITE WE HAVE OAKLAND MAYOR
LIBBY SCHAAF IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THE MORNING.
CARELL.
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO AND SOUTH
SACRAMENTO SENIOR CITIZENS
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING SERRA FEES FOSSEL
FREE CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR GOOD MORNING.
IT MEANS LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
LOU AS A MATTER OF SOUTH
BERKELEY NOW IN SUPPORT EXPENSE.
THE MORNING.
TINA GAILLARD FROM THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR HANGING WITH US.
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING MR MEMBERS BRIAN WHITE
ON THE OUTSIDE CALVET HOUSE
ALLIANCE ALSO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE GOOD
MORNING.
THE BOY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION HERE
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE MORNING MORNING NIKITA
CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL HERE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE MORNING MORNING AMANDA
CRUISE WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
GIVING HERE.
ARMOR SHELL ON BEHALF OF HOW
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
I'M AN OLD TIMER ON BEHALF OF
STRIFE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
WE'LL BE OFFERING YOU HAVE A
FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
HAVE ANY ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I JUST OF LANDS AS A PRESIDENT
OF THE I. CONSORTIUM HOMELESS
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY IN FAVOR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE GONNA
LAST CALL LAST CALL FOR THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ON A LAWLER WITH THE
RESTAURANTS ARE A LONG POVERTY
WE DO NOT HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL YET SO I'M TO SQUEEZE IN IN
THE MIDDLE HERE.
BUT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS ON
ALONG WITH A NUMBER OF STATEWIDE
AND LOCAL EQUITY AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING GROUPS TO CONTINUE
NEGOTIATING THE BILL WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE PROGRESS THAT'S
BEEN MADE TO DATE.
WE'RE NOT READY TO TAKE A
POSITION YET OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO THE LEDGE
COUNSELING WHICH AND WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE SENATOR TED TO REVIEW THAT
LANGUAGE AND I'M VERY.
PLEASED TO NOT BE IN THE OPPOSE
LINE AT THIS POINT IN TIME AND
AND AND HOPEFUL THAT AS THE BILL
MOVES WE ME BUT BE ABLE TO GET
TO A SUPPORT POSITION ACTUALLY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE HARD
WORK ON IT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE MORNING.
SO I WON LAST YES I CAN BE
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
ALSO REPRESENTING -- ABOUT TEN
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TONY CONSEILS REPRESENTING CAL
CALIFORNIA PRESERVATION
FOUNDATION WHICH INCLUDES SAN
FRANCISCO HERITAGE ELLIE
CONSERVANCY WE'RE IN A SUPPORT
IF AMENDED POSITION WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL.
FOR THE AMENDMENTS HAD BEEN
TAKEN TODAY WE'LL DISCUSS --
ISSUES AND RANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE HUNDRED CITY WEST HOLLYWOOD
WE ARE NEUTRAL THIS POINT BUT WE
WOULD LIKE THE RENO PER OF
PROVISIONS WITHIN SB FOUR
REGARDING OUT BIRD.
REGARDING ELIGIBLE PROJECTS TO
BE ADDED INTO SB FIFTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SIR MELISSA ROMERO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS.
WE HAVE A CONDITIONAL SUPPORT
POSITION IT'S A BIT AND WITH THE
BILL AND PRINT CURRENTLY -- WE
DO REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK BEING DONE TO TALK WITH THE
EQUITY ANTI DISPLACEMENT AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING GROUPS AND WE
HOPE TO COME IN SUPPORT SOON
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE GOOD MORNING SIR.
MORNING ADAM REGULAR BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE HAVE A SUPPORT POSITION WE
DID NOT SEE THE NEW AMENDMENTS
BUT WE STILL ROUTE ONE REGISTER
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
MORNING MA'AM.
CHRIS ROSA ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ONE LAST CALL.
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT.
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA
ASK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE NOT
GONNA ASK FOR THOSE WHO ARE
OPPOSED WERE HERE'S HOW THIS IS
GONNA WORK GLAZER GENTLEMAN.
WE HAVE THE ABILITY. FOR FOR FOR
INDIVIDUALS.
THE BILL TO SPEAK WHO ARE OPPOSE.
SO WE ARE CURRENTLY.
CAN YOU GIVE US THIRTY SECONDS
PLEASE
.
YOU WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE.
SO HERE'S WHAT WE LIKE TO BE
ABLE.
TO PRESENT TO EVERYONE HERE
TODAY.
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE ONE PRIMARY.
AND THREE SECONDARY.
WOULD LIKE TO BETTER IDENTIFY
WHO ARE PRIMARY WITNESSES OUT OF
THE FOUR IF YOU HAVE NOT.
WITH GERMAN RIGHT THERE.
HERE'S ON YOU WANT TO GIVE YOU
ALL THIRTY SECONDS TO BE ABLE TO
DISCUSS THIS IS A GROUP WE'RE
GONNA COME RIGHT BACK TO YOU
.
QUESTION I'M IS THE PRIME I MUCH
RAIMES A SECULAR AGAIN MERION
SECONDARY -- THE PRIMARY HOW
MUCH TIME IS A SECONDARY GIVEN.
SAME EQUAL TIME IS TWO MINUTES
AS WE HAD THREE WITNESSES WHO
ARE TWO MINUTES AND WE HAVE ONE
PRIMARY THANK YOU SIR SO WHO IS
GOING TO KICK US OFF IS OUR
PRIMARY WITNESS.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IF YOUR MIND
IS GIVES YOUR FIRST LASSEN
ORGANIZATION WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE FOUR OF YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY.
SO MA'AM YOU HAVE THE FLOOR AND
THEY WERE GRANT THREE WITNESSES
WHO ARE SECONDARY OF TWO MINUTES
EACH AGAIN EQUAL TIME FOR ALL
SIDES.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS SHANTI THING I'M
REPRESENTING TENANTS TOGETHER
CALIFORNIA'S STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION FOR RENTERS RATES --
WE ORGANIZED IN OUR THIRTY SIX
MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS ARE ALLIES
AND PARTNERS -- WHICH THEY'RE
MORE ORGANIZED WITH THE VICTIMS
OF GENTRIFICATION DISPLACING
CALIFORNIA THESE ARE OUR
COMMUNITIES THESE ARE WHERE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE ROOTED WHERE
ORGANIZER'S COME FROM.
I WANT TO START BY SAYING THAT
WE HAVE WITNESSED FIRSTHAND THE
POLITICS OF EXCLUSION THE TELL
OUR RENTER'S SEVENTEEN MILLION
CALIFORNIA -- ANSWERS ALMOST
HALF OF THE POPULATION THAT THEY
DO NOT DESERVE TO LIVE WHERE
THEY CANNOT AFFORD TO LIVE WE
FEEL IS ACUTELY.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE SOLUTIONS TO
THE HOUSING CRISIS MUST BE LED
BY THOSE MOST VICTIMIZED
EXERCISING THEIR VOICES FULLY IN
OUR DEMOCRACY.
THIS IS WHY WE SUPPORT
GRASSROOTS TENANT ORGANIZATIONS
BUT THIS IS ALSO WHY ARE THIRTY
SIX MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
UNANIMOUSLY VOTED TO OPPOSE SB.
FIFTY FOR COMMUNITIES TO
ORGANIZE LOCALLY WHO HAVE BEEN
MARGINALIZED FOR DECADES IN OUR
HISTORY DEVELOP A PLAN FOR
EQUITABLE DEVELOPMENT.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY PASS THAT
PLAN THROUGH LOCAL NEGOTIATIONS
WITH MUNICIPAL GOVERNMENTS THIS
IS WHAT WE DO THIS IS OUR
ORGANIZATION'S EXPERIENCE.
TAKES FAR LONGER THAN FIVE YEARS.
AND REQUIRES LOCAL EMPOWERMENT
LOCAL SUPPORT AND RESOURCES AS
WELL AS SUPPORT WE AT THE STATE
LEVEL.
IT ALSO REQUIRES THOUGHTFUL
PLANNING FOR DEEPLY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR COMMUNITIES THAT WE
SERVE BEING DISPLACED DOWN MASS
RIGHT NOW.
WE ALSO RETAIN DEEP CONCERNS
THAT THE OWNERS OF ENFORCING
ANTI DEMOLITION PROVISIONS WILL
FALL ON THESE ALREADY STRUGGLING
COMMUNITIES WERE BEARING THE
BRUNT OF EVICTION AND
DISPLACEMENT.
WE UNANIMOUSLY SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
BILL.
TWELVE SEVENTY NINE WHICH DOES
SOMETHING SIMILAR IT IDENTIFIES
AND TARGETS JOBS RICH AREAS TO
BUILD HOUSING COMMENSURATE TO
THE JOBS THEY CREATE.
IT'S SPECIFICALLY TACKLES THE
LEGACIES OF EXCLUSIONARY ZONING --
BY TARGETING THOSE COMMUNITIES.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT IF THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED
EXCLUSIONARY COMMUNITIES WHO
HAVE NOT DONE THEIR PART TO
SOLVE THE SHORTAGE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND I THINK WE AGREE ON
THAT I WOULD NOT BE SITTING USE
HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY VOICING MY
OPPOSITION.
FRANKLY WE HAVE TOO MANY DEEP
CONCERNS WITH SB FIFTIES IMPACTS
DESPITE THE AMENDMENTS ON LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHERE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE BASED WHERE WE
ARE ROOTED. TO SUPPORT IT
HOWEVER WELL MEANING ITS
INTENTIONS THANK YOU.
I AM EMIGRATE OF YOUR TESTIMONY
WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO SECOND.
ALL RIGHT THE MORNING TWO
MINUTES THE FLOOR IS YOURS GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NORMA
GARCIA I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
POLICY AND ADVOCACY FOR THE
MISSION ECONOMIC.
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY HEADQUARTERED
IN SAN FRANCISCO'S MISSION
DISTRICT WHICH IS GROUND ZERO
FOR GENTRIFICATION AND
DISPLACEMENT. ONE OF THE GROUND
ZEROES IN THIS COUNTRY AND
CERTAINLY A BIG GROUND ZERO FOR
CALIFORNIA.
I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE WITH RESPECT TO
THE PUBLIC PROCESS I WHILE I
RESPECT THE WORK THAT THE
SENATORS HAVE DONE TO COME UP
WITH A COMPROMISE THAT SEEMS TO
WORK FOR MOST -- NONE OF US
ACTUALLY HAVE SEEN THE
AMENDMENTS.
IN FORM AND WE HAVEN'T HAD A
CHANCE TO FULLY ANALYZE THEM AND
TO SEE WHERE THEY FIT INTO THE
EXISTING TAX OF THE MOST RECENT
VERSION OF SB FIFTY SO.
AS A WORD OF PROCESS I WOULD SAY
THAT WE NEED MORE CLARITY WE MAY
NOT TRANSPARENCY MORE TIME TO BE
ABLE TO EVALUATE THE AMENDMENTS
AS BEING PROPOSED TODAY.
AND THERE'S AN ISSUE HERE THAT
LOOMS LARGE OVER THIS BILL AND
AND THAT IS IT EVERYONE EXPECTED
SB FIFTY IS GOING TO DELIVER
HOUSING FOR A CALIFORNIANS AT
ALL INCOME LEVELS.
BUT WHEN WE DID AN ANALYSIS OF
THE AFFORDABILITY ASPECTS OF SB
FIFTY THE VAST MAJORITY OF SB
FIFTY HOUSING WILL BE MARKET
RATE HOUSING.
AND AS A MATTER OF FACT SB FIFTY
THE MOST CURRENT DRAFT BASICALLY
HAS NO AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR BUILDINGS THAT
ARE UNDER TEN YOU TEN UNITS ARE
UNDER.
I'M SO IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BUILDING A UNIVERSE OF FOUR
UNITS SMALL APARTMENT BUILDINGS
HOW ARE WE GOING TO BUILD IN
AFFORDABILITY THERE BECAUSE AS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED THOSE
BUILDINGS ARE COMPLETELY EXEMPT.
FROM ANY AFFORDABILITY MANDATE
UNDER SB -- FIFTY THIS IS A THIS
IS A VERY SWEEPING BILL AND
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT HOUSING
IS AN ISSUE THAT IMPACTS US ALL.
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT REZONING
THE ENTIRE STATE WITHOUT A STUDY.
AND I I JUST CAN'T IMAGINE THAT
THAT THAT THAT IS PRUDENT I
THINK THAT AS A STATE WE NEED TO
BE CAREFUL ABOUT HOW WE DO THIS
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT WE DON'T
GET TO A GOOD SOLUTION.
IT IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
WE'VE DONE IT THOUGHTFULLY AND
THAT WE HAVE AN HARM SENSITIVE
COMMUNITIES LIKE THE MISSION
DISTRICT WHICH IS ACTUALLY
EXCLUDED CURRENTLY FROM THE
SENSE OF COMMUNITY.
DEFINITION WHICH IS UNBELIEVABLE.
THANK YOU SHOP MA'AM THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
AND FOR YOUR WORDS.
AND WE'D BE HAPPY TO BE A TO GET
YOU COPY THE AMENDMENTS -- AS
WELL.
I HERE IN JUST A MOMENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH I WOULD LIKE TO BE A
RAINY DAY DAVID RAST DIRECTOR OF
PLANNING TO DEVELOPMENT CITY OF
PASADENA.
THE CITY OF PASADENA
ACKNOWLEDGES THE STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS.
THE CITY OF PASADENA
ACKNOWLEDGES THE BILL'S DESIRE
TO INCREASE SUPPLY IN TRANSIT
RICH AREAS.
THE CITY PASADENA KNOWLEDGES
THAT THESE VERY PROVISIONS ARE
WHAT THE CITY HAS BEEN DOING FOR
OVER FIFTEEN YEARS.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT VERY
TECHNICAL ZONING TERMS.
T. O. D. TRANSIT AREAS DENSITY
DENSITY BONUS.
FROM ARENA PERSPECTIVE WHICH IS
THE REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT REQUIREMENTS
ESTABLISHED BY THE STATE TO EACH
CITY.
THE CITY OF PASADENA IS
REQUIREMENTS.
TOTAL THIRTEEN HUNDRED UNITS FOR
THE CYCLE.
WE WILL BE CLOSE TO PRODUCING
SEVEN THOUSAND UNITS WE'RE DOING
OUR SHARE.
THIS IS NOT TO SAY WE ARE
SPECIAL.
BUT 87% OF THE UNITS THAT WE
APPROVE OUR WITHIN TEO DE AREAS.
WE ARE THE ONLY CITY IN SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY IT HAS A 15%
REQUIRED INCLUSIONARY PERCENTAGE.
WE HAVE PRODUCED OVER TWO
HUNDRED UNITS A CYCLE THAT ARE
AFFORDABLE DEED RESTRICTED.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT WE
HAVE EIGHT AN ORDINANCE ON THE
BOOKS THAT ALLOWS HOTELS TO BE
CONVERTED TO PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
WE CONTINUE TO STRIVE TO CHANGE
OUR ORDINANCES TO REFLECT THE
CITY'S NEEDS THE STATE'S NEEDS
THE REGION'S NEEDS WITH RESPECT
TO HOUSING AT ALL INCOME LEVELS.
BY TRYING TO ESTABLISH A
WORKFORCE HOUSING PROVISION AND
DEEPER AFFORDABILITY WE ARE JUST
FINISHING OUR INCLUSIONARY
REQUIREMENT STUDY TO INCREASE
OUR 15% TO ANOTHER NUMBER.
WE ARE DEEPLY DEDICATED TO DOING
THIS.
WHAT THIS BILL FAILS TO
RECOGNIZE IS THAT IN ORDER FOR
THE CITY TO PRODUCE THE UNITS
THAT I'VE DISCUSSED TO HAVE THE
ZONING THE SIXTY UNITS PER ACRE
IN AND AROUND ARGUE THESE?
IS COMPROMISE BETWEEN RESIDENTS
LOCAL GRASS ROOTS RESIDENTS
FOLKS THAT WANT TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IT'S A COMPROMISE
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF HOURS
OF PUBLIC MEETINGS AND PUBLIC
TESTIMONY.
BETWEEN RESIDENTS STAFF MEMBERS
AND ELECTED OFFICIALS THIS BILL.
THAT BY ESTABLISHING ZONING NOW
IT'S NOT ONE SIZE IT'S TO SIZE
FITS ALL I ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
BUT THE REALITY IS IS THAT THIS
WILL ALL THIS IS GOING TO WHAT
CITIES WILL DO IN RESPONSE TO A
BILL LIKE THIS IS TO THE STATE
ASK YOU TO CONCLUDE.
AND WHEN WHAT CITIES.
WILL DO IS HAVE CHAOS WITH
RESPECT TO THE MARK THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS AND WE WILL
NO LONGER HAVE GOOD PLANNING.
IN THE CITY OR THE STATE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
FOR TAKING TIME TO TRAVEL HERE
TODAY CAN ASK FOLKS WE CAN JUST
PLEASE HOLD ON THE APPLAUSE
THANK OU SO MUCH AND WE'RE
REALLY GRATEFUL THAT ALL OF YOUR
HERE TODAY SIR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS RENEE MOORE
M. THE DIRECTOR OF HOUSING IS A
HUMAN RIGHT AND I'M ALSO A
VOLUNTEER MEMBER OF THE LOS
ANGELES TENANTS UNION -- I'VE
TWICE EXPERIENCED HOUSING IN
SECURITY MYSELF AND HAIL FROM A
COMMUNITY IN NORTHEAST LA IS
EXPERIENCED SEVERE
GENTRIFICATION IT'S Y. LOS
ANGELES ALONG SIDE SAN FRANCISCO
HAVE BOTH NOW EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AS WE DO
TODAY.
WE OPPOSE SB FIFTY BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE IT WILL NOT DELIVER ON
THE PROMISES OF ITS SPONSORS
BILL IN FACT BE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE IN THE MOST
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
PUT DIFFERENTLY WE BELIEVE THAT
SB FIFTY WILL FURTHER FUEL THE
ENGINE OF GENTRIFICATION THAT IS
DISPLACING WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN
CALIFORNIA.
CONTRIBUTING TO THE CRISES OF IT
SHOULDN'T AFFECT AFFORDABILITY
AND TO THE SPECULATIVE FORCES
THAT DRIVE BOTH WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THE SB FIFTY AS A TOOL
FOR THE EMPOWERMENT WORKING IN
MIDDLE CLASS COMMUNITIES BUT A
WEAPON. FOR THEIR FOR THEIR
DISEMPOWERMENT.
OUR OPPOSITION TO THE SPECIFICS
OF THE BILL AS WE HAVE SO FAR
FALL INTO THREE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES.
FIRST WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THE
AFFORDABILITY MANDATES IN THE
BILL ARE ANYWHERE NEAR
SUFFICIENT TO MEET THE SCALE OF
THE CHALLENGES FACING THE STATE
ALTHOUGH ALL OF KNOWLEDGE
APPARENTLY THERE WILL BE MADE A
MAINTENANCE ME TO THE BILL -- IN
FUTURE ABOUT THAT.
WORD TO MEANINGFULLY IMPACT
DISAPPEAR SHORTFALL IN THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SB FIFTY AS DRAFTED WILL ALMOST
CERTAINLY INDUCE THE NEED FOR
EVEN FURTHER AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION.
OR FOR TRULY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WHICH IS WHAT WE REALLY NEED IN
OUR MAJOR CITIES.
SECOND WE HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS AS
DRAFTED.
ON THE BILL'S TEMPORARY
EXEMPTIONS FOR SENSITIVE
COMMUNITIES.
SB FIFTY IN EFFECT STREETS
GENTRIFICATION IS INEVITABLE IT
ONLY TEMPORARILY EXAMS
GENTRIFYING COMMUNITIES FROM SB
FIFTIES REQUIREMENTS AND IT
WOULD LOCK COMMUNITIES IN TO SB
FIFTY DEFAULTS.
IF THEY CANNOT PROPOSE
ALTERNATIVE PLANS TO AN ACT
PRETTY MUCH THE SAME A FRAMEWORK
THE SB FIFTY REQUIRES THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE WE ALSO HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS BY HOW
SENSITIVE COMMUNITIES WILL BE
DETERMINED.
RAISING CONCERNS OF THE FOR THE
DISEMPOWERMENT OF WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR SUCH AS MY
OWN.
THIRD.
THE MUCH ANNOUNCE DEMOLITION
PROTECTIONS IN SB FIFTY ARE
WOEFULLY INSUFFICIENT WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THESE PROTECTIONS
ARE PRACTICALLY ENFORCEABLE AND
THEREFORE DIFFICULT TO SEE AS
MEANINGFUL PROTECTIONS AT ALL.
IF WE SORRY.
I DON'T MEAN A RATHER WE'RE
GONNA ASK YOU TO CONCLUDE OKAY.
AND LIKE TO DISCLOSE WORKING TWO
QUICK POINTS WE ARE PRESENTLY
CONSIDERING OTHER.
BILLS TO POSSIBLY SUPPORT IN
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE.
AND WE WILL BE MAKING OUR OUR
POINTS ARE NOT MADE LATER ON
INSOFAR AS THE ACTUALLY DO --
WHAT SB FIFTY DOES THEN WE WOULD
BE VERY HAPPY TO EXTEND OUR
SUPPORT IN? FOR THOSE BILLS I DO
NOT BELIEVE THOUGH THAT WOULD BE
HERE TODAY I HAVE TO SAY THAT
HIS BILL HAD PROPERLY CENTER
THE NEEDS OF WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLYTHOSE OF
COLOR.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO WHO ARE OPPOSED REMAIN
HERE AND WE'RE GONNA WELCOME. TO
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT WITNESSES TO
PLEASE JOIN CENTER WIENER NEXT
TO HIM -- SO WE'RE NOW GOING TO
BE TURNING IT OVER TO THOSE WHO
ARE IN OPPOSITION INDOOR WHO ARE
IN BETWEEN.
SO -- MA'AM IF YOU DON'T MIND%
JUST GIVE ME YOUR FIRST LAST IN
YOUR POSITION GOOD MORNING.
BUT MISTER CHAMBERS JENNIFER
SPOKE ABOUT CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS MY
SENSORS POLICY APOLOGIES WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSORS OF SB FIFTY
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU IN A
SENATOR FOR YOUR GOOD WORK ON
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING SANDY
GEORGE REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION -- WERE
REALLY.
HAPPY TO SEE THE AMENDMENTS MANY
OF THEM ARE CONCEPTS CITY PA
SUPPORTS.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO LOOKING
AT THE AMENDMENTS REASSESSING
OUR POSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THE MORNING HEY MORNING JOHN
DUNBAR MAYOR OF THE TOWN OF YON
PHIL AND ALSO THE SECOND VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIACITIES.
I WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
THE GOOD WORK THAT THE AUTHORS
HAVE ALREADY PUT FORWARD.
BUT UNTIL WE SEE FURTHER
AMENDMENTS IT WILL.
PROTECT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AUTHORITY WITH DEVELOPMENT A
LAND USE WE WILL OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED FURTHER THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO MISTER DUNBAR FOR
TRAVELING ALL THIS WAY TO IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU AS ALWAYS SIR
GOOD MORNING MA'AM.
MORNING JILL STEWART OF
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR COALITION TO
PRESERVE PRESERVE LA SIX
THOUSAND MEMBERS.
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE THE BILL
AND WE APPRECIATE THE ATTEMPT
SAID AT A COMPROMISE BUT THIS IS
A GENTRIFICATION BILL LOS%
ANGELES IN THE POOR
NEIGHBORHOODS WHO WE WORK WITH
WE DO WORKSHOPS EVERY WEEK EVERY
MONTH OR SO.
THE WILL BE PUSHED OUT THERE
BEING PUSHED OUT NOW THIS REVS
IT UP AND I'M SORRY TO SAY THAT
I AGREE THAT IT IS NOW TO SIZE
FITS ALL AND IT STILL DOESN'T
WORK.
AND IS FATALLY FLAWED PLEASE
READ SOME OF OUR MATERIALS WE
SENT THEM TO YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
CORINNE WHOLE REPRESENTING
CANOGA PARK RESIDENTS RENTERS
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO WE ARE A
COMMUNITY THAT FIGHTS
GENTRIFICATION.
AND I AM HERE IN A THE FIFTY
THANK YOU SO MUCH BEFORE WE GO
TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER IF WE COULD
PLEASE SHUT THAT DOOR AND I
APOLOGIZE JUST BECAUSE WE HAVE.
A LOT OF NOISE IN THE HALL AND I
WANNA MAKE SURE THEY WERE ABLE
TO HEAR SPEAKERS.
OR HERE DATA.
PRESENT THEIR OPINION.
I APOLOGIZE SIR GOOD MORNING YES
RECALL WITH CULTURAL ACTION
NETWORK.
AN ORGANIZATION ITS ANTI
GENTRIFICATION FIGHTING IN THE
MISSION DISTRICT OF SAN
FRANCISCO NOTING THAT SAN
FRANCISCO OPPOSES THIS BILL --
WE TOTALLY OPPOSE THE EVEN WITH
THE AMENDMENTS WE BELIEVE THAT
IT IS A GENTRIFICATION.
OF MACHINE ON STEROIDS AND THAT
INSTEAD OF HELPING.
IT IS GOING TO EXACERBATE THE BE
ALL THE HOMELESS ISSUE.
THE LOW INCOME HOUSING NEEDS
IT'S GOING TO COST A TON OF
MONEY AND IT'S VERY BAD.
I APPRECIATE THANK YOU SO MUCH
JOHN THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD MORNING MORNING MICHAEL
ARNOLD HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF REDONDO BEACH IN
OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE SUBMITTED
A LETTER THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU MISTER ARNOLD GOOD MORNING
MA'AM THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
YOU KERRY SAID CAN FROM A LSION
VALLEY IN LOS ANGELES CITY I'M
ACTIVE ON MY NEIGHBORHOOD
COUNCIL AND I REPRESENT SIXTEEN
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCILS UP AND
DOWN THE LOS ANGELES RIVER.
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
GENTRIFICATION AND
REVITALIZATION AND WE'RE NOT
SEEING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN OUR
CITY WITH OUR LOCAL POLICIES AND
YET AS AN URBAN PLANNER THAT'S
WHERE IT SHOULD START SO I
WELCOME.
THE MESSAGE FROM SACRAMENTO BUT
I THINK THE DETAIL IS IN
IMPLEMENTING THIS THE STATE
DENSITY PROGRAM IS NOT PRODUCING
AFFORDABILITY EITHER OUR CITY IS
NOT DOING COVENANTS LIKE THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO SO WORK WITH US
LOCALLY.
WE'RE A BIG CITY FOUR MILLION
RESIDENTS.
MAYBE WE SHOULD HAVE A SPECIAL
HOUSING SESSION WITH VOUCHERS
AND YOU KNOW -- MERGES THE
HOUSING FOR HOMELESS PEOPLE WE
HAVE FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE ON
THE STREETS OF LA.
IN AND DISCUSS A THANK YOU FOR
TRAVELING ALL THIS WAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH -- HERE GOOD MORNING
MA'AM MORNING SUSAN HUNTER WITH
THE LOS ANGELES TENANTS UNION
I'M A CASE WORKER FOR THE
HOLLYWOOD LOCAL THIS BILL IS
ONLY GOING TO CREATE ECONOMIC
DISCRIMINATION WE ARE HELLO
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING THIS SILLY SHOW ME
HOW FOR THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THE MORNING THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
HIS IN MARCH WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO TENANTS UNION IN THE
HOUSING RIGHTS COMMITTEE OF SAN
FRANCISCO WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
WE AMONG MANY OTHER REASONS WE
DO NOT BELIEVE THT THE TENANT
PROTECTIONS OF ENFORCEABLE.
OR THAT THEY CAN BE MADE A
FORCIBLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR COMING HERE TODAY
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING CARA
ROUGHLY HALF THE CITIES OF
GLENDALE IN SALON A BEAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD MORNING
MORNING KIANA VALENTINE ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
DID HAVE CONCERNS WITH SB FIFTY
BEFORE ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS
DISCUSS TODAY BUT HAVE HAD
POSITIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR STAFF AND SO LOOK FORWARD
TO REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS AND
REVISING OUR POSITION.
THEY CAN BE FOUND ON MORNING SIR.
GOOD MORNING READING CALVIN
SOLVES UNITED METHODIST PASTOR --
AND ONE WHO WORKS WITH SEVERAL
MULTI RACIAL MULTI FAITH --
ORGANIZATIONS ON THE ISSUE OF
AFFORDABILITY IN EQUITY AND
FIGHTING DISPLACEMENT -- WE KNOW --
ALSO SERVE ON THE THE LOS
ANGELES.
HOUSING SERVICES AUTHORITY AS A
CITY COMMISSIONER.
AND NOW WE KNOW THAT TO THE
ISSUE OF AFFORDABILITY HAD
DISPLACEMENT IS A MORAL.
CHALLENGE FOR US AND WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS --
THIS -- BILL WHICH SHE'S REALLY
DISPLACEMENT ON STEROIDS HE'S
JUST BEING SLOW DOWN BY THE
AMENDMENTS AND SO WE OPPOSE IT
AND LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING
HOW WE CAN MOVE TOWARDS.
YOU KNOW A A MORE DIGNIFIED WAYS
OF DEALING WITH THE CRISIS OF
THE HOUSING CRISIS IN THE STATE
THANK YOU REVEREND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU FOR COMING.
THANK YOU CINDY SILVA MAYOR OF
WALNUT CREEK AND ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE LEAGUE OF CITIES BOARD.
ON A FEW ISSUES -- OPPOSE UNLESS
IT'S AMENDED WE BELIEVE THE
DEFINITION OF JOB RICHEST TOO
VAGUE AND WILL ACTUALLY INCREASE
THE USE OF SINGLE OCCUPANCY
VEHICLES AND MANY OF OUR
SUBURBAN COMMUNITIES.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS -- ALSO IS
GOING TO LEAD TO SPECULATION
AROUND TRANSIT SO THAT LAND
PRICES WILL RISE WHICH WILL NOT
ADDRESS THE AFFORDABILITY ISSUE.
AND IN ADDITION THIS DOES NOT
ADDRESS THAT WE HAVE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND UNITS IN THE
ENTITLED AND IN THE PIPELINE
THAT WE CAN'T GET OUT OF THE
PIPELINE TO THE LACK OF
AVAILABILITY OF LABOR.
OR FINANCING THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM MAYOR THEY GIVE A
TRAVELING HERE TODAY THE MORAL
HAS Q. AND MAYOR PRO TEM OF
WALNUT CREEK AND SHE ALREADY
SAID EVERYTHING GOOD SO.
THANK YOU FOR TEN THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY.
GOOD MORNING MA'AM -- HAGENS
COUNCILMAN AND FORMER MAYOR OF
THE CITY OF OAKLEY WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB.
FIFTY THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH COUNCILMAN APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY GOOD MORNING IN GOD
MILLER MAYOR OF THE CITY EVER
RENDA AND THEY ARE SILVA FROM
WALNUT CREEK STATED OUR POSITION
WHICH IS THAT WE ARE OPPOSED AT
THIS POINT AND WE HOPE TO BE.
OF AGREEMENT WITH FURTHER
AMENDMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH BEEN A BEAR THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE GOOD MORNING AND
ORDERS MATT REGION WITH THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL I APOLOGIZE I
COULDN'T GET ANY EARLIER AT AT
TO THE SUPPORT LINE BUT WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL -
BUILDING HOMES DOES NOT CAUSE
DISPLACEMENT NOT BUILDING HOMES
CAUSES DISPLACEMENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING HELLO.
JULIE TELLS THE CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER PLEASANTON.
I OPPOSE SB.
FIFTY IT IS THE A BILL THAT YOU
SURPLUS LOCAL CONTROL BENEFIT
SPECIAL INTEREST AND WILL NOT
SOLVE.
THE CALIFORNIA AFFORDABILITY
PROBLEM THANK YOU.
ALEX GIVES HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
REMAINING TRI VALLEY CITIES OF
DANVILLE DUBLIN PLEASANTON
LIVERMORE AND SAN RAMON AS WELL
CITY OF LAFAYETTE.
POSE UNLESS AMENDED BUT WE THINK
THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH US THROUGH
THIS PROCESS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR YOUR HERE GOOD MORNING MA'AM
THE MORNING -- MY NAME'S EVA
CHELL I'M FROM -- SAN FRANCISCO
AND ALSO I'M WITH A LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL I THINK EVERYBODY.
HERE SHOOT TRY TO THINK OUTSIDE
OF THE BOX UNITED STATES IS THE
LAND RICH UP PLACE WE DON'T HAVE
TO PACK EVERYONE CRAM EVERYONE
INTO A SMALL PLACE.
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE IN ASIA ALL
THE ASIAN COUNTRIES I'VE JUST
REASON RECENTLY BEEN TO IN
EUROPE THAT'S WHAT THEY DO
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER LAND.
AND THEY HAVE TO FILL UP UNITED
STATES WERE LAMB.
I APOLOGIZE MA'AM I'LL GIVE YOU
BACK YOUR TIMING WE CAN THIS
HAVE FOLKS TO SINCE WE HAVE A
LOT OF SPEAKERS IN AGAIN WE ARE
SO GRATEFUL THAT ALL OF YOU'VE
BEEN SO PATIENT NO WE HAVE A LOT
OF FOLKS.
I AM I APOLOGIZE TO FLOOR IS
YOURS CAN GIVE YOU ABOUT FIFTEEN
MORE SECONDS OR AT THE MOVE ON
TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER I APOLOGIZE
FOR INTERRUPTING YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT -- I'M SAYING
THAT UNITED STATES IS LAND RICH
WE SHOULD THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX
WE DON'T HAVE TO ALL.
CRAM EVERYONE THE ONE PLACE WEEK
PEOPLE WILL MOVE TO WHERE THE
JOBS AREN'T LET'S ASK THE
COMPANIES. TO MOVE AND SPREAD
OUT TO OTHER COUNTRIES COUNTIES
AND REGIONS IT WILL BE A LOT
CHEAPER AND LOVE.
MAKE HOUSING A LOT MORE
AFFORDABLE AND AT THE SAME TIME
HIGHER QUALITY OF LIVING FOR
EVERYONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND AGAIN I
APOLOGIZE FOR INTERRUPTING YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JORGE CASTANEDA.
THE COALITION TO PRESERVE A LAMB
A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER I'M ALSO
WITH THE BOYLE HEIGHTS --
COMMITTEE PARTNERS -- THIS IS A
SILLY BILL.
THIS IS A PRO LUXURY DEVELOPMENT
AND PRO MARKET RATE DEVELOPMENT
BILL WHEN WHAT'S NEEDED IS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND IT NEEDS
TO BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
PLEASE SPONSORED OPPOSE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ATTENDING TODAY GOOD MORNING SIR
GOOD MORNING HONORABLE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS ALI TAJ.
TEACHER LOS I MISCARRY OPPOSE
THE BILL ON THE SUSPENDED.
I THINK IT MEANS A LOT TO YOU
HERE TODAY THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING SIR GOOD MORNING NEW
ALIGNER IT'S SIX TERM MAYOR OF
DANVILLE ARCHITECT HOUSING
DEVELOPER.
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY'S MAYOR'S
REPRESENTATIVE ON HOUSING.
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED FIRST IT'S
A GOOD IDEA TO COMBINE AS BEFORE
SB.
FIFTY THERE ARE THREE POINTS ONE
DENSITY IS NOT THE SOLUTION IN
TERMS OF HIGH.
AS AN ARCHITECT OF DESIGN LARGER
UNITS AND WILL MAKE MONEY.
DENSITY SHOULD BE DENSITY NOT
HIGH SECONDLY THERE SHOULD BE A
PROVISION IN THERE.
THAT IT DOES NOT ALLOW GREATER
THAN 50%.
INCREASE IN DENSITY FOR HIGH.
OF THE ADJACENT USES THAT'S GOOD
URBAN DESIGN THANK YOU AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING MORE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU SO MUCH
JUST MAYOR GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE
GOOD MORNING MA'AM.
MAILING STEPHAN OPPOSING FOR
MYSELF AND FOR SUNNYVALE
NEIGHBORS SUPPORTING LOW TO
DEMOCRACY AND SUSTAINABLE AND
EQUITABLE CITY PLANNING AND
GARRETT AND GAUGING LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
CITIES DO A BETTER JOB OF PUBLIC
OUTREACH IT'S REALLY HARD FOR
PEOPLE TO COME HERE TO SPEAK.
AND PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON IN SACRAMENTO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU FOR ATTENDING THANK
YOU FOR MAKING THE CLOVER GOOD
MORNING SIR THE MORNING MY
NAME'S TOMMY BUSTLE OF SENSE
CALIFORNIA.
ME AND MANY OTHERS IN MY
ARGUMENT A VERY OPPOSED SB FIFTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
TRAVELLING VERY GRATEFUL SIR
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DONE ON
THE FIELD FROM THE SAYS
CALIFORNIA OF A SUBSTANCE
BECAUSE THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR
THE MORNING.
A LOT ABOUT HIS FAMILY.
MISTER WINNER THE LAST LAST YEAR
YOU SAY YOU YOU LOST.
NOW MICHAEL ONCE HE THANK YOU
FOR COMING SIR GOOD MORNING
MONEY MY NAME IS FERNANDO
CARREIRA ARE YOU LA.
THE STAFF IS MAYES FIFTY PLEASE.
THE HOUSES ISN'T RIGHT APARTMENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MORNING.
MY NAME IS HELLO GROUPS.
THE LADY RAMOS I PLEASE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
MORNING SIR.
THE ONLY NUMBER ROLLED BEING OUT
OF A LOT BEEN LITTLE FOCUS.
THANK YOU FOR TO MAKE SURE THAT
FOLKS ARE TO SPEAKING IN THE
MIKE TO SO WE CAN GET YOUR WORDS
I APOLOGIZE PLACER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS BUILDINGS THREE STORY
BUILDINGS AND OUT OF THAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MA'AM I'M GONNA HAVE YOU JUST
HOLD ONE MOMENT.
I APOLOGIZE YOU CAN TRY TO GIVE
VOICE IS DOWN JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE GIVE AS MUCH
ATTENTION AS POSSIBLE TO ALL OF
OUR SPEAKERS.
ON THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
I'M SHARON SPRINGER VICE MAYOR
OF BURBANK AND I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SB FIFTY AND THE
AMENDMENTS WE RECENTLY --
COMMITTED TO TWELVE THOUSAND
UNITS OVER FIFTEEN YEARS
CONSISTENT WITH OUR GENERAL PLAN
OUR HOW HOUSING ELEMENT.
AND ARENA NUMBERS THIS BILL AND
THE AMENDMENTS HAVE A COMPLETE
DISREGARD FOR OUR GENERAL PLAN
OUR HOUSING ELEMENT.
RESPONSIBLE MINDFUL PLANNING AND
ARE COMPETENT.
WELL EDUCATED PLANNING STAFF
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
BETTER VICE MAYOR GOOD MORNING
SIR THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE MY
NAME IS IAN OFTEN ALSO IN FROM.
CANADA BUT CALIFORNIA THIS IS
THE PURPOSES SB.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS THE
MORNING.
WARNING ON JOHNSON IS CLOSER --
KOREATOWN AND I OPPOSE A ON SB
FIFTY THANK YOU SO MUCH MORNING
CLOSE ON SB FIFTY THANK YOU VERY
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS SIR GOOD
MORNING SIR.
THANK YOU SIR THE MOTOR MIDDLE
ROOKIE IS IN CONTROL THERE.
THE LUXURY HOUSING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS TO
MORNING.
BINGO IN LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
IS THREE AND COULD PLAY LASSEN
CUENTA.
STOP.
THANK YOU SIR GOOD MORNING.
MONEY MINIMUS ONE CONTEST I AM
LEAVING THE LOS ANGELES
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MORNING MY NAME IS MARK RUFFALO
MASON IF YOU TOOK A STEP OF
THESE.
EVENTS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING WHEN THE WHEN THEY
RESORT ALASKA THIS A IT.
DOESN'T IS OF NO REAL.
IS THE IS THE VICTIM.
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD MORNING THE MORNING MY NAME
IS ON THE MEND THEIR METABOLISM
PLEASE.
FIFTY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING RECTOR FOR ACE
ACTION AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO SB
FIFTY UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS NANCY
SHARE FROM SIX ON THE MONICA
CALIFORNIA PLACE TO STOP THE SB.
FIFTY THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE MORNING.
MORNING MICHAEL BARNES IS CITY
OF ALBANY COUNCILMEMBER OPPOSED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH COUNCIL MEMBER
GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU JACKSON HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION HIGHLAND PARK
CALIFORNIA WHICH WERE IS A BI
NATIONAL PUBLIC RADIO.
CALLED THE GROUND ZERO OF
GENTRIFICATION.
OF LONG TIME RESIDENT.
AND REALLY RESULT IN THE ENTIRE
STATE.
WITHOUT A STUDY A PLAN ANYTHING
THEY DON'T REZONE THE TINIEST
CITY WITHOUT THAT.
THIS IS JUST MEGALOMANIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM MA'AM
DO FOR YOU I SPEAK OF IS OKAY
WE'RE GONNA START TRANSITION
FOLKS WE ALL WANT TO START
COMING OVER WILL START TO NOT
OVER HERE.
THANK YOU EVEN DODGER FANS SO
SEE THERE YOU GO HI TODAY.
NOW WE'RE GETTING SAY THERE YOU
GO HI.
ALL RIGHT MA'AM I APOLOGIZE I
DID NOT MEAN IRAQ THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING IN Q. MY NAME IS TO BE
DEPRESSED CITY ON THE POLICY
MANAGER WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PERSONS WITH CHILDREN -- WE DO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
AMENDMENTS AND WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF IT -- WE STILL
THINK THERE IS SOME WORK TO DO
AND SO WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO BE A THORN IN YOUR SIDE WITH
RESPECT TO TRYING TO KEEP THE
PROCESS HONEST AND MAKING SURE
THEY WERE ALL GOING IN THE BEST
DIRECTION FOR THE STATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
ATTENDING HEARING TODAY GOOD
MORNING.
MORNING MY NAME IS PAUL BRILEY A
POLICY FELLOW WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN.
WE OPPOSE UNTIL FURTHER
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOOD MORNING MA'AM.
ON A MY NAME IS HERRIOT DAVIS
I'M A CITIZEN OF ALAMEDA COUNTY.
AND I'M WITH ALL OF US IN ON THE
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PERSONS WITH
CHILDREN I'M A REGISTERED NURSE
AND A MOTHER OF THREE AND
GRANDMOTHER OF NINE PLUS -- I
OPPOSE SB FIFTY THANK YOU SO
MUCH [inaudible]
THE MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KATIE
DIXON I'M A POLICY FELLOW ELLIS
PIECE IN ALL THOSE UNKNOWN I'M
HERE TODAY AS A POOR CALIFORNIA
CITIZEN.
I POLLS SB FIFTY YEAH RIGHT -- I
ONLY MAKE FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR I CANNOT AFFORD THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT YOU GUYS
HAVE START AT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND I CANNOT AFFORD
THAT WITH THREE OF MY SALARIES.
PLEASE THIS IS NOT I CAN'T
AFFORD IT I'M ONLY SPEND I CAN
AFFORD IT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY THE MORNING.
ACCORDING TO RECENT GEHRINGER
COUNCIL MEMBER FROM THE CITY OF
LAFAYETTE AND WE ARE OPPOSE IT
MUST AMENDED I DO I LOOK FORWARD
WITH THE OTHER EAST BAY CITIES
AND TOWNS AND WORKING ON HOW WE
CAN WORK TO GET AN AGREEMENT ON
THIS.
SOLVING THE IMPORTANT ISSUE
THANK YOU.
I SEVEN COMMITTEE CITY
COUNCILMAN THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING HI THERE MY NAME IS TO
MAKE ITEM THE VICE MAYOR OF THE-CITY OF CONCORD AND WE ARE
OPPOSED TO SB FIFTY UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER VICE MAYOR.
GOOD MORNING SIR SB FIFTY WILL
NOT SOLVE THE HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA WHAT WAS STOP IS MORE
A. B. YOU YET MINUTES.
MORE AT INFILL UNITS.
THE MORE YOU HAVE.
WE'RE GOING TO WANT URBAN SPRAWL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR.
MORNING MA'AM HELLO GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS LOU BAD A LACK OF THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR TENANTS TO
GATHER WE ARE A COALITION OF
OVER THIRTY ORGANIZATION
STATEWIDE.
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL --
WE DEFINITELY BELIEVE THAT THE
POWER TO CHANGE YOUR CITY SHOULD
BE WITHIN THE COMMUNITIES THAT
EXIST AND IT SHOULD NOT BE GIVEN
TO THE STATE AS A ONE FOR ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU HERE GOOD
MORNING SIR.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS A PART
OF TOURISM THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL COORDINATOR
WITH TENANTS TOGETHER I STRONGLY
SUPPORT OPPOSE SB FIFTY I
CURRENTLY LIVE IN A POINT IN
UNINCORPORATED IMPOVERISHED
COMMUNITY IN EAST CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY WHERE THEY KEEP BUILDING.
MORE APARTMENTS BUT IT'S NOT
AFFORDABLE AND AND
JUSTIFICATIONS ALREADY HAPPENED
WE NEED TO STOP AT ALL COSTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
GOOD MORNING.
THE SECURE MEMBERS RAND MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION I THINK THESE MANY
FINE PEOPLE SAID IT ALL
ESPECIALLY THOSE WERE LIVING IN
COMMUNITIES ARE LIKELY TO BE
IMPACTED NEGATIVELY BY SB.
FIFTY AND WE URGE OUR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN YOUR N
COMMITTEE THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO DO A LAST CALL.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO OPPOSE
HIM TO DO THIS TWICE.
LAST CALL FIRST TIME LAST CALL
FOR THOSE FOR POSTED TO PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
OUR SECOND TO LAST TIME LAST
CALL FOR THOSE WHO OPPOSE IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD
[inaudible]
OKAY.
GEN WE'D LIKE TO NOW BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE GONNA BE DOING HERE IS
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION.
WITH THE COMMITTEE -- AND CENTER
WIENER -- THEN WE WILL -- TAKE A
BRIEF BREAK IS WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO DO SOME PAPERWORK OUT FOR
ABOUT TWO MINUTES AFTER THE
COMMITTEES ABLE TO HAVE DIALOGUE
AND CONVERSATION AND THEN WILL
BE ASKING. FOR A MOTION AFTER%
THAT BRIEF RECESS THERE'S A
GENTLEMAN OF THE COMMITTEE LET'S
OPEN IT UP WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
CHAIR AND THERE IT IS.
MR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU FOR DOING A GREAT JOB
IN THIS HEARING AND I APOLOGIZE.
TO YOU AND TO THE SENATOR WIENER
FOR HAVING TO GO.
JUMP UNFORTUNATELY FOR EVERYBODY
ELSE'S HERE WE'VE GOT A NUMBER
OF HEARINGS HAPPENING AT THE
SAME TIME.
AND ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE HAVE IS THESE WHEN WE HAVE
THESE DEADLINES WE HAVE MEMBERS
WHERE WERE FINAL TENUOUSLY ON
DIFFERENT COMMITTEES SO I JUST
WANTED.
TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU AND I
WANTED TO YOU KNOW LOOK.
THIS IS FROM MY POINT OF VIEW
AND HONEST EFFORT BY A EXCELLENT
SENATOR.
WAS A MAN OF INTEGRITY DO NOT
THE STREETS HIS NAME BECAUSE
HE'S AS IDEAS THAT MAY NOT AGREE
WITH YOU BUT HE HAS THE GUTS TO
TRY HIS IDEAS.
I OPPOSE THOSE IDEAS BUT THAT'S
WHAT THIS DELIBERATION IS ABOUT
MR BOWERS IS HERE IS A MAN OF
GREAT INTEGRITY.
AND GREAT STRENGTH IN THESE
PEOPLE ARE GOOD PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRYING TO SOLVE A PROBLEM.
SO I JUST I WANT TO SAY THAT YOU
KNOW I I LOVE MY MOTHER BUT I
DON'T ALWAYS AGREE WITH HER.
AND THAT'S THE GENIUS OF THIS
PROCESS ON IT ALSO I HAVE NOT
BEEN SOMEONE I REPRESENT THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
AND SINCE MR.
SINCE THE AUTHOR MISTER WEINER
IT INTRODUCES MEASURE LAST YEAR
I FELT.
A MORAL RESPONSIBILITY.
NOT TO BE SOMEBODY.
WHO JUST SAYS I DISAGREE WITH
HIS IDEA?
WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM
THAT HE CORRECTLY NOTES HE'S
RIGHT.
I DON'T NECESSARILY AGREE AS TO
THE REASONS FOR THE PROBLEMS BUT
WE CLEARLY HAVE A HOUSING ISSUE
THAT AFFECTS A MULTITUDE OF
FOLKS IN COMMUNITIES AND
AFFORDABILITY OBJECTIFICATION
AND PEOPLE FIND THEMSELVES
HOMELESS AND ALL OF THOSE ISSUES.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT'S THE
PROPER APPROACH.
AND SO I STARTED LAST YEAR IN
LOS ANGELES THAT I REPRESENTED A
HOMEWORK I DID MY OWN HOMEWORK I
SO I DON'T HAVE AN ABILITY TO
JUST SAY NO.
AND I ALSO PROMISED THE SENATOR
IT WHICH I THINK THE HONORABLE
THING TO DO BECAUSE WE WORK
TOGETHER ON SO MANY MATTERS I
WOULD DEMAGOGUE AGAINST HIS
MEASURE WHICH I HAVE NOT DONE.
MY PUBLIC POSITION IS I DID NOT
SUPPORT ITS CURRENT FORM AND I
DON'T SUPPORT NOW FOR MORE
REASONS.
SO WHAT I WANTED TO DO IT BEFORE
I ASKED HIM A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS WHICH IS TO SHARE SOME
THINKING PUBLICLY WHICH I
HAVEN'T DONE.
A BECAUSE I THINK THAT.
IT'S IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF THIS
THIS LARGER DEBATE.
MY ENTIRE CITY COUNCIL FROM THE
EAST SIDE OF LOS ANGELES FROM
HIGHLAND PARK TO BOYLE HEIGHTS
TO SOUTH LA SAID NO.
WHY WHY WHAT'S GOING ON THE
QUESTION IS A DEAR FRIEND OF
MINE OF MENTIONS TO SOME OF THE
AT THE COULD YOU COME TO MY
OFFICE IS IN THE HIGH TECH
BUSINESS SAID?
DON'T FALL IN LOVE WITH THE
SOLUTION FALL IN LOVE WITH THE
PROBLEM.
THE PROBLEM IS HOW DO WE GET
MORE HOUSING.
BECAUSE I WOULD SUGGEST THAT ONE
OF THE BIG REASONS WHEN ARNOLD
SCHWARZENEGGER WAS GOVERNOR I
WORKED ON THIS.
WE HAVE WHAT'S CALLED BRADLEY
BURNS WITH AS AN INCENTIVE TO
BUILD BIG BOX RETAIL IN THE BILL
AUTO MALLS AND WE WANTED TO
REVERSE THAT WE DIDN'T WIN WE
CREATE INCENTIVE TO BUILD
HOUSING.
THERE'S A SERIES OF REASONS WHY
THAT'S THE CASE.
THERE'S AS TO WHY HOUSING AS MEN
BUILT IT'S NOT ECONOMICALLY
ADVANTAGES IT'S BEEN A NUMBER OF
OTHER REASONS IT'S IMPORTANT
WHEN WE DIAGNOSE THIS. TO
UNDERSTAND IN MY VIEW THAT IT'S
A LARGER S. THE LARGER ISSUE IN
THAT REGARD.
IN SO.
I LOOKED AT AND THINK THAT WHAT
GOVERNOR NEWSOME IS DOING IS
QUITE BRILLIANT.
AND I'VE BEEN TRYING TO PUT SOME.
REAL ELBOW GREASE INTO IT WITH A
NUMBER OF INTERNS AND STAFF IN
MY OFFICE IN LOS ANGELES.
WHICH BASICALLY SAYS THE
GOVERNOR DID EXECUTIVE ORDER FOR
THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW THAT SAYS
LET'S LOOK AT STATE PROPERTY.
LET'S SEE.
HE'S IDENTIFIED FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND PIECES.
OF PROPERTY.
OF THAT HE'S IDENTIFIED THIRTEEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY I THINK THAT
ACTUALLY COULD POTENTIALLY BE
THE CASE BE AVAILABLE.
THE TEAM WOULD WHO WITH WHOM I
HAVE COMMUNICATED WITH IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
DONE AN EXCELLENT JOB AND
SCRUBBING THIS.
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS AN R.
BETTER THAN I ACTUALLY
ANTICIPATED IS THEY'RE LOOKING
AT THOSE PARCELS AND SAYING OKAY
WHICH ONES REALLY AREN'T
AVAILABLE?
WHICH ONES DO WORK FOR A NUMBER
OF OTHER REASONS THAT ARE
ENCUMBERED FOR OTHER RASONS
THEY'RE ALSO ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATIONS THROUGH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ENTITY CALIFORNIA
LEGAL CITIES.
ASKING CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
SAY CAN WE HARSH TRADE OTHER
PROPERTIES THAT COULD BE GOOD
FOR HOUSING THAT WOULD WORK FOR
FOLKS.
BOMB THAT WE COULD TRADE WITH
YOU AND I'M TOLD THAT IN LAKE
COUNTY THERE'S A MILITARY
SURPLUS PROPERTY IT'S BEING
DISCUSSED I'M TOLD THAT THERE'S
A SIMILAR PROPERTY IN SANTA CRUZ.
I'VE MADE SIMILAR REQUESTS FOR
PEOPLE IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES IT'S NOT YOU KNOW AND
THE IDEA BEHIND WITH THE
GOVERNOR WANTS TO DO.
IS THAT IF WE CAN IDENTIFY THIS
PROPERTY WHATEVER IT IS WE CAN A
SINCE WE OWN IT WE CAN LEASE IT
FOR A DOLLAR A YEAR SO LITTLE
AMOUNT OF MONEY.
WHAT'S HAPPENING UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL IS WE'RE GONNA INCREASE
LAND COSTS MY SIGNIFICANT OTHERS
PARENTS LIVE IN A HOUSE IN
HOLLYWOOD.
AND THEY PAID.
TAX DOLLARS AND NOW THEY WANT
TWENTY X. BECAUSE IT'S GOT
APARTMENT BUILDINGS AND MOS
LIKELY WANT TO TEAR IT DOWN WITH
AN APARTMENT BUILDINGS.
AND SO THEY'LL MAKE A WINDFALL
THAT'S GREAT BUT DOESN'T REALLY
SOLVE THE UNDERLYING
ARCHITECTURE THE PROBLEM IN
TERMS OF MONEY IF YOU CAN REDUCE
LAND COSTS HOW TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM THREE THINGS ONE REDUCE
LAND COSTS.
IF THE GOVERNMENT CAN DO THIS
ACROSS THE STATE FOR VERY FEW
DOLLARS ALL OF A SUDDEN
DRAMATICALLY CHANGE THE ISSUE.
TOO IF YOU COULD EXPEDITE AS
UPSET AS BEFORE DOES TO SOME
EXTENT THE APPROVAL PROCESS ON
THOSE SPECIFICALLY DESIGNATED
STATE PROPERTIES.
YOU DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE
SPEED ONE OF THE GREAT
CHALLENGES THAT I'VE BEEN
FRUSTRATED WITH IT IS I'VE GOING
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES THAT I
REPRESENT TALKING HOMEOWNERS.
WERE OUT THERE WRITING A CHECK
FOR FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
BECAUSE ALL THE MAYORS ARE
SAYING WE WANT MONEY FOR PEOPLE
FIND THEMSELVES HOMELESSNESS.
I BRING THEM IN THE OFFICE HOW
MANY BILLS THEY'RE COMING IN
ASKING FOR THE CHECK THIS YEAR
WHAT HAVE YOU DONE I'M SORRY.
YOU IN IN IN CITIES ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES YOU APPROVED
ALL SORTS OF MONEY WHAT HAS BEEN
PRODUCED PEOPLE ARE FRUSTRATED
THEY'RE ANGRY DELIVERABLE TIMES
ARE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT NOT
JUST TO SAY WE HAVE A POLICY.
WE'VE GOT TO DO IT
INSTANTANEOUSLY THESE AMENDMENTS
I SAW TALK ABOUT FACTORS
RELATING.
TO TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THIRD WE
HAVE EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE OPPORTUNITIES OWNS THAT
HAVE BEEN DESIGNATED THAT
PROVIDE CAPITAL CAPITAL SPEED OF
APPROVAL.
SHE PLAN COSTS I WOULD ADD IN
BECAUSE IT'S MY POLITICS I WANT
PREVAILING WAGE ON ALL THOSE
PROPERTIES BECAUSE I WANT PEOPLE
EARN A FAIR WAGE THAT'S MY
POLITICS.
SO BOTTOM LINE IS.
THE WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S WORKING
ON AND I'VE TALKED TO THE PEOPLE
IN A VERY IMPRESSED BY THE SPEED
WITH WHICH THE WORKING SO IF IT
IN TERMS OF THE DELIVERABLE OF
HOW DO WE BUILD FOUR MILLION
UNITS.
HOW DO WE MAKE THIS STUFF HAPPEN
ASQUICKLY AS POSSIBLE HOW DO WE
ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING COSTS THE
ISSUE OBJECTIFICATION
AFFORDABILITY IS DIRECTLY
RELATED TO COST BY CAN BUILD THE
PLACE TO COST ME FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS?
I CAN'T RENTED FOR A HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH IF I CAN BUILD A
PLACE TO COST FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS I CAN RENT IT FOR LESS
MONEY.
SO YOU HAVE TO TREAD TRY TO DO
THAT AND WHILE THIS IS AN
INTERESTING APPROACH AND I LOOK
AT THESE GUYS HAVE WORKED THEIR
HEARTS OUT -- THE ONLY OTHER
THINGS I WANT TO SHARE IS WHAT
WE'VE DONE AND I'VE SEEN THIS IN
POLITICS I WAS ON THE PAYROLL IN
THIS PLACE ONE MILE REAGAN WAS
GOVERNOR.
BROWN A LONG TIME AND SEEN A LOT
OF STUFF I DON'T KNOW IF I'M
RIGHT I JUST HAVE GOTTEN THE
GUTS TO ASK QUESTIONS.
AND WHAT I LOOK AT HERE IS.
THIS IS ONE OF THESE THINGS
WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO GET A
MEASURE THROUGH BUT WHAT WE'RE
WE HAVE WE HAVE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA WE NOW
HAVE THIS AND MERGE APPROACHES
AS WELL FORTY THREE COUNTIES
HAVE. ONE FORTY FIVE COUNTIES
HAVE ONE RULE.
THE FORTY FORTY THREE COUNTY
SOMEONE RULES AND FIFTEEN
COUNTIES OF ANOTHER RULE BECAUSE
THEY'RE SMALLER THAN.
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND AT LEAST I
MAY BE WRONG ON THIS BUT MY
READING OF EXEMPTION OF COASTAL
ZONES MEANING THAT THIS THIS
RULE DOES NOT APPLY TO THE CITY
OF DEL MAR WHICH IS APPLIED TO
THE CITY OF MALIBU.
IS THAT JUSTICE IS THAT RIGHT
CERTAINLY IT BEARS A QUESTION IN
TERMS OF THE EXEMPTION OF
COASTAL ZONES.
YOU KNOW CERTAIN THE BUS ROUTES
ARE ISSUES THE CHALLENGE ME
BECAUSE WE'RE BASICALLY
TRANSFERRING LAND USE POLICIES
TO THE TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES.
OF WHAT THEY DO I KNOW SOME OF
THE CORRECTIONS BUT I ONLY GOT
THIS EIGHT FORTY FIVE THIS MORE
EIGHT FIFTEEN THIS MORNING.
AND I HAD A CONVERSATION GOOD
CONVERSATION WITH THE GREAT
CHAIRMAN OF THIS COMMITTEE
TRYING TO GET A HANDLE ON IT.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS.
YOU KNOW.
I AM I AM NOT SUPPORTING THIS BY
ANY STRETCH IMAGINATION I HAVE
HELD QUIET BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT
WAS RESPECTFUL TO MY COLLEAGUES.
IT IN WORKING AN INSTITUTION
LIKE THIS THIS IS HOW I WORK.
I DON'T THINK IT'S RIGHT TO
DEMAGOGUE AGAINST YOUR
COLLEAGUES IT'S IT'S STAND UP
FOR ISSUES BUT I JUST LOOK AT
HOW THIS APPROACHES AND I SE
THAT IS FROM MY POINT OF VIEW A
COBBLING TOGETHER OF A NUMBER OF
INTERESTS -- THAT DON'T REALLY
GET TO THE POINT THAT I TALK
ABOUT IN THAT THAT THE THIS.
A HIGH TECH PERSON SAYS FALL IN
LOVE WITH THE PROBLEM NOT THE
SOLUTION.
AND WE HAVE FALLEN IN LOVE WITH
THE SOLUTION AND TRY TO RE
JIGGER IT SOMETIMES IT WORKS AND
SOMETIMES IT DOESN'T WHAT WE
HAVE AS AN ALTERNATIVE ON THE
TABLE IS THERE SOME MEMBERS THAT
HAVE ABILITY. TO MOVE THE
PROCESS QUICKLY WITH THE
GOVERNOR IS DOING IS ELEGANT.
ELEGANT AND SO TO ME BY ORDERS
OF MAGNITUDE HOW TO GET THINGS
DONE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
WOULD BE -- TO UTILIZE THAT AND
THE LAST THING I WOULD SAY IS OF
COURSE THAT'S NOT A BIG ENOUGH
SOLUTION.
MR WE I THINK YOU'RE CORRECT BUT
THE IDEA OF AND I'M NOT A BIG
FAN IWAS CHAIRMAN THIS
COMMITTEE WAS SAID I AND AND THE
PEOPLE HAVE LEGAL CITIES KNOW
THAT I'M NOT A BIG FAN OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND I THINK THEY DO A LOT OF
STUFF THAT'S WRONG A LOT OF
TIMES.
BUT BUT THAT'S NOT IT.
THE QUESTION IS THROWING OUT THE
ZONING IN MY CITY AS YOU KNOW
FROM CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD A
MISTER WINNER IT IS THIS IS A
VERY DIFFERENT SITUATION -- IN
LOS ANGELES HAS AGREED BAY CITY --
AND CERTAINLY THE COMMUNITIES
THAT I REPRESENT BUT BROUGHT
MORE BROADLY SPEAKING I'M I
THINK NOT JUST ABOUT THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY WHICH IS I
REPRESENT WITH EVERY BONE IN MY
BODY.
BUT ALSO THE REST OF THE CITY
THAT I HAVE HAD GREAT EPERIENCE
WITH ALL AROUND THE PLACE AND
THE COUNTY.
AND SO YOU KNOW YOU LOOK AT WHY
WHY THESE FOLKS HAVE DONE WHAT
THEY'VE DONE AND WHAT THEY SAID.
YEAH IT'S A TORTILLA OVER LOCAL
JURISDICTION YOUR NO QUESTION
SIR THE QUESTION BUT I I DO
THINK THAT THERE'S A LARGER
DYNAMIC HERE THAT I DON'T THINK.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE SOLUTION
AND I THINK THAT WE'VE CREATED
SO MANY MORE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES WITH RESPECT TO
THIS APPROACH.
ON THAT WE NEED TO TAKE IT BACK
TO THE DRAWING BOARD BUT
CONTINUE TO ROLL UP OUR SLEEVES
AND I WILL CONTINUE SERVER
EASIER JUST ABOUT CLOSEST TO THE
HARDEST WORKING PERSON.
I THINK HE IS THE HARDEST
WORKING PERSON YOUR NUMBER --
TWO IN THIS BUILDING AND TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU IN
THAT REGARD BUT I WANT TO SHARE
MY THINKING AFTER I GOT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO READ ALL THIS
STUFF.
AND HAPPY TO HEAR ANY OTHER
RESPONSES BUT IT HAS BEEN A A
LOT OF HOMEWORK FOR ME AND IT'S
BEEN A LOT A LOT OF TIME.
AND I'VE GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
WORKING ON THIS IN MY COMMUNITY
WE HAVE OVER EIGHT THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED UNITS ON THE ORANGE LINE
THAT WE PUT IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY SO WE HAVE RESPONDED IN A
VERY SIGNIFICANT WAY TO TRANCE
OR IN DEVELOPMENT.
THERE'S TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
MORE UNITS UNDER CONSERVATIVE
PERMIT IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THE BIGGEST SINCE WE'VE
HAD SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE SO
CORRECT WE HAVE A PROBLEM.
CORRECT IT'S A BIG DEAL GIGANTIC
LEE IMPORTANT THAT YOU HAVE
RAISED EVERYBODY'S ATTENTION BY
VIRTUE WHAT YOU'VE DONE YOU HAVE
BROUGHT THIS TO THE FOREFRONT
AND YOU DESERVE GREAT CREDIT FOR
THAT.
NOW LET'S QUIT LET'S SAY HOW DO
WE MARCH FORWARD AND THOSE ARE
THE CONCERNS THAT I HAVE SIR.
HE SO MUCH AS A MAJORITY LEADER
WE'RE GONNA HAVE CENTER WIENER
BE ABLE TO RESPOND THEN WE'D
LIKE YOU TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
VICE CHAIR CENTER WIENER.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU -- CENTER HEARD FOR
FOR THOSE COMMENTS. TO BE VERY
CLEAR ON THE ONLY THE ONLY.
TIME I FALL IN LOVE WITH
ANYTHING IS WITH -- FAMILY AND
FRIENDS I DON'T FALL IN LOVE
WITH PROBLEMS OR SOLUTIONS
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD FALL IN
LOVE WITH THIS PROBLEM THIS IS A
TOXIC PROBLEM THAT IS
DEBILITATING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OUR ENVIRONMENT.
OUR ECONOMY THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
STATE IS PUSHING PEOPLE OUT.
IS PUSHING PEOPLE AND YOU KNOW
IN YOUR DISTRICT SENATOR AND MY
DISTRICT HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
COMMUTING. TWO PLUS HOURS EACH
WAY EVERY DAY TO GO TO WORK
BECAUSE YOUR CITY AND MY CITY
HAVE MADE IT IMPOSSIBLE TO BUILD
ENOUGH HOUSING SO THOSE WORKERS
CAN ACTUALLY LIVE IN THE CITY
AND THERE'S TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY ON THE ROAD.
SPEWING CARBON INTO THE AIR ****
UP THEIR BACKS. 60% OF THE
PEOPLE THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
THAT LIVE IN THE VALLEY WORK IN
THE VALLEY WE'VE CHANGE THAT
AROUND IT'S IT'S OUR ASSUMPTION
THAT'S WRONG WITH ALL WITH ALL
RESPECT WE HAVE A HUGE IN
COMMUTES BOTH IN THE LA AND INTO
THE BAY AREA.
AND IT IS CAUSING REAL DAMAGE SO
IS A PROBLEM THAT I WILL NEVER
FALL IN LOVE WITH BUT IT IS A
PROBLEM THAT WE DO IF THE TECHS
AND I'M NOT IN LOVE WITH ANY
PARTICULAR SOLUTION.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS MAKE
A GOOD FAITH EFFORT TO ACTUALLY
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAVE A THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION HOME DEFICIT
IN CALIFORNIA?
AND THAT WE RANK FORTY NINE OUT
OF FIFTY IN HOMES FOR CAPITAL
THOSE NUMBERS DON'T LIE THAT'S
NOT ABOUT SURPLUS PROPERTY THAT
ISABEL FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGING
HOW WE DO HOUSING TO SAY HOW DO
WE DIG OUT OF THE THREE POINT.
FIVE MILLION HOME HOLE I AM A
1000% SUPPORTIVE.
OF THE GOVERNOR SURPLUS PROPERTY
PLAN THERE'S A SURPLUS PROPERTY
BILL THE CENTRE BELL TALKED
ABOUT THE IS OUGHT THE TWO
SENATORS ARE AUTHORING THE
LEGISLATURE I AM ALL ABOUT.
TAKING OUR SURPLUS PROPERTY IN
TURNING INTO 1100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR LOWER INCOME
RESIDENTS THAT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT THAT'S NOT GOING TO
DIG US OUT OF A THREE AND A HALF
MILLION HOLE AND IT WILL NOT.
HELP THE MIDDLE CLASS BECAUSE
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT A 100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHETHER IT'S
AN SURPLUS PROPERTY -- ELSEWHERE
WE'RE BUILDING FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AS WE SHOULD.
IF WE'RE GOING TO HELP THE
MIDDLE CLASS IT'S ABOUT
INCREASING THE SUPPLY.
OVERALL AND THEN FINALLY I
WANTED TO SAY I AGREE WITH YOU
ON THE TAX INCENTIVES THEY'RE
ALL WRONG AND I APPLAUD YOU FOR
TRYING TO FIX SOME ASPECTS OF A
BROKEN TAX SYSTEM.
AND WE DO NEED TO STREAMLINE
HOUSING APPROVALS THANK YOU FOR
VOTING FOR SB.
THIRTY FIVE WHICH IS EFFECTIVELY
STREAMLINING LOW INCOME HOUSING
ALL OVER CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER WINNER
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE VICE CHAIR
AND I I NEGLECTED TO SAY EARLIER
AND I JUST WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO SAY THANK YOU THE VICE CHAIR.
VICE CHAIR DOES AN AMAZING JOB --
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE HE WAS AT
EVERY HOUSING HEARING THAT WE'VE
HAD UP AND DOWN AT THIS GREAT
STATE I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
CENTER MORE LOCK IN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR YOU MISTER CARE.
WIENER JUST FOR QUICK QUESTIONS
BUT MAYBE LONG ANSWER.
IN THE LIKELY MICROPHONE.
OKAY YES YOU SEE ME.
I CAN SEE YOU AND HEAR YOU.
FIRST QUESTION IS DO I JUST ONE
WORD GENTRIFICATION.
YOU JUST RESPOND SURE ABSOLUTELY
ON GENTRIFICATION OR
DISPLACEMENT.
WE ARE IS SOMETHING PERSONAL I
YOU KNOW.
I LIVE IN NEIGHBORHOODS JUST
LIKE EVERYONE ELSE AND I I LIVE
IN THE CASTRO WHICH HAS BEEN
PROFOUNDLY IMPACTED.
BY GENTRIFICATION DISPLACEMENT I
LIVE ABOUT. FOUR BLOCKS FROM THE
MISSION -- WHICH HAS BEEN
UNBELIEVABLY IMPACTED.
BY GENTRIFICATION AND
DISPLACEMENT.
AND THESE NEIGHBORHOODS
EXPERIENCED DISPLACEMENT
GENTRIFICATION OVER A PERIOD AS
A MATTER AS WITH MANY OTHER
NEIGHBORHOODS.
OVER A PERIOD OF DECADES WHERE
WE WERE BUILDING VERY LITTLE NEW
HOUSING.
DISPLACEMENT HAPPENS WHEN PEOPLE
GET PUSHED OUT BECAUSE HOUSING
COSTS GO THROUGH THE ROOF.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE EOUGH
HOUSING AND WE DON'T HAVE A
STRONG ENOUGH TENER PROTECTIONS
WHICH WE ALSO NEED TO DO THIS
YEAR AND THE LEGISLATURE -- AND
SO WE HAVE BUILT VERY STRONG
ANTI DISPLAYS FROM PROTECTIONS
INTO THIS BILL THE STRONGER SAID
EXIST UNDER STATE LAW -- IF THE
TENANT HAS RESIDED ON A PROPERTY
AT ANY POINT IN THE LAST SEVEN
YEARS.
THE NOT BUILDING COULD NOT BE
TORN DOWN TO BUILD IN SB FIFTY
PROJECT EVEN IF THE LOCAL CITY
GOVERNMENT WOULD ALLOW IT.
IF THERE'S BEEN AN ALLIS
ACTIVATION THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS YOU CAN'T USE THIS BILL.
ARE WE NEGOTIATED THESE
PROVISIONS WITH.
THE EQUITY COALITION BEEN HEARD
FROM BEFORE WHICH IS STILL
WORKING WITH US.
AND I'M VERY SENSITIVE TO MAKING
SURE NOT TO PLACING PEOPLE THIS
IS ABOUT ADDING NEW HOUSING NOT
REPLACING RESIDENTS WHO ARE
ALREADY EXISTING -- ALREADY
RESIDING IN A NEIGHBORHOOD.
SECOND QUESTION IS ADDING.
RENTAL UNITS OR APARTMENTS
ADJACENT TO ARE DIRECTLY IN
RESIDENTIAL AREAS IN.
DRAWBRIDGE AREAS THAT SEEMS TO
BE THE BIGGEST.
CONCERN I'M GETTING FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS TO JUST.
EXPLAIN WHAT.
THAT MEANS SO THAT ONLY A PERSON
CAN APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING ABSOLUTELY ONE THING
IT'S IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND -- IS
THAT -- AND THIS IS OF COURSE
OUR SECOND TIME AT THE RODEO ON
ON THIS BILL WE WANT TO WE DID
SB TWO SEVEN LAST YEAR.
AND WE GOT A LOT OF CONSTRUCTIVE
FEEDBACK ABOUT THAT BILL I AM ON
FROM FOLKS WHO WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT -- INTENSIFICATION IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD FOLKS CONCERNED
ABOUT DISPLACEMENT SO FORTH.
ON AND WE TOOK ALL THAT COULD BE
BACK TO HER AND WE MADE CHANGES
TO THE BILL.
THE ORIGINAL VERSION OF SB.
TWO SEVEN AROUND BUS STOPS
TRIGGERED A HEIGHT INCREASE
ABOVE LOCAL HEIGHT LIMITS.
WE THEN IN THE NEW VERSION OF
THE BILL.
BOTH ARE IN THE JOBS RICH
CLASSIFICATION AT AROUND BUS
STOPS.
THE LOCAL HEIGHT LIMIT IS
RESPECTED SO IN THE JOB RICH
AREAS THE LOCAL HEIGHT LIMIT
APPLIES LOCAL SETBACK RULES
APPLY.
LOCAL DESIGN STANDARDS APPLY
LOCAL DEMOLITION RULES.
APPLY LOCAL INCLUSIONARY APPLIES
LOCAL IMPACT FEES.
APPLY AND SO FOR THE MOST PART
THE LOCAL CRUCIAL PROCESS
APPLIES.
SO FOR THE MOST PART LOCAL RULES
WILL STILL APPLY.
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THIS BILL DOES NOT TRIGGER A
HIGH INCREASE -- IT DIFFERS TO
LOCAL HEARTS SO YES IT WILL
ALLOW THESE SMALL MULTI UNIT
BUILDINGS BUT THIS ISN'T ABOUT
PUTTING YOU KNOW SKYSCRAPERS AND
MEMBERS THE OTHER THING I WILL
SAY IS.
AND THIS DIFFERENT PEOPLE TAKE
THIS DIFFERENTLY -- I THINK
SOMETIMES.
PEOPLE I WHEN I LISTEN TO TO
SOME PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT THE
BILL IT'S AS IF THE GOVERNOR
SIGNS THE BILL IF YOU KNOW IF
THAT HAPPENS IF WE GET THERE.
HE SIGNS IT AND THE NEXT DAY
APARTMENT BUILDING START
DSCENDING FROM THE SKY IN THE
PEOPLE'S NEIGHBORHOODS WELL
THAT'S NOT HELD A BILL IN THE
WORKS DEVELOPMENT IS SLOW EVEN
WHEN YOU'RE IN A IN A PROCESS OR
IN AN ENVIRONMENT THAT IS
FAVORABLE.
AND SO THIS IS GOING TO GIVE
THEMAN AVAILABLE PARCEL
DEVELOPER WHO IS FUNDING GO
THROUGH THE APPROVAL PROCESS
IT'S GOING TO TAKE YEARS AND
FRANKLY DECADES -- TO SEE REALLY
REALLY SIGNIFICANT.
ANY KIND OF SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
A VERY GRADUAL THING OVER TIME.
THE THIRD QUESTION IS A STUDY.
I MENTIONED A FEW TIMES YOU'RE
DOING THIS WITHOUT A STUDY WOULD
YOU COMMENT ON THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN.
MORE STUDIES ABOUT HOUSING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEN WE
COULD PROBABLY FIT IN THIS ROOM
IF WE STOCKTON FROM FLOOR TO
CEILING.
STUDIES THAT HAVE SHOWN AS I
MENTIONED THE THREE AND A HALF
MILLION HOME DEFICIT STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT RESTRICTIVE
ZONING IN CALIFORNIA PLACES A
VERY HARSH COP ON OUR ABILITY.
TO CLOSE THAT -- BACK OUT OF
STUDIES THAT HAVE SHOWN THAT
RESTRICTIVE ZONING LEADS TO
SPRAWL SO THAT MORE MORE HOUSING
GETS PUSHED INTO FARMLANDS --
AND FAR FAR AWAY CLOGGING UPPER
FREEWAYS -- STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT RESTRICTIVE ZONING MAKES
COMMUNITIES LESS DIVERSE BECAUSE
IT BANS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ABOUNDS APARTMENT BUILDINGS WE
HAVE.
MORE STUDIES NO WE COULD EVER
NEED -- WE HAVE ALL THE DATA WE
NEED AND NOW WHICH IS IN THE
POLITICAL WILL TO EXECUTE ON THE
SOLUTION.
LAST QUESTION IS -- THE CITY OF
PASADENA SAID WE HAVE BEEN DOING.
X. Y. Z. AND THEREFORE WE YOU
KNOW WHAT.
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE REBELLING
ABOUT.
WHAT THEY'RE PROPOSING WE MAY
SUE?
I'M JUST CURIOUS IF THERE'S A A
PROVISION THAT SAYS.
THANK YOU FOR PRIOR EFFORTS.
YOU'VE MET THE CRITERIA WE HAVE
YOU JUST RESPONSE IT FOR ANYONE
TO FILE A LAWSUIT WE KNOW THE
HUNTINGTON BEACH IS ALREADY
SUING THE STATE REPEATEDLY
TRYING TO OVERTURN THE SB THIRTY
FIVE THAT I AUTHORED TWO YEARS
AGO.
THERE HOUSING IS AN ISSUE
STATEWIDE CONCERN AND SO I I
DON'T BELIEVE THE LAWSUIT HAMMER
BUT ANYONE COMPILERS SUIT.
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF WHAT
PASADENA SAID AND I APPLAUD ANY
CITY IN THERE ARE PLENTY OF
CITIES THAT ARE AT THEIR CITIES
THAT ARE REALLY MAKING GOOD
FAITH EFFORTS TO BUILD HOUSING.
I THINK THAT SOMETIMES IN THESE
HOUSING THE BATES -- WE ARE
QUICKLY PEOPLE START DEMONIZING
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THE CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS -- AND I KNOW
MANY MANY CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS
ALL UP AND DOWN THE STATE AND
OVERWHELMINGLY THESE ARE.
GOOD HARD WORKING COMMITTED
PEOPLE RUN FOR OFFICE FOR ALL
THE RIGHT REASONS AND THEY WANT
TO SERVE THEIR COMMUNITY AND
THEY GET PAID VERY LITTLE AND
THEY GET YELLED OUT AT THE
SUPERMARKET AND IT'S YOU KNOW.
IT'S NOT ALWAYS THE MOST FUN JOB
IN THE WORLD BUT THEY'RE DOING
IT BECAUSE THEY'RE COMMITTED --
BUT WE HAVE CREATED A SYSTEM
THAT HAS SET CITIES OUGHT TO
FAIL BOTH FIRST TAXES STRUCTURE
REASONS.
BUT ALSO BECAUSE WE HAVE SET ME
VERY FEW STATE RULES IN THE ONCE
WE SET OUR UNENFORCEABLE AND WE
EXPECT CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS TO
WALK THE PLANK EVERY WEEK VOTE
FOR PROJECTS.%
AND RISK THEIR OWN POLITICAL
FUTURE.
ON THIS IS NOT WHAT WE NEED TO
GET AWAY FROM THE IDEA OF THE
BAD ACTORS CITIES AND THE GOOD
ACTORS CITIES.
AND YOU PUT THE HOUSING IN THE
IN THE NAUGHTY BAD ACTORS CITIES
AND FOR THE GOOD ACTORS CITIES
THEY GOT A BENEFIT OF NO HOUSING --
WE NEED TO MOVE AWAY FROM THIS
NOTION THAT HOUSING IS SOME SOME
HELP PUNISHMENT.
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA IF YOU'RE BAD
AND AUDIENCES CITY WERE GOING TO
PUNISH YOU WITH MORE HOUSING AND
IF YOU'RE GOOD WE'RE GOING TO
REWARD YOU BY NOT HAVING.
MORE HOUSING THERE.
I HOUSING IS A BENEFIT.
AND WHAT BIG PICTURE WE HAVE
THIS MASSIVE HOUSING DEFICIT AND
THE QUESTION IS NOT WHO'S BEEN
GOOD WHO'S BEEN BAD.
BUT TO ADD THESE HOMES THAT WE
NEED WHERE DO WE NEED TO PUT
THEM TO BE SUSTAINABLE NEAR JOBS
YOU'RE TRANSIT -- SO THAT'S HOW
I LOOK AT IT -- A AND AYE AYE
THAT'S TO BE THE BEST APPROACH
THANK YOU MISTER CENTER WINNER
JUST AS CALIFORNIA QUESTIONS AS
YOU FINISH OKAY I WAS JUST GOING
TO ASK IF -- I MISS MISS GARCIA
AND HIS SIBLINGS THING THING IF
IF YOU HAD.
MAYBE. ONE MINUTE EACH JUST TO
RESPOND.
TO THE SENATOR.
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION ABOUT
THE STUDIES SO.
REALLY WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE IS THE PROPOSAL BEFORE US
AND DO WE KNOW WHETHER THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE US IS REALLY THE
RIGHT.
ROUTE TO ACHIEVE WHAT WE NEED
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THERE MAY BE NUMEROUS STUDIES
BUT HAS ANYONE LOOKED AT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL AT THE
PARTICULAR PROVISIONS THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING HERE THAT ARE AT THE
TABLE. TO SAY THIS IS THE RIGHT
APPROACH THAT SAID HE HAS NOT
BEEN DONE TO OUR KNOWLEDGE
[inaudible]
IN -- I WANT TO SAY -- IN
REGARDS THE DEMOLITION
PROVISIONS I'M GLAD CENTER
WIENER IS STARTING TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT THE PROBLEM OF
DEMOLITIONS IN CALIFORNIA BUT I
HAVE TO SAY IS A TENANT ADVOCATE --
THAT WE SEE DEMOLITION AS A
BRAMPTON ISSUE EVEN IN PLACES
FROM PLATE LOS ANGELES WHICH
LOSES FIVE AND A HALF RENT
CONTROLLED UNITS A DAY.
LARGELY DUE TO DEMOLITION --
EVEN IN SAN FRANCISCO WHICH HAS
RELATIVELY STRONG DEMOLITION
PROTECTIONS I IN MY PRIVATE
CAPACITY WAS JUST ORGANIZING
WITH A BUNCH OF TENANTS HIS
ENTIRE BUILDING WAS DE
CONTROLLED -- BECAUSE OF
RENOVATIONS WE SEE RENT
EVICTIONS BASICALLY LIKE
EVICTION SLASH RENOVATION AS A
PRETEXT TO GET LOW INCOME
TENANTS IS IN OUT OUT OF HOUSING --
AND SO WHILE THE ELLIS ACT
INTENDANT EXEMPTION PROVISIONS
LOOK EXCELLENT ON PAPER THEY ARE
VERY DIFFICULT TO ENFORCE -- AND
THE OWNERS WOULD STILL LARGELY
BE ON TEN ORGANIZATIONS OUT
WHICH IS WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW
LIKE TEN ORGANIZATIONS WERE
UNDERFUNDED UNDER RESOURCE THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THE SATURDAYS
EASTER BASIN ARE THE ONES
FIGHTING THE DISPLACEMENT OF
ACTION THEIR NEIGHBORS THEY'RE
FIGHTING THESE DEMOLITIONS.
AND WHAT THIS PROVISION DOESN'T
REALLY CHANGES THE FACT THAT BY
THAT TIME THE THE BOTH THE SHIP
IS ALREADY SAILED.
THE TRAINS ROLLED OUT OF THE
STATION WE'RE THERE IS ALREADY A
DEMOLITION OR AND ALICE
ACTIVATION OR SOMETHING THAT HAS
HAPPENED.
I STILL HAVE SERIOUS QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW THIS PROVISION IS
GOING TO AFFECT OUR PENALIZES
LIKE IS IT GOING TO BE AN ASK
FOR YOU KNOW FORGIVENESS NOT FOR
PERMISSION SITUATION. FOR
SOMEONE WHO IS INCENTIVIZE TO
DEMOLISH EXISTING RENTAL HOUSING
AND REDEVELOPMENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF THANK YOU
SO MISTER MAJORITY LEADER FOR
SOURCE I JUST WANT TO BUILD ON
YOUR POINT THAT YOU MADE EXACTLY
WHAT -- CENTER MORLOCK SAID WAS
THIS NOTION OF A STUDY -- AND
AGAIN I'M NOT.
YOU'RE EXACTLY CORRECT THE
CENTER WIENER THAT WE'VE SEEN IS
NOT STUDIES TO FILL THIS ROOM I
PROBABLY READ QUARTER OF SOME --
BUT THAT IS THE QUESTION A STUDY
GIVEN HOW BIG THIS IS HOW BIG
THIS ENDEAVOR IS.
IF YOU LITERALLY THIS GETS
ENACTED IT WON'T BE THE LAW TO
JANUARY ONE TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY OKAY.
IF WE COULD CREATE A SITUATION
SAYS LET'S LOOK AT THIS
PARTICULAR OF WHAT THESE DO
BECAUSE I LITERACY SECONDS I
LITERALLY TALK TALK TO SOMEBODY
TOLD ME.
THAT THE TEN MINUTE THING ON THE
BUS DEAL MASS NO IMPACT IN MY
CITY. ZERO THAT'S UNTRUE I I
DIDN'T SEE IT'S NOT CHOICES I
WAS TOLD THAT THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT YOU STUDY TO KNOW WHETHER
IT'S TRUE OR NOT.
SO THE POINT IS THAT.
THAT THAT THE THE IDEA IS ON IF
YOU DID THIS AND THEN PUT IN THE
TRAILER BILL IN JUNE IN JUNE OF
THE FOLLOWING YEAR YOU'RE
DELAYING IT BY SIX MONTHS.
BUT WHAT YOU'RE IN THE MEANTIME
THE GOVERNOR MOVES QUICKLY ON ON
IS A PROPERTY STUFF YOU COULD
BUILD A TON OF STUFF PROBABLY
FIFTY THOUSAND UNITS I'M
GUESSING JUST HERTZBERG OFFICE
HAD. FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND UNITS
IT STARTS YOUR BILL IS NOT GOING
TO BUILD A THING. FOR THE FIRST
SIX MONTHS GIVES US COMFORT THAT
THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
ACCURATE WELL AS I WAS FIND
CHALLENGING IN THIS AND MY OWN
BILLS.
YOU DON'T HAVE A LOT OF MISTAKES
I'VE SEEN IT HAPPEN WE YOU COME
IN AND YOU SAY I WANT TO DO
SOMETHING AND YOU DOESN'T.
WORK THE WAY YOU WANT TO WORK.
SOMETHING THIS BIG CAN YOU TAKE
AN EXTRA SIX MONTHS AND SAY OKAY
LET'S PUT THIS BILL.
THE EXACT LANGUAGE INTO A STUDY
WITH THE SUPER COMMISSION
WHOEVER GETS APPOINTED AND LOOK
AT THE HARD HOMEWORK AND IF IT
WORKS PUT THE TRAILER BILL IN
JUNE YOU'VE GOT A SIX MONTH
DELAY BUT YOU REALLY HAVE.
THE WHOLE WORK THAT'S DONE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE RIGHT AS
WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
NGUYEN M. A CENTER I I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT FIRST OF ALL
BECAUSE THIS BILL IN ITS.
TWO DIFFERENT FORMS HAS BEEN
AROUND NOW FOR ABOUT A YEAR AND
A HALF THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
BILLS WHICH TALKS INTRODUCED
AROUND FOR A LONG TIME -- THERE
HAVE BEEN SPECIFIC STUDIES AND
ANALYSIS ON THIS BILL VARIOUS
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO PROVIDE THEM
TOO SO NOT ACCURATE TO SAY THAT
THE BILL HAS BEEN STUDIED.
IN DEPTH AND WE CAN PROVIDE THAT --
TO YOU -- AND I DON'T THINK AN
EXTRA SIX MONTHS IS GOING.
TO DO ANYTHING BODY BUT IT'S
BEEN AROUND FOR A LONG TIME IT'S
BEEN STUDIED AND BEDDED -- AD
NAUSEAM IN A GOOD WAY SEC YES
IT'S GOOD THAT IT'S BEEN --
BETTER AND STARTED SO THAT'S
HAPPENED ALREADY.
I JUST GOT THE AMENDMENTS WHICH
EMERGES AS PEOPLE WITH SB FIFTY
AT EIGHT FIFTEEN THIS MORNING
WHICH I GOT A CHANCE TO LOOK TO
AND THEN HANDED HERE AGAIN.
MERGE INTO ONE DOCUMENT AT EIGHT
TWENTY FOUR SO WHEN YOU SAY THAT
YOU'VE NOW TAKING THESE TWO
MEASURES YOURS DIDN'T WASN'T SB
FOR YOURS SB FIFTY IS THAT RIGHT
K..
I'VE TAKEN MOMENTS TO SB FIFTY
THIS IN THE SAME WAY THAT.
WE ALL TAKE AMENDMENTS IN
COMMITTEE AND IT'S VERY COMMON
THAT ANALYSIS COMES OUT TRULY
BEFORE HEARING ESPECIALLY WHEN
IN NEGOTIATIONS HAVING SO
THERE'S NOTHING UNTOWARD ABOUT
THAT AND YOU KNOW THAT BETTER
THAN I DO BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN
HERE LONGER THAN I'VE BEEN HERE.
ALAN JESTING IS WHEN YOU SAID
THIS IS BEEN AROUND A LONG TIME
YOU'VE TAKEN ENTIRE OTHER BILL
EMERGED IN.
MAYBE IT IS WORTH THINKING ABOUT
A WE MADE AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL
AND THE BILL IF THINGS GO WELL
THE BILL WILL HAVE UP TO FOUR
MORE HEARINGS IF IF IT KEEPS
GOING -- FOR MORE HEARINGS THIS
LANGUAGE WILL BE IMPRINT WILL DO
WHAT WE'VE ALWAYS DONE WHICH IS
MEET WITH PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
MEET IDEA YEAH I'VE MET WITH A
LOT OF MAYORS AND CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS EQUITY GROUPS -- ALL
SORTS OF PEOPLE TO RECEIVE OUR
MENTALIST PEOPLE TO RECEIVE
FEEDBACK ON THE BILL I STAFF HAS
AND WE'RE COMMITTED TO DOING
THAT WORK AND I'VE SPENT A LOT
OF TIME IN LA.
ON THIS BILL AND I'VE
CORRESPONDED WITH A NUMBER OF
YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT [inaudible]
CENTRE BELL [inaudible]
GERMAN GNOME.
AS YOU KNOW -- COMPLICATED
PROCESS INVOLVEDCOMPLICATED
ISSUES SO.
WE'RE WE'RE NOW IN A PROCESS IN
MY OPINION. TO FORM OF COCKETT.
AND I LOOK AT THIS BILL IS ONE
PART OF THE PACKAGE AND I WANT
TO STATE AGAIN.
DOT IF THE PACKAGE MOVES FORWARD
I'M FULLY SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
PACKAGE DOES NOT MOVE FORWARD.
I'M NOT SUPPORTIVE OF ANY
ELEMENT OF THE PACKAGE WITHOUT
ALL THE OTHER ELEMENTS.
SO IF BOB AND I WANT TO REPEAT
WHAT I SAID ABOUT [inaudible]
THANK.
SB FOUR NSP FIFTY IS PART OF THE
PACKAGE THAT'S GOING TO EVOLVE
INTO A BILL.
THAT WILL DEAL WITH STREAMLINING --
OF PROPS ENCOURAGING -- PROPER --
DEVELOPMENT AROUND TRANSIT.
AND MORE SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
I HOPE THAT'S WHAT THE GOAL IS.
I THINK THE GOAL SHOULD BE
INCLUSIVE COMMUNITY THERE
INCLUDES -- AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND PEOPLE OF ALL INCOME MALES
IN A DIVERSE COMMUNITY THAT LIVE
AROUND THAT TRANSIT THAT'S WHAT
WE HAVE TO INSIST ON SB FIVE
WOULD PROVIDE THE FINANCING AND
OTHER BILLS -- WE'LL SEE WHAT
THE GOVERNOR DOES IN HIS BUDGET
AND I'M GONNA TELL GOVERNOR.
THAT WE CANNOT HAVE A PACKAGE ON
HOUSING LEGISLATION UNLESS THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED.
AN ONGOING SOURCE OF FUNDS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IF THAT DOES NOT HAPPEN IF THE
GOVERNOR DOES NOT GOAL IF YOU
JUST CONTINUES WITH THE ONE TIME
ONLY SOURCE OF FUNDS.
THAT'S NOT APPROPRIATE IF WE DO
THESE KINDS OF BILLS.
NOT APPROPRIATE.
IT'S NOT THE CORRECT THING TO DO --
I SUPPORT SB SIX AND THAT'S
INCLUDING AND I THINK WE'RE
SEEING GOOD SCIENCE FROM THE
GOVERNOR THAT WE'RE GONNA
IDENTIFIED LAN.
AND PERHAPS RATHER THAN
DISPLACING.
HOUSING WE OUGHT TO LOOK AT
THINGS LIKE GOD WITH THE HELP OF
NEIGHBORHOODS.
VACANT -- PARKING LOTS A LONG
STRIP COMMERCIAL AREAS THAT ARE
VACANT.
UNDER UTILIZED PROPERTY AS
OPPOSED TO LOOKING AT WHERE
THERE'S A APARTMENT COMPLEX.
THAT WE WOULD HAVE A LOT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE DON'T WANT
TO RIP DOWN THE APARTMENT
COMPLEX.
AS OPPOSED TO BUILDING ON DOWN
THE BLOCK A VACANT PIECE OF
PROPERTY.
AND THAT WOULD TAKE HELP.
AND ASSISTANCE FROM THE
COMMUNITY.
AND THE PLANNING DEPARTMENTS OF
THE CITIES ARE SO IMPORTANT TO
MAKE IN THAT WORK THE PLANE
DEPARTMENTS DAVID REYES TALKED
ABOUT IT FROM PASADENA.
THE THE CITY COUNCIL MEMBER.
WE HAVE TO HAVE GOOD PLANNING.
GOOD PLANNING HOUSE TO BE PART
OF THE PROCESS.
WE DON'T HVE GOOD PLANNING.
OF LONG TERM -- NONE OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING TODAY IS GOING TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE SO WE HAVE TO
SUPPORT GOOD PLANNING
[inaudible]
AND THIS IS A LONG TERM ISSUE --
WE ALSO HAVE TO CHANGE THE
DYNAMIC OF FISCAL ZONING.
YOU KNOW THE PLAN DEPARTMENT
WORKS FOR THE CITY MANAGER.
CITY MANAGERS AND THE CITY -- IT
MINISTRATIONS.
ARE LOOKING AT YOUR BUDGET EVERY
YEAR AND THEY WANT LAND USES
THAT.
THE GENERATE TAX INCOME.
TAX INCOME OR OR REVENUE
GENERATED OF LAND USE POLICIES
THAT.
THAT ARE NOT IN WRITING BUT
ACTUALLY ARE WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENS.
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS FOR
THOSE PROJECTS THAT ARE.
GENERATING A LOT OF JOBS IN TAX
REVENUE AS OPPOSED TO JAY IT'S A
HOUSING PROJECT AS AFFORDABLE.
THAT'S INAPPROPRIATE.
INAPPROPRIATE FROM A MORAL
STANDPOINT.
AND AND I THINK FROM THE LONG
TERM STATE FISCAL STANDPOINT FOR
OUR COMMUNITY WE HAVE TO HAVE
PRIORITIES SET STRAIGHT.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS TO
PRIORITY NOT THOSE LAND USES A
CREATE A LOT OF JOBS WITHOUT
HOUSING IS THEY JUST MAKE THE
PROBLEM WORSE.
ME AND THEN I ALSO WANT TO STATE
TENET PROTECTIONS AND DISPLACED
ANTI DISPLACEMENT LAWS.
IN THE SENATE PACKAGE I DON'T
SEE THOSE KINDS OF PROPOSALS AS
MUCH WE HAVE TO WORK WITH OUR
ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES ON THEIR
BILLS.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THOSE BILLS
ARE SUPPORTED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
AND NAM SUPPORT THOSE TENANTS --
DISPLACEMENTS TENSE RIGHTS BILLS
RENT CONTROL BILLS WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT ALL THAT.
AS A SOLUTION TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO I SEE THIS IS A
PACKAGE MISTER GERMAN -- I WANT
TO INVOLVE THE COMMUNITY IN THE
IN THE CONCEPT OF A PACKAGE.
AND IF WE DON'T HAVE A PACKAGE
OF THIS BILL IN THE OTHER BILLS.
OF I DON'T THINK IT'S A
SUCCESSFUL EFFORT THIS YEAR'S SO.
TWENTY NINETEEN WE HAVE TO
INSIST ON A PACKAGE.
IF THERE'S NOT A PACKAGE OF WILL
CONTINUE HAVE CONFLICTS.
AND WE SHOULD WORK TOGETHER TO
TRY TO CREATE A PACKAGE AND I
I'D BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH ALL
SIDES ON THE QUESTION.
ON THIS ISSUE AND PULL EVERYBODY
TOGETHER WITH EVERYBODY'S
ASSISTANCE.
AND I HOPE THE REST OF YOU AGREE
WITH THAT I'M I'M -- COMMITTED.
AND WE CAN WE CAN DO THIS WE
CAN'T CREATE A A GOOD -- PACKAGE
INVOLVING ALL THESE ELEMENTS
THAT I MENTIONED.
AND I I ACTUALLY I I FEEL I
PROBABLY MISS ON TOM AND THE
REASON I PROBABLY MISSED SOME IS
BECAUSE I'D LOVE TO HEAR MORE
IDEAS FROM EVERYBODY ABOUT HOW
WE CAN PROVIDE MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT THING -- WE
SHOULD NOT USE CONFLICTING
STATEMENTS ON ON EACH OTHER.
I HOPE THAT WE DON'T WE DON'T --
CREATE ANTAGONISTIC STATEMENTS
ON THE SUBJECT I THINK WE OUGHT
TO WORK TOGETHER IN ORDER TO
WORK TOGETHER WE HAVE.
TO RESPECT ONE ANOTHER.
AND NOW IT TAKES -- A LOT OF
EFFORT -- TO TO DO THAT AND YOU
KNOW THE SENATE AND EVERYBODY
ELSE WE WE ARE VERY RESPECTFUL
OF OUR COLLEAGUES EVEN IF
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE AND I THINK.
ON THIS ISSUE -- I I SEE A LOT
OF ALBUMS IN WE HAVE TO KIND OF
RESPECT ONE ANOTHER FOR GOING TO
BE SUCCESSFUL SO.
IF WE'RE NOT DOING THINGS TO
RESPECT ONE ANOTHER THAT WILL
INHIBIT.
THE KIND OF COALITION PACKAGE
THAN TALKING ABOUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER NO
THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS IS
SENATOR GRATEFUL FOR ALL YOUR
WORK SIR.
LET'S GO TO THE DEAN OF THE
SENATE CENTER NIELSEN. SEVEN
MEMBERS I WANNA THANK.
CENTER WIENER HE'S TAKEN ON A
MONUMENTAL [inaudible]
EFFORT HERE. ONE THAT.
HAS PREOCCUPIED THE LEGISLATURE
FOR MANY YEARS BUT IT APPEARS TO
ME HAVING WATCHED FOR A NUMBER
OF YEAR THAT MAYBE SOME
SOMETHING THIS.
WE'RE GOING TO GET SOMEWHERE.
INDEED MAYBE IN A PACKAGE BUT
THIS WOULD BE A KEY.
FUNDAMENTAL ELEMENT OF THAT
PACKAGE.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
FOR BEING SENSITIVE SO LONG TIME
CONCERNS.
THE VALLEY COUNTIES HAVE BEEN.
PLAGUED WITH.
MASSES OF PEOPLE MOVING OUT.
OF THE AREAS WHERE THEY CANNOT
AFFORD TO LIVE.
AND WE ARE FOCUSED ON THE
TRANSIT.
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE IN THESE
AREAS.
I HAVE OFTEN WONDERED WHAT WHAT
WE PUT IN ALL THIS MONEY INTO
TRANSIT AND THEREBY STILL MOVING
OUT.
WHAT'S THE TRANSIT.
FOR IF YOU COULD EVEN ARGUE
HOW'S IT GOING TO BE SUSTAINED
WITHOUTA RIDERSHIP.
WELL THIS IS THE ADDRESSES OF
ONE OF THOSE CONCERNS AS WELL.
AND VERY PARTICULARLY.
OUR HOUSING PROBLEMS HAVE BEEN
EXACERBATED OVER DECADES BY THE
STATE LEGISLATURE IMPOSING
ITSELF.
AND ITS WILL ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
IN MANY WAYS.
THAT HAVE IMPEDED THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES TO PROVIDE HOUSING
THE PEOPLE IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
CERTAINLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS
BEEN GUILTY AS WELL.
BUT IN YOUR CASE I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BEING SENSITIVE. TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THAT A LOT OF
DISCUSSION HAS.
CENTERED AROUND THAT HERE.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT
THE END OF THE FOR THE BILL
MOVING ALONG AND I WOULD OFFER A
MOTION FOR SUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH LAYS IN GERMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
BUT WE'RE GONNA TAKE A VERY
BRIEF RECESS BEFORE WE DO WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS CONVERSATIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT.
HEARING SEE NINE DAYS CHEN WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WE
APOLOGIZE WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO
GET -- ARE.
OUR WORK HERE TOGETHER I AM WILL
BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU HERE IN
JUST A FEW MOMENTS THANK YOU SO
MUCH
[inaudible] NINE AND WHICH
EMAIL THE
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH
.
WELCOME BACK LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AND WE ARE GETTING A
TORTURE LUNCH HOUR -- DO
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S PATIENCE.
WOULD LIKE TO BETTER DO ONE LAST
CALL OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO BE
ABLE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS -- OTHERWISE I
HAVE A FEW COMMENTS AND I GIVE
IT A TURN IT OVER TO CENTER
WIENER THE BILL TO PROVIDE HIS
CLOSING COMMENTS TO COMMITTEE.
XENON.
AGAIN I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
FIRST OF ALL. TO SAY THANK YOU
TO ALL OF YOU WHETHER YOU ARE
OPPOSE OR SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU FOR TAKING TIME OUT OF
YOUR WEEK DAY.
JOIN US IN LENDING YOUR VOICE
ADD TO THIS IMPORTANT PROCESS
LOOKING AHEAD I THIS IS NOT
GOING TO BE THE LAST TIME THAT
THIS BILL WILL HAVE A PUBLIC
HEARING.
THERE IS GONNA BILLY AMPLE
OPPORTUNITY AS THIS MOVE TOWARDS
AYE IF THIS COMMITTEE -- AFFIRMS.
TOWARDS APPROPRIATION. TO THE
FLOOR THE SENATE.
AND I OBVIOUSLY TO GET OFF THE
FLOOR THE SENATE. TWENTY TIMING
POLICY COMMITTEE IN THE ASSEMBLY
IS WELL.
MY BOTTOM LINE IS -- LAST YEAR I
DID NOT SUPPORT.
EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN AS I WAS
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH.
IN CANDIDLY WHAT WORKS FOR
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES.
DOESN'T WORK FOR A COUNTY OF SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND OR LESS.
CAN I ASK THE SERGEANTS IF WE
COULD PLEASE CLOSE THE DOOR
.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AS I WAS SAYING WHAT WORKS FOR
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES OR A CITY
OF FOUR MILLION DOESN'T WORK
NECESSARILY FOR A COUNTY OF A
POPULATION. SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
FOLKS OR LEX.
AND I'M ALSO A BELIEVER THAT NO
COMMUNITY SHOULD SEE DRAMATIC
CHANGE BUT EVERY COMMUNITY
SHOULD SEE SOME CHANGE.
I DO BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO STRIKE THAT BALANCE.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE IS NOT A
SILVER BULLET. TO BE ABLE TO
SOLVE THE HOUSING CRISIS.
WE HAVE TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS
MOVING RIGHT NOW OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS IN ONE TIME
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUNDS.
AND WE NEED A PERMANENT ONGOING
SOURCE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WHICH IS WHY IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
TO PASS.
SB.
FIVE OUR REAL CRISIS IN THIS
STATE EXISTS.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE CATEGORIES
OF LOW INCOME AND VERY LITTLE
LOW INCOME OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING?
AND THAT IS WHY WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE HOUSING FOR THE
NEXT GENERATION THE WORK FORCE
IN FAMILIES AND SENIORS.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I DO HAVE TO SAY THAT THIS BILL
GOES A LONG WAY WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN
RELATED TO BUS STOPS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN THE BUS
STOPS BECAUSE AS I'VE SAID
BEFORE A ONE SIZE FITS ALL.
THAT ONE SIZE DOESN'T FIT ALL.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN PLACE
TODAY WILL WORK FOR COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE LORENA HAD WAYS DURING
PEAK PERIODS IN TEN MINUTES.
WHICH IS A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
FROM WHERE WE WERE.
COMING INTO THIS HEARING.
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE ADVANCED BY COMMUNITIES UP
AND DOWN THE CALIFORNIA COAST.
WITH PLEASE AMEND AMENDMENTS
ONLY THE HIGHEST QUALITY STOCKS.
WE'LL BE INCLUDING.
I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TURN THE
COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION. TO THE
AMENDMENTS.
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO BE VOTING
ON THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN
FRONT OF THIS COMMITTEE.
A FULL LIST OF THE AMENDMENTS.
WILL BE PROVIDED AT ONE PM
OUTSIDE THIS COMMITTEE.
IN THE HALL.
WILL BE VOTING ON THE
DISTRIBUTION AMENDMENTS WITH
THREE CLARIFICATIONS TODAY.
NUMBER ONE MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE
[inaudible] FOR PLEXUS.
CONVERSIONS BUT NO DEMOLITION
STATE WHY.
CLARIFICATION COASTAL ZONES
COASTAL ZONE DEVELOPMENT IS
EXCLUDED IN CITIES A FIFTY
THOUSAND OR BELOW.
STATEWIDE.
AND THAT'S FIFTY THOUSAND
POPULATION OR BELOW [inaudible]
AND DEVELOPMENT WILL NOT BE
ALLOWED IN VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES STATEWIDE.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
BUT BEFORE WE GO TO A FORMAL
VOTE.
WE LIKE TO GO TO TURN IT OVER TO
CENTER WIENER AND I WANNA INDEED
HERE.
CENTER WINNER AND I HAVE NOT
ALWAYS AGREED OVER THESE PAST.
THREE OR FOUR MONTHS.
BUT ONE THING THAT WE HAVE
ALWAYS FOCUS ON ITS
COLLABORATION RESPECT.
I AND WHILE WE MAY NOT ALWAYS
AGREE I GREATLY RESPECT THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
I WHEN HE SEES YOU IN HIS WORD
HE STICKS TO IT.
AND I'M GRATEFUL I AND IT HAS
BEEN.
COMPROMISE ON BOTH SIDES THE
ENTIRE WAY.
THIS IS NOT THE EASIEST OF BILLS
THAT WILL BE IN FRONT OF THIS
LEGISLATURE.
AND HE'S WILLING TO BE A TACKLE
ONE OF OUR TOUGHEST CHALLENGES.
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT THERE IS
MORE WORK TO DO IN THE WEEKS AND
MONTHS TO COME.
AND WE'RE GONNA NEED YOUR VOICE
IS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THIS
POLICY STRONGER.
SO WITHOUT FURTHER DO CENTER
WIENER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL YOUR
COLLABORATION YOUR COMPROMISED.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS FOR THE
CLOSING STATEMENT.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR WORKING SO HARD WITH
US AND ALSO YOUR STAFF -- FOR
WORKING HARD.
WITH MY STAFF -- WE ALL AS IT AS
A TEAM I THINK BEEN WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY TO COME TO A
GOOD RESOLUTION.
THERE'S ALWAYS GIVE AND TAKE AND
I THINK WE'VE ALL ENGAGED IN
THAT I THINK WE HAVE A VERY
STRONG BILL THAT WE CAN ALL GET
BEHIND -- AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HERE I GO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MR SENATOR
MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS AS FOLLOWS IN THIS
IS BEEN BROUGHT FORWARD BY
CENTER NIELSEN.
MOTION HONEST SB FIFTY IS A DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
WITH THE ATTACHED AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE STATED OUT LOUD.
A FEW HOURS AGO ALONG WITH THE
CLARIFICATIONS THAT WERE JUST
OFFERED.
SB FOUR HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
CONSIDERATION AND WILL BE
BLENDED WITH SB.
FIFTY WITH THAT SAID.
SANCHEZ A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HI WHILE I'M MORE A LOT MORE
LIKE AYE BELL BILL I HERTZBERG
HER CONDO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER AYE.
AYE.
MASON GENERAL THAT CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO VOTE WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP THE BILL ON CALL
ALLOW INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS TO BE
ABLE TO ADD ON WE ARE NOW GOING
TO ALLOW FOLKS WHO ARE HERE FOR
THE S. BEFORE SB FIFTY
PRESENTATION. TO BE ABLE TO FILE
OUT AS YOU DO WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
TWO MINUTE BREAK TO ALLOWED INTO
THE ROOM AND THEN WE'RE GONNA GO
STRAIGHT INTO BILLS [inaudible]
ONE HEY NOTHING MONEY CAN'T CURE.
IT WOULD BE NICE NAY JEEZ
[inaudible]
YEAH
GIVEN
.
ALL RIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING
BACK TOGETHER.
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT OUR AFTERNOON SESSION HERE
TODAY.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO BE OUT
OF THIS ROOM AT APPROXIMATELY.
TWELVE FIFTEEN H. -- WE WILL BE
RECONVENING IN.
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE AT
APPROXIMATELY ONE THIRTY ISHE.
I WITH A FULL AFTERNOON -- IF
YOU EXPECTED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
DINNER IN COMMITTEE.
YOU'RE THINKING RIGHT.
I AS WE WILL BE GOING OUT LATE
INTO THE NIGHT OUT WITH THE
REMAINDER OF OUR BILLS.
OUT OF THE TWENTY SEVEN BILLS WE
HAVE ACCOMPLISHED.
ONE SO WE APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
PATIENCE AND WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR WORK.
MEMBERS WE'RE NOW GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO THE VICE CHAIR THIS
IS ITEM NUMBER NINE SB.
TWO FORTY ONE ON VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION FIND SOMEONE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE VICE CHAIR FOR ALL OF HIS
WORK ON THIS.
MORE LIKE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES -- THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO FOCUS ON
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTIONS OR
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION FUNDS
KNOWN AS THE CF.
FOR IN OUR CASE SO
AFFECTIONATELY KNOWN AS WALLY
KAHN'S.
THE PREVIOUS CHAIR SENATOR
HERTZBERG.
HELD A HEARING ON VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS IN LOS ANGELES WE
LEARNED THAT THIS MAJOR
COMPONENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE INCOME TAX FORM. FIVE
FORTY PAGE WISE COULD USE SOME
SERIOUS IMPROVEMENTS.
MISTER CHAIR YOU HAVEN'T BEEN AN
OUTSTANDING LEADER.
IN PROVIDING DIRECTION AND
GUIDANCE ON THIS UNIQUE ENDEAVOR.
WE ARE BOTH TERRIBLY INCLINED
AND DESIRE CALIFORNIA'S NON
PROFITS TO THRIVE ESPECIALLY
WHEN THE BENEFIT OF TAX
DEDUCTIBILITY HAS BEEN REDUCED
IN RECENT MONTHS.
ALLOW ME TO SHARE HOW SENATE
BILL TWO FORTY ONE WILL TURBO
CHARGE BALI CONS AND ASSIST ARE
CRITICAL NONPROFIT SECTOR.
MR SURE LET ME BEGIN BY FIRST
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
AS YOUR LIKELY AWARE WE ARE
SEEING A DECLINE IN DONATIONS TO
THE VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION
PROGRAM.
I RECENTLY SPOKE TO A LARGE
GATHERING A CONFERENCE OF
CERTIFIED PUBLIC ACCOUNTANTS AND
ASK THEM HOW MANY WERE EVEN
ADVISING OR MENTIONING VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS.
IN THE TAX ORGANIZER IS THAT
THEY PROVIDE TO THEIR CLIENTS.
OUT OF SOME TWO HUNDRED PRESENT
ONLY TO RAISE THEIR HANDS.
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD DATA
CONFIRMS THAT.
IS ONLY ABOUT A 2% PARTICIPATION
RATE WITH VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS.
A FEW YEARS AGO EVEN TURBOTAX.
FAILED TO INCLUDE THE VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS IN THEIR SOFTWARE.
IN ROLE AGENTS ARE ALSO IGNORING
THIS OPPORTUNITY IN ADVISING
THEIR CLIENTS EACH OF THE
CURRENT FUNDS HAVE BEEN ADDED
THROUGH LEGISLATION.
IT CAN BE SEEN AS UNFAIR. TO
ONLY ALLOWED CHARITIES WHO HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO BE ELIGIBLE
TO RECEIVE.
DONATIONS A CASE OF THE TWO YOU
KNOW.
AND HOW INFLUENTIAL IN LOBBYING
AN ORGANIZATION IS.
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD NOTES
THAT ROUGHLY FORTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IS CONTRIBUTED EACH YEAR
AND THAT'S FORTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS DOES NOT SEEM TO
INCREASE OR DECREASE BY A WIDE
MARGIN.
THEREFORE THE SAME PEOPLE SEEM
TO BE DONATING.
HOWEVER MORE FUNDS ARE ADDED TO
THE PROGRAM EACH YEAR.
IF WE DO NOT INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF CONTRIBUTORS THE AMOUNT EACH
FUND WILLRECEIVE WILL DECREASE
EVERY YEAR AND AS THOSE THAT
RECEIVE THESE DONATIONS NO THE
PRIVACY LAWS PREVENT CONTRIBUTOR
DATA DIET DATA DIVERGENT EVEN
KNOW WHO IS ACTUALLY
CONTRIBUTING. TO YOUR FINE SO
YOU CAN'T SOLICIT THEM ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS.
BUT TO MAKE THIS PROGRAM
SUCCESSFUL WE NEED MORE
MOTIVATING FACTORS.
THAT'S THE INTENT OF SB.
TWO FORTY ONE INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF CHARITIES WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TO PARTICIPATE.
SHOULD INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
DONORS.
YOU GET THE NONPROFIT INDUSTRY
TO SHARE THEIR IDENTIFICATION
NUMBER WITH THEIR MEMBERS
THROUGH MARKETING.
THEY CAN UTILIZE SOCIAL MEDIA
CAMPAIGNS MAILERS AND PROMOTE
THEIR CAUSE AT MEETINGS.
THE ENTIRE PROGRAM SHOULD BE
MARKETED IN A MORE EFFECTIVE WAY
AND BY INCREASING ELIGIBILITY I
BELIEVE WE CAN ACHIEVE THAT
SUCCESS.
OUT OF FIVE PAGES THE VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION PROGRAM.
PROGRAMS TAKE UP AN ENTIRE PAGE
HOW LONG UNTIL WE ADD MORE AND
HAVE TO ADD A SIX PAGE.
EACH OF THE FUNDS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY LISTED WITH THE
PROGRAM ARE WORTHY CAUSES BUT I
BELIEVE THERE ARE MANY OTHER
CHARITIES.
WHO ARE ALSO WORTHY THEY JUST
DON'T HAVE FRIENDS IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHO CAN ADD THEM TO
THE LIST?
IN ORDER TO EXPAND THE
CONTRIBUTION OPTIONS FOR
TAXPAYERS WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION PROGRAM
THIS BILL MAKES SEVERAL
PROCEDURAL CHANGES SUCH AS
ELIMINATES THE CURRENT REPEAL
DATES. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTERS MEMORIAL FUND AND
THE CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
MEMORIAL FUND.
IT REQUIRES THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO DEVELOP AN APPLICATION
TO ALLOW CHARITIES WHO APPLIED
TO BE INCLUDED IN THE PROGRAM.
IT DEFINES QUALIFICATIONS THAT
CHARITIES MUST MEET IN ORDER TO
PARTICIPATE.
IN ORDER TO PARTICIPATE
CHARITIES MUST COMPLETE THE
APPLICATION WHICH INCLUDES BANK
ACCOUNT INFORMATION EVIDENCE OF
QUALIFICATIONS AND APPLICATION
FEE.
CHARITIES MUST CONTINUE TO MEET
QUALIFICATION SPELL OUT OF
RENEWAL APPLICATION AND PAY
RENEWAL FEES IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE TO PARTICIPATE.
IF CHARITIES NO LONGER MEET
QUALIFICATIONS THEIR ELIGIBILITY
WILL BE REVOKED IF ELIGIBILITY
IS REVOKED CHARITIES MAY RE
APPLY TO THE PROGRAM AFTER ONE
YEAR.
TAXPAYERS MAY CONTRIBUTE TO MORE
THAN ONE CHARITY.
IT ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION FUND IN
THE STATE TREASURY TO RECEIVE
CONTRIBUTIONS.
IT REQUIRES THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO NOTIFY THE STATE
COMPTROLLER THE DOLLAR AMOUNT
INDIVIDUALS DONATED TO THE FUND.
IT REQUIRES THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO CREATE INDIVIDUAL
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS FOR EACH
PARTICIPATING CHARITY.
IT REQUIRES THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO CREATE MAINTAIN SEARCH
A SEARCHABLE WEBSITE FOR
CHARITIES TO BE LISTED WHERE
TAXPAYERS MAY FIND THE CHARITIES
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER.
IT REQUIRES THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO CREATE A NEW FIELD ON
THE TAX FORM FOR TAXPAYERS TO
ENTER THE IDENTIFICATION NUMBER.
OF THEIR DESIRE CHARITY AND
DONATION AMOUNT.
THE FUNDS CURRENTLY LISTED ON
THE TAX FROM WILL CONTINUE TO BE
LIFTED UNTIL THEY'RE ALREADY
PREVIOUSLY SCHEDULED REPEAL DATE.
ONCE OFFENSE WITH AN EXPIRATION
DATE HAVE EXPIRED THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD WILL LIST THE TOP
SEVEN GROSSING FUNDS FROM THE
PREVIOUS YEAR.
AND THE THREE PERMANENT FUNDS
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL SENIORS
FIND CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS
MEMORIAL FUND AND THE CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS MEMORIAL FUND ON
THE TAX FORM.
THE TOP SEVEN GROSSING FUNDS
THAT WILL BE LISTED WILL BE
REVOLVING YOUR TO YOUR BASED ON
THE PREVIOUS YEAR'S
CONTRIBUTIONS.
AND REQUIRES THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO CREATE AND REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE AN ANNUAL REPORT
THE TRACK TO FIND COSTS AND
CONTRIBUTION LEVELS.
IT ALSO ALLOWS THE STATE AUDITOR
TO AUDIT THE FUNDED NECESSARY
AND WISHES AND REASONABLE FEES
TO COVER THE COST OF
ADMINISTERING THE PROGRAM.
AND BECAUSE IT'S A BIG ENDEAVOR
RESEARCHER WE HAVE DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE.
TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR INDULGING ME ON ON
THIS PROJECT THIS REFORM SHOULD
HELP.
THE EXISTING FUNDS AND INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF CONTRIBUTIONS BY
FILERS AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
AND YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB.
TWO FORTY ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS A VICE CHAIR AND I JUST.
I WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE VICE
CHAIR FOR WADING INTO THIS SOME
CALL IT A SWAMP.
THERE ARE A LOT OF MOVING PARTS
ON THIS BILL.
THERE'S BEEN THERE'S ONLY ONE
INDIVIDUAL IN THIS LEGISLATURE
THIS WILLING TO BE ABLE TO
TACKLE THIS ISSUE.
AND THAT'S BEEN THE VICE CHAIR
CENTER MORE WALK I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE YOU YOUR HARD WORK.
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO BE ABLE TO
MEET WITH ALL SIDES
UNDERSTANDING THAT NOT ALWAYS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO BRING
CONSENSUS BUT TRYING TO BE ABLE
OF A DATA DRIVEN APPROACH. TO
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR MANY
CHARITIES ACROSS THE CITY
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US.
IT IS BEEN AN ABSOLUTE PLEASURE
SIR WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD AT
THIS TIME.
WHERE DO ONE CALL FOR SUPPORT
LAST CALL SUPPORT?
ALL RIGHT WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO
MAY E OPPOSE IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME.
LAST CALL FOR SUPPORT.
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE AGAIN
MISTER VICE CHAIR.
I AM DETERMINED TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THIS RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMPROMISE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR DUE DILIGENCE.
IN THANK YOU FOR BEING OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT AND WORKING WITH ALL
SIDES TO TRY TO DRIVE CONSENSUS.
GRATEFUL FOR IT I IT'S SOMETHING
EVEN TALKING ABOUT NOW FOR THE
PAST COUPLE OF YEARS AND AND
ALLOW YOU TO CLOSER AND ONE IS
IN IT.
AS I STARTED IT SAYING THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR OF THANK YOU. FOR
BEING -- SUCH A GREAT.
TEAMMATE IT TAKES A TEAM TO WORK
ON SOMETHING LIKE THIS AND YOU
HAVE BEEN.
AN OUTSTANDING CHAIRED IT'S AN
HONOR TO YOUR VICE CHAIR.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
VIGOROUS DEBATE TODAY.
AND THE I I THINK THIS IS GONNA
INVIGORATES THE NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY.
IT SHOULD GET A LOT OF SOCIAL
MEDIA ATTENTION AND AND WE'LL
HAVE SOME FUN WITH THE SECTION
OF THE FIVE FORTY AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
ON SB.
TWO FORTY ONE BUT IS IN GERMAN.
THE MOTION OF THAT IT WAS
BROUGHT FORWARD BY SENATOR BAIL.
IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PREPARATIONS.
CAN YOU GIVE US THIRTY SECONDS
AND WILL TAKE THE VOTE
.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE
PATIENTS A LOT OF MOVING PARTS
TODAY IN -- THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM SACRAMENTO WHO'S HERE HAS A
TWELVE HOUR HEARING IN HEALTH
THAT YOU'LL BE TEARING I'M BEING
A LITTLE SLIP -- BUT HE HAS A
VERY LONG HEARING TODAY -- AND
WE WE WILL NEED TO TALK TO THE
VICE CHAIR RIGHT AFTER WE TAKE
THIS VOTE TO PASS IS A MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS MISS LANE JUST
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HI WHY I'M MORE LONG AYE.
AYE BELL.
WELL I HEARD BURKE CHAU
[inaudible]
NIELSEN WIENER.
THANK CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE
ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN.
THERE IS IN GENERAL IF YOU CAN
GIVE US ONE MINUTE I'M GOING TO
DO A QUICK CUDDLE WITH THE VICE
CHAIR.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE ONE MORE BILL.
WE ARE STILL IN OUR MORNING
SESSION.
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO RECESS
UNTIL ONE THIRTY ISHE BE RIGHT
BACK WITH YOU
[inaudible]
THIS IS
.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE TO BE
TAKING ITEM NUMBER EIGHT ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT THIS IS SB ONE
SEVENTY FIVE SENATOR PAN.
LAYS IN GERMAN.
I'M GONNA HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
LEAVE COMMITTEE -- THAT WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE ONE LAST BILL UP
GONNA TURN THE BILL OVER TO THE
VICE CHAIR AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO RECESS UNTIL ONE THIRTY ISHE.
MISTER VICE CHAIR.
AND YOU HAVE A FOR ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU AS CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR AND SENATORS THAT'S
THE ONE SEVENTY FIVE IS
NECESSARY TO KEEP CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE MARKETS STABLE
AND PREMIUMS DOWN THERE'S NO
QUESTION OF THE BENEFITS OF
HEALTH INSURANCE.
WHERE YOU KNOW THAT A MINIMUM
ESSENTIAL COVERAGE REQUIREMENT
PENALTY WORK IN THE FIRST YEAR
THAT THE PENALTY MATT HAS BEEN
ZEROED OUT NEW ENROLLMENT
COVERED CALIFORNIA DECLINED
ALMOST 24%?
AND PLAN TO INCREASE THE RATES
BY 2210% JUST BECAUSE THE LACK
OF ENFORCEMENT ACQUIREMENT AT
THE ONE SEVENTY FIVE TREAT THE
STATE LEVEL REQUIREMENT.
IS MODELED CLOSELY AFTER THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENT AND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
SB ONE SEVENTY FIVE IS ONLY AN
ACTIVE SB SIXTY FIVE AT SEVEN
OPINION SUBSIDY BILL IS ENACTED.
I LIKED INTRODUCED BY WITNESSES
PATH TO POWER FROM HAVE ACCESS
CALIFORNIAN AT BOTTOM I DID FROM
THE AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY
CANCER ACTION NETWORK SPEAKING
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
A CHAIR MEMBERS ALTAMONT IS MADE
WITH THE AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY
CANCER ACTION NETWORK I'M HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ONE
SEVENTY FIVE TODAY.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS MAINTAIN HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE AND WILL HELP TO DRIVE
DOWN COSTS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR
CANCER PATIENTS WHO SPEND
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS EVERY YEAR.
TO COVER THE COST OF THEIR CARE
WITHOUT THE PARTICIPATION OF
HEALTHY CALIFORNIANS IN THE
MARKET THE BURDEN OF COSTS FALLS
ON THE SHOULDERS OF THE VERY
SICK.
WE CANNOT AFFORD TO GO WITHOUT
THEIR COVERAGE SB ONE SEVENTY
FIVE WILL HELP TO DRIVE DOWN
THIS COSTS BY ENSURING THE
BURDEN IS TO DIVERSIFY AND
SHARED BY ALL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HELLO ON BEHALF OF HEALTH TEXAS
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S
AGGRESSIVE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT MEANS THAT
WE HAVE CUT THE NUMBER OF
UNINSURED IN HALF IN THE STATE.
THERE USED TO BE MORE ON
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT HEALTH
INSURANCE THERE'D LITERALLY
THERE WERE PEOPLE IN
MASSACHUSETTS WE HAVE REVERSED
THAT WE HAVE.
GOTTEN MORE AND MORE PEOPLE
HEALTH INSURANCE.
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THE
REPEAL THE OF THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE AND OTHER ACTIONS TAKEN
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL WE'RE IN
DANGER OF GOING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION.
A STUDY TO BE RELEASED MORAL
INDICATE THAT.
IF WE TAKE ALL THE STEPS THAT
ARE PROPOSED THIS YEAR AND
SENATOR PANTS LEGISLATION IN
THAT BY SENATOR ALSO AND OTHERS.
THE DIFFERENCE WILL BE TWO
MILLION MORE ALMOST TWO MILLION
MORE CALIFORNIANS WITH HEALTH
INSURANCE WE'RE PLEASED TO BE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
WHICH IS TIED TO IMPROVING
AFFORDABILITY FOR INDIVIDUALS.
AND ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
YOU.
OTHER ANY OTHER INDIVIDUALS IN
SUPPORT.
KELLY BEING HERE BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
LOUISE THOSE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS IN
SUPPORT.
BRENT SPENCE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND THE CALIFORNIA
PUT AFTER MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
THERESA START WITH KAISER
PERMANENTE A IN SUPPORT.
BARBARA GLAZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS ALSO ME HALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE WATKINS ON THE OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
IN SUPPORT.
CARL SUPPORTER BLUE SHIELD OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
CáC THRILL ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTH SACRAMENTO SENIOR CITIZENS
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JEAN HER SOME A HALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
IN THE ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE ANY OTHER INDIVIDUALS IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON NOW DAVID WOLF AT THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TODAY --
MEMBERS THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT RULED A FEW YEARS
BACK IN TWENTY TWELVE THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE WAS A TAX AND
BECAUSE OF THAT WERE A LITTLE
BIT CONFUSED WHY THIS BILL IS
NOT A TAX THAT SHOULD REQUIRE A
TWO THIRDS VOTE.
OF THIS LEGISLATURE -- WE DO
BELIEVE ACCORDING TO ARTICLE
THIRTEEN A SECTION THREE THAT IT
SHOULD IN FACT BE A TAX.
IN ADDITION MEMBERS
PHILOSOPHICALLY REDEFINED THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE TO BE
REGRESSIVE IN THAT IT WILL PRICE
MILLIONS OF YOUNG INDIVIDUALS
EFFECTIVELY RIGHT OUT OF THE
HEALTH CARE MARKET.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ASK
FOR NUMBER.
BUT THERE ARE OTHER ANY OTHER
INDIVIDUALS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE I ANY MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU OF THIS REST HERE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THEY THEN WILL WAIT THEN.
WE GET BACK TO MAKE THE MOTION
AND TAKE THE VOTE.
SO IT'S ON CALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I SEE YOU AROUND NINE
AROUND HIM YES MY LOOK FOR TO
SEE YOU THEN.
I REMIND EVERYONE THAT THEY
SHOULD BE SURE THAT YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT AT A
REASONABLE TIME OF THE DAY WE'LL
BE WATCHING YOU THANK YOU.
THE WE WILL NOW RECESS UNTIL ONE
THIRTY PM THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE UNDERSTANDING
MAYBE YOU SEE A THREE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT OF MY
WITNESSES.
FOR SB SIX NINETY NINE ARE
COMING DOWN FROM THE OFFICE AND
IT'S A LITTLE CROWDED OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW.
HI.
THERE IS A GERMAN WELCOME BACK
TO GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE WE ARE
GRATEFUL THAT YOU ARE ALL HERE
IN WELCOME THE AFTERNOON EDITION
SOON TO TURN INTO THE EVENING
EDITION.
WE ONLY HAVE TWENTY SIX BILLS
LEFT SO -- SHOULD BE LIGHTNING
SPEED TODAY WE HAVE THREE BILLS
THAT SENATOR HILL WILL BE
PRESENTIG WE CALL THIS THE
SENATOR HILL SHOW -- WE'RE GONNA
START WITH ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
SIX SCA.
THREE THEN WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
ITEM TWENTY SEVEN SCA.
FIVE THEN WE'RE GONNA MOVE THE
OTHERS REQUEST TO ITEM EIGHTEEN
SB.
SIX NINETY NINE I DON'T TWENTY
SIX TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN IN
THAT ORDER THE GERMAN WE'RE
GONNA TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR HILL FOCUSING ON
PROPERTY TAXATION THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES --
SCA THREE AT ITS CORE IS ABOUT
EQUITY AND FAIRNESS.
PROPOSES TO MODIFY THE PROPERTY
TAX INHERENT IT'S EXCLUSION LAW
PROSPECTIVELY. TO REQUIRE
CHILDREN GRANDCHILDREN THAT
INHERENT HOME TO ACTUALLY LIVE
IN THE HOME IN ORDER TO KEEP
THEIR PROP THIRTEEN BASE YEAR
AND TO AVOID REASSESSMENT.
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE IN
THE COUNTRY THAT ALLOWS PARENTS
TO LEAVE THEIR HOME TO A CHILD
AND NOT HAVE THAT HOME
REASSESSED.
YOUNG PROFESSIONALS AND
STRUGGLING FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS ALL HAVE TO PAY PROPERTY
TAXES ON THE FULL VALUE OF THEIR
HOMES.
IT SEEMS BLATANTLY UNFAIR THAT
SOMEONE COULD INHERIT A HOME
THEY DON'T EVEN WANT TO LIVE IN
AND PAY A FRACTION OF PROPERTY
TAXES THAT THEIR NEIGHBORS.
UNDER SCA THREE OF A CHILD
GRANDCHILD INHERITS PROPERTY
WANTS TO KEEP THEIR PARENTS ARE
GRANDPA PERRANCE ASSESSED VALUE
FOR PROPERTY TAXES.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO LIVE I THE
HOME AS THEIR PRIMARY RESIDENCE
WITHIN TWELVE MONTHS OF
INHERITING THE PROPERTY.
THIS ADDITIONAL TWELVE MONTHS
ALLOWS THE CHILD GRANDCHILD TO
MAKE ARRANGEMENTS AND DECIDE IF
THEY WANT TO MOVE INTO THE HOME
IF THEY DECIDE TO RENT OUT THE
HOME.
IT WOULD BE REASSESSED A MARKET
RATE IN THE PROPERTY TAXES WOULD
BE ADJUSTED ACCORDINGLY.
PROPOSITION FIFTY EIGHT WHICH
PASSED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX
WAS DESIGNED TO KEEP A HOME IN
THE FAMILY ALLOW CHILDREN TO
BENEFIT FROM THE ASSESSED VALUE.
WHEN PARENTS DIE NOT BE
IMMEDIATELY FACED WITH THE
EXORBITANT PROPERTY TAX INCREASE
HOWEVER?
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO BEAR THE BRUNT OF THIS
EXCLUSION WHEN THOSE THAT
INHERIT PROPERTIES ARE RENTING
THEM OUT FOR INCOME.
DOES IT BENEFIT FROM A RENTAL
INCOME FROM PROPERTY THEY
INHERIT SHOULD NOT AND THEY
SHOULD HAVE TO PAY THEIR FAIR
SHARE OF PROPERTY TAXES LOCAL
POLICE FIRE LIBRARIES PARKER
CENTER.
ALREADY FINANCIALLY STRUGGLING
ACROSS THE STATE AND SHOULDN'T
SUFFER UNNECESSARILY MORE
BECAUSE OF THIS INHERITANCE
EXCLUSION LAW.
I DO HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
MATURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY CENTER HELL WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL WE WELCOME YOU TOO MANY
FIRST LAST NAME ORGANIZATION OF
TWO MINUTES GOOD TO SEE AGAIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SCA.
THREE BY CLOSING THIS LOOPHOLE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WOULD RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL PROPERTY TAX REVENUES
WHICH IN TURN WOULD MAKE THE
GUARANTEED PROPERTY NINETY EIGHT
PORTION OF STATE BUDGET GO
FURTHER. TO ADDRESS STUDENT
NEEDS -- AS YOU KNOW -- WE'VE
NOTED THAT EVEN THOUGH THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA IS FULLY
FUNDED IT IS AND NO WAIT
ADEQUATE THAT BY CLOSING THIS
LOOPHOLE IN CREATING MORE
FAIRNESS AND EQUITY WE BELIEVE
THAT OUR SCHOOL CHILDREN ARE
GOING TO BENEFIT AS WELL AND
DRIVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THINGS IN
GERMAN I WOULD LIKE THAT OPEN UP
TO ANYONE ELSE WHO IS IN SUPPORT
IF YOU COULD PLEASE ADVANCE
FIRST LAST NAME ORGANIZATION WE
WELCOME YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL KENDO
KAISER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH -- OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM CTA WHO IS ONE OF OUR ONE
DOZEN MEMBERS THANK YOU IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BUT I COULD DO A LAST CALL FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME.
FOR WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
ANY INDIVIDUAL WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION IF
YOU COULD PLEASE ADVANCED AT
THIS TIME.
LOW'S IN OPPOSITION.
THIS IS GONNA BE A LASSEN ONLY
CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM ESTABLISHING OR MORNING
ADDITION.
WOULD LIKE TO GO TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
KERN SEEN NINE IS THERE A MOTION
TO APPROVE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
SIX SCA.
THREE WE HAVE A MOTION BY THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE
CENTER HELLO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS CENTER
HEALTH FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON THIS
IN ON ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
IS WELL.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR BELL
THIS IS TO BE A JOB TO DO
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS THIS LINE JUST A ROLL
CALL PLEASE CHOIR HI WHY I'M
MORE A LOT.
WELL.
WELL I HEARD FIRST HELLO NIELSEN
WIENER.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A TWO ZERO VOTE
LADIES IN GENERAL WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
MEMBERS ARE NOT GONNA MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN SCA FIVE
RELATED TO PERSONAL TAXES AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SENATOR HELD
THE FLOOR IS YOURS AND AGAIN.
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON
THIS BILL.
WELL IN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT VOTERS TO IMPOSE EXTEND
OR INCREASE A PARTIAL TAX WITH
55% VOTER APPROVAL RATHER.
THAN THE CURRENT TWO THIRDS VOTE
REQUIREMENT DESPITE STATE
FUNDING INCREASES IN K. THROUGH
TWELVE AND HIGHER EDUCATION OVER
THE PAST SIX YEARS MANY SCHOOL
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
ARE STRUGGLING TO MAINTAIN
QUALITY EDUCATIONAL SERVICES.
DUE TO THESE PRESSURES AN
ESTIMATED TWO THIRDS OF SCHOOL
DISTRICT WILL HAVE DEFICITS IN
FISCAL YEAR. TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWO THIRDS OF SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
MANY DISTRICTS HAVE HAD TO LAY
OFF FOR FOR LOW TEACHERS AND
CLASSIFIED STAFF AND CUT
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
WELCOME UNITY COLLEGES SERVE THE
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENT
POPULATIONS THERE PER STUDENT
FUNDING LEVELS ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
LOWER THAN YOU SEE ISSUES OR YOU
SEE PARTIAL TAXES ARE ONE OF THE
FEW WAYS.
LOCAL SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT ARE ABLE TO
RAISE REVENUE AND SUPPLEMENT
FUNDS THEY RECEIVE FROM THE
STATE.
BUT THEY REMAIN IN THE
INACCESSIBLE TO MOST COMMUNITIES
GIVEN THE HIGH TWO THIRDS VOTER
THRESHOLD OF A 55% VOTING
THRESHOLD I PREVIOUSLY BEEN IN
PLACE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE PARTIAL
TAX MEASURES WOULD HAVE BEEN
APPROVED MORE THAN 80%.
OF THE TWENTY SIX A LOCAL SCHOOL
PARTIAL TAX MEASURES THAT FAILED
IN CALIFORNIA.
FROM TWENTY TWELVE TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WOULD HAVE PASSED IF A
SUPER MAJORITY VOTE OF 55% WERE
REQUIRED FOR APPROVAL INSTEAD OF
A TWO THIRDS VOTE.
SCA BOUGHT FIVE IS FUNDAMENTALLY
ABOUT FAIRNESS EXISTING LAW HAS
ENABLED A MINORITY OF VOTERS TO
BLOCK EFFORTS TO PROVIDE VITAL.
LOCAL EDUCATION FUNNY THIS IS
LIKE THIS IS REALLY CONTRARY TO
OUR DEMOCRATIC PRINCIPLES.
WE WERE WITH RESPECT TO
REQUIRING SUPERMAJORITY VOTES
JAMES MADISON WROTE IN THE
FEDERALIST PAPERS.
WELL IT WOULD BE NO LONGER IT
WOULD BE NO LONGER THE MAJORITY
THAT WOULD RULE THE POWER WOULD
BE TRANSFERRED TO THE MINORITY
SIMILARLY.
ALEXANDERHAMILTON WROTE QUOTE
WHAT A FIRST SIGHT MAY SEEM A
REMEDY IS IN REALITY A POISON.
TO GIVE A MINORITY A NEGATIVE
UPON THE MAJORITY IS IN ITS
TENDENCY TO SUBJECT THE SENSE OF
THE GREATER NOW. TO THAT OF THE
LESSER SCA FIVE RETAINS THE
REQUIREMENT FOR SUPERMAJORITY
APPROVAL OF LOCAL SCHOOL PARTIAL
FACTORS BUT THE LEGISLATION
CHANGES THE SUPERMAJORITY
THRESHOLD. TO A MORE REALISTIC
PERCENTAGE.
HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER HELL IT WE HAVE A BOOK OF
QUOTES AN IMPORTANT BILL ON ALL
ISSUES OF EDUCATION VERY
GRATEFUL SIR.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
KICK US OFF IN REGARDS TO BEING
OUR WITNESS?
ALL RIGHT IF YOU COULD PLEASE
GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND LAST AS
WELL AS YOUR ORGANIZATION YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS RICHARD
FERRER I'M ON THE BOARD OF THE
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WELCOME SENATOR UNIFIED
REPRESENTS ABOUT A HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS
DATED TWELVE WITH THE SECOND
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT -- THE
STATISTICS THAT SENATOR HILL WAS
GOING.
GOING PROVED VERY MUCH IS
REALITY THAT IT IS MY ELEVENTH
YEAR ON THE SCHOOL BOARD.
EVERY YEAR EVERY SPRING I AS WE
TRY TO BALANCE OUR BUDGET WERE
FACED WITH SO PIECE CHOICES.
I DO WE CUT COUNSELORS DO WE
INCREASE CLASS SIZES I DO WE
FAILED TO ADEQUATELY COMPENSATE
OUR TEACHERS WERE HAVING A MORE
A MORE DIFFICULT TIME.
IN ABLE TO AFFORD TO LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA.
BEING THAT.
WE KNOW WILL TAKE A CONCERTED
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN LOCAL
DISTRICTS AND THE STATE TO
ADDRESS.
BUT WE ARE READY AND WILLING TO
PLAY OUR PART.
OUR DISTRICT IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS HAS GONE FOR VOTERS THREE
TIMES.
PER BOND MEASURES I EACH OF
THOSE BOND MEASURES OF PAST
THAT'S A TOTAL OF EIGHT AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS THAT LOCAL
VOTERS.
HAVE INVESTED IN THEIR LOCAL
SCHOOLS.
I BUT NONE OF THOSE MEASURES
WOULD HAVE MEDIC TWO THIRDS
SPECIAL WE JUST PASSED IN
NOVEMBER A AT THREE AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLAR BOND MEASURE.
I THAT GOT 65% OF THE VOTE THAT
WOULD HAVE FAILED AT A TWO
THIRDS A THRESHOLD.
SO WE ARE VERY CONFIDENT THAT
LOCAL VOTERS WILL SUPPORT THEIR
LOCAL SCHOOLS IF WE HAVE A FAIR
PLAYING.
AND JUST BRINGING DOWN THE
THRESHOLD 255% I THE SAME THAT
WERE ABLE TO DO THE SAUDIS BONDS
BUT TO BE ABLE TO INVEST BAD
INTO INTO MONEY INTO.
LAST ROOMS I WOULD MAKE AN
ENORMOUS DIFFERENCE IN OUR
ABILITY TO OUT OF THE EDUCATOR.
THE SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER WE'RE
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE AND YOU
TRAVEL NORTH. TO BE WITH SINCE
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TO HAVE ANY
CLOSING WORDS BEFORE WE GO TO
OUR NEXT WITNESS.
I WE JUST I CAN TELL YOU THAT.
OUR DISTRICT EVERY DISTRICT IN
THE STATE IS FACING AN
UNSUSTAINABLE I SITUATION IF WE
CONTINUE.
TO TODAY I TECH OPERATE AT THE
CURRENT LEVELS OF FUNDING WE
SIMPLY CANNOT PROVIDE OUR KIDS
WHAT THEY NEED.
CANNOT ADEQUATELY COMPENSATE OUR
EDUCATORS I'M LESS WE DO
SOMETHING AND WE ARE READY TO BE
PART OF SOMETHING.
AND I PASSING SENATOR I HILLS
BILL I WILL ALLOW US TO MAKE A
BIG CONTRIBUTION THIS CHALLENGE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR OVER DECADES
OF SERVICER WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU
HEARING COMMITTEES THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOUR TESTIMONY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MA'AM HE IS GIVES
HER FIRST LASSEN ORGANIZATION WE
WELCOME TO COMMITTEE OF TWO
MINUTES THANK YOU I'M JODY DAY
BERRY CHAIR FINANCING PUBLIC
EDUCATION. FOR CTA I ALSO M. A
SCHOOL TEACHER AT LAKE TAHOE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME SENATOR
AND THE MANY MEMBERS.
I'M PLEASED TO TESTIFY TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SCA.
FIVE AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR HILL FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THIS IMPORTANT CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT WOULD PROVIDE A MORE
DEMOCRATIC.
THIS TO THE WAY SCHOOL SEE
COMMUNITY SUPPORT TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
FOR THE CHILDREN THEY SERVE.
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS CONTINUE TO
BE FUNDED SIGNIFICANTLY BELOW
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE.
LEAVING MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WITHOUT THE FINANCIAL SUPPORT
THEY NEED TO PROVIDE OUR
CHILDREN WITH ALL THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION THEY DESERVE.
OUR DISTRICTS ARE NOT RECEIVING
ADEQUATE FUNDING FROM BOTH THE
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS.
AS A TWENTY THREE YEAR VETERAN.
I SEE IT EVERY DAY.
YEAR IN YEAR OUT I USE THE WORD
VETERAN BECAUSE I FEEL I TOO AM
AT WAR. TO SEEK FUNDING FOR
PUBLIC EDUCATION WE ARE
CONTINUALLY UNDER ATTACK.
AND TO HAVE TO BATTLE FOR THE
BASIC SERVICES OUR STUDENTS NEED
[inaudible]
IS LUDICROUS.
I AM CURRENTLY WITNESSING IN MY
DISTRICT CUTS TO VITAL PROGRAMS
SUCH AS READING INTERVENTION
MATH INTERVENTION SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
NURSING AND COUNSELING.
SCIENCE AND STEM PROGRAMS AND
CAREER TECH EDUCATION.
AS I SEE IT.
IT IS OUR DUTY. TO CHANGE THE
SYSTEM.
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT LOCAL
COMMUNITIES SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT AND SHOULD HAVE THE
FAIRNESS OF BEING ABLE TO PASS
PARCEL TAXES.
BELOW THE TWO THIRDS SPECIAL
THAT WE SEE NOW.
SCA FIVE WOULD ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO
HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS.
CTA BELIEVES THAT THIS MEASURE
IS GOOD FOR KIDS.
GOOD FOR SCHOOLS AND GOOD FOR
DEMOCRACY.
ON BEHALF OF THE CTA I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT ON SCA.
FIVE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TRAVELING HERE FROM THE TOP OVER
FULL IN FOR TWENTY THREE YEARS
OF SERVICE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NOW WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORTIVE.
PERSON LASSEN YOUR ORGANIZATION
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
MARC PATTERSON ABOUT THE WHOLE
STATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS ACSA.
GOOD TO SEE YOU THANK YOU.
CAITLYN JUNK ON BEHALF OF THE
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION THE MONTEREY COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION VENTURA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT I DANG
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SEVEN BEAR
SNYDER BEHALF OF THE SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICT ASSOCIATION AND
THE CENSUS GOING ABOUT SCHOOL
DISTRICT TOO MUCH BECAUSE YOU.
DEFINITELY LONNIE I CANNOT ON
BEHALF OF TOWARDS UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT PRESENT UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SCHOOLS AND FINANCE AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FEAR ABOUT JUST WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THE AFTERNOON SURELY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL PRECISION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
DOES FINE CITIZEN INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA AND CITY OF CLAREMONT --
VERY MUCH IN FAVOR OF THE RETURN --
TO THOUGHT OF MAJORITY RULE ON
ISSUES LIKE THIS AND NO BETTER
THAN A PARTIAL TAX -- TO GIVE
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FUND -- EDUCATION
ADEQUATELY THANK REFER YOU HERE
SIR THANK YOU.
WE'D LIKE TO GETA LOOK FOR LAST
CALL LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE ADVANCED
MICRO LAST CALL.
ALL RIGHT NOW WE NOW WOULD LIKE
TO BETTER [inaudible] TO
OPPOSITION.
IF WE'RE GONNA BE IF WE CAN MAKE
ROOM FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE.
THE WAY WE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
RUN OPPOSITION IS TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE EQUAL TIME. FOR EACH
SIDE WE'RE GONNA HAVE ONE
PRIMARY WITNESS.
I AND THEN WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
SECONDARY WITNESSES I TO BE A TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY WHO WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO KICK US OFF AS A
PRIMARY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER SHERMAN
I'M GONNA MISS TOMAGO FIRST OKAY.
THEIR GOVERNMENTS TO MAKE YOU
MINE -- THERE WE GO.
THANK YOU SIR.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS AND THEN OUR
SECONDARY WITNESSES WHAT TWO
MINUTES EACH WE WELCOME YOU BACK
TO COMMITTEE IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO
SEE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TO RESTORE
MAY REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION.
AND WHILE WE RECOGNIZE THE
WELL AS PROVIDING A POLICY A
QUALITY EDUCATION WE HAVE
SEVERAL CONCERNS WITH THE BILL.
THE FIRST IS BY FACILITATING
PARCEL TAX INCREASES THIS BILL
WOULD MAKE IT HARDER FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO AFFORD EITHER
THE RENTAL OR HOME OWNERSHIP.
THIS MORNING THE COMMITTEE SPENT
OVER TWO HOURS TALKING ABOUT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND WE'RE
VERY CONCERNED THAT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL WOULD MAKE IT
MORE DIFFICULT LESS AFFORDABLE
FOR CALIFORNIANS.
OUR SECOND ISSUE IS THAT.
SCHOOLS ALREADY HAVE A SPECIAL
55% CARVE OUT UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION ALL OTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS REQUIRED TWO THIRDS
VOTE FOR TAX WILL TAX INCREASES.
HOWEVER FOR SCHOOL BONTA
CONSTITUTION ALREADY GRANTS A
LOWER VOTE THRESHOLD FOR SCHOOL
BONDS AT THIS TIME.
THE EDUCATION FUNDING UNDER PROP
NINETY EIGHT IS AT AN ALL TIME
HIGH PROPERTY TAXES HAVE BEEN
CONSISTENTLY GOING.
AND HAVE THAT HAS PROVIDE A LOT
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND BRACED
REVENUES FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FUNDING PRIMARILY WHICH GOOD
EDUCATION SO WE QUESTION THE
NEED FOR THE BILL AT THIS TIME.
LAST AND NOT LEAST THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE OF ON YOUR
RELEASED A POLL ON MARCH TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THAT POLL
INDICATED THAT THE VAST MAJORITY.
A VOTERS SUPPORTED.
THE TWO THIRDS AND MAINTAINING
THE CURRENT VOTE THRESHOLD AND
THAT WAS A CROSS DEMOGRAPHICS
BOTH REPUBLICAN VOTERS AS WELL
AS DEMOCRATIC VOTERS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND THAT
ENCOMPASSES LARGE COUNTIES AND
CITIES INCLUDING A LATE SUMMER
CISCO Là AND LOS ANGELES SAN
DIEGO RIVERSIDE EXEDRA AND THOSE
IN SMALLER COUNTIES.
SO WE QUESTION THE NEEDTO
CHANGE
THE VOTE THE SHOW AT THIS TIME
AND ALSO THE MAJORITY OF DOLE'S
I THINK IT'S OVER 60% CURRENTLY
APPROVED BY VOTERS AT THE TWO
THIRDS DASCHLE.
SO IN OUR OPINION AND OUR HUMBLE
OPINION THERE'S REALLY NO NEED
TO CHANGE THE VOTE SPECIAL WHEN
THERE HAD BEEN BILLS THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN PASS OF THE TWO THIRDS.
VOTE THRESHOLD THAT HAS RESULTED
IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS GOING BACK.
LOOKING AT THE LANGUAGE AND
REFORMATTING THAT PROPOSAL SO
THAT IT IS BETTER HAS GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY. FOR VOTERS IN
ORDER TO RECEIVE THE TWO THIRDS
VOTE AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE
BILL HAS ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES.
BUT BASED ON TRACK RECORD THAT
WE HAVE AND FROM A DATABASE.
OF THE LOWER VOTE THRESHOLD IS
NOT NECESSARY THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON DAVID
WARFARE WITH THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION AND I DO
JUST WANT TO BEGIN BY PICKING UP
ON THE THEME THAT MISSED HIM AND
TALKED ABOUT ABOUT WEARING A TWO
THIRDS VOTE BING UNNECESSARY.
THERE'S MANY COUNTIES MEMBERS
INCLUDING ORANGE COUNTY THAT
HAVE PASSED TRANSPORTATION SALES
TAX MEASURES WITH A TWO THIRDS
VOTE SO CARLY THE THRESHOLD CAN
BE REACHED AND WE KNOW IT CAN
BECAUSE ACCORDING TO THE WEBSITE
CALIFORNIA CITY FINANCE.
A REVIEW SCHOOL DISTRICT
PERSONAL TAXES SINCE TWENTY
TWELVE SHOWED THAT IN NOVEMBER
ELKS IN NOVEMBER ELECTION SINCE
201275% OF THOSE MEASURES HAVE
BEEN APPROVED.
THE MAIN ISSUE MEMBERS THAT WE
HAVE WITH PERSONAL TAXES IS THAT
THEY ARE VERY REGRESSIVE IN THAT
NO MATTER IF YOU OWN A ONE
BEDROOM HOUSE OR A MILLION
DOLLAR MANSION.
YOU PAY THE EXACT SAME AMOUNT --
IN TEN THROUGH THIRDS VOTE IS
FOR HOMEOWNERS IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ALSO BECAUSE WELL
EVERYBODY GETS TO VOTE ON THESE
LOCAL PERSONAL TAXES ONLY
PROPERTY OWNERS PAY THEM.
YOU KNOW I LOVE BRING UP THIS
QUOTING COMMITTEE EVERY YEAR AND
I ATTRIBUTE IT TO BEN FRANKLIN
IT'S A TRIBUTE TO BEN FRANKLIN
SAID.
DEMOCRACY IS TWO WOLVES AND A
SHEEP DECIDING WHAT'S FOR DINNER.
AND I LOVE THAT QUOTE BECAUSE I
THINK IT SPEAKS TO THE BILL YOU
KNOW YOU DON'T WANNA CARRY THE
METAPHOR ON TOO FAR BUT
TAXPAYERS ARE THE SHEEP AND THE
NEED TO BE PROTECTED IN THIS
INSTANCE.
AND HAVING A TWO THIRDS VOTE
INSURERS THAT THAT'S THE CASE
AND I'LL JUST CLOSE MISTER
CHAIRMAN BY SAYING FINALLY THIS
MEASURE DOES NOTHING EVEN AS MR
MAY MENTIONED. TO AID AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THERE'S ONLY 30% OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS RIGHT NOW
THAT CAN AFFORD A MEDIAN PRICED
HOME A FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ADDING PERSONAL
TAXES.
IN THE HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS PER
YEAR THERE'S NOTHING TO AID THAT
AND MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR
MILLENNIALS LIKE ME AND OTHER
PEOPLE TO OF SO FOR ALL THOSE
REASONS ASPIRIN ABOUT.
THIS WOLF IT WE HAVE THE WAR OF
DOING QUOTE TODAY -- A WATCH OUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL RIGHT
YOU'RE PICKING PER GAME SIR.
ALSO IF IN THE PAPERS AGAINST.
SENATOR HILL HE HASN'T QUITE IT
EXPERIENCE LET US ALL BE ON ANY
OF THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION.
WE RESPECT THE PASSIONOF THE
CENTER FOR EDUCATION FINANCE BUT
WE ALSO -- AND IN FACT OUR
FAMILY BUSINESS OR SOME OF THE
MOST PHILANTHROPIC SEVERAL
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN.
IN CALIFORNIA COMMITTED TO
CALIFORNIA THE CHALLENGES YOU
CAN'T LOOK AT ONE TAX.
INDEPENDENT OF THE REST OF MY
THINK THAT THAT'S THE REFERENCE
OF THIS OF THE THE STUDY OF THE
PP I SEE STUDY.
THAT THEY SAID LOOK THIS IS WHAT
ONE TAX I IN A HIGH TAX STATE.
WE NEED A TWO THIRDS VOTE IS
APPROPRIATE WHEN.
LOOKING AT IT COMPARED TO ALL
THE REST OF THE TAXES THAT ARE
REQUIRED ON BUSINESSES AND AND
FRANKLY OUR EMPLOYEES AS WELL.
SO FROM THAT STANDPOINT AND AND
AS MR WILL PUT IT OUT THIS IS DO
NOT COULD DEVOTE BUT THEY DO YOU
KNOW OWN PROPERTY AND PAY THESE
ADDITIONAL TAXES.
AND SO WE APPRECIATE THE AGAIN
THE FOCUS ON EDUCATION BUT AT
THIS POINT NOT MUST CONTINUE TO
OPPOSE.
CHARLIE I THINK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE -- INTO OUR WITNESSES
WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP TO THOSE WHO
OPPOSE IF YOU JUST GIVE US YOUR
FIRST AND LAST AS WELL AS
ORGANIZATION WELCOMED COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
SERRA BOOT ON BEHALF OF CAL
CHAMBER IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU HAVE TO ANSWER EVERY MISTER
MEMBERS REC TIME ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION ALSO.
THANK YOU SIR I'M [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
APOLOGIES FOR GOING OUT OF ORDER
BUT NANCY TRIED ASSISTING US ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RETIRED
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IT'S GOOD TO
SEE.
BRING TO A LAST CALL LAST CALL
FOR THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD
LOOKING FOR THOSE WERE OPPOSED.
ALL RIGHT WE LIKE TO BETTER
BRING IN BACK TO COMMITTEE. TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF CENTER HILL.
I HAVE JUST A FEW COMMENTS BUT
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR DO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR AS
WELL.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR BELL
[inaudible]
LOOK.
I THINK THAT I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS SOME OF THE CONCERN
THAT THE OPPOSITION HAS REYES
AMBER STILL LOOKING IN
SUPERMAJORITY VOTERS.
WERE STILL GONNA PROVEN
EFFECTIVE 5%.
AND GOING OFF OF WHERE WE COULD
BE ABOVE AND BEYOND 50% PLUS.
ONE MR WILL BRINGS UP A POINT
REGARDS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING I
THINK THAT'S WHY STATE IS
ADVANCING TWELVE BILLION FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS AND THAT'S WHY WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO PUT A
PERMANENT SOURCE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BACK IN.
AND BE ABLE TO LOOK AT PICKING
UP THE PACE WHEN IT COMES
APPROVAL OF HOUSING ESPECIALLY
ON A PORTABLE [inaudible]
THAT SAID.
WANT TO SEE ANY FINAL THOUGHTS
AS WELL AS YOUR CLOSING STILL
IMAGES THANK YOU AND AND MY ONLY
THOUGHT IS JUST YOU KNOW MISTER
WOLF DID MAKE THE RATES THE
COMMENT LOVE HIS METAPHOR ABOUT
THE SHEEP BUT YOU KNOW ABOUT
PROTECTING.
THE POPULATION TECHNOLOGY
CITIZENS.
THEY ARE PROTECT.
YOU'RE PROTECTED BY THEIR VOTE.
THEY CAN EITHER AS A MAJORITY
VOTE.
IN THAT VOTE.
SHOULD BE DETERMINED BY MAJORITY
IN THAT DECISION NOT BY A
MINORITY AND THAT'S WHAT IT IS
TODAY THIS IS IT THIS IS JUST
BASIC.
BASIC DEMOCRACY AND THAT'S HOW
WE SHOULD TREAT.
OUR ELECTIONS THAT'S HOW WE
SHOULD TREAT TAXATION AND THAT'S
HOW WE SHOULD TREAT THE EVER
EVERYTHING THAT THE SOCIETY IN
THIS COUNTRY IS BASED ON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND MR HELL WE
DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
THIS MOTION IS TO BE ADOPTED
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS.
CENTER SOROKA POLICE FIRE.
WIRE I MORE LOCKED.
WELL I AM HERTZBERG.
NIELSEN WIENER.
WIENER.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ZERO
VOTE.
MASON GERMAN WE ARE GOING TO BE
LOOKING FOR AUTHORS -- RIGHT
AFTER SENATOR HILL ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHTEEN SO SERGEANTS ARE GONNA
START CALLING -- IN REGARDS TO
ADDITIONAL AUTHORS CENTER HILL I
HAVE TO GO VOTE IN EDUCATION.
SO I'M GONNA TURN THE GAVEL OVER
TO SENATOR BELL -- AND I
APOLOGIZE NOT TRYING TO BE RUDE
BUT I WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
EDUCATION UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEM
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OR CENTER I DO THANK THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU CHAIR THE
CHAIRS SENATOR.
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY NINE
WOULD EXTEND THE EXISTING SUNSET
PROVISIONS FOR STATE OVERSIGHT
OF SAN FRANCISCO'S REQUIRED
LITTLE PROGRAM.
FROM JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TO JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY SIX THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO EXPAND SAN FRANCISCO
BAY REGIONAL WATER SYSTEM
FINANCING AUTHORITY AND
AUTHORIZES THE RFA TO ISSUE
REVENUE BONDS AND TAKE OTHER
ACTIONS TO IMPROVE THE
RELIABILITY OF THE REAL.
REGIONAL WATER SYSTEM OF SAN
FRANCISCO.
EXISTING LAW PROHIBITS THE RFA
FROM ISSUING REVENUE BONDS AFTER
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY JENNIFER DISCO WAS
NOT COMPLETED IT'S LEGISLATIVELY
REQUIRED CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM ANTICIPATES FINANCING
ACTIVITY FOR THESE IMPROVEMENTS
TO CONTINUE BEYOND. TWENTY
TWENTY TO FACILITATE ADEQUATE
FINANCING AND SMOOTH COMPLETION
OF THE CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM THE ARE IF THESE
FINANCING AUTHORITY SHOULD BE
EXTENDED.
ARE THERE SEEMS TO BE NO
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THAT
WE'VE SEEN AND THE I HAVE A
WITNESS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SIR HERE WITNESSES.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
CHAIR BILL MY NAME IS NICOLE
SAYING CLIMB THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR THE BAY AREA WATER
SUPPLYING CONSERVATION AGENCY.
A SPECIAL DISTRICT THAT WAS
AUTHORIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR IN
TWO THOUSAND AND TWO I REPRESENT
THE WATER INTEREST OF THE TWENTY
SIX SUPPLIERS IN THE BAY AREA
THAT BY WATER FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO REGIONAL HAD TO TO
WATER SYSTEM.
AND THEY DELIVER IT TO ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION RESIDENTS OVER
FORTY THOUSAND BUSINESSES
INCLUDING MOST OF SILICON VALLEY.
AND THOUSANDS OF COMMUNITY
AGENCIES AND ALAMEDA SAN MATEO
AND SANTA CLARA COUNTIES.
BUSCA SUPPORTS SENATE BILL.
SIX NINETY NINE THE BILL
PROPOSES NEEDED AMENDMENTS TO
EXTEND TO LAWS ORIGINALLY
ENACTED IN. TWO THOUSAND TWO ONE
OF THE BILLS WAS AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY THREE BI PAP IN WHICH
REQUIRES SAN FRANCISCO TO
IMPLEMENT CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS
FOR ITS REGIONAL WATER SYSTEM.
TO ENSURE THE COULD WITHSTAND A
MAJOR SEISMIC EVENT AND CONTINUE
TO DELIVER ESSENTIAL WATER
AFTERWARDS.
THAT WORK IS NOW 97% COMPLETE
BUT TO CRITICAL PROJECTS ARE NOT
YET DONE AND CONTINUING STATE
OVERSIGHT SENATE BILL SIX NINETY
NINE AS NECESSARY.
UNTIL THOSE PROJECTS ARE
COMPLETE.
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY NINE ALSO
EXTENDS THE OTHER ORIGINAL BILL
SENATE BILL EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
WITH I JACKIE SPEAR.
WHICH AUTHORIZES THE FORMATION
OF THE REGIONAL FINANCING
AUTHORITY TO ISSUE REVENUE BONDS
TO FINANCE THOSE IMPROVEMENTS
FOR THE WATER SYSTEM. THREE DAYS
FROM DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY THIRTY OSCAR IS PLEASED
TO SUPPORT SENATE BILL SIX
NINETY NINE INTRODUCED BY
SENATOR KERRY HILL.
WHICH WILL PROVIDE THIS
CONTINUING PROTECTION TO IS
TWENTY SIX MEMBER AGENCIES.
THE RESIDENTS AND THE BUSINESSES
THAT THEY SERVE WE ASK FOR YOUR
EYES DR OF HEY -- WITNESSES EVER.
WORD ANYWHERE.
WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
AND ANY -- OPPOSED WITNESSES
APPROACH ANYBODY.
AND IT'S IT'S SIX NINE NINE
QUESTION FROM COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
REMOTE.
THE MOTION.
SIR WINNER [inaudible]
AND QUESTION [inaudible]
WIRE [inaudible]
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT.
HELLO NIELSEN.
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
BOTH SO YOU [inaudible]
COLLEGE
[inaudible]
WHAT BROUGHT
SIR WELL -- THERE'S
COMMITTEE PRO TEN CHAIRMAN -- I
WOULD.
REQUEST THAT YOU PRESENT YOUR
BILL.
GREAT I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBER.
I AM HERE TO PRESENT SB.
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH IS
CLEAN UP -- TO MY SB SIX THIRTY
FOUR FROM TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN WHICH CREATED THE NEW
SET UP CREATED VALLEY WATER
AGENCY WHICH WAS A CONSOLIDATION
OF TO PRIOR WATER AGENCIES. ONE
OF THE PROVISIONS IN SB SIX
THIRTY FOUR REQUIRES AGENCY
BOARD OF DIRECTORS TO REDUCE ITS
MMBERSHIP.
TOTAL FROM FIFTEEN WHICH WAS THE
MERGING OF THE TWO BOARDS TO
EVENTUALLY DOWN TO NINE MEMBERS.
I SB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
AUTHORIZES AGENCIES BORDER
DIRECTORS TO LIMITED A BOARD
POSITION IF THERE'S A VACANCY
PRIOR TO THE NEXT ELECTION LIKE
SOMEBODY MOVES AWAY.
OR WHAT HAVE YOU THIS BILL IS
NEEDED TO AVOID EITHER AN
ELECTION OR IMPORTANT PROCESS
FOR SEAT AS REQUIRED TO BE
ELIMINATED -- BY BY THE BY THE
PRIOR LEGISLATION IN THE NEXT
TWO ELECTION CYCLES SO THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A MATH ALL AND
METHODOLOGY TO FAIRLY STATE
WHICH WHICH SEATS GET TWO YEAR
AND FOUR YEAR TERMS.
IF THIS THE THORNIEST EXERCISED.
IT SPECIFY IT SPECIFIES A CAESAR
CONSOLIDATED PRIOR TO ELECTION A
LOT TO DETERMINE WHICH SEATS
RECEIVED TWO AND FOUR YEAR TERMS
WILL OCCUR.
EXCEPT THE TECHNICAL MEMBERS
PROPOSED BY THE COMMITTEE THAT
DISCLAIMS THE STATE MANDATE AND
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE COMMITTEE
STAFF. FOR THE FULL ATTENTION ON
THIS BILL THIS BILL SPONSORED BY
THE AGENCY WE HAVE NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
AND WHERE EVERYBODY HERE ALL WE
HAVE MET STONE HERE FROM.
THE GENERAL MANAGER.
THE WATER AGENCY THE QUESTION I
GET YEAH YOU'RE JUST GONNA
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS RIGHT
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY
YEAH COME SIT DOWN.
OKAY -- ELSEWHERE -- SPEAKERS IN
FAVOR ANYBODY ELSE WANTS TO
SPEAK ON THIS BILL.
OKAY SPEAKERS EMOTIONS OVER
SUMMER WHAT IT DOES.
SO I DON'T SEE ANY OPPOSITION --
THE RECOMMENDATIONS TWO THOUSAND
AND THE THROUGH PROCREATION.
YEAH MOTION PLEASE.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION -- CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE.
FIRE MORE LOT FELL A BILL I
HERTZBERG.
HELLO NIELSEN WIENER.
WE ARE ALL RIGHT.
TWO ZERO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBER.
I SEE.
MANY CALL YOU SEE KATHLEEN
GALGIANI HERE -- CENTER GALGIANI
HAS IS BEING.
SEVEN SEVENTY KATHLEEN GALGIANI
YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THE LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED THE
PROPERTY TAX POSTPONEMENT
PROGRAM TO PROTECT AND SUPPORT
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS.
BY ALLOWING QUALIFIED HOMEOWNERS
TO POSTPONE PROPERTY TAXES WHY
THIS PROGRAM IS VALUABLE FOR
COUNTLESS INDIVIDUALS AND
ESPECIALLY OUR ELDERLY
UNFORTUNATELY THE PROGRAM HAS
ALWAYS HAD HISTORICALLY LOW
PARTICIPATION RATES.
COMPARED TO THE NUMBER OF
POTENTIAL PARTICIPANTS.
SB SEVEN SEVENTY ADDRESSES THIS
PROBLEM BY EXPANDING HOMEOWNER
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE PROGRAM BY
LOWERING THE EQUITY REQUIREMENT
FOR EACH POSTPONEMENT CLAIM FOR
PROPERTY TAX DEFERMENT.
ELIGIBILITY FROM 40% 220%.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS REQUIRING THAT
APPLICANTS HAVE NO MORE THAN ONE
LEAN AGAINST THEIR PROPERTY.
AND MEMBERS MEMBER LET ME
EXPLAIN TO YOU THE RATIONALE FOR
THIS LEGISLATION -- SENATOR BELL
WHEN YOU AND I WERE IN THE
ASSEMBLY TOGETHER WE WENT
THROUGH THE HOUSING CRISIS AND
THE ECONOMIC CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA. TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
EIGHT THEY HIT A RECORD LOW A
COUPLE OF YEARS LATER WHERE
THOSE HOMES WERE WORTH.
HALF OF WHAT THEY ORIGINALLY
WERE WORTH IN SOME AREAS OF THE
STATE HOME PRICES HAVE RECOVERED
BUT IN OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE
HOME PRICES ARE STILL.
ARTIFICIALLY LOW AND MANY
HOMEOWNERS WHO PURCHASED HOMES
DURING THAT TIME WHEN PRICES
WERE AT RECORD HIGHS.
THEY STILL HAVE LESS THAN 20%
EQUITY IN THEIR HOME SO IF YOU
HAVE SOMEBODY WHO WAS FIFTY FIVE
SIXTY FIVE I TEN FIFTEEN YEARS
AGO.
AND THERE THE VALUE OF THEIR
HOME CRASHED AND THEY'RE NEEDING
THIS ASSISTANCE.
IT'S HIGHLY LIKELY THAT THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE -- EVEN 20% EQUITY
IN THEIR HOME.
BEFORE THE ECONOMIC CRISIS WE
DID OFFER THIS PROGRAM AS LONG
AS INDIVIDUALS HAD AT LEAST 20%
EQUITY IN THEIR HOME AND NOW.
THAN THAT PROGRAM WENT AWAY
BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMIC CRISIS
AND THEN WHEN IT WAS RESTORED.
THE LEGISLATURE CAUTIOUSLY
REIMPLEMENTED THE PROGRAM WITH A
40% REQUIREMENT FOR EQUITY WHICH
MANY HOMEOWNERS WHO AGAIN BOUGHT.
WHEN HOMES WERE RECORD HIGHS?
IT WOULD BE YEARS BEFORE THEY
COULD REACH THAT 40% EQUITY
LEVEL SO WHAT I'M ASKING FOR IN
THIS BILL IS FOR US TO SIMPLY
RETURN.
TO THE PROGRAM THAT WE HAD IN
PLACE PRIOR TO THE ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN BUT WE ACTUALLY MAKE.
WHERE HOMEOWNERS CAN INDEED
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM IF
THE NEED ARISES FOR THEM TO DO
SO AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE?
THANK YOU AND YOU MADE AN
AMENDMENT TO THE BILL YES IDEA
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE IN MINUTES.
WE HAVE -- SPEAKERS IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL [inaudible]
THE MONEY.
ABOUT -- TO OPPOSITION ANYBODY
OPPOSED.
LISTEN TO THIS BILL THIS IS SO.
SB -- SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO INITIAL
COMMENTS -- I WOULD MENTION THAT
IF.
ACCORDING TO THE LEGISLATION TO
PUT THIS PROGRAM BACK INTO PLACE
BUT GAIN IT WAS A A CAUTIOUS
IMPLEMENTATION AND AND SO I'M
ASKING TODAY THAT WE RESTORED TO
PREVIOUS LEVELS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION TO A
RECOMMENDATION DO PASSES A
MINUTE TO APPROPRIATIONS.
OUR MOTION.
THERE'S MOTION TO PASS.
YOU PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS --
OKAY -- FIRE ALARM BELL.
ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG.
HELLO NIELSEN WIENER.
WIENER ALL RIGHT [inaudible] TWO
ZERO HELLO OPEN PERHAPS NUMBERS --
SOME AUTHORS.
THANK YOU CENTER
.
IT IS IN GENERAL WE'RE GONNA.
A LITTLE BIT OF HOUSEKEEPING TO
DO THAT WE HAVE TO DO THAT WE
DID NOT HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS.
IN COMMITTEE.
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
ACTION ON ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WE
HAVE A MOTION AND I TO ME SB ONE
SEVENTY FIVE SENATOR PAN.
ITEM EIGHT SQ ONE SEVENTY FIVE
PAN.
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU SIR ROLL CALL PLEASE
MCGUIRE HI WHY I'M MORE A LOT
BELL.
TELL AYE HERTZBERG CHAU NIELSEN
WIENER.
WHEN I?
THREE ENJOYS A THREE ZERO VOTE
FOR AND KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
[inaudible]
RIGHT
.
I DON'T HAVE.
ALRIGHT LADIES IN GENERAL WE'RE
GONNA BE TAKING UP A FEW ITEMS
WILL TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER NINE
WE'RE JUST GOING TO ADD.
SENATORS ON ITEM NUMBER.
NINE ITEM.
THIRTEEN ITEM.
EIGHTEEN ITEM TWENTY ONE IN ITEM.
TWENTY SIX ALL RIGHT TO LET'S
START WITH ITEM NUMBER NINE SB
TWO FORTY ONE THIS MOTION IS DO
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
MISSILE INTEREST.
HERTZBERG CARLO NELSON WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN NOW MOVING ON
TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB.
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN THIS IS A
MOTION TO DO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MISLAID CHESTER.
WIRE HI WHY I'M MORE LONG.
HERTZBERG HELLO NIELSEN. THREE
ZERO WE'RE GONNA KEEP ROLE OPEN
MEMBERS ARE NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN SB SIX NINETY
NINE THIS IS A DO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS MISSING CHESTER.
WIRE HIGH WIRE I MORE LAW
HERTZBERG.
HELLO NIELSEN.
ENJOYS A THREE ZERO VOTE WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
ADD MEMBERS ON AT A LATER TIME
RIGHT NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY ONE SB.
SEVEN SEVENTY THIS IS THE MOTION
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENTLY ENJOYS
A TWO ZERO VOTE MISSING CHESTER
WIRE HIGH WIRE I'D MORE LOCK.
NIELSEN. THREE ZERO VOTE WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN AT ON
MEMBERS FIND THE ITEM TWENTY SIX
SCA THREE THIS IS A MOTION BE
ADOPTED.
TO ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
TWO ZERO VOTE THE SAME CHESTER.
MARLA HERTZBERG HELLO NIELSEN
WIENER.
I THREE ZERO THANK YOU GENERAL
WE ARE ALL CAUGHT UP
[inaudible]
WHICH MEANS.
WE WELCOME ANY SONG OR ANYBODY
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE.
SO -- ANTON I AREA ANTON LOVE
KARAOKE -- A I IN IN IN IN TOWN
ALSO WAS ON THE WORLD
CHAMPIONSHIP.
A CONFERENCE BETWEEN CORRECT.
THE WORLD HELP SET A WORLD
RECORD.
IT'S AMAZING -- THERE'S A GOOD
NOW WOULD YOU THINK ABOUT THAT.
AS FOR THE MOTION ALL RIGHT
THERE YOU GO WE LIKE TO KEEP IT
AWKWARD HERE GOVERNS IN FINANCE
AND SO -- WE'LL BE BACK WITH YOU
AS SOON AS WE HAVE AN OFFICE
[inaudible]
LIKE WHEN [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
YEAH.
IT IS IN GENERAL NOW MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM FIFTEEN WE WELCOME
THAT.
GOOD SENATOR FIRMANDO HERE HE IS
BRINGING BACK.
HE WAS FOCUS ON LAST YEAR
GRATEFUL FOR HIS WORK ON THIS HI
THIS IS SB.
FIVE THIRTY ONE MISTER GLAZIER
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
SAME AYE ISSUE DIFFERENT
APPROACH YEAH -- AS AS ALL TALK
ABOUT IN JUST A MOMENT BUT FIRST
I WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING YOU
AT THE CHAIR IN YOUR TO YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH.
MY TEAM TO IMPROVE THIS BILL AND
I ACCEPT THE PROPOSED.
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
SB FIVE THIRTY ONE SIXTY AND
PERVERSE INCENTIVES IN OUR
CURRENT TAX CODE.
THAT HAVE LED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO GIVE AWAY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN TAX REVENUE TO PRIVATE
COMPANIES.
UNDERTHE BRADLEY BURNS UNIFORM
LOCAL SALES TAX LAW.
SALES TAX REVENUES ALLOCATED TO
THE POINT OF SALE. FOR A BRICK
AND MORTAR STORE THIS MEANS
ALLOCATING THE REVENUE TO THE
JURISDICTION THE STORE IS
LOCATED IN.
ONLINE RETAILERS HOWEVER HAVE
THE ABILITY TO CHOOSE WHERE THEY
ALLOCATE SALES TAX REVENUES.
THE THAT A WAREHOUSE AND
DISTRIBUTION CENTER WORSE EVEN A
SALES OFFICE.
THIS ALLOWS CORPORATIONS TO
DIRECT REVENUES TO A SINGLE
JURISDICTION IN THE STATE.
NOW CORPORATIONS USE THIS AS
LEVERAGE WHEN NEGOTIATING WHERE
TO LOCATE WITHIN A STATE.
WHAT RESULTS IS A RIG PROCESS IT
TO DRIVE CITIES TO ACCEPT
INCREASINGLY ONEROUS TAX SHARING
AGREEMENTS IN EXCHANGE FOR
ONLINE RETAILERS BUILDING?
A RECOLLECT RELOCATING IN THEIR
JURISDICTION.
UNDER THESE AGREEMENTS PRIVATE
COMPANIES PROFIT BOTH FROM THEIR
ONLINE SALES.
AND FROM SALES TAX REBATES OFTEN
CITIES WILL GIVE THESE COMPANIES
THESE CORPORATIONS UP TO A 100%.
OF THE SALES TAX REVENUE.
THAT'S ALLOCATED TO THEIR
JURISDICTION THEY'LL TAKE THAT
MONEY AND I'LL GIVE IT TO THOSE
CORPORATIONS AS AN INCENTIVE FOR
THEM TO COME. TO THEIR I AREA.
THESE COMPANIES BENEFIT AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE PUBLIC.
AT A TIME WHEN CITIES ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIND PUBLIC
PROGRAMS.
COMPANIES RECYCLING SIPHONING
BILLIONS IN TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO
THESE AGREEMENTS -- WHILE THESE
DEALS ARE OFTEN TOUTED FOR
CREATING JOBS AND HAVING
SUBSTANTIAL ECONOMIC BENEFITS.
GAINS ARE DOUBTFUL.
SOME OF THESE AGREEMENTS DO NOT
REQUIRE THAT THE PROMISED JOBS
OR EVEN CREATED EVEN WHEN THEY
DO.
HOWEVER.
JOBS IN THESE WAREHOUSES ARE
GRUELING LOW WAGE AND LACK
BENEFITS.
THE CITY'S NEED REAL JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WORKING
FAMILIES NOT A RACE TO THE
BOTTOM FOR THESE REASONS SB FIVE
THIRTY ONE WOULD PROHIBIT ANY
FUTURE.
SALES TAX SHARING AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
PRIVATE CORPORATIONS THAT'S
DIFFERENT THAN THE BILL LAST
YEAR WHICH WOULD HAVE ENDED.
EXISTING AGREEMENTS.
AND PLACING THAT MEASURE ON THE
BALLOT FOR THE VOTERS TO DECIDE.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD PROHIBIT ANY
FUTURE SALES TAX SHARING
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND PRIVATE
COMPANIES.
WITH ME I HAVE DâN KERIK FROM
THE LEAGUE OF CITIES.
WHO HAS AT HELP DAY AND A GREAT?
WHEN A GOOD MAN MANY WAYS ALONG
THE PROCESS OF THE OF THIS ISSUE
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS AND IS
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN DEBATING IT
FOR QUITE SOME TIME?
AND I APPRECIATE HIM BEING HERE
TO SHARE HIS THOUGHTS THANK YOU
SO MUCH SENATOR.
KERR GIVE TWO MINUTES -- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SETH
AND TAKE YOU TO THE SENATOR YOU
KNOW FOR OUR FLAG IN AN ISSUE OF
LAST YEAR AS WELL THAT IT'S A
IT'S IT IS AN EMERGING ISSUE --
AS THE AS OUR ECONOMY CHANGES
THE INTERNET PEOPLE MORE MORE
PURCHASING OVER THE INTERNET
THAT BEGINS TO CHANGE --
CONSUMER BEHAVIOR AND IN OFFICE
CO WHAT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
RALLY BURN TO STARTS AFFECTING
WHERE DOLLARS GO.
ON THE THE WHILE THE BILL WAS
INTRODUCED LAST YEAR THE LEAGUE
ACTUALLY START STARTED TALKING
ABOUT THESE ISSUES GOING ALL THE
WAY BACK TO TWENTY FIFTEEN THERE
WAS A SENSE THAT THINGS WERE
CHANGING AND TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY.
THAT WE COULD GET BEGIN TO GET
AHEAD OF IT AS AN ORGANIZATION.
AS YOU ALL KNOWS A SALES TAX
ALLOCATION RATHER BURNS VERY
IMPORTANT TO IT TO CITIES VERY
IMPORTANT REVENUE SOURCE AND
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
GET AHEAD OF THE ISSUE.
SO -- ANYWAY THIS BILL -- IN ITS
CURRENT FORM -- AS SENATOR SAYS
IT FOCUSES ON THE ISSUE OF THESE
AGREEMENTS.
A GOING FORWARD AND AND YOU KNOW
WE HISTORICALLY OF FIGHT HARD --
AS AS I'M SURE SOME OF THE
MEMBERS IN THIS BUILDING NO TO
PROTECT OUR LOCAL INDIVIDUAL --
FORTY INCLUDING THE AUTHORITY OF
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DO
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
OBVIOUSLY WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO.
THE TRICKY PART ABOUT THE IS
WHEN THERE IS AN AGREEMENT THAT
INVOLVES REBATE YOU'RE NOT
REBATE YOUR OWN MONEY WHICH IS
YOUR OWN DECISION -- IT YOUR
GREAT REBATE IN SOMEBODY ELSE'S
MONEY IN FACT A LOT OF OTHER
MAYBE SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES IT
KIND OF HAS AN EFFECTIVE
CONSOLIDATING REVENUE AND THEN
RE BETTY.
THAT'S THE TOUCHY POINT WITHIN
OUR MEMBERSHIP IS IS IS TRYING
TO DEFEND THE WIND WERE A LOCAL
AGENCY K<c.cyan> CAN HAVE THE</c>
FREEDOM TO MAKE ECONOMIC
DECISIONS WITH THEIR OWN REVENUE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THAT WOULD
TOUCH IS ANOTHER COMMUNITIES
REVENUES WERE THE SENSE.
BUT WE THINK THE BILL IS A
HELPFUL STEP A IT'S NOT THE ONLY
STEP RELATED TO THIS ISSUE IT'S
A VERY COMPLEX ISSUE THERE'S
LOTS OF OTHER OF MOVING PIECES.
AND THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE DONE
WILL BE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
BRING IT FORWARD AND WE WOULD --
CERTAINLY -- DRIVE UP THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR CARE WE NOW
WOULD LIKE THAT A WELCOME ANYONE
ELSE WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL TO PLEASE COME FOR THE
MICROPHONE.
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND
LAST AS WELL AS YOUR
ORGANIZATION WE WELCOME YOU TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD THIS TIME.
WHERE DO A LAST CALL FOR THOSE
WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT?
HEARING SEEN NINE WHEN I WOULD
LIKE TO WELCOME ANY OPPOSITION.
FAIRNESS WE'RE GONNA HAVE ONE
PRIMARY WITNESS.
AS WELL AS ONE SECONDARY WITNESS.
THAT WORKS PLEASE.
I'M GONNA HAVE BY THE TWO
WITNESSES VERY SIDE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO BE OUR
PRIMARY.
AND THEN OUR SECONDARY WITNESS
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
KICK US OFF AS OUR PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION YES HAPPY
BECAUSE ALL RIGHT SO MUCH
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE BECAUSE
GIVES YOUR FIRST AND LASTING
ORGANIZATION?
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING A
COMMITTEE TO YES ABSOLUTELY HI
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND A MEMBER -- ANTI MINETTI
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
FRESNO I RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASK.
FIVE THIRTY ONE ON IT AGAIN YES
THE SAME ISSUE -- DIFFERENT
APPROACH BUT I THINK WE ARE
STILL OVERALL OPPOSED TO
ADDRESSING THE SPECIFIC ISSUE AS
IT RELATES TO THE RETAIL
INCENTIVE AGREEMENTS.
ON UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS BILL
DOES RANDFATHER IN EXISTING
AGREEMENTS WE STILL BELIEVE THAT
ELIMINATING PRAYER ON THIS TOOL
PROSPECT OF LEE -- COMPLETELY
AFFECTS THE ECONOMIC VITALITY
DEVELOPMENT AND JOBS THAT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM THESE
AGREEMENTS.
ON THAT FOR FRESNO THESE
INCENTIVE AGREEMENTS HAVE
TRANSFORMED OUR ECONOMIC
SITUATION DRAMATICALLY AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
WE'VE HAD -- FOUR THOUSAND NEW
JOBS AS A RESULT OF THESE
DISTRIBUTION AND WAREHOUSE
CENTERS NOT TO MENTION -- BUT WE
HAVE STUDY REVENUES AS WELL THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO A SUPPORTING OUR
PUBLIC PROGRAMS AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS
WIDELY KNOWN FOR OUR AG INDUSTRY
WHICH IS LARGELY SEASONAL AND
LOW WAGE.
OUR EFFORTS TO DIVERSIFY THE
COMMUNITY -- AND DIVERSIFY OUR
ECONOMY LOCALLY IS WHAT HELPS
SPARK THAT COMPETITION WHAT
HELPS RAISE WAGES IN OUR REGION
AND THAT'S A RIPPLE EFFECT THAT
BENEFITS THE FRESNO ECONOMY AND
OUR RESIDENTS IN GENERAL -- WE
ARE A MEMBER OF THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES AND HAVE PARTICIPATED IN
THE WORK GROUP THAT DEVELOPED
THE POLICY THAT FOR YOU TODAY WE
VOICE OUR CONCERNS THROUGHOUT
THAT PROCESS AND IT IS
UNFORTUNATE THE LEAGUE HAS
DECIDED TO TAKE A POSITION.
ON STANDING WITH CITIES TO
BENEFIT AND SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION RATHER THAN THOSE
WHO ARE SIGNIFICANTLY HARMED.
AS OBSERVED IN THE ANALYSIS
WHICH WAS VERY WELL WRITTEN ON
IT DOES SB.
FIVE THIRTY ONE ADDRESSES A
SYMPTOM NOT A DISEASE.
YOU KNOW THE AUDITOR'S REPORT
HAD VARIOUS RECOMMENDATIONS IT
ALSO MENTIONED THE E. COMMERCE
GAP AS WELL WE HAVE A BILL THAT
SITTING BEFORE THE GOVERNOR --
THAT MANY OF YOU VOTED ON AND
SUPPORTED TO ADDRESS THE E.
COMMERCE GAP.
AND YET YOU KNOW THERE ARE OTHER
MEASURES THAT THE AUDITOR'S
REPORT HAD MENTIONED -- TO LOOK
AT TRANSPARENCY IN THESE TYPES
OF AGREEMENTS AGAIN WE'RE NOT
SURE WHY THIS IS THE FIRST STEP
THAT WE'RE TAKING IN THIS
DIRECTION WITHOUT THOROUGHLY --
STARTING THE RAMIFICATIONS WE
BELIEVE THIS ISSUE MERITS MORE
DISCUSSION AND POSSIBLY EVEN A
STUDY TO EVALUATE THE IMPACT.
I AM IT'S YOU KNOW WE THINK IT
SHOULD BE DONE IN A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE MANNER THAT
DOESN'T DEVASTATE ROLAND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES NOR
PERPETUATE WEALTH AND CALL THEM
pIN ANY QUALITY. FOR THESE
REASONS WE OPPOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
FRESNO AS WELL WE'RE GRATEFUL
YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE MA'AM WE
WELCOME YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE YOU HAVE TO MAKE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I DO WANT TO THANK YOUR
STAFF FOR HIS VERY THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS YOU SPENT QUITE A BIT
OF TIME TALKINGTO US AND WE
WERE ABLE TO RELAY SOME OF OUR
CONCERNS AND IT DOES SHOW IT WAS
A VERY.
BY -- AWFUL BALANCED ASA SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
MITCHELL WENT OVER HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF PARIS WE
ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
UNFORTUNATELY TO SB. FIVE THIRTY
ONE FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE NOT
AWARE AT THE CITY OF PARIS IS
LOCATED IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
SEVENTY ONE MILES EAST SOUTHEAST
OF LOS ANGELES AND EIGHTY MILES
NORTH OF SAN DIEGO.
IT'S MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME IS
FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT
IS AN INCREASE OF 4% UP FROM
LAST YEAR.
AND THE POVERTY RATE IN PARIS IS
TWENTY ONE POINT 2% AS COMPARED
TO OUR NATIONAL POVERTY RATE OF
TWELVE POINT 3%.
PARIS IS LONG STRUGGLE WITH COM
GENERATIONAL POVERTY FOR DECADES
AND IS ONLY NOW RECENTLY
BEGINNING.
TO A SLOW CLIMB OUT OF THAT
SITUATION AND THE PRIMARY TOOL
THAT HAS ASSISTANCE CITY OF
PARIS IT IN DOING THAT HAVE BEEN
THESE TYPE OF INCENTIVES
AGREEMENTS.
THAT ARE TARGETED BY SB.
FIVE THIRTY ONE THESE INCENTIVE
AGREEMENT HAVE ALLOWED THE CITY
OF PARIS TO PROVIDE THEIR
CITIZENS WITH CRITICAL SERVICES
SUCH AS FIRE AND POLICE.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT AND MORE
CRITICALLY THE REVENUES
GENERATED BY THESE INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO ALLOW
THE CITY TO PROVIDE A BETTER
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR ITS
RESIDENTS.
PARIS HAS AN HONEST BEGAN TO
CREATE PARKS AND REC PROGRAMS
THE NEVER EXISTED BEFORE.
IN FACT THE CITY OF PARIS HAS
BEEN RECOGNIZED BY THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND REC FOR
THEIR EFFORTS RECEIVING AWARDS
IN THE LAST THREE YEARS.
ALL THESE BENEFITS ARE NOW
THREATENED BY SB.
FIVE THIRTY ONE WHETHER IT'S THE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATION OR NOT
THIS.
BILL DOES CREATE WINNERS AND
LOSERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE MAJORITY OF
THOSE LOSERS ARE THE STATE'S
POOR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
IF ENACTED SB FIVE THIRTY ONE
WILL LIMóN EIGHT A LEGAL AND
EFFECTIVE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
TOOL THAT IS CRITICAL FOR
COMMUNITIES LIKE PARIS IN ORDER
TO ATTRACT AND RETAIN BUSINESSES
WITHOUT PROVIDING AN ALTERNATIVE.
AS ALREADY STATED THERE IS A
BILL THAT IS CURRENTLY BEING
CONSIDERED BY THE GOVERNOR AND
WOULD ADDRESS HE COMMERCE GAPS.
I WOULD REDUCE EIGHT THE REQUEST
THAT THIS ISSUE DESERVING OF A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE DIALOGUE
ABOUT THE DEVASTATING IMPACT
THIS BILL WILL HAVE FOR RULING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
WE KINDLY ASK THAT YOU VOTE NO
ON SB FIVE THIRTY ONE TODAY AND
ALLOW THE CITIES THAT DO NOT
AGREE WITH THE LEAGUE OF CITIES
POSITION -- AND THE CITIES THAT
ARE NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THIS
BILL TO SIT DOWN WITH THE AUTHOR
AND COME TO MORE EQUITABLE
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MA'AM OF
REGRET FOR YOUR HERE.
IT IS AN CHEN HERE THE COMMITTEE
WE NOW WOULD LIKETO WELCOME
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FOR THE
MICROPHONE.
STATE YOUR FIRST AND LAST THE
ORGANIZATION.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED.
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE CENTER ABOUT.
IT JUST.
EXACTLY HOW MANY OF THESE.
YOUR BILL LAST YEAR WITH.
I FEEL THEM YEAH SO.
WHAT'S THE CURRENT STATUS.
I CENTER I I DON'T HAVE A AN
ACCURATE COUNT OF THAT IN FACT.
IT'S ADDITIONAL DATA THAT WOULD
LIKE TO GET AND PART OF THE
REASON WHY WE'RENOT GOING TO
THE BILL WE HAD LAST YEAR.
IS THAT WE DO LACKS SOME DATA ON
WINNERS AND LOSERS AND WE FAST.
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND OTHERS
TO HELP US ASSESS THAT WHAT WE
DO NOW.
I AND THIS IS A DOCUMENT THAT --
RESEARCH THAT THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES.
I IS THAT THAT ONE OF THE
CONCLUSIONS WAS THAT A BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
THAT SHOULD BE GOING TO PUBLIC
ENTITIES ARE CITIES [inaudible]
OUR OUR IS THE AMOUNT OF REBATE
THAT'S GOING TO THE COMPANIES.
WERE TAKING A BILLION DOLLARS A
THAT DOESN'T ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT HOW MANY CITIES
ARE DOING IT RIGHT HOW MANY
AGREEMENTS.
BUT THAT'S A CUMULATIVE NUMBER
THAT CAME OUT OF THEIR RESEARCH
SO.
FAR AS I CAN GO.
SO IS THERE ANY ONE BIG ONE OR
ARE STILL.
I KNOW THAT BLOOMBERG NEWS IS
STARTING A SERIES TODAY THAT'S
LOOKING AT THAT I DON'T KNOW I
HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO READ IT
BECAUSE OF ALL THE I DON'T KNOW
IF THEY IDENTIFIED IN THEIR
STORY.
I CAN GET BACK TO YOU AS BEST I
CAN IN TERMS OF LIKE AMAZON.
THERE ARE THERE'S BEEN A SPAM
SPATTERING OF STORIES CERTAINLY
FRESNO CAME UP IS -- AS A
SIGNIFICANT AGREEMENT THAT WAS
WAS WAGED.
I WOULD NOTE THAT.
THIS MEASURE BEFORE YOU DOESN'T
AFFECT ANY OF THOSE EXISTING
AGREEMENTS.
OKAY YEAH NONE OF THEM ARE
AFFECTED IT WOULD ONLY BE A
FUTURE AGREEMENT.
GOING FORWARD THAT THIS BILL
WOULD AFFECT.
SO LIKE THESE AGREEMENTS ARE.
TAKE A BUSINESS OR AN AREA.
SO LET'S SAY YEAR THE CITY OF
WELL.
WELL THERE IS ONE THERE IS A D.
A. L..
OKAY WELL LET ME SALES WILL
MARYLAND OKAY IT IS THE CITY OF
JIM AND JIM I YOU WANT TO LOCATE
A WAREHOUSE FROM MY COMPANY IN
YOUR IN YOUR AREA OKAY.
SO YOU COME TO ME AND YOU SAY
STEVE.
WOULD YOU LOCATE YOUR COMPANY IN
MY AREA -- I MIGHT COME TO YOU
AND SAY JIM I I HAVE ON A BILL
TO WAREHOUSE.
SALE CENTER FOR MY INTERNET
COMPANY OMINOUS YOU KNOW WHEN OF
TWO HUNDRED PERMANENT JOBS IN
YOUR AREA.
IF I LOCATED IN YOUR PLACE IN
YOUR CITY I YOU'RE GONNA GET OUR
ESTá IS YOU'RE GONNA MAKE.
A MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS
BRADLEY BURNS THE REBATE BECAUSE
AND GO TO YOU NOW.
IF WE GET A WE CAN USE AND I SAY
LISTEN.
IF WE COME TO YOUR PLACE HELLO
ALL ASK IS THAT YOU READ
REIMBURSE US. 80% OF THAT YOU'RE
GONNA GET 20% WITHOUT DOING
ANYTHING EXCEPT TO PROVE IN OUR
WAREHOUSE IN YOUR CITY.
THAT'S THAT'S THE TYPICAL
AGREEMENT OKAY.
AND THAT'S THAT'S WHAT'S IN
PLACE TODAY.
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE 20%.
I'M GONNA GET 80% OF THAT IN MY
COMPANY AND A 100% OF THAT MONEY
WOULD HAVE NORMALLY GONE TO THE
CITIES AROUND THE STATE WHERE
THAT SALES MIGHT HAVE A SO THE
OF THEY ALSO MIX OTHER TAXES
WHAT.
THOSE ARE ALL PARTS OF DIFFERENT
DEALS AGAIN I DIDN'T GET.
I'M ONLY DEALING WITH THIS
BRADLEY BURNS BECAUSE IT'S A
IT'S A IT'S A MOBILE APP YOU
WILL UNDER CURRENT DEFINITION
IT'S A MOBILE TAXES THE WHERE
YOU SS THAT SALES WE DETERMINE
THAT SALES.
THAT INTERNET SALES THAT YOU
MAKE FROM YOUR PLACE IN SAN JOSE
IF THAT DISTRIBUTION CENTER THAT
WE LOCATE IN THE CITY OF JEMBER
BELL.
ARE NOW INSTEAD OF GOING TO SAN
JOSE TRUCKS THE COMMON
DELIBERATE NOW THAT BRADLEY
BURNS IS GOING TO THAT AT OTHERS.
OKAY EVEN THOUGH YOU ORDERED ON
THE INTERNET IN YOUR LOCAL AREA
STATE OF GOING YOUR BRICK AND
MORTAR THAT WOULD HAVE AFTER
THAT AUTOMATICALLY GONE YOUR
CITY.
THAT MIGHT AS I'VE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SENATOR AT
TO RAISE YOUR I WANNA HAVE YOU
FOCUS ON THE CHANGE.
FROM LAST YEAR SO I'M GOING TO
PARAPHRASE.
YOU ARE KEEPING COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE.
RECENTLY AGREED UPON CONTRACTS
IN PLACE.
THAT'S CORRECT IN THAT DOES NOT
PRECLUDE THAT LAST YEAR.
THE PROPOSAL WAS TO ELIMINATE
ALL THESE AGREEMENTS.
I AND AND THIS IS THAT A MEMBER
I TOOK IN THE ASSEMBLY WAS
FACING THOSE CONTRACTS AS
EXISTING CONTRACTS OUT OVER TEN
YEARS.
SO WOULD HAVE PLACED ON THE
BALLOT PROPOSAL BECAUSE THE
VOTERS HAVE TO DECIDE THAT TYPE
OF A CHANGE.
AND THEN THE TEN YEAR PHASE AND
THAT'S HOW THE AS IT WAS SITTING
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE THAT'S
WHERE IT ENDED UP.
AND SO DOES HIS ME WAS IT MAYBE
WE DID THAT HERE.
I'M NT SURE BUT I THINK THAT IT
DOESN'T PRECLUDE SOMEONE ANOTHER
IT DOESN'T PRECLUDE AN ENTITY
FROM MAKING TO EXTENDING THEIR
CONTRACT NOW.
AS WELL I DON'T BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATION THREE DOZEN TO
AFFECT THAT YEAH THAT SIR THE
ONLY REASON I BRING THAT UP IS
THAT.
AGAIN WANTING TO BE A STRIKE A
COMPROMISE RIGHT OF LIGHT.
IF SOMEONE IS NEGOTIATED
CONTRACTS ON MAKING THIS UP IT'S
GIVEN 50% TO MACY'S OR 60% OLD.
RIGHT OUR OF WHATEVER THAT
REVENUES BACK AND THEY'RE ABLE
TO KEEP THE OTHER FORTY OR 50%.
THIS BILL WILL NOT INTERRUPTING
THE TERM OF THE CONTRACT WITH IT
WOULD NOT AND THAT'S WHY THE
LANGUAGE THAT WE HEARD FROM
WITNESSES THAT SAID WE WERE
GOING TO DEVASTATE OVER GOING TO
HARM.
IT'S A LITTLE HARD TO KIND OF
UNDERSTAND HOW THEY COULD SAY
WE'RE GONNA DEVASTATE WE'RE
GONNA HARM AND WE'RE NOT.
AFFECTING ANY OF THEIR EXISTING
AGREEMENTS YEAH I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THIS.
REVISED LEGISLATION IS.
I'LL CALL THAT HOLD HARMLESS AT
IF YOU HAVE A CONTRACT IN PLACE
IT STAYS IN PLACE AND DOES NOT
PRECLUDE FOR EXAMPLE THIS YEAR.
IF THE MINISTER I WANT TO BE
ABLE TO EXTEND IT ALWAYS EXTEND
NOW AS WELL I MEAN THAT'S WITHIN
THE BILL THAT THAT'S CORRECT AND
I I HOPE AND BELIEVE THAT ALL
THOSE AGREEMENTS THAT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT A POTENTIAL CHANGE IN
LAW.
SO THAT IF WE WERE TO CHANGE THE
LAW THOSE CONTRACTS COULD BE
VOID I I I BELIEVE THAT MANY THE
MERIT THAT WAY SO THAT.
THE CITY'S WOULD NOT BE HARMED
BY THAT THAT MORNING OF THE
CONTRACT BUT THAT WAS UNDER THE
OLD BILL LAST YEAR.
THIS YEAR IT'S NOT AS YOU'VE
EXPLAINED.
ALL RIGHT.
I WANT TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OR IF WE HAVE A MOTION TO BE
ABLE.
TO MOVE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN SB.
FIVE THIRTY ONE WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR BASS IN A GLAZER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
CLOSE TO SAY THAT THERE'S AN
ASSERTION THAT SOMEHOW WE'RE
HURTING POOR COMMUNITIES I'D
ARGUE THAT WERE ACTUALLY
STEALING FROM FOR COMMUNITIES.
RIGHT NOW THAT DESERVE THAT
SALES TAX MONEY. TO PAY FOR
LOCAL SERVICES FOR STEALING FROM
THOSE POOR COMMUNITIES AND IT'S
GOING TO THE BIGGEST COMPANIES
IN THE WORLD.
THERE ARE MANIPULATING OUR TAX
CODE I'M TAKING ADVANTAGE OF OUR
RULES ARE THE BENEFIT A FEW
CITIES.
BUT REALLY HURTING EVERYBODY
ELSE AND WE NEED TO STRAIGHTEN
THAT OUT IN THE LONG RUN IN THE
SHORT RUN.
WE DON'T WANT TO MAKE IT WORSE
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT BILL THAT TO MOVE
ALONG AND APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER GLAZER THIS IS A DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FOR
MOTION.
BY I SENATOR ABOUT MISS LANE
CHESTER BROKE UP PLEASE CHOIR.
CHOIR HAD MORE LOCKE L..
I BURKE AUTO [inaudible]
NIELSEN WIENER [inaudible]
I CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ZERO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLE
OF WE ARE ON THE HUNT NOW FOR
EITHER SENATOR RUBIO. FOR
SENATOR ALLEN.
I DO WE JUST HAD CENTER RUBIO IN
THE ROOM.
WE'RE GONNA LOOK TO CENTER
ALLEN'S TEAM.
WE'LL SEE IF WE HAVE.
WHAT -- JUST CHECKING TO SEE IF
WE HAVE BY. EIGHTY EYES ON
SENATOR ALLEN.
ALL RIGHT HERE WE GO.
LOW PRESSURE RELIEF OKAY
[inaudible]
GOING
.
I'VE NEVER BEEN SO WELCOME TO
THE GOVERNMENT TO FINANCE
COMMITTEE IS A YOUNG MAN --
GENERALITIES MANY OF THE BLESSED
US WITH HIS APPEARANCE OUTSIDE
TODAY.
WELL WE'VE BEEN.
IN A RIP ROARING COMMITTEE ON
THE U. Q. AND I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
HAVING SIMILAR IN THE DREAM
LIVING I SUPPOSE WE ARE.
THERE'S A GENTLEMAN THERE WE HAD
THE SENATOR HILL SHOW EARLIER
THIS AFTERNOON WE ARE NOW ABOUT
TO PRESENT THE SENATOR ALLEN-CHAU -- WE HAVE NOT TWO THREE WE
HAVE FOR SENATOR ALLEN BILLS AND
THEY ARE ALL GOOD ONES SO WHAT
WE HAVE -- ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
FORTY THREE WHICH WILL START
WITH IF THAT WORKS FOR YOU
CENTER OF ENTICING I APPRECIATE
THAT.
HEY THERE WE GO WE THEN HAVE THE
ITEM NUMBER FOR SB FORTY FIVE
WHICH WILL BE READING OUT AND
THEN IS TO BE TAKEN INTO THE
NEXT COMMITTEE IN HAPPY TO HAVE
A CONVERSATION WITH YOU.
SIR ON THAT.
WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB ONE
THIRTY NINE I AND THEN WE ALSO
HAVE ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN SB.
SEVEN THIRTY TWO OKAY SO --
CERRONE JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK ON EACH
OF THESE BILLS WE'RE GONNA KICK
OFF IF IT WORKS FOR YOU ON ITEM
NUMBER THREE THAT'S RIGHT ALL
RIGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE IT SO LET ME WE START
BY A COURSE THINKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND ALSO
ACCEPTING THE THE OUT THE
AMENDMENTS OUT THE AMENDMENT
OUTLINED IN THIS ANALYSIS.
I AND I CERTAINLY DO APPRECIATE
THE QUESTIONS RAISED BY THE
HOUSES WHICH IS WHY YOU KNOW THE
BILL MULTIPLE CALLS FOR STUDY.
TENS ALL THESE QUESTIONS THIS IS
A STUDY BALLOTS NOTHING MORE I
MADE VERY FIRM COMMITMENTS I'M
NOT GONNA TRY TO EXPAND IT --
THIS IS A STUDY BILL THIS IS
THAT'S THAT'S WELL THIS BILL IS.
I'M SO YOU KNOW EVERYONE RELAX.
SB.
FORTY THREE DOES IT WHAT IT DOES
TO YOU WHAT IT DOES DO IS
REQUIRE OUR AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND
FEE ADMINISTRATION.
IN CONSULTATION WITH OTHER
AGENCIES. TO CONDUCT A STUDY
EVALUATING -- SALES AND USE TAX
AND REPLACE IT WITH A REVENUE
NEUTRAL CARBON TAXES THAT WOULD
NOT BE A NET.
TAX INCREASE ON THE POPULATION
BUT WHAT IT WOULD DO IS BETTER
ALIGN.
POTENTIALLY BETTER.
OUR OUR TAXATION SYSTEM TO MEET
THE CARBON.
GOALS THAT WE HAVE IN THE AND
AND AND REFLECT THE B. S. THE
ISSUES THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS WITH REGARDS TO OUR OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS.
GOALS IN OUR POLLUTION GOALS IN
OUR OUR OUR CLIMATE GOALS
[inaudible]
SO.
YOU KNOW WE ALL KNOW THAT OUR
OUR CURRENT CABINETRY SYSTEM IS
PLAYING AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
REDUCING EMISSIONS -- BUT IT IS.
A RELATIVELY SMALL AND BY
IMPLEMENTING A REVENUE NEUTRAL
PRICING MECHANISM BASED ON THE
CARBON FOOTPRINT.
OF THE PRODUCTS SOLD AND
CONSUMED IN THE STATE A DIRECT
FINANCIAL BENEFIT IS OFFERED TO
THOSE WHO CHOOSE THE BY PRODUCTS
OF LOW EMISSIONS LOW CARBON
INTENSITY.
I THEN I THOSE WHO CHOOSE --
OTHERWISE WOULD BE ASKED TO PAY
FOR THE IMPACTS.
IN ADDITION A REVENUE NEUTRAL
CARBON TAX WOULD.
FURTHER THE ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS
SET BY THE STATE AS I MENTIONED --
YOU KNOW WE WE KNOW THAT.
DID WITH CIGARETTES FOR EXAMPLE
THEY'VE THEIR TAX IN NEARLY
THREE DOLLARS THAT'S REDUCE
SMOKING RATES SIGNIFICANTLY BUT
THOSE PEOPLE WHO BUT IMPORTANT
HERE BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
REVENUE NEUTRAL.
ITEM THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PURCHASING.
LOW INTENSITY -- ITEMS OUT OF BE
ABLE TO PAY LESS.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE SO.
NOW THEY SAY IT'S A STUDY BILL.
AND I SERIOUSLY MEAN IT WHEN I
SAY THAT IF CARP COMES BACK TO
US IN TAX AND FEE AND THEY SAY
LOOK LOVE THE IDEA.
BUT IT'S JUST TOO ON FEASIBLE
HERE HERE THE REASONS WHY -- YOU
KNOW EVEN THOUGH IT'S A GREAT
IDEA CONCEPTUALLY IT'S JUST TOO
COMPLICATED OR TOO DIFFICULT TO
IMPLEMENT.
LET'S NOT PURSUE IT AT THE LAST
THING I WANT IS A A BEAR OF A
IMPLEMENTATION IT'S GONNA ROLL
OUT POORLY IN UPSET EVERYBODY IN
BE CONFUSING NOT.
ULTIMATELY REACH OUR GOAL SO WE
JUST WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
WE WANT THEM TO COME BACK WITH
US.
IT WAS SOME IDEAS AND THOUGHTS
AND AS THEY SAY IF THEY COME
BACK AND SAY IT'S ON FEASIBLE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO PURSUE IT --
AND SO WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
MICHELLE CERRILLOS FROM NATURE
CONSERVANCY ALSO I CHRISTINE
SHOEMAKER FROM FOSSEL.
POINT IN THEIR HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND AGAIN I AM
GRATEFUL TO THE SENATOR FOR
TAKING A PRACTICAL APPROACH OF
THIS AND TAKING A LOOK AT IT AND
THEN -- IF DANCING A DATA DRIVEN
STRATEGY AS WE MOVE FORWARD AS
WELL SO JUST WANNA I TAKE MOMENT
SAY HOW GRATEFUL WE ARE TO
CENTER ALLEN ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
THE TECH WILL TURN OVER TO TWO
WITNESSES EACH WITNESS HAS TWO
MINUTES WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE A
KICK ASSAD.
ALL RIGHT IF YOU DON'T NâNG
DISCLOSURE PERSON LAST NAME
ORGANIZATION WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE THINKS RIGHT THANK YOU --
SHALL PASS THROUGH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY AND
WE THANK SENATOR ALLEN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE -- AS YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD --
SENATE BILL -- FORTY THREE IS A
STUDY BILL THAT PRIDE THE STATE
WITH ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
THAT'LL INFORM US IN THE STATE
ON HOW OTHER MECHANISMS FOR
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GASES EVEN
FURTHER.
AND AT THIS POINT WE NEED ALL
THE INFORMATION WE CAN GET TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE MOST EFFECTIVELY.
I AND THE SHOULD INCLUDE EXAM IN
THE STATE'S HOUSING USE TAX AS A
CENTRAL MECHANISM.
LAST FALL THE INTERGOVERNMENTAL
PANEL ON CLIMATE CHANGE IF
YOU'RE REPORT AROUND THE
SPEAKING TO THE GLOBAL URGENCY
OF BECOMING CARBON NEUTRAL IF
NOT CARBON NEGATIVE BY MID
CENTURY. TO KEEP OVERALL
TEMPERATURES FROM RISING NO MORE
THAN ONE POINT FIVE DEGREES
CELSIUS I'M IN THIS REPORT FILED
ON THE HEELS OF THE GLOBAL PARIS
AGREEMENT WHERE.
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD
AGREED TO KEEP TEMPERATURES FROM
RISING MORE THAN TWO DEGREES TO
AVOID THE MOST CATASTROPHIC
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A LEADER ON
THE CLIMB AFFRONT BUT WE DO NEED
TO DO MORE.
IF YOU WANT TO DO OUR PART AND
ALSO HELP MEET.
UP THAT KIND OF COMMITMENTS THAT
WERE PLEDGED IN PARIS AND WELLS
FOLLOW THE GUIDANCE OF THE I. P..
REPORT -- WE SEE SB FORTY THREE
AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO UNDERSTAND
THE VIABILITY AND EFFECTIVENESS
OF ANOTHER TOOL. TO HELP US IN
THIS EFFORT TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA AND
POTENTIALLY OUTSIDE OF OUR
BORDERS CELEBRITY IN
CALIFORNIA'S WORK -- AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL SO WE
CAN UNDERSTAND WHETHER THE
CHANGES THE SALES AND USE TAX
CAN BE AN EFFECTIVE PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO I THINK YOUR
TESTIMONY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MA'AM THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US.
SO CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
SHOEMAKER.
I'M A RETIRED PLANT MOLECULAR
BIOLOGIST IN A BOARD MEMBER OF
PHILOSOPHY CALIFORNIA WHICH I'M
REPRESENTING TODAY.
AND ALSO FOR CALIFORNIA IS A
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION WAS
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED ONLINE
SUPPORTERS IN OUR MISSION.
OUR STATED MISSION IS TO WORK TO
AND FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR
CLIMATE DAMAGING FOSSIL FUELS
AND TO PROMOTE A JUST TRANSITION
TO A LOW CARBON ECONOMY WE FEEL
THIS BILL FITS WITH OUR MISSION.
ON THE PROBLEM WE ARE ADDRESSING
IS CLIMATE CHANGE AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY SAID IT'S AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT.
THAT REQUIRES FAST DRAWDOWN OF
FOSSIL FUEL USAGE AND WE REALLY
NEED A MULTI PRONGED APPROACH
FOR GOING TO LOWER OUR
GREENHOUSE GASES.
RAPIDLY ON THE BILL OFFERS A
UNIQUE REPOSE APPROACH AS A
CENTER EMPHASIZE THIS IS A STUDY
BILL.
BUT IT COULD LEAD IF IT WAS
ENACTED TWO ONE SOLUTION TO
LOWERING GREENHOUSE GASES.
ARE BY A CARBON INTENSITY TAX
THAT IF ENACTED COULD LOWER
GREENHOUSE GASES BY DRIVING
CHARGE OF CHANGES BY PRODUCERS
AND CONSUMERS.
AND THIS IS A REPLACEMENT IT'S
NOT A NEW TAX.
ADDITIONALLY THE STUDY WILL LEAD
TO IMPORTANT INFORMATION ON
CARBON INTENSITY OF PRODUCTS.
IN THE MARKET PLACE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY NEEDED
AND THIS WOULD BE USEFUL FOR
CONSUMERS LEGISLATORS REGULATORY
REGULATORS ETCETERA AND COULD
LEAD TO MAKING BETTER AND
SMARTER -- ENVIRONMENTAL
DECISIONS.
WE WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
INCLUDING.
AN AMENDMENT THAT RELATES TO
ECONOMIC EQUITY IN THE STUDY
THAT IS IT ADDS THAT THE STUDY.
DURING THE IMPACTS OF A REVENUE
NEUTRAL CARBON INTENSITY TAX ON
VARIOUS INCOME LEVELS AND WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
[inaudible]
JUST TRANSITION -- FINALLY WE
WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT THIS
COULD HELP FUTURE PROOF THE
ECONOMY TO PREPARE BUSINESSES.
OPERATING IN A LOW CARBON WORLD --
FINALLY WE WILL URGENT I VOTE TO
EXPLORE UNIQUE MARKET BASED
APPROACH TO LOWER GREENHOUSE
GASES.
AND ALSO GIVE NEEDED INFORMATION
ON CARBON INTENSITY OF PRODUCTS.
WE WANT TO THANK SENATOR ALLEN
FOR INTRODUCING THE BILL AND
INVITING US TO SPEAK WE THANK
YOU.
FOR LISTENING TO US THANK YOU SO
MUCH OF A GROUP OF YOUR
TESTIMONY.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE TODAY
THANK YOU SEE.
IT IS A GERMAN I WOULD LIKE TO
OPEN UP TO ALL OF YOU WE WELCOME
ANYONE WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL TO PLEASE ADVANCE AT
THIS TIME.
WE'RE GONNA ASK THAT YOU KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS THAT YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT PERSON LAST NAME
ORGANIZATION AND WE WELCOME YOU
TO COMMITTEE THANKS FOR HANGING
WITH US AND FOR YOUR PATIENCE ON
THIS LONGER.
YES OUT WILL BRING YOUR TEEN I
GATHER AND LEASE OUR HERE.
WE'RE ON BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO
THREE FIFTY OR I SHOULD SAY
THREE FIFTY SACRAMENTO AND THREE
FIFTY SAN DIEGO.
AND WE SUPPORT THE BILL WE
SUPPORT KNOWLEDGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING SO PATIENT TODAY I'M SORRY
THAT WE KEPT YOU WAITING.
I'M SARAH THESIS I'M HERE IN IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL FOR THREE
FIFTY SILICON VALLEY AND THREE
FIFTIES.
SOUTH BAY LA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HEY GOOD AFTERNOON SELECT US ON
BEHALF OF STOP WASTE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
AFTERNOON MATTHEW BAKER PLANNING
CONSERVATION LEAGUE WE'RE NOT A
RECORD YEP BUT WE'RE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE
GRATEFUL.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO DO
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHOARE IN
SUPPORT LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO
IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT NOW GOING TO TURN IT
OVER TO THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED.
WE'RE GONNA NOT WELCOME WE'RE
GONNA ASK OUR TWO WITNESSES TO
BE ABLE.
TO MAKE ROOM FOR OUR FOLKS WHO
ARE IN OPPOSITION. TO BE FAIR
AND EQUITABLE WE ARE GOING TO
ALLOW A PRIMARY WITNESS.
AND IF THERE ARE TWO SECONDARY
WITNESSES WE WOULD ALSO WELCOME
THEIR TESTIMONY AS WELL.
PRIMARY WITNESS WILL.
BE PROVIDING THE TESTIMONY AND
AGAIN.
I HAVE UP.
TO TWO ADDITION.
SECONDARY OP.
WITNESSES IN TWO MINUTES. FOR
YOURS MA'AM AND WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON KEREN MEMBERS LEAH
SOBRE THORN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
I WANNA SPUR STARTUP I THINKING
THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR
MANY MANY CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THIS BILL AND I THINK WE'RE
MOVING IN A PRODUCTIVE --
PRODUCTIVE MANNER SO WE EIGHT
OUTLINED CONCERNS WITH RESPECT
TO THE FACT THAT YES THIS IS A
STUDY BILL BUT IT IS A BIG STUDY
BILL -- IT ENCOMPASSES A LOT OF
ISSUES NOT TO MENTION JUST.
COMPLETELY REDOING OUR SALES TAX
IS A BIG ISSUE -- SO -- WE
RAISED ALSO CONCERNS ABOUT
WHETHER CARVE IS THE APPROPRIATE
AGENCY TO DO SUCH A STUDY -- AND
WE MUST ALL THESE CONCERNS TO
THE OFFERS WE HAVE A WE HAVE
PROVIDED THE AUTHOR WITH SOME
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS AND WE DO
APPRECIATE THE MOMENTS THAT WERE
TAKEN.
ON BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
AMENDMENTS THERE ARE SUGGESTED
BY THE COMMITTEE AS WELL ON THE
ADDITIONAL EVIDENCE BUT REST
SOME OF OUR REMAINING CONCERNS
FIRST OF ALL WOULD BE DEPARTMENT
OF TAX.
PERFORMING THE STUDY AND HAVING
CARP LOOK AT THE CARBON
INTENSITY PIECE -- WITH RESPECT
TO WHO IS APPROPRIATE TO ENGAGE
IN THIS COURSE YES. TO THE
EXTENT.
THE STUDY ALSO IS SO BROAD WE
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
AGENCIES ARE CONSIDERING
SPECIFIC FACTORS.
AND WE OUTLINED THAT IN OUR
AMENDMENTS -- WANNA TALK ABOUT
THE IMPACTS ON TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING PLEASE AND WAYS IN WHICH
THAT THE IF IF THIS.
IF THIS TYPE OF TAX WOULD
ENCOURAGE DIFFERENT BEHAVIOR HOW
WE'RE GOING TO MAINTAIN THE
CARBON -- THE TAX NEUTRALITY OF
THE BILL SO WE'VE OUTLINED OUR
CONCERNS TO THE AUTHORS OFFICE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK THROUGH THOSE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
NOW I WOULD LIKE TO BE A WELCOME
ME ANYONE ELSE WHO'S IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD JUST
GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND LAST NAME --
IN YOUR ORGANIZATION WE WELCOME
YOU BACK ACTUALLY MARGOT PARKS
AND HALF OF WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION.
OPPOSITION WE I THINK THE STUDY
IS IMPORTANT BUT WHAT WE'D LIKE
TO SEE IS -- IT REPRESENT FROM
THE CHAMBERS POINT A LITTLE BIT
MORE DETAIL WITH THAT SAY LOOKS
LIKE SPECIFICALLY HOW THIS
POLICY INTERACTS OUR CURRENT
CLIMATE POLICIES.
AND THINK THAT'S EXTRAORDINARILY
IMPORTANT SO WOULD ENCOURAGE AND
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS PARKS.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORTH THIS
TIME.
WE LAST CALL PROPOSITION.
NOW I WOULD LIKE TO BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE WE WANT TO
WELCOME MISTER VICE CHAIR.
I SHARE ORE LOCKED I TO
COMMITTEE HE HAS BEEN -- IN
ABOUT EIGHT DIFFERENT COMMITTEES
HERE TODAY.
SO WE WELCOME SIR LET'S SEE IF
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE CENTER ABOUT.
TERMS OF THE THE WAY YOU'RE
GOING TO STUDY THIS IS IT --
INCLUDE A DISCUSSION OF HOW IT
IMPACTS.
SOCIAL ECONOMIC GROUPS.
ABSOLUTE THAT'S SO HOW HOW WOULD
THAT TAKE PLACE.
I KNOW WE HAVE TO RESERVE YOUR
YACHT -- SO.
THE SALES TAXES REALTORS
REPRESSIVE COMPARED TO OTHER.
SO [inaudible]
RAISES -- YEAH.
YEAH IS A VERY IS OUT YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU LOOK AT TAXES YOU HAVE
TO REVIEW.
YES SAID OF THINGS TO LOOK OUT.
AND INCLUDING THAT REGRESSIVITY
AND YOU KNOW THE IMPACT ON YEAH
MAYBE THE IMPACT ON CERTAIN
AREAS OF THE ECONOMY.
GREAT QUESTION CENTER WE
ABSOLUTELY THOSE WOULD BE THINGS
HAVE BEEN LOOKED AT I YOU KNOW I
I KNOW THAT OF COURSE REMEMBER
WE'RE GETTING RID OF THE CELLS
WE WILL BE RIGHT IN THE CITY THE
STATE PORTIONS.
AND AND ON PAGE THREE OF THE
BILL RIGHT ITEM SEVENTY TALKS
ABOUT AND THE FACT THAT THEY
THEY WILL NEED.
TO EXPLORE.
AND IDENTIFY THE IMPACTS OF
REVENUE NEUTRAL CARBON TAX ON
VARIOUS INCOME LEVELS AND WAYS
TO ENSURE THAT IT IS NOT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT.
LOW INCOME CONSUMERS THAT'S AYE
LINES.
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY SO THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT AND REQUIRED PORTION
OF THIS.
AND THEN THE SALES TAX HAS AREAS --
EXEMPTIONS OTHER KINDS OF PAYING
TO NO LOOPHOLES.
IT'S KIND OF A SWISS CHEESE TAX
LIKE A LOT OF OUR TAX OR THE
HOLES IN IT NO.
ARE YOU LOOKING AT A LOT.
KIND OF TAX FOR DEPARTMENT OR
SOMETHING THAT SUGGESTED WERE
[inaudible]
ECONOMIC.
ECONOMIC ISSUES I THINK THE IDEA
WAS WOULD LIKELY BE THAT IT
WOULD BE YEAH THE IF IF IT WERE
EVER TO BE IMPLEMENTED IT WOULD
IT WOULD BE DONE.
LACE AND WE DETERMINE BY
INTENSITY BY BY CARBON INTENSITY
TO THEIR BE.
I VARYING LEVELS.
YOU KNOW ASSOCIATED WITH WITH
COMPETENCY BUT NO ALL THAT BEING
SAID [inaudible]
TAX AND IN VIEW MINISTRATION
WOULD HAVE TO SPEND A LOT OF
TIME LOOKING AT ALL THE
IMPLICATIONS IN ISSUES INCLUDING
SOCIAL ECONOMIC STATUS.
IMPACTS AND COME UP WITH A
FORMULA THAT WE DID THE BOTH IS
REFLECTIVE OF THE GOALS OF THE
THE BILL.
WHILE ALSO REFLECTING A NUMBER
OF THE OTHER FACTORS INCLUDING
FAIRNESS AND EQUITY AND MAKE
SURE THIS IS A DISPROPORTIONATE
BURDEN MORE.
AND THE LAST ONE MISTER CHAIRMAN
I THINK IN TERMS WHAT I'M.
MASSIVE SOME QUESTIONS ARE
PROBABLY WOULD APPLY TO ANY KIND
OF STUDY OF ANY -- ANOTHER GREAT
DAY AT THE STATE.
WHEN YOU DO A -- WHEN YOU LOOK
AT A TAX I THINK?
IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT HOW
MUCH IT COSTS TO MINISTER.
COMPARED SO IF YOU WANTED.
TO LOOK AT IT FROM THE
GOVERNMENT STANDPOINT.
AND THEN YOU WANT TO LOOK AT IT
FROM THE BUSINESS STANDPOINT.
COM YEAH LIKE THE SALES TAX.
THE FACT BUSINESS AND THEY HAVE
TO DO.
THAT KIND OF COLLECTION IN THE
COLLECTION PROCESS AND
ADMINISTRATION OF THE TAX.
I THINK I THINK THE THERE'S AN
ADVANTAGE TO TAXES THAT DON'T
HAVE HIGH ADMINISTRATIVE OVER
CAPSULES.
ON THE OTHER HAND WE WANT TO BE
FAIR.
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND.
THE THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS OF
THE TAXES THAT ARE THIS.
YES.
SO BOTH TURNED. TO BOOK BOTH THE
SECTION JUST AFTER THE ONE THAT
I READY ABOUT LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS SECTION EIGHT TALKS
ABOUT -- YOU KNOW.
THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO COMPLY WITH
THE NEW TAX SYSTEM IDENTIFY THE
NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND SYSTEMS FOR
COMPLIANCE.
THE OTHER THING I'LL MENTION IS
IT PAGE FOR THE HOUSE OF
GOVERNMENT TO RIGHT TO THE
GOVERNMENT.
TO I'M SO THAT WOULD ACTUALLY BE
A GOOD IDEA FOR US TO ADD INTO
THE BILL I WOULD I THINK THAT
WOULD BE A GOOD ADDITION TO THAT
I DON'T ANYMORE.
I WILL SAY I THERE'S THE THE
BOTTOM PAGE FOUR OF YOUR
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS DOES TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
THIS ISSUE IT SAYS CARBON TAXES
REGIONAL CONSIDERED A MINISTRY
USABLE AND REASONABLY SIMPLE.
FOR AGENCIES TO ENFORCE
COMPLIANCE BECAUSE SOMEBODY LIKE
90% OF GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
ARE CURRENTLY REPORTED. TO THE
USEPA SO THERE'S THERE'S ALREADY
A WELL DEVELOPED STRUCTURE FOR
COLLECTING.
A DATE ON THIS AND AND IT TALKS
ABOUT THIS ON WATER MORE THAN I
HAD ONE MORE.
YEAH PLEASE I'M LIKE COLUMBO MY
LOVE AND MORE.
YEAH.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS DID YOU
LOOK AT SALES TAX AND?
YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE NOT DWELLING
ON THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM.
RIGHT.
THIS IS JUST A SALES IS JUST
SELL STOCK OKAY.
YEAH YOU'RE NOT GETTING INTO
THAT WE FOLLOW IS QUITE A BIT
LARGER THAN THE CAP AND TRADE
YEAH YEAH.
OKAY THANKS.
THANK YOU CENTER ON A GREAT IDEA
I I WE WILL ABSOLUTELY AT AND
THE THE THE COST FOR THE PUBLIC
SECTOR THE GOVERNMENT.
TO THE PRESENTATION OF THE GREAT
IDEA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I DO HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I JUST A QUICK COMING UP FOR
CENTER ON WHICH I REALLY
APPRECIATE AND REPRESENTED THE
IS THAT ALWAYS WILLING TO BE
ABLE TO MEET AND WORK ISSUES OUT.
IN JUST ONE MOMENT TO SAY THANK
YOU SEEN AROUND.
NO MATTER HOW BIG THE ISSUE HOW
CHALLENGING ISSUE THE WILL AND
GET A SIT DOWN AND COMPROMISE --
IN VERY VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT
AND JUST WANNA -- DEEPLY
FOCUSING ON THAT AS TRYING TO BE
A TACKLE REALLY SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE. ONE MOST CHALLENGING
ISSUES ARE TIME THAT'S CLIMATE
CHANGE.
IN NOW WANTING TO BE TO GET A
DATA DRIVEN APPROACH AND DO
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS.
WITH THAT YEAH THIS IS CENTER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AND
BEFORE YOU DO DO WE HAVE A
MOTION TO BE ABLE TO PROVE.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB.
FORTY THREE THE MOTION BY
SENATOR BALCO'S INCOME IS FROM
CENTER ALLEN.
SHOULD THE QUESTIONS AND THE
DISCUSSION A GREAT DEAL
APPRECIATE THE HELP OF THE
COMMITTEE AND I WILL SAY I IN I
LISTENED CAREFULLY TO THE
COMMENTS FROM MY MY FRIEND OF
THE CHAMBER AND I REALLY DO.
FEEL THAT THIS IS STUFF WE CAN
WORK OUT AND IF IT'S A MATTER OF
YOU KNOW THAT.
KIND OF CALIBRATING THE ROLE
THAT CARP PLAYS VERSES THE
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE AYE
AYE I THINK THAT IS IT
ABSOLUTELY THAT'S A CONVERSATION
WE CAN HAVE -- SOME OF THE
LOGISTICAL CONCERNS THEY HAVE AS
WELL SO I THINK WE'RE GETTING.
WE'RE GETTING CLOSER AND CLOSER
I YOU KNOW I GET I MEAN
ULTIMATELY IT'S TAX AND FEE THEY
HAVE THE EXPERTISE.
TAXATION AND AND IT'S CARB HAS
THE EXPERTISE AND THE QUESTIONS
OF RELATING TO THE CARBON
INTENSITY SO I THINK THAT TIME.
I I I I I JUST CAN'T IMAGINE WE
WILL BUILD A WORK OUT THAT THAT
TIME THE CHALLENGE.
THEN WITHOUT A RESPECT
RESTAURANT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH JUST A QUICK
CLARIFYING QUESTIONS IN AROUND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE ABLE. TO
ADD IT IN.
THE COST OF PUBLIC SECTOR AS
WELL IN APPROPRIATIONS IS THAT
SOMETHING YOU'D YEAH I LOVE THAT
I MEAN IT'S A GREAT IDEA BY THE
WAY IT'S ON AN AMENDMENT THAT IS
IN FRONT OF US TODAY WE ONLY
HAVE.
THE ENEMY INCOMING SIX BUT THAT
IS AN ITEM THAT YOU WORK WITH
APPROPRIATIONS ON AND HAVE YOU
EVER PROVISIONS WERE THIS
COMMITTEE WERE PRESENTED BILLS
OFFICE TO JUST MAKE SURE WE WERE
CLEAR ON THE LANGUAGE THAT'S
GREAT AND I WOULD JUST SAY I'M
YOU KNOW.
I KNOW TIME WHILE I WAS HERE FOR
THE BEGINNING BUT THIS THIS THIS
LITERALLY IS A STUDY BILL I'VE
COMMITTED.
I'VE VERY CLEARLY TO EVERYBODY
INVOLVED THAT THERE'S NO PLAN TO
MAKE A CHANGE THIS BILL THE THIS
BILL WILL NOT BE CHANGED.
AND IF IT GETS OUT.
I AND YOU KNOW THIS IS THIS IS
MERELY TO GIVE THE AT THE
DIFFERENT TACK TO BE.
CARBON FEW OTHER AGENCIES THE
OPPORTUNITY STUDY THIS IDEA IF
IT TURNS OUT THAT IT'S ON
FEASIBLE.
I WRITE WHAT I AM NOR NOT PURSUE
ANYTHING FURTHER IN THIS AREA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AROUND HAS
BEEN VERY CLEAR -- WE HAVE AT
THE MOMENT IN FRONT OF US AND
THAT HAS BEEN AROUND BE WORKING
WITH SENATOR BATTLE.
ON THAT ISSUE IN REGARDS TO COST
PUBLIC SECTOR IS IS HEADS TO
PROCREATION.
THIS HAS A DO PASS AS AMENDED
HER PREPARATIONS MOTION THE
MOTION WAS BY CENTER ABOUT
MISSING JUST A REAL CONFLICT
WIRE HI WHY I'M MORE LONG.
NOBEL.
WELL I HERTZBERG.
HELLO NIELSEN WIENER.
THAT IS A TWO ONE WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN THANKS IN
GERMANY WE'RE GONNA A RECESS FOR
LESS THAN TWO MINUTES AND WE'LL
BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU
.
MASON GERMAN IF YOU CAN GIVE US
MAYBE FIVE MINUTES IS WELL WE
APOLOGIZE WILL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU
.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE ASIAN GENTLEMAN LITTLE
BIT OF A CRAZY DAY WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE -- TAKING ON ITEM
NUMBER TWO OF TWELVE BUT I
SENATOR ALLEN'S BILLS.
SB -- FORTY FIVE LOOK THIS IS.
A SAY ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
BILLS OF THE YEAR -- AND HE IN
TURN AROUND CERTAIN PUT MEAT ON
THE BONE ON ALL ISSUES OF THE
WILDFIRE DROUGHT AND FLOOD
PROTECTION BY AN ACTIVE --
TWENTY TWENTY WILL BE READING
OUT SOME AMENDMENTS THAT THE
GOOD SENATOR WILL BE TAKING.
IN APPROPRIATIONS AT THE END OF
THE DISCUSSION HERE TODAY BUT I
JUST WANNA COMPLEMENT A CENTER
ALLEN.
AND HIS WORK ON THIS ISSUE I ANY
TIME THAT.
A BOND IS MOVING FORWARD THERE
ARE A LOT OF FORCES THAT WANT A
LOT OF ITEMS.
AND THERE IS A LOT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ACROSS THE STATE A
LOT OF REALLY IMPORTANT PROJECTS
I EN CENTER ALLEN IS WILLING TO
BE A TACKLE THIS ISSUE WE'RE
VERYGRATEFUL THE FLOOR IS YOURS
ON SB.
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU MISTER
SHARON AND I HAVE IF YOU DON'T
MIND IF I PUSH BACK ON THE IDEA
THAT IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF CRAZY
DATES A LOT OF A CRAZY DAY.
AND I AND I JUST I DO WANT TO
PERSONALLY.
BOTH APOLOGIZE AND THANK THE
FOLKS WHO STUCK AROUND FOR THE
BILLS THAT I'M PRESENTING TODAY.
YOU KNOW I I I I I'M SURE ALL
YOU TO DO IS WALK AROUND THIS
BUILDING TO FEEL THE THE MADNESS
OF THE DAY BUT I'M.
HI YOU KNOW THE FACT THAT WE
THIS IS THE ONLY MEMBER HEARING
OUT IT'S NOT BECAUSE THEY'RE
TWIDDLING THEIR THUMBS Và
COMARCA REASON IS BECAUSE THERE
AND OTHER COMMITTEES AND IF IT'S
JUST A CRAZY WAY THAT WE READ
THIS ALMOST.
PLASTERED A TIME THAT CAN YEAH
SO BUT I BUT I I I I WAS BUSILY --
CHEERING THE ARRIVAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE ALL DAY TODAY WE JUST
FINALLY ADJOURNED SO.
I DO APPRECIATE RENTS
FORBEARANCE AND PATIENCE AND IN
PARTICULAR THANKS TO THOSE WHO
COME IN FROM OTHER PLACES TO TO
BE HERE.
SO.
WITH THAT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT SB FORTY FIVE
SO SO WE'VE ON WE'VE BEEN INTO
COMMITTEES SO FAR THIS IS A
TRIPLE REFERRED BILL.
AND THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT ANY
ND EVERY BILL IS ALWAYS A WORK
IN PROGRESS OF SORTS BUT BUT A
BOND OF THIS SIZE AND SCOPE.
IS ABSOLUTELY WORK IN PROGRESS I
I KNOW WE STILL HAVE A WAYS TO
GO TO FLESH OUT THE DETAILS.
BUT THE IDEA IS THAT IF PASSED
BY THE VOTERS IN THIS WOULD
BASICALLY AUTHORIZED.
OF THIS BOND ON THE BALLOT BUT
IF PASSED BY THE VOTERS THIS
WOULD FIND ON THE GROUND
PROJECTS.
DESIGNED TO HELP US PREPARE
HELPLESS PREPARE FOR THE EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS AND OTHER IMPACTS
THAT WE'RE ALREADY SEEING AS A
RESULT OF CLIMATE CHANGE
EVERYTHING FROM SEVERE WILDFIRES
CATASTROPHIC FLOODS IN MUSCLE
MUD SLIDES.
PROLONGED DROUGHTS EXTREME HEAT
AND MORE.
NOW WE KNOW THERE ENORMOUS
IMPACTS THAT -- THE THAT ARE ARE
ARE GOING TO BE METED UPON US.
I THE LA ALWAYS JUST ESTIMATED
THE POTENTIAL COST.
OF THESE IMPACTS IN THE ORDER OF
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
BILLION AND CENTURY NOTED OF ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR
REST OF PROPERTY VALUE.
RESULTING FROM JUST MODEST.
LEVEL RISE ALONE.
WE HAD A THERE'S AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGON THE NEW
ABNORMAL IN FIRE PRONE THEIR
REGIONS THAT WE WE ALL HELD
TOGETHER ROBERT SPENT IN THE
REGION.
NINE DIRECTOR ADMINISTRATOR FOR
FEMALE HE SAID THAT EVERY DOLLAR
INVESTED ACTIVITIES OF PREVENT
FIRES.
OR MITIGATE THEIR SEVERITY WE WE
WILL SERVE WE WILL SAVE SIX
DOLLARS AND RESPONSE AND YOU
KNOW ANYBODY'S PAYING ANY
ATTENTION TO THE BASICS OF THE
DEBATE OVER THE FUTURE OF
UTILITIES.
AND FUTURE ENERGY ELECTRICITY IN
THE STATE KNOWN HOW MUCH OUR
ENTIRE SYSTEM IS FINANCIALLY AT
RISK AS A RESULT.
OF WILDFIRE IMPACT.
SO THIS.
THIS.
BILL.
I SUCH A COURSE TO REDUCE THE
IMPACTS.
OF RISING GLOBAL TEMPERATURES --
AND ALL THE THINGS THAT WE KNOW
WILL BE HAPPENING ON THE GROUND
AS A RESULT MY INVESTING IN
NECESSARY MEASURES TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES.
AND OUR VITAL NATURAL RESOURCES
AND ENSURE THAT WERE ABLE TO
ADAPT TO A CHANGING CLIMATE
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGHT THE THE
THE THE SEVERITY AND THE
REPEATEDLY WITH WHICH CLIMATE
CHANGES BUT WE ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT IT IS GOING TO BE CHANGING.
IT ALREADY I CHANGING WE NEED
TO BE MORE RESILIENT SO.
I THE SB FORTY FIVE DEDICATE
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING TO PROJECTS
THAT WILL REDUCE FIRE RISK IN
YOUR COMMUNITIES.
ONCE OUR FORESTS ARE HEALTHY
ENOUGH TO WITHSTAND MORE INTENSE
WILDFIRES.
OUR WARM TEMPERATURES OF COURSE
ARE ALSO EXPECTED INCREASE THE
FREQUENCY OF BOTH LARGE SCALE
SMALL SCALE FLOODS.
I GET WE ARE INVESTING LESS THAN
HALF OF WHAT'S NEEDED TO
PROPERLY DRESSED THOSE GROWING
RISKS IT RELATES TO THE FLIGHTS
WITH THE REPAIR OF EXISTING.
LEVY AND DEFENSIVE FLOOD CONTROL
INFRASTRUCTURE ALONE COSTING
ESTIMATED. TO BE.
MORE THAN THIRTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS OF THE AREA OF
PARTICULAR INTEREST IN FEAR AND
CONCERN FOR ANYBODY WHO WORKS IN
AND AROUND THE STATE CAPITAL IN
SACRAMENTO IN A IN A FLOOD ZONE.
I ASK YOU FORTY FIVE DEDICATES
FUNDING A PROJECT THAT WILL
REDUCE THE RISK OF CATASTROPHIC
FLOOD EVENTS BY SLOWING RUNOFF
IMPROVING GROUND WATER
FILTRATION IN PROTECTING.
COASTAL COMMUNITIES FROM FROM
SEA LEVEL RISE AND OF COURSE
CALIFORNIA'S URBAN COMMUNITIES A
NOT AT RISK FOR FIRE.
NOT QUITE AS MUCH INTEREST FOR
FIRE OR FLOOD.
ARE STILL VULNERABLE TO A LOT OF
OTHER IMPACTS REALLY THE CLIMATE
CHANGE OR EXTREME HEAT EVENTS IT
CAN BE DEADLY ESPECIALLY FOR
OLDER ADULTS YOUNG CHILDREN.
PEOPLE WITH CHRONIC ILLNESS
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY AND AND SO THE BILL
ALSO DIRECTS MONEY TO HELP LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ADAPT TO RISING
TEMPERATURES BY RELEASED
REDUCING HEAT ISLAND.
A FACT IN OUR CITIES THE
GREENING PROJECTS AND CAPTION
STORM WATER TO HELP STABILIZE.
DRINKING WATER SUPPLIES AND THE
MEASURE ALSO PREFERS PROPOSES
FINES ADD TO PROTECT WETLANDS IN
WATER WAYS WATERSHEDS.
SO IT'S OUR STRONG FEELING WE
HAVE TO TAKE AGGRESSIVE
PROACTIVE APPROACHES TO
ADDRESSING THE THAT WHICH WE
KNOW IS COMING.
HI THIS BILL IS ONE STEP IN THAT
EFFORT AND I HAVE WITH ME TODAY
KIM SNYDER WHOSE.
REPRESENTS CINEMA COUNTY WATER
AGENCY AND ALSO REGARDLESS OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH WHO THAT
KICKS OFF GOOD AFTERNOON SIR
GOOD TO SEE YOU IF YOU DON'T
MIND.
YOUR COMMENTS TO TWO MINUTES WE
APPRECIATE YOU BEING A COMEDIAN
THANKS FOR HANGING WITH US ALONG
TODAY THE PROBLEM CHAIR THANK
YOU READ OUT US ON BEHALF OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION.
HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY AT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION
SERVES SEVEN HUNDRED LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE ARE A STATEWIDE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION OF BEEN
AROUND FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
WE PRIMARILY WORK ON CLIMATE
CHANGE AND SUSTAINABLE RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT ISSUES THAT'S WHY
WE'RE HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
ARE BEING OVERWHELMED BY THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE THAT'S
THE ONE COMMON ISSUE BETWEEN ALL
YOUR DISTRICTS CLIMATE CHANGE
MAY BE IMPACTING YOU DIFFERENTLY.
BUT IT'S IMPACTING ALL YOUR
LOCAL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS EQUALLY.
AND WE CANNOT KEEP UP AND DEAL
WITH ALL THE ISSUES -- BY
OURSELVES.
THAT BEING SAID WE ARE BEING
PROACTIVE LOS ANGELES HAS
PROGRAMS TO DEAL WITH COOL ROOFS
IN THE STREET PROJECTS THAT AND
IMPROVE ACCESSIBILITY AND COME.
TO HELP PEOPLE GET TO PLACES
WITHOUT ALWAYS EMBODIES THE
ANTIS.
THE BAY AREA.
HAS.
PUT FORWARD SOME OF SOME LOCAL
INVESTMENT DOLLARS THAT CAN HELP
THEM TACKLE WITH FLOOD
PROTECTION AND HABITAT
RESTORATION.
BUT WE CANNOT DO IT ALONE AND
THESE PROGRAMS AT A LOCAL LEVEL
THESE FUNDING PROGRAMS AT A
LOCAL LEVEL WELL SUPPORTIVE.
DON'T SOLVE ALL OF OUR ISSUES.
BUT WE LIKE TO DO IS BE ABLE TO
PARTNER WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE SEE SB FORTY FIVE
IS.
THAT VEHICLE THAT ALLOWS STATE
FUNDING TO BE BROUGHT TO BEAR
ALLOWS US TO LEVERAGE THOSE
DOLLARS.
AND ALLOWS IS ACTUALLY SIR
DEALING WITH SOME OF THE MASSIVE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROBLEMS AT THIS
HE'S GONNA HAVE TO DEAL WITH
BECAUSE OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS WE
ACTUALLY LIKE IN THIS BILL MORE
THAN OTHERS JUST OUR FAVORITES
IF YOU WILL THAT WE WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT TODAY.
THERE'S A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR REGIONAL CLIMATE
RESILIENCY.
THAT'S EXCITING TO US BECAUSE WE
DEFINITELY WORK WITH SOME OF THE
REGIONAL COLLABORATORS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE'RE VERY EXCITED WITH THE
MONEY IN THERE FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WE THINK THAT'S
GONNA BE VERY USEFUL TO SOME THE
CONSERVATION CORES BUT ALSO.
THE CIVIC SPARK AMERICORPS
PROGRAM THAT WE WORK WITH.
AND CLEARLY THE MONEY TO DEAL
WITH WILD FIRE RISK AND SOME OF
THE FUNDING FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES.
IS SUPER IMPORTANT.
FINALLY WE ALSO WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED.
THIS PROGRAM ALSO DEALS WITH ARE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES THIS IS
NOT JUST A PROGRAM TO HELP
COMMUNITIES OUT RURALAREAS IT'S
ALSO PROGRAM THAT REALLY HELPS
US IN OUR URBAN AREAS. FOR THOSE
REASONS WERE TO HEAR TODAY
STRONG WRIST SUPPORT -- THE TO
DEAL WITH CLIMATE CHANGE IT'S
GONNA TAKE SWIFT BOLD ACTION.
SB FORTY FIVE WEALTHIEST DO THAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU FOR TESTIMONY WE ARE
ALWAYS GRATEFUL WHEN CINEMA
WATER IS IN.
THE HOUSE -- AND PLEASE GIVE OUR
BEST TO MISTER DAVIS AS WELL AS
YOUR BOARD THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE GIVE TWO MINUTES
THANK YOU AND GRAY DAVIS WAS
HERE EARLIER AND HAD IT HAS AT
THE CINEMA SO AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK ON HIS.
THANK YOU AND JASON SO I DON'T
NEED TO GO INTO DETAILS A MISTER
CHAIR TO EXPLAIN HOUSE NO HAS
RECENTLY BEEN IMPACTED I'M
BUYING INCREASE INTENSITY AND
SEVERITY OF WILDFIRES.
BUT THOSE ARE NOT THE ONLY
IMPACTS THAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING
WE HAVE COMMUNITIES ALONG THE
RUSSIAN RIVER.
A FLOODED THE STATE IS NOW ONLY
RECOVERING FROM OUR DROUGHT.
BEATING SPENDING MONEY IN
ADVANCE TO REDUCE THE LIKELY
IMPACTS FROM CLIMATE CHANGE WILL
MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES MORE
RESILIENT.
AS A LOCAL AGENCY WE LACK THE
FUNDS TO TACKLE THISPROBLEM.
AS AGGRESSIVELY AS AS WE NEED TO
BE DOING THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ARE GOING TO WAIT FOR US.
THERE ARE THE RIDE AND WILL
LIKELY WORSEN -- WE NEED THE
STATE TO STEP IN AND SUPPORT
DOES NOT THIS GREAT STUFF
HAPPENING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
I'LL LOCAL LEVEL WHICH MCCAULEY
READ SPOKE.
TO BUT WE NEED THE STATE -- TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT -- SO MY
COMMENTS ARE BRIEF -- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I URGE OR ON THIS.
JOB THANK YOU SO MUCH THANKS FOR
BEING HERE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE
A WELCOME ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE GIVE US YOUR
FIRST AND LAST NME ALONG WITH
YOUR ORGANIZATION WE WANT TO SAY
A HEARTY THANK YOU FOR HANGING
OUT WITH THIS -- AND THIS
MARATHON SESSION.
GOOD ALMOST EVENING MA'AM THE
FOR SURE I WAS JUST GONNA SAY
GOOD EVENING -- DANIELLE LYNCH
ON BEHALF OF US.
I'M STARTING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IS SAVE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE MID PENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT AND
THE OCEAN CONSERVANCY ISLANDS OF
THANK YOU THANKS FOR HANGING.
GOING ON GOOD AFTERNOON PAUL
MASON SPECIFIC FOR US TRUST
THANK YOU FOR RUNNING SUCH A
GRACIOUS LONG.
WE HAVE A COLOSSAL CHALLENGE IN
FRONT OF US IS GOING TAKE ALL
KINDS OF DIFFERENT FUNDING
SOURCES IN EFFORTS TO DEAL WITH
OUR ADAPTATION CHALLENGES.
THIS IS HOW THE STATE CAN HELP
CATALYZE OF THOSE EFFORTS WITH
SOME.
ON SUNDAYS WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE
THANK YOU THINK IS MISSING
GARCIA.
WELCOME BACK.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN MATTHEW
BAKER OF PAYING CONSERVATION THE
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND PC -- IS
ALSO THE CALIFORNIA AFFILIATE OF
THE NATIONAL WILDLIFE FEDERATION.
YOUR STRENGTH COOL THANK YOU SO
MUCH HEY DON'T GET AFTERNOON
JAMIE GO ON BEHALF OF AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA A SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY ALL IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON.
HELLO KILLER ROBINSON ON BEHALF
OF NATURE FOR ALL FRIENDS OF THE
LA RIVER AND LA NEIGHBORHOOD
PLAN TRUST OWN SUPPORT THANKS
FOR BEING WITH US.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
TELL CROW ON BEHALF THE
MOUNTAINS RECREATION
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY SANTA
CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE
AUTHORITY -- CALIFORNIA'S
APPOINT COUNSEL ANSWER MAGNUM
SPACE DISTRICT -- AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU GOOD STUFF I LIKE
THANKS SO MUCH.
HELLO VICTORIA LOCKWOOD HERE
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA FOOD AND
FARMING NETWORK PRINCE.
BEEN BASED TRUST THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVANCY ON STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON HELLO RUNNING
RCM HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HABITAT.
PLANNING COALITION IN THIS
ENVIRONS FUND THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MARK FENCE MAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA BERMAN
FORCED COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD TO SEE.
HAS GONE.
GOOD EVENING NATALIE MAX
CALIFORNIA OUTLANDER SENATE
COUNTY IN THE NATURE OF
TECHNOLOGY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
[inaudible]
WELCOME BACK.
MR TURN MEMBER SYLVIA SOLUTION
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND STRONG.
OF THE ALSO.
COMPANY.
SUPPORT THING SHOT.
WE WOULD LIKE TO BE RECEIVED
HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT THIS
IS GOING TO BE LAST CALL FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT NOW WE'D LIKE YOU TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION.
CURRENCY NINE WITH ACTIVATOR
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. TO
BE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE MISTER VICE CHAIR.
WELL SOMEONE'S GOT TO BE ENOUGH.
COULDN'T PICK A RESTAURANT.
HEY THERE YOU KNOW.
I AM NOT GOING TO SAY ONE THING.
IN OPPOSITION WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO.
EVERYTHING IN IN THE IN THE BOND.
NOT GONNA I'M NOT GONNA
CRITICIZE.
ONE THANK IN THE BOND.
I'M ONLY A SAY.
DATA IF YOU LOOK ON PAGE FIVE OF
THE STAFF REPORT.
THE TEN LARGEST STATES WERE WERE
AT THE BOTTOM.
THE THIRD FROM THE BOTTOM
[inaudible]
END.
YOU KNOW ONE OF MY GOALS IS THE
STATE'S SENATORS IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT CALIFORNIA DOES NOT BECOME
ILLINOIS.
IN ILLINOIS IS LITERALLY AT THE
BOTTOM AND WITH MULTIPLES THAT.
THE DATA IS THERE IN THIS IN
THIS DATA SHOWS UP IN EVERY
STAFF REPORT.
BOND MEASURE [inaudible] TO THE
STATE'S UNRESTRICTED NET
POSITION CURRENTLY IS A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY EIGHT POINT.
FIVE AS OF JUNE. THIRTY TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED
THE AUDITED FINANCIAL STATEMENTS
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. FOR
THE YEAR ENDED JUNE [inaudible]
THIRTY EIGHTEEN IN ITS
[inaudible]
APRIL. TWENTY BUT WHAT IS TODAY.
FOUR TWENTY FOURTHS APRIL TWENTY
FOURTH.
HAD SAID TEN MONTHS.
AGO WE STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN IT
AND I THINK PART OF THE REASON
SENATOR ALLEN IS THAT.
ARE OUR WORST PROBABLY WAITING
FOR THE ACTUARIAL REPORT ON WHAT
OUR RETIREE MEDIC.
LAST YEAR WAS NINETY ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION AND THAT HAS TO BE
ADDED.
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT MAYBE A
STATE THAT HAS A QUARTER
TRILLION.
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT SO.
WE DON'T NEED MORE DATA WE'RE
READY.
IT WILL END IN IN BIG NUMBERS
[inaudible] THIRTY THE COST OF
THIS BOND WILL PROBABLY BE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION A YEAR
THERE'S NO WHERE IN THE STAFF
REPORT THIS IS WHAT THE ACTUAL
COSTS WILL BE.
THEY'LL COME OUT OF THE GENERAL
FUND WHICH MEANS IT'S GOING TO
PUSH SOMETHING ELSE OUT WHETHER.
YOU KNOW.
YOU CAN NAME ALL THE GREAT
PROGRAMS WERE TRYING TO DO
HELPING THE MENTALLY ILL
WHATEVER IT IS.
SOMETHING'S GONNA GET PUSHED OUT.
AND LASTLY JUST.
DOES A WORD OF CAUTION.
WE HAVE AN INVERTED YIED CURVE
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT SINCE LIKE.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR BUT UC
INDICATES A RECESSION IS COMING
AND THE INVERTED YIELD CURVE IN
THE BOND MARKET HAS BEEN RIGHT
ABOUT.
EVERY TIME FOR SIXTY YEARS SO.
I'M SAYING THAT MAYBE THE TIMING
FOR A BOND ISN'T RIGHT ALL
ALTHOUGH I DON'T HAVE ANY
DISAGREEMENT OR I DON'T WANT TO
GET INTO THE DETAILS OF THE
PROCEEDS.
I'M JUST CONCERNED FOR THE
FINANCIAL WELL BEING OF THE
STATE WHAT THAT.
COULD MEAN GOING FORWARD SO
THAT'S WHY.
I I SURE THOSE CONCERNS AND ONE
OF THANK CHAIRMAN AND AND THE
AUTHOR FOR MY BEING ABLE TO
THESE EXPRESSED MY CONCERNS NO.
ALWAYS LOVE IT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR SURVEYS CHAIR.
SURROUND YOU LIKE TO RESPOND.
WELL LOOK VERY.
I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING HE SAID.
NOW I THINK THAT THE CHALLENGE
FOR US IS.
I THAT THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS ARE.
ALSO HI.
AND THAT -- ALL YOU GOTTA DO IS
TAKE ONE LOOK AT THE DEVASTATING
IMPACT OF THE WILDFIRES.
ON OUR ECONOMY HONOR UTILITY
SYSTEM.
I ON PROPERTY VALUES ON
INSURANCE MARKETS.
ARE THERE REAL DOWNSIDES NOT
ACTING TO BUT THERE THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THIS IS A DELICATE
BALANCE.
AND I'VE ALWAYS RESPECTED YOUR
AND YOUR COMMITMENT. TO TO
FISCAL ACCOUNTABILITY AND AND I
I I I I TOTALLY EVEN REGARDLESS
OF HOW YOU VOTE TODAY I WOULD
LOVE. TO TO TALK TO YOU WORK
WITH YOU ON AND MAKING SURE THAT
THAT.
IS REALLY DOES BECOME A A GOOD
VALUE PROPOSITION THE STATE.
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY THIS IS NOT
ABOUT JUST GOING OFF AND
SPENDING.
ON STUFF THAT THE NECESSARY THIS
IS ACTUALLY GONE ABOUT GOING ON
THE SPENDING SO THAT.
WE WILL HAVE.
LESS OF A FINANCIAL IMPACT IN
VARIOUS RESPECTS IN THE FUTURE --
BUT THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
IT'S VERY APPROPRIATE FOR US TO
BE LOOKING WITH AN EAGLE EYE.
AT THESE DEBT. TO GDP DUCTED TO
PERSONAL INCOME RATIOS I THINK
THE ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE.
I AND YOU KNOW TO BE HONEST THIS
IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE.
A DISCUSSION AT THE HIGH HIGHEST
LEVELS -- WITH AND THE
LEADERSHIP.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE
LEADERS OF BOTH HOUSES TO REALLY
DETERMINE.
WHETHER THIS GETS UP TO THE
LEVEL THAT IT'S WORTH INCURRING
SOME MORE DEBT [inaudible]
I TO YOU KNOW TO TO BE ABLE TO
MEET THESE KINDS OF FUNDING
OBLIGATIONS.
WE'RE GONNA PUT TOGETHER I GUESS
HERE'S MY HERE'S MY THING THOUGH
SENATOR.
LAST YEAR THERE WAS A MEASURE ON
THE BALLOT THAT ALMOST PASSED.
I THAT WAS A KIND OF A PAY TO
PLAY [inaudible] THREE BOND.
I REALLY NO WATER.
THAT A LOT OF ORGANIZATIONS WERE
IN A VERY REAL QUANDARY AS TO
WHETHER THE SUPPORTER NOT
BECAUSE THEY WERE SOME GOOD
STUFF IN THERE NO QUESTION ABOUT
IT.
BUT ALSO -- WAS.
YOU KNOW.
HELLO TRANSACTIONAL ABOUT HOW IT
ALL CAME TOGETHER.
AND IT END UP LOSING BUT YOU
KNOW OUR WHOLE SYSTEM IS VERY
SUSCEPTIBLE.
TO MANIPULATION BY OUT.
EDU THERE'S ONE TIME THERE'S A
BOND THAT ONE GUY PUT ON THE
BALLOT OF A MEASURE JUST TO
BASICALLY FIND HIS OWN BUSINESS.
I'M SO WE WILL WE WANTED TO HEAR
WAS GONNA TAKE CHARGE OF THE
CONVERSATION.
SEVENTY ONE AND YOU HAVE COME UP
WITH A WITH A MEASURE THAT
ACTUALLY WAS LIMITED IN SIZE.
YOU KNOW I KNOW LOOKS BIG BUT
IT'S CERTAINLY SMALLER THAN.
SOME OF THE PRESSURE WE'RE
GETTING WE'RE GETTING A LOT OF
PRESSURE FROM A LOT OF PEOPLE OF
EVERYONE TURNS IN TO THE BIGGEST
CHRISTMAS.
OUR BUT ONE THAT IS LIMITED IN
SIZE AND REALLY.
FOCUSED ON VALUE FOR MONEY.
I WHILE ALSO HAVING THE PAST
POLITICAL MUSTER THAT THAT'S
KIND OF THAT THE THE DIFFICULT
BALANCE IN GETTING SOMETHING
LIKE THIS TO THE LEGISLATURE.
AND SO ON I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
SINGLE THING YOU SAID AND I
SHARE THOSE CONCERNS.
I REALLY WANNA MAKE SURE THAT IF
WE DO PUT SOMETHING ON THE
BALLOT IT'S THAT WE CAN BE PROUD
OF IT BEING A IN PERFECT BUT BUT
BUT BUT BUT YET.
STRONG AND HELPFUL AND
PRODUCTIVE WAY OF ADDRESSING
THESE LONG TERM LIABILITIES THAT
WE KNOW THE STATE IS GOING TO
FACE.
AND IF WE WERE IN A PERFECT
WORLD SENATOR ALLEN.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE THIS.
MASSIVE DEFICIT WE'D HAVE A CASH
POSITION AND WE'LL BE GIVING YOU
THE FOR A BILLION LIKE THAT SAID
TODAY THAT I KNOW IT TODAY.
AS OPPOSED TO PAYING MAYBE EIGHT
BILLION OVERALL FOR ALL THESE
PROJECT WITH THE INTEREST COSTS.
SO I'M I'M I GET I GET THE
PASSION I GUESS.
I'M JUST.
RIGHT IS THERE TO HOW WE BALANCE
IT ALL SO THAT WE DON'T LEAVE
OUR KIDS.
WITH THE YOU KNOW MASSIVE.
DAD AND AND AND WE ARE THEY'LL
BE IN YOUR FROM THE SCHOOL
INDUSTRY.
SCHOOL DISTRICT SERVES.
I MEAN THEIR BALANCE SHEETS ARE
AWFUL.
YES LEVY EL UNIFIED ON DOWN SO
I'M JUST TRYING TO SAY OKAY HOW
DO WE WHEN IT ALL COMES IN OUR
FRONT PORCH HOW DO WE DEAL WITH
IT YEAH.
THAT'S ALL I'M I'M I'M OTHERWISE
YOU'RE YOU'RE A STAR YEAH WELL
AND I AM I AM.
HEY WE ARE DOING THANK YOU THANK
YOU CENTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A VICE
CHAIR.
THIS TIME I WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE.
TO READ.
AND AMENDMENTS THAT WILL BE
TAKEN IN APPROPRIATIONS THIS IS
NOT IN FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE
TODAY -- IN I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
SANTA MONICA AS WELL AS HIS TEAM.
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS AND
IT'S UNDER SECTION.
EIGHTY THREE ONE ONE AND IT'S
GONNA GO EIGHTEEN SEE OF THE
FUNDS PROVIDED IN THIS CHAPTER
WHICH WAS THREE MILLION A SUM OF
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS SHALL BE
AVAILABLE PROJECTS.
IDENTIFIED BY THE SAM'S IS KOBE
RESTORATION THIRTY TO ADDRESS
SEALEVEL RISE PUT MANAGEMENT
WETLANDS RESTORATION.
BE OF THE FUNDS PROVIDED IN
CHAPTER THE SUM OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR PART. FIVE BY THE
CALIFORNIA COAST CONSERVANCY IN
C. OF THE FUNDS PROVIDED IN THIS
CHAPTER.
SOME OF FIFTY NINE DOLLARS
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR PROJECTS
IDENTIFIED BY THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL.
I IN THAT IS AN ITEM THAT I KNOW.
THE SENATOR HAS BEEN WORKING.
FOR A BIT.
AND APPRECIATE HIM WORKING WITH
US IS WELL.
IN SOME CONSIDERATION.
ON LANGUAGE.
RELATING TO THE VOLUNTARY
CONSOLIDATION FIRE DISTRICTS
THERE ARE SOME TO WHAT WE SAW
WITH PROP ONE REPORT -- AS WE
LOOK AT THIS NEW REALITY THAT WE
FACE I'M AT THOSE -- A BEING SEE
WOULD BE TAKEN IN APPROPRIATIONS
THEY'RE NOT IN FRONT OF THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY.
I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
AN OPPORTUNE.
SEN AROUND CLOSE TWENTY THANK
YOU TO YOU AND YOUR TEAM FOR
WORKING WITH US -- INFERTILITY
SHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I HAVETO THE ROBUST DISCUSSION
I REALLY DO.
YOU KNOW ME I I DO WANT TO WORK
WITH BOTH THE THE MAJORITY AND
MINORITY AND STAFF OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO TEND TO REALLY MAKE
THE SOMETHING WE CAN BE PROUD OF
I MEAN AT ALL TO YOUR RIGHT THIS
IS ABOUT.
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE NOT.
THAT THEY WERE LEAVING OUR
FUTURE AND OUR CHILDREN WITH A
BETTER STATE.
AND THAT I BOTH MEANS INVOLVED
AT BOTH INVOLVES.
MAKING SURE THEY WERE BEING
FISCALLY PRUDENT WHILE ALSO
ADDRESSING THE SERIES
LIABILITIES.
THAT WE WE KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
FACE AS RESULT OF OF OF CHANGING
CLIMATE.
AND SO WITHOUT I RESPECT THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER SENATOR --
AND OFFER ONE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
OF SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE A
MOTION IF WE DON'T HAVE THAT.
WE WILL WAIT.
AND I HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL MEMBER
AFTER THAT MOTION INTO ANOTHER
TIME IN JUST A BIT THIRTY ONE ON
THIS COMMITTEE.
THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE A MOTION.
ALL RIGHT.
I THOUGHT.
NO WORRIES NO WORRIES IT'S ALL
GOOD.
YEAH IT WILL IT WILL SO WE'LL
WAIT TO HAVE THE TO MAKE THAT
MOTION HERE IN JUST A BIT -- IN
VERY GRATEFUL THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE ARE MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS SB.
ONE THIRTY NINE IT'S RELATED TO
INDEPENDENT REGISTERING
COMMISSIONS WE WELCOME A
TESTIMONY. TO COME FORWARD
CENTER ALLEN.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH  REALLY
DO APPRECIATE THAT REVERSE
DISCUSSION IN AND THIS IS A
WHOLE OTHER ISSUE VERY DIFFERENT --
ONE BUT CERTAINLY ONE THAT
IMPACTS LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
IN A SUBSTANTIVE WAY AND IT'S MY
HOPE THAT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT MIGHT.
NGUYEN.
BROADER SUPPORT SO I'M FIRST AYE
AYE I WILL COMMIT TO TAKING THE
TACKLE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN
THE HOUSES AS WELL AS AS ON
DEMAND THAT REALLY REQUIRES ITS.
COUNTY SO THAT'S SEVEN FIFTY
THOUSAND OR FEWER.
NOT THAT SMALL BUT BUT CERTAINLY
SMALLER COUNTIES ESTABLISH A
COMMISSION CONTINGENT
APPROPRIATIONS.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT I I I UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERN OF THE OF THE OF THE
CHAIR -- BECAUSE IN.
A SMALL COUNTY AS FAR BUDGET AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE.
HOW YOU HAVE BEEN IMPACTED AT A
DISPROPORTIONATELY AS A RESULT
OF THIS REQUIREMENT?
AND WHAT IS A GROW BASICALLY THE
REQUIREMENT.
REQUIRES COUNTIES WITH MORE THAN.
TWO FIFTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS TO
ESTABLISH AN INDEPENDENT
DISTRICT COMMISSION.
ENSURING A MORE FAIR NONPARTISAN
SYSTEM FOR DRAWING THE LINES.
OF COUNTY SUPERVISORS ORIEL
DISTRICTS HELP FOLKS KNOW THAT
AND BEGINNING WITH THE THE PROOF
WILL OF PROP ELEVEN BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT WE'VE BEEN
DRAWN ALLIANCE BASED ON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE CITIZEN.
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION THE CRC
IT'S AN INDEPENDENT.
REGISTERED COMMISSION AND AND
WE'VE NOW.
THEY THEY'VE BEEN DRAW THE LINES
FOR THE ASSEMBLY FOR THE SENATE
FOR THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
FOR CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF OUR DISTRICT.
LINES WERE DRAWN UP BY.
THE CITIZENS OUR DISTRICT
MISSION INDEPENDENT REGISTERED
COMMISSION.
I THERE'S BEEN A SURGEON
INTERESTED IN THIS I SINCE WE
DID THIS AT THE STATE LEVEL.
AND WE PASSED BOTH SB ELEVEN
AWAIT IN JUST SIXTEEN IN SB TEN
EIGHTEEN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
BOTH MY BILLS.
THOSE BILLS AUTHORIZE ALL COUNTY
CITIES.
SCHOOL COMMUNICATIONS SPECIAL
DISTRICTS TO ESTABLISH AN
INDEPENDENT HYBRID.
OR ADVISORY RISEN COMMISSION.
THE WATER PERMISSIVE IN
JURISDICTIONS CAN CHOOSE WHETHER
TO ADOPT REDUCING COMMISSIONS.
I WHILE MANY LOCATE LOCALITIES
HAVE FAIR TRANSPARENT REGION
PROCESSES.
GERRYMANDERING HAS CONTINUED IN
SOME JURISDICTIONS.
AND DONE.
YOU KNOW.
THE IDEA HERE IS THAT YOU KNOW I
I FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE THAT
THAT THE SYSTEM IS BETTER WHEN
INCUMBENTS DON'T TRY OTHER
ONLINE AS PAINFUL AS IT IS AND
WE'RE ABOUT TO GO INTO RESTORING
PROCESS AND THAT -- THAT MOUSE
HOUSE CAN IMPACT ALL OF US A
LITTLE SCARY FOR ANYWAY.
INCUMBENT.
BUT THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT --
THIS CURRENT SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE
I JUST THINK IT'S FAIR -- IT WAS
SUCH A POLITICAL PROCESS IN A
TALK ANY THE OLD TIMERS REAR AT
THE TIME THAT WE WE USE THE
REDISTRICTING HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND AYE AYE AYE
EVERYONE WILL TELL YOU THAT IT'S
A BETTER SYSTEM NOW [inaudible]
I'M SO.
WE HAVE ALREADY PASSED PRAYER
BILLS REQUIRE LA IN SENIOR
COUNTY SUIT OPTIONS HAVE BEEN IT
REGISTRY COMMISSIONS.
AND I JUST WANT EXTEND THAT
REQUIREMENT. TO THE OTHER LARGE
COUNTIES TAKE GERRYMANDERING OUT
OF REDISTRICTING.
THE KEY THING HERE IS A BILL
REQUIRES INDEPENDENT DISHING
COMMISSION HAS PASSED OUT FULL
POWER TO DRAFTING DOT MAPS
INDEPENDENT OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
ARE THE THE BILL REQUIRES THE
COMMISSION MEMBERS TO BE
POLITICALLY INDEPENDENT. FOR THE
FIRST TIME IT PROHIBITS PARTISAN
GERRYMANDERING IN COUNTY
REDISTRICTING -- YOU KNOW IT
ALSO HAS SOME RULES ABOUT ABOUT --
TRIP TRANSPARENCIES OF THE MAPS
HAVE TO BE PUBLISHED BEFORE
ADOPTION HAVE TO BE AT LEAST
FIVE PUBLIC HEARINGS PRIOR TO
ADOPTING ANY MAPS.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT THING FOR
OUR DEMOCRACY IT'S WHY WE HAVE
SOME IMPORTANT GOOD GOVERNMENT
GROUPS NONPARTISAN GOOD
GOVERNMENT GROUPS HERE.
I IN SUPPORT CYNICAL SIDE OR
WHOSE FROM COMMON CAUSE TOROS
FROM LEE WOMEN VOTERS.
AND I LOOK FOR THEIR TESTIMONY
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO LIKE TO GO
TO KEEP HIS OFF.
ALL RIGHT BECAUSE YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES WE WALKING BACK TO
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBER.
BECAUSE I DON'T WITH CALIFORNIA
COMMON CAUSE WE'RE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR RESCUE ONE THIRTY NINE
TO ENSURE A FAIR AND INDEPENDENT
COUNTY REDUCING PROCESS.
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST COUNTIES
NOW WHEN IT COMES TO STATE AND
CONGRESSIONAL REDISTRICTING
CALIFORNIA'S DONE MORE THAN ANY
OTHER STATE.
ELIMINATE GERRYMANDERING
CALIFORNIA STATE CITIZEN
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION IS
CONSIDERED THE NATIONAL GOLD
STANDARD.
REDUCING REFORM BY MANY
ACADEMICS AND GOOD GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATIONS.
THIS BILL EXTENDS A BEST
PRACTICE OF INDEPENDENT REDUCING
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST COUNTIES.
THEIR NUMBER REASONS FAVOR
INDEPENDENT REDUCING FIRST
COMMISSIONS ARE MORE LIKELY TO
KEEP COMMUNITIES INTACT
INCLUDING DIVERSE COMMUNITIES TO
PROMOTE A MORE REPRESENTATIVE
DEMOCRACY.
SECOND COMMISSIONS CONSTRUCTION
WITH PROTECTION CENTER
COMMISSION PARTIALITY.
ARE LESS LIKELY TO DRAW LINES TO
CHIEF POLITICAL OR PARTISAN ENDS.
AND FINALLY REDUCING COMMISSIONS
ALSO TEND TO PROMOTE PUBLIC
TRUST.
SELECT FISHEL'S BROTHER ON
DISTRICTS IT CAN CREATE THE RISK
OR JUST THE PERCEPTION OF
CONFLICT OF INTEREST ELECTED
OFFICIAL MIGHT USE PROCESS.
PRIMARILY BENEFIT THEIR OWN
REELECTION.
PUTTING THE SP ONE THIRTY NINE
TEXAS.
WORKED AT THE STATE LEVEL AND
PAN REDUCING AND EXTENDS IT DOWN
TO THE LOCAL LEVEL THIS BILL
CORPORATE MONEY THE BEST IN
PRACTICE STANDARDS FOR FAIRNESS
AND TRANSPARENCY.
PROMOTED BY GOOD GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE COMMON CAUSE
AND WE JUST TO CONCLUDE WE THINK
IN A PEN REDUCING AS FOSTER IS
FIRMLY TAKEN ROOT IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING.
WITH FOR COUNTIES AS A TWENTY
TWENTY REDUCING CYCLE PERCHES WE
THINK IT'S TIME TO EXTEND THIS
IMPORTANT DEMOCRATIC PROTECTION
TOLD CALIFORNIA'S BECAUSE
COUNTIES.
THESE REASONS WE'RE TONIGHT
THANK YOU SHE WORK IN THE STORE
FOR SURE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
THANK YOU DOOR ROSALIE WHO THERE
IS A CALIFORNIA.
THE FIGHT FOR AN INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION AT THE
STATE LEVEL AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
ARE LOCAL LEAGUES ARE ARE.
VERY ENGAGED IN THE MOVEMENT TO
BRING INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSIONS TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE.
AND IN TERMS OF IMPLEMENTATION
THERE REALLY THOSE LOCAL LEAGUES
ARE REALLY IN THE TRENCHES DOING
THE WORK OF FINDING
COMMISSIONERS.
WHO REPRESENT THE DIVERSITY OF
THE COMMUNITY THAT THEY'RE THAT
THEY'RE WORKING IN?
OF IT DURING THIS MAP DRAWING
THEMSELVES SUBMITTING THAT THE
CELLS AND ALSO.
REALLY WORKING TO ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE THAT PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
ROBUST.
AND DIVERSE AND MEANINGFUL.
AND THAT THE FOLKS WERE DRAWING
THE LINES ARE REALLY LISTENING.
SO.
WHEN A LEGISLATIVE BODY DRAWS
ITS OWN LINES THERE'S ALWAYS A
TEMPTATION TO DRAW THEM IN SUCH
A WAY THAT IS GOING TO EITHER
HELP OR HURT INCUMBENTS OR
POTENTIAL NEW MEMBERS COMING ON
BOARD?
THAT'S JUST.
IT'S THE WAY IT HAPPENS WORK TO
PRESERVE -- POLITICAL CONTROL IN
ONE POLITICAL PARTY.
THESE AREN'T ABSTRACT CONCERNS
THEY ARE THEY HAVE AN ALL TOO
OFTEN SO WE BELIEVE IT'S TIME TO
TAKE THIS NEXT STEP TIME TO
ENACT BILLING SB ONE THIRTY NINE
THAT'S THE LOGICAL NEXT STEP.
VOTERS WANT TO KNOW THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ELECT TO COUNTY SUPERVISORS.
SUPERVISOR WHO REFLECTS THE
INTERESTS THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO TRUST
THAT ELECTIONS ARE CLEAN FIGHTS.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS REALLY
ABOUT WE'RE A MAJORITY MINORITY
STATE BUT THAT DIVERSITY IS
WOEFULLY UNDERREPRESENTED AMONG
OUR COUNTY SUPERVISORS SO BY
FIXING THE WAY THAT WE TO DRAW
THE LINES WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
IT ONE STEP CLOSER TO THE WAY WE
DO IT AND MANY OF OUR ELECTION.
REFORMS TO REALLY ACHIEVING A A
MORE REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE SO WE ASK
YOUR YES VOTE AS TO ONE THIRTY
NINE THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH
FOR ARE YOU WORKING FOR YOUR
TESTING TODAY END.
SHOULD BOTH YOU HANG IN WITH US
NO IT'S BEEN A LONG ONE AND KNOW
HOW THIS TO YOU ARE SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU.
THAT COULD BE RECEIVE ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE THIS WE CAN
SUPPORT THE BILL IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR FIRST LAST
NAME AN ORGANIZATION WE WALKING
I TO ANSWER.
THE AFTERNOON GOING BACK IS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE AND THE
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I EVAN MENTEN
WITH CALIFORNIA VOICES FOR
PROGRESS IN THIS IS A PRIORITY
BILL ALSO AT THE LUTHERAN OFFICE
OF PUBLIC POLICY.
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL
NETWORK AND THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT EXCEPT.
A GOOD AFTERNOON HEY MUSSER
AMERO WITH THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT.
I DON'T THINK SO MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON.
THE TERM MEMBERS ROBERT HARRIS
ON BEHALF OF THE LC I USE
CALIFORNIAN ARE SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA FAMILIES.
OR IN SUPPORT GRATEFUL THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
MORE IN COMMON THE OFFICER CALL
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT BEFORE.
HEY.
BRENT LANG ON BEHALF CALVET THE
MONEY CAMPAIGN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND I WAS DEPUTIZED TO
EXPRESS THE SUPPORT OF MI
FAMILIA PHOTO YEAH HERE TODAY I
LIKE IT THANK.
LIKE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE WHO'S IN SUPPORT.
WE'RE GOING TO A LAST CALL FOR
THOSE WHO IN SUPPORT.
NOT ASKING ANYONE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED TO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED
[inaudible]
MA'AM.
MAYBE TAKES HE READ OVER HERE WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING THE TIME
AND FOR BE PATIENT WITH US TODAY.
IF YOU DON'T MIND GIVING US YOUR
FIRST LAST NAME ORGANIZATION THE
FLOOR IS YOURS [inaudible]
YES PLEASE.
HI TRICIA WEBER I AM THE CO
CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE FOR CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLARK AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS ARE CA CEO.
WHEN CAN I AM I WANT TO START
OFF BY SAYING THAT I'M I'D LIKE
TO THINK -- AND BECAUSE SPONSORS
AND FOR ALL YOUR HELP -- AND
LISTENING TO OUR CONCERNS AND
FOR ADDRESSING SOME OF THEM IN
THE APRIL ELEVENTH AMENDMENT.
I ALSO WANT TO STATE THAT WE ARE
NOT IN OPPOSITION OF THE POLICY
OF THE BILL IT'S MORE OF THE
PROCEDURE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING.
I'M OUR MAIN CONCERNS HAVE TO DO
WITH THE ELECTION OFFICIALS.
PLACED IN THE POSITION. TO AND
OVERSEE THE PROCESS OF CREATING
THIS COMMISSION NOT NECESSARILY
PICKING THE COMMISSION BUT
PICKING THE SCREENING -- TEAM
AND THEN -- CORRECT TAKING ALL
THE APPLICATIONS AND QUALIFYING
THEM IN ORDER TO BE.
PART OF THE APPLICANT POOL.
THE TIMING OF THIS IS KIND OF
CRUDE OF A CRITICAL TO OUR
THOUGHTS BECAUSE IT'S HAPPENING
IN SEPTEMBER OCTOBER NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY THE EXACT TIME
THAT WE WILL BE RUNNING.
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
AND ALTHOUGH I KNOW IT'S TIME
OPEN AS TO WHEN WE CAN DO IT
EVEN EARLIER IN THE YEAR OF
TWENTY TWENTY IS STILL DEALING
WITH -- THE PRIMARY ELECTION THE
VOTER MAINTENANCE THAT HAPPENS
AFTER THE ELECTION AND THEN THE
PREPARATION FOR THE NOVEMBER
WHICH IS NOT JUST THE
PRESIDENTIAL BUT IT'S ALL OF THE
LOCAL.
OFFICES SCHOOLS AND STUFF SO
IT'S A HEAVY TIME FOR CANDIDATE
FINALLY -- SO THIS PUTS AN UNDUE
BURDEN ON THE OFFICE -- AND WE
WOULD PROBABLY NEED TO HIRE MORE
STAFF.
AND MAYBE MORE SPACE WHO KNOWS
TO CONDUCT THE REGULAR FUNCTIONS
OF THE ELECTION REMEMBERING THAT
NOT ALL ELECTION OFFICES ARE
SOLELY FOR ELECTIONS THERE OFTEN
COMBINED.
WITH RECORDER COUNTY CLERK AND
OTHER FUNCTIONS.
I'M.
I'M THERE'S ALSO A QUESTION THAT
WE HAVE REGARDING THE
APPLICATION PROCESS ITSELF.
ON WHEN WE ACTUALLY SCREEN IS --
AND I KNOW THAT WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE UP WE'VE EXPRESSED THIS
TO AUTHORS OFFICE.
I'M AND WE'RE GONNA WORK ON THAT
LANGUAGE AND ALSO ON THE APRIL
ELEVENTH AMENDMENT BROUGHT IN A
PARTISAN ISSUE MEANING THAT THE
COMMISSION IS.
TO BE PROPORTIONALLY
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE REGISTER
THE REGISTRATIONS ON A PARTY OR
NO PARTY -- WHICH IS KIND OF
WEIRD FOR THE ELECTIONS OFFICE.
TO NOT WE CAN CONFIRM THAT YOU
ARE REGISTERED AND HAVE BEEN FOR
FIVE YEARS BUT NOW ALL OF THIS
AND THAT BECOMES A PARTISAN
ISSUE FOR A VERY NON PARTISAN
OFFICE. TO USE AS ONE OF THE
SCREENING MECHANISMS IN ON THE
PROCESS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GONNA BE
HANGING THERE IN HIS TO A CASE
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS WHEN I
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME ANYONE
ELSE WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION.
TO CREATE YOUR FIRST MASS IN THE
ORGANIZATION WELCOME SIR OUT
MAYBE IN BETWEEN WE HAVE
CONCERNS.
AS OUR AS OUR LEAD TO POINT OUT
JEFF DEAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
WELL I WANT TO THANK THE CENTER
ALAMEDA IS A I THOUGHT.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT WERE PHILOSOPHICALLY
OPPOSED TO BUT WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS I JUST WANT OUTLINED A
COUPLE OF THEM HERE.
AND ONE IS IS THAT -- YOU KNOW
WHEN THE STATE REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION WAS CREATED IT TOOK
THE PROCESS FROM A PARTISAN BODY
TO ONE THAT WAS.
MORE EVENLY PARTISAN BUT IN THE
CASE OF KIND OF SUPERVISORS.
I WELL IT IS TAKING IT OUT OF
SELF INTERESTED HANDS IS
ACTUALLY TAKING WHAT IS
CURRENTLY A NONPARTISAN OFFICE
ALL AS YOU GUYS KNOW ALL LOCAL
OFFICES ARE NONPARTISAN.
AND PUT IT IN HANDS OF A BODY
THAT IS APPOINTED BASED ON THEIR
PARTY PREFERENCE -- AND SO
THAT'S NOT AGAIN IT'S SOMETHING
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT I THINK IT'S
I THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
WORTH.
CONSIDERING AND THE THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRES THAT THE
COMMISSION MEMBERS TO BE ARE
FORTUNATE TO THE AS THAT.
AS MS WEBER POINTED OUT TO THE
PARTY REGISTRATION OF THE COUNTY --
BUT IT ALSO DISALLOWS THE A
MAJORITY OF THE COMMISSION TO BE
MADE UP OF ANYONE PARTY AND
THERE ARE SEVERAL COUNTIES WHERE
YOU CAN'T DO BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS AND SO IN THOSE CASES
WHAT WHAT DO WE DO WITH THAT
EXTRA MEMBER.
WHO WHO DO WE GIVE IT -- TO IF
WE WE EITHER HAVE TO MAKE IT NON
PROPORTIONAL OR WE HAVE TO GIVE
A MAJORITY TO A SINGLE PART.
SO I I JUST THAT SOMETHING WORTH
CONSIDERING GETTING NOT NOT OF A
REASON TO BE OPPOSED TO
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
I WE WOULD ALSO BRING UP THE
POINT THAT WAS RAISED ABOUT THE
FLEXIBILITY IN THE APPOINTMENT
PROCESS -- THE THE THE WITH THE
CURRENT -- ALLOWANCE PERMISSION
IN STATUTE.
LOCAL AGENCIES TO HAVE AN
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION GIVES QUITE A BIT OF
FLEXIBILITY IN HOW THIS
COMMISSION MEMBERS ARE APPOINTED --
AND IT WAS UNCLEAR TO US IN THE
BILL BECAUSE THERE ARE FEW NOT
WITHSTANDING -- THAT KIND OF
COMPETE WITH EACH OTHER WHETHER
THAT FLEXIBILITY IS ALLOWED OR
NOT WHICH NOTWITHSTANDING.
ANY OTHER LAW TAKES PRECEDENT
OVER THE OTHER THE ABOUT THIRTY
SECONDS -- THAT'S PERFECT YOU'RE
HAS EXACTLY.
AND SO -- WE WOULD APPRECIATE IF
IF WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT PLEDGE
ABILITY DOES STAY HOME BECAUSE
WE LIKE FLEXIBILITY GENERALLY WE
STRETCH EVERY MORNING.
M..
AND THEN THE LAST THING OF
COURSE IS THE COST CENTER THAT'S
PARTLY -- TAKING CARE OF IN THE
AMENDMENTS -- BUT IN FACT YOU
KNOW FOUR TO FIVE COUNTIES ARE
STILL STRUGGLING TO REGAIN THEIR
PRE RECESSION DISCRETIONARY
REVENUE LEVEL INCLUDING SOME OF
THE BIGGEST -- COUNTIES IN FACT
ARE SOME OF THE BIGGEST REVENUE
LOSERS AFTER THE RECESSION SO WE
JUST.
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO THAT FACT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TO KNOW YOU'RE
GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH REALLY
QUICKLY HERE THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING THE PERSPECTIVE YOU
SEE SACK AND THANK YOU FOR THAT
SIR.
THANKS VERY SEE IF THERE IS
ANYONE ELSE WHO'S IN OPPOSITION
OR SQUISHY AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
LAST CALL.
ALL RIGHT WE'D LIKE TO HELP
BRING IT BACK OUT HERE TO
COMMITTEE WE LIKE THE FIRST TURN
OVER TO THE GOOD SENATOR TO BE
ABLE TO RESPOND TO SOME OF THE
CONCERN YEAH I KNOW I FOR SHE
THAT AM I LET ME START BY SAYING --
IT'S INTERESTING THE MOST THE
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED SO FAR
HAVE.
COME OUT OF THE PARTY PREFERENCE
ISSUE.
AS FOLKS EVEN FARMS BONO THERE
WAS NOTHING HAVING TO A PARTY
PREFERENCE WHEN WE FIRST STARTED
THIS BILL.
AND IT WOULD STILL BE MY INTENT.
I WOULD PREFER IS KEEP THE
ORIGINAL VERSION OF THE BILL IN
THAT RESPECT.
IT WAS IN A MAN THAT WAS ASKED
OF US IN ELECTIONS COMMITTEE.
NOW THAT BEING SAID.
IN MY CONVERSATION WITH THE
ELECTIONS CHAIR I THINK THERE IS
A GOOD DEGREE OF FLEXIBILITY.
I AND THAT THE COMMITTEE WOULD
BE WILLING TO WORK WITH US ON
THAT LANGUAGE.
BECAUSE I YOU KNOW I MEAN OUR
FRIENDS IN COMMON CAUSE IN
PARTICULAR.
YOU REALLY DON'T WANT TO IN
TRYING.
I EIGHTY DEGREE OF PARTISANSHIP
INTO THE LAW.
I WILL SAY TO CORRECT THERE YOU
JUST A THE RECORD.
THE RULE IS INTERESTING IT SAYS
THAT THE V. PARTY FROM TEST BE
PROPORTIONAL.
BUT NO INDIVIDUAL PARTY.
COULD HAVE A MAJORITY.
SO EVEN IN A KIND OF LIKE
ALAMEDA.
WHERE THERE'S A STRONG
DEMOCRATIC?
REGISTRATION MAJORITY.
HI THERE COULD NOT BE A
DEMOCRATIC.
ON THE REGISTRY COMMISSION.
NOW THAT WOULD YOU COULD YOU
COULD HAVE A TO THE TO SAID THAT
THAT WOULD HAVE TO THEN BE
DISTRIBUTED BASICALLY TO TO KNOW
PARTY PREFERENCE VOTES. FOR
OTHERS.
SO I'M.
SIMILARLY IN A HEAVILY
REPUBLICAN DISTRICT YOU'D HAVE
YOU KIND OF HAVE AN INTERESTING.
I MIX WITH THE IDEA IS THAT THE
BEHALF HE PROPORTIONAL BUT THE
NO. ONE TYPE BY THE REPUBLICAN
DEMOCRAT NO PARTY PREFERENCE
COULD HAVE A MAJORITY OF THE
ADDITION COMMISSION AND AND THAT
WAS ONE WAY THAT I THINK WE WE
FELT LIKE WE ARE MAINTAINING A
CERTAIN DEGREE OF FAIRNESS.
WHILE ALSO MEETING A CERTAIN
DEGREE OF OF PROPORTIONALITY SO
THAT YEAH SO THAT THERE WOULDN'T
BE MANIPULATION OF MAY I WILL
SAY IN THE OF THE DAY YOU KNOW
THE THE YOU KNOW.
THE THE THE FOLKS RUNNING THE
COUNTY ARE.
ARE -- DID YOU ANSWER TO ELECTED
BOARDS AND AND YOU KNOW BOTH ON
THE DEMOCRATIC AND REPUBLICAN
SITE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY COULDN'T.
NEITHER SIDE COULD JUST.
STUFF THE THE COMMITTEE FULL OF
FOLKS FROM THEIR POLITICAL
PERSPECTIVE SO.
I I DIDN'T LOVE THE CHANGE BUT
THE SAME TIME I ACTUALLY GET WAS
ELEGANTLY CONSTRUCTED.
IN A WAY TO ADDRESS THE COR
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED I
WILL SAY WITH REGARD SENATE
HAPPY TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
TIMELINE ISSUES.
I'M.
WE DO ACTUALLY GIVE A MORE
FLEXIBLE IN THE COUNTIES UNDER
THIS BUILDING LA WAS GIVEN UNDER
THE BILL LAST YEAR.
I AND I WILL SAY THE NOTHING
STOPS YOU FROM GETTING GOING
EARLIER I MEAN PART OF WHAT WE
WANTED TO DO THE BILL NOW.
AND GET IT DONE EARLIER RATHER
THAN LATER.
I WAS SO AS TO GIVE THE COUNTIES
IF IT WERE TO PASS WE GIVE THE
COUNTIES THE HEADS UP THEY COULD
START THE PROCESS IMMEDIATELY.
SO THAT SO AS NOT TO HAVE TO
BACK UP TO THE ELECTION SEASON
WHICH IS A WHICH IS THE WHICH
CERTAINLY A AN ISSUE I
UNDERSTAND THAT HAVING GONE BEEN
THE ELECTIONS CHAIR AND HAVING.
SPENT A LOT OF TIME I'M HERE
WITH SOME OF YOUR FOOT.
SO.
BUT THAT BEING SAID I'M HAPPY TO
WORK WITH OKAY SALE ARE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE FOLKS FROM SEIZE
ACTED TO JUST REFER.
TRY TO MAKE IT WORKABLE I MEAN
ULTIMATELY THIS IS.
IT'S ALL ABOUT MAKING WORKABLE
FOR FOLKS IN AND LET'S ALL SIT
DOWN AND TALK ABOUT HOW TO MAKE
IT REALLY WORK.
THE PEOPLE ON THE GROUND IF YOUR
BILL IS WORKING HARD TO MAKE IT.
WORK BUT THE REASON WHY WE
FOCUSED ON THE CLERKS ELECTED
OFFICIALS BECAUSE THEY REALLY
ARE THE INDEPENDENT.
RESPECTED NONPARTISAN FOLKS IN
IN THE GAME RIGHT THERE THEY'RE
NOT ELECTED OFFICIALS.
THEY'RE NOT INVOLVED IN
PARTISANSHIP.
ARE THEY ARE THEY ARE A HIGHLY
RESPECTED INDEPENDENT PLAYER.
IN OUR GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE AND
THAT'S WHY WE WANTED THEM TO BE
RUNNING POINT.
ON THE PROCESS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE SELECTION FOR THE REDUCING
COMMISSIONS BECAUSE THEY WERE
ABOVE REPROACH.
AND THEN IT'S IS THIS IS THIS IS
THE THE PUNISHMENT YOU GET FOR
BEING ABOVE REPROACH.
NO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'D LIKE TO BE TO SEE WITH THE
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS.
QUICK RESPONSE ANY ITEMS THAT
YOU'D LIKE TO BE UNDERSTAND THAT
AND WITH THAT WE TURN OVER TO
COMMITTEE.
NO.
OTHER THAN AND WE JUST LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THEM.
TO THE MILK.
AND AREA THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU.
WOULD LIKE ME TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION -- AND OR
A MOTION FROM THE COMMISSION.
WE DO HAVE SOME CONSIDERATION
ANIMOTION RIGHT.
I WILL MOVE AND I WILL DISCUSS
ALL RIGHT THERE WE GO.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS OVER THE
YEARS I JUST THINK FOR THE
RECORD IT'S IMPORTANT TO SAY YOU
KNOW I I REALLY THINK THIS IS
GREAT I MEAN THERE'S ALWAYS SOME.
ISSUES IS TRYING TO SCRUB THE
STUFF AND GETTING IT RIGHT BUT
THESE CAMINO ONE OF THE GREAT
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACED.
EVER SINCE CONGRESSMAN JERRY
CAME UP WITH THE DRAWING OF
CONGRESSIONAL LINES AND WE CAME
UP WITH THE STERN CALLED
GERRYMANDERING.
ARMED IT'S BEEN A GREAT
CHALLENGE IN ON MY OLD ROLE I I
DID THIS STUFF AND IT.
IT REALLY IS PROBLEMATIC AND
BOTTOM LINE IS COMING UP WITH
ANY PROCESS THAT INSPIRES
CONFIDENCE IN GOVERNMENT.
AND AND WE CERTAINLY ALL OF US
NOW HERE TODAY IN THIS
LEGISLATURE'S RESULT OF THIS
SIMILAR TYPE PROCESS.
AND SO YOU KNOW I I'VE FOUGHT
FOR THIS STUFF AND AGAINST MY
OWN PARTY OF THREE FOUR TIMES
AND IT WAS HARD AND AND I'M NOT
SUGGESTING.
IS EASY BUT IT SHOULD GIVE YOU A
LOTOF CREDIT FOR I THANK YOU
LOOKING FOR BE A CO AUTHOR ON
THIS THING BUT I I WANT TO MOVE
THE BILL. TO GIVE YOU A LOT OF
CREDIT FOR BECAUSE I THINK THIS
IS ONE OF THESE QUIET THINGS.
IT'S A PROCESS OF GOVERNMENT
THAT PEOPLE DON'T PAY ATTENTION
TO WHAT ARE THE THE THINGS THAT
INSPIRE CONFIDENCE THAT WE DON'T
RUN AROUND AND SAY LIKE WE SEE
IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS ALL MY
GOD SOMEBODY'S JR AMENDING THIS
GERMINATING THAT.
AND THESE PROCESSES WORK THE
LAST POINT -- SHARES THE REASON
THEY PARTICULARLY WORKERS WHICH
FROM THE LAST FIFTY YEARS.
ARMED TO THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT
CASE AFTER CASE AFTER CASE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ENGAGING.
AND I THINK REALLY SCRUBBING THE
ISSUE.
OF HOW TO DEAL WITH THE
UNDERLYING CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES
OF ALL THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
FACE WE DEAL WITH REDISTRICTING.
AND I HAVE A HIGH LEVEL OF
CONFIDENCE OF THESE PROCESSES
WORK AND CERTAINLY YOU'VE DONE
THIS THE RIGHT WAY SO AGAIN I I
DO SEE ABSOLUTELY.
A MOVE THIS AND THANK YOU FOR A
INTRODUCING AND THE PROSECUTING
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER MAJORITY LEADER
WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
THIS HAS A DO PASSES A MINIATURE
PREPARATION.
I THOUGHT -- TURNED THE LIGHT ON
THAT WOULD.
I I SAW YOU SURVEYS CHAIR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS I'M SORRY MR JR.
I'M.
MAYBE I COULD GIVE THE OPPOSITE.
CONCERNS FROM HAVING SERVED AS A
SUPERVISOR.
I COUNTY SO SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT I I SEE THAT IT LIKE YOU
THINK ABOUT.
THE FIRST IS -- YOU DID SB
ELEVEN OH EIGHT AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND I VOTED FOR THAT
BILL.
AND THAT'S PERMISSIVE RIGHT BUT
IT'S NEVER BEEN IMPLEMENTED.
YEAH SO WHAT DO YOU MEAN -- IF
IT HAD A GOOD TRACK RECORD.
WE JUST HAVE WITH OF COURSE
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE HERE FOR THE
NEXT TO EIGHTEEN YEARS WITH
EFFORT IS THE TO BE ABLE. TO TO
TO MODIFY LATER BUT I I'M A
LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT --
TWO SB TEN EIGHTEEN BUDGET LAST
YEAR I VOTED FOR THAT AS WELL
NOW WAS PERMISSIVE AS WELL SIDE.
THAT'S COMFORTABLE WITH YOUR
WITH YOUR BILL. ELEVEN AWAY DID
REDISTRICTING THE AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN YOU KNOW THEY CAME TO
MY TURN ON YOUR MIKE CENTER.
I'M SO SORRY AN INSIDER UPDATE
THE THE APPROVED IT FOR THE NEXT
ROUND.
YEAH BUT THEY HAVEN'T TRIED IT
YET YOU'RE ACTUALLY RIGHT BUT
THEY THEY'VE TAKEN INTO THE
MECHANISM FOR THEY HAVE ANY
IMPLEMENTED ABSOLUTELY SO -- SO
WHERE I'M HAVING SOME DIFFICULTY
IS THIS IS NOW REQUIRED THIS IS
NOW AN IMPOSITION YOU HAVE TO DO
IT THIS WAY.
IT'S NOT PERMISSIVE.
SO IT'S IT'S AGAIN PART OF THIS
TEAM THAT KIND OF COPS UP THIS
CROPS OF THIS YEAR.
ALLEN THIS IS LOCAL CONTROL WERE
TELLING SO MANY.
MUNICIPALITIES THIS YEAR WE'RE
GONNA FORCE LAND PLANNING OR YOU
KNOW HOUSING ARE ALL KIND OF
HEALTH NEEDS OF IDEAS ON THE
LOCALS ARE.
SO I JUST BRING THAT UP.
ANOTHER CONCERN I HAVE IS IS A
PHILOSOPHY OF NO BETTER NO WORSE
AND THEY WERE SAYING THIS IS
APPLICABLE TO ONLY COUNTIES WITH.
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND OR
MORE SO IT DOESN'T GO TO ALL
COUNTY SAMPLE NERVOUS ABOUT A
TWO TIERED.
SYSTEM THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- I
WILL SUGGEST SURE THIS THAT
THEIR POINT THAT WAS MADE TO THE
SUPERVISORS ARE NONPARTISAN.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATED BEING A
NON PARTISAN OFFICE I'M NOW IN
PARTISAN OFFICE AND IT IS.
I'D SAY IT'S A BIG DIFFERENCE
BEING OF A REPUBLICAN SENATOR
YOU KNOW THAT WITH THAT LETTER
BY MY NAME.
I NEVER HAD THAT WHEN I WAS A
SUPERVISOR OR OR COUNTY WHITE
OFFICIALS SO YOUR LETTERS
SCARLET.
YEAH.
I'M JUST SAYING IT'S A WHOLE
DIFFERENT ANIMAL SO WE ARE DOING
THIS.
TO NONPARTISAN INDIVIDUALS
THAT'S THAT'S IT'S A NEW TWIST.
AND THEN I WILL ALSO SAVE OR ON
BEHALF OF ELECTION OFFICIALS
THERE APPOINTED BY THE BOARD.
IN.
A LEASE OURS IS OUR REGION NOT
ALL OKAY WELL.
I'M I WILL SAY FOR MY COUNTY THE
RIGHT FOR VOTERS IS APPOINTED.
AND IF THERE'S JUST A SIMPLE
RULE OF DEPARTMENT HEADS AND
THAT IS COUNT.
TO THREE AND THERE IS A A
POLITICAL COMPONENT TO THE WHOLE
THING THAT I WOULD.
I WOULD WARN YOU ABOUT.
AS WELL SO THOSE ARE JUST SOME
OF MY MY THOUGHTS WERE I'M INDA
LIKE NERVOUS ABOUT ABOUT YOUR
BILLS I'M.
SURE THOSE.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
SENATOR I MEAN I I YOU KNOW LOOK
IT'S IT'S ALWAYS IN PERFECT
RIGHT WE'RE TRYING TO COME UP
WITH THE WAY [inaudible]
OF OUR SYSTEM.
I'M AYE AYE I SUPPOSE I SUPPOSE
THE IDEA IS A RIGHT WE WE WE WE
DON'T WANT.
WE IN THE SPIRIT OF LOVE CONTROL
pRIGHT YOU DON'T WANT TO JUST.
HAVE SACRAMENTO I DRAW THE LINES
THEMSELVES YOU DON'T GIVE IT TO
THE STATEWIDE COMMISSION SO WE
DID WANT TO COUNTIES TO BE
INVOLVED REALLY WHAT.
FOLKS WHO KNOW THE COUNTY OR
FROM THE COUNTY OR OF THE COUNTY
TO HELP CREATE THESE COMMISSIONS.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT THEY ARE
POINTED OR YOU KNOW THEY ARE
POLITICAL FIGURES OF SORTS BUT
WE DID FEEL AS THOUGH THEY WERE
THE MOST INDEPENDENT.
AND MOST APPROPRIATE PLACE. TO
TO TO TO DO THIS -- BUT IT'S IN
PERFECT NOW COURSE I STILL THINK
THAT'S BETTER I MEAN THEY'RE
STILL KIND OF SEVERAL DEGREES OF
SEPARATION INOCULATION.
FROM.
THE FROM THE ELECTED FOR
SUPERVISOR STATE OF COURSE AS
SUCH A SELF INTEREST ASSOCIATE
WITHDRAWN THEIR ALLIANCE.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT THERE IS A
CERTAIN DEGREE OF PARTISANSHIP
IN THIS NOW BUT ONCE AGAIN I
JUST REPEAT.
ON THE THE NO ONE PARTY CAN HAVE
A MAJORITY SO EVEN IF.
AS I SAY ALAMEDA COUNTY STRONG
DEMOCRATIC MAJORITY OF OF A
RESERVOIRS AND YET DEMOCRATS
WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED. TO HAVE
OVER 50% OF THAT I WOULD
DISTRICT COMMISSION.
SO WE HAVE TO BE FILLED IN BY
THE WAY WITH.
THE REALLY IMPORTANT GROWING
PORTION OF POPULATION WHICH IS
INDEPENDENCE.
AND SO THEY'LL HAVE A
IMPORTANCIA TABLE AND DRIVE
THESE LINE.
SO I I DO LOVE THE PARTISANSHIP
BUT I BUT AS I SAY IT WAS IT WAS
FORCED UPON US THE IN EARLIER
COMMITTEE BUT I THINK WE FOUND
AN ELEGANT WAY OF OF OF REALLY
MAKING SURE THAT.
THEY DO THEIR THEIR WINDY UNDUE
INFLUENCE OF BY ANY ONE
INDIVIDUAL PARTY.
I HAVE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
DOING REDISTRICTING AS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR AND I MET WITH HER
SPONSORS AND AND I'LL TELL YOU
IT'S A FIFTY FIFTY DEAL I TRY TO
BE AS PURE.
PERSONALLY IT'S LIKE COULD BE --
BUT I AM PUBLIC COMMENTS THAT
HAVE YOU KNOW THE DAY I WAS NOT
HAPPY.
WITH THE PROCESS I ST STE I
STOOD UP AND SAID HERE'S WHY AM
VOTING THE WAY I AM YEAH BECAUSE
I DON'T LIKE SOME OF THAT.
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WERE THAT WERE DONE SO I I I I
GET WHAT YOU'RE.
JUST WHEN IT.
THE SHARED FROM FROM THAT
RESPECT YEAH YEAH BUT WE'RE ON
THIS ON THE TWO TIER THING YOU
BROUGHT UP QUICKLY MR ONLY A
MOTHER BILLS ONLY REASON WE DID
YOU CAN ONE OF THE HOSE.
A VERY SMALL COUNTY YEAH THIS IS
IS COUNTY WITH LIKE OUTDOOR
FOURTEENER PEOPLE AT AGE OUTLINE.
YEAH IT SEEMS LIKE IT WOULD BE
REALLY INAPPROPRIATE TO YOU --
IMPOSE YOU KNOW THE COST ON THEM
BUT THE COST SYSTEMS AND LIKE
THIS.
WOULD BE A BIG DEAL FOR ALL FINE
BUT NOT A BIG DEAL.
FOR YOU KNOW FOR A WARRANT.
FOR ITEM IN TWO DIFFERENT SIZES.
NO THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG IT'S A DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTER ON WEDNESDAY TO CLOSE
REALLY FOR SHOULD DISCUSSION
ONCE AGAIN LOVE TO YOU KNOW AND
LOVE CONTINUED INPUT FROM
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE AND AND
AND LOOK FOR TO WORKING CLOSELY
WITH OUR FRIENDS FROM.
THE SECOND ALSO FROM -- TO SAY I
I THINK WE CAN GET TO A PLACE
THAT THAT WILL THAT WILL BE WILL
BE FAIR.
JUST CHAIR AND EIGHTY IS TERROR
ME TOO YEAH.
A BETTER SYSTEM THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE NOTS ULTIMATELY
ALL WE CAN ASK.
FOR IN THE SPIRIT OF THE
SERENITY PRAYER.
YES OR NO VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER ON THE CENTER'S RECALL
PLEASE WHINER HI.
I'M MORE LOT.
NOBEL.
YEAH I HEARD -- I DON'T
[inaudible]
NIELSEN.
THERE'S BEEN NO WINNER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF THAT
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR TO VOTE
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. FOR
THE FINAL TIME AIM THIS
AFTERNOON SOON TO BE THIS
EVENING.
WE ARE GOING TO BE HAVING ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN SB SEVEN THIRTY
TWO SENATOR ALLEN.
WE STILL HAVE CENTER RUBIO IS
GONNA COME INCIDENTS IN YOUR
SKIN AND SINCE HOW MY GOD YEAH.
N. S. ENERGY.
HELLO HEAD SEE [inaudible]
OKAY.
YEAH I THINK THAT'S WHERE I AM
LEADER YEAH YEAH YOU'RE FINE --
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO.
LET ME START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR ITS INCISIVE
ANALYSIS AND AND ADDED
SUGGESTION I AM.
VERY HAPPY TO ADOPT THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS. TO ASSIST
THE LOGISTICAL WORK THAT WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO BE PERFORMED
UNDER THIS BILL BY THE
DEPARTMENT TAX.
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION.
SO I THIS BILL.
ASKS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOT
YOU TORIE PERMISSION TO PLACE A
BALLOT MEASURE.
OF BEFORE THE VOTERS.
RESIDING WITHIN THE TEN THOUSAND
SEVEN FORTY THREE SQUARE MILES
AND COMPRISE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
WHICH WAS AYE NEAR BASIN THAT
COLLECTIVELY ENCOMPASSES.
THE THE LA THE GREATER LA BASIN.
THESE BOUNDARIES ARE HOME TO
ROUGHLY TWENTY MILLION RESIDENTS.
ARE THE WITH THE VERY FIRST AIR
POLLUTION CONTROLS IN THE US --
THEY WERE IMPOSE WITHIN THIS
YEAR BOTH BASIN BY THE
PREDECESSOR AGENCY TO THE
CURRENT A C<c.cyan> DE.</c>
OVER DECADES SUBSTANTIAL.
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE BUT BUT
NONE THE LESS -- YEAH.
WE WE'VE WE CONTINUE TO SEE
CHALLENGES AND YOU KNOW SOMEONE
WHO'S NOW RAISING A CHILD IN THE
SOUTH COAST IN IN IN THE LA AREA
AYE AYE AYE SIR WE REMAIN VERY
CONCERNED.
ABOUT AIR QUALITY LEVELS WE'VE
IMPROVE THEIR QUALITY LEVEL
SIGNIFICANTLY LARGELY AS A
RESULT OF ALL THE WORK THAT
EIGHTEEN D. OTHERS HAVE DONE.
ARE THERE WAS A TIME WHEN I
THINK THE AVERAGE ANGELINA WAS
WARY ABOUT HALF OF THE LUNG
CAPACITY.
I I HAVE A KID GROWING UP IN
RURAL PARTS OF THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE OF THE LEVEL THE AIR
QUALITY THANK GOD WE'VE MOVED
BEYOND THAT BUT NONETHELESS ARE
STILL CONTINUES TO BE.
ENORMOUS HEALTH IMPACTS.
ON ON OUR RESIDENTS ASTHMA
BRONCHITIS DECREASED.
ALONG GROWTH IN IN CHILDREN
CANCER CARDIOVASCULAR RISK
PREMATURE DEATH EMERGENCY ROOM
HOSPITAL VISITS.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF HEALTH
REALLY LOST WORKDAYS AND STUDENT
ABSENCE FROM SCHOOL WHAT A LOT
OF ECONOMIC COST TO DO ALL THIS
AS WELL.
I INTO THE I CAN DE RECENTLY
ADOPTED A SCIENTIFICALLY
RIGOROUS AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
PLAN.
WHICH PROPOSES TO FURTHER ITS
MISSION TO ACHIEVE AND MAINTAIN
LEGALLY MANDATED CLEANER
OBJECTIVE THROUGH ESPECIALLY
REPLACING BOTH STATIONARY AND
MOBILE SOURCES.
I CONTINUE TO POLLUTE THE AIR
BASIN WITH ZERO EMISSION NEAR
EMISSIONS.
OR THE CLEANEST COMMERCIALLY
AVAILABLE ALTERNATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES HOWEVER.
THE SUCCESS OF THIS.
THIS AMBITIOUS PLAN IS INCURRED
UPON SECURING A ROBUST MULTI
YEAR REVENUE STREAM TO FIND A
WIDE SPECTRUM OF LONG TERM
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS -- THIS BILL
PROVIDES STATURE FRAMEWORK TO
ENABLE VOTERS IN THE SOUTH COAST
FOR COUNTY DISTRICT TO CONSIDER.
A POTENTIAL SALES TAX INCREASE
SUFFICIENT IN SIZE AND SCOPE TO
CLEAN UP THE AIR IF.
THE AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT WANTS.
TO PUT OUT FOR IT.
SO I'M SO GRATEFUL AND BY THE
WAY KI<c.cyan> DE BORD IS A MIX OF</c>
FOLKS.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF BACK AND
FORTH IN TERMS THE PARTISAN
MAKEUP OF THE BOARD.
SO I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE BOARD.
I ABOVE OF BOARD MEMBERS
COALITION REGIONAL LEADERS OF
OUR MAILCHIMP MEANS WHO
SUGGESTED THAT IF THE BILL MOVES
TOWARD WEEK WE CONSIDER
EXPLICITLY INCLUDING THE
FOLLOWING BOTH PROVISIONS TO
EXPRESSLY ENABLE FUNDING. FOR
ENHANCED REDUCTIONS IN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THAT
CAUSE CLIMATE CHANGE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS MAY
INCLUDE INVESTMENTS. TO REDUCE
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
END AUTHORIZATION FOR REGIONAL
EXPENDITURES TO ELECTRIFY
MODERNIZE AND FULLY BUILT OUT
THE METROLINK.
COMMUTER RAIL SYSTEM INTO EIGHT
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION'S IN THEIR PLANS TO
IMPLEMENT.
A CLEANER TRANSIT SYSTEM.
FINALLY MY STAFF AND I HAVE HAD
NUMEROUS INDUCTORS QUESTIONS
WITH OPPONENTS AND SUPPORTERS
MANY GROUPS.
INCLUDING ORGANIZED LABOR WHO
HAVE LEGITIMATE POLICY CONCERNS
ABOUT HOW THE REVENUES OF
POTENTIAL BALLOT MEASURE WOULD
BE SPENT. TO TRANSITION TO A
CLEANER REGIONAL ECONOMY THAT
ALSO SUPPORTS A STABLE MIDDLE
CLASS.
I RECOGNIZE THE CONCERN THE TAX
DOLLARS YOUR MIND.
A LOT OF HARD WORK FOR THAT
LABOR HAS TO COLLECTIVELY
BARGAIN WITH EMPLOYERS ON BEHALF
OF THEIR MEMBERS AND SO.
THESE ISSUES CONTINUE TO BE
WORKED OUT BUT WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE WE NOT ST IS EXACTLY
DIRECTOR OF SOUTH COAST HM DIAZ
OF ANYTHING.
WHO IS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
MOVE LA?
THANK YOU SO MUCH EXACTLY RIGHT
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT YOU TRAVEL
HERE THANK YOU FOR TOLERATING
THE LENGTH OF THIS HEARING.
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TRULY AT YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES SIR. FOR SOURCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
WAYNE ASTRI ON THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
IN SPITE OF ALL THE AIR QUALITY
PROGRESS THAT SAID MADE.
IN THE SOUTH COAST BASIN WE
STILL HAVE THE WORST OZONE AIR
QUALITY IN THE NATION.
ADVERSELY IMPACTING THE HEALTH
OF OVER SEVENTEEN MILLION PEOPLE.
I TWENTY SIXTEEN AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT PLAN CALLS FOR OVER
ONE BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
AN INCENTIVE FUNDING TO
ACCELERATE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
CLEAN VEHICLES.
EQUIPMENT AND ASSOCIATED
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SB SEVEN THIRTY TWO ALLOWS THE
PEOPLE OF THE SOUTH COAST REGION
TO DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES.
WHAT THEY WANT TO INVEST IN
CLEAN AIR AND ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE?
FUNDING FOR FULL IMPLEMENTATION
OF OUR AQ MP WOULD RESULT IN
UNPRECEDENTED BENEFITS.
FIRST WE WOULD ATTAIN FEDERAL
STANDARDS FOR THE FIRST TIME AND
ELIMINATE UNHEALTHY AIR
POLLUTION IN THE SOUTH COAST
REGION.
SECOND WE WOULD MEET OUR REGION
CHAIR.
OF THE STATE'S GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS REDUCTION GOAL OF 80%
BELOW NINETEEN NINETY MISSION
LEVELS BY.
TWENTY FIFTY AND THIRD.
WE SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED TOXIC
RISK DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
BY ELIMINATING DIESEL EMISSIONS.
ACHIEVING CLEAN AIR MEANS
REDUCING SERIOUS HEALTH IMPACTS.
AS MUG BRONCHITIS PREMATURE
DEATH.
HUNDREDSOF THOUSANDS OF MISS
SCHOOL AND WORK DAYS.
ALL OF THIS REPRESENTING OVER
TEN BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN
TERMS OF HEALTH BENEFITS OVERALL.
BUT IMPORTANTLY UNDER THE
FEDERAL CLEAN AIR ACT THE SOUTH
COAST MUST ATTAIN.
THE NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN OZONE
STANDARD BY.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE DISTRICT
MUST SUBMIT MEASURES TO EPA BY.
TWENTY TWENTY THEY'RE SUFFICIENT
TO REDUCE AN ADDITIONAL EIGHTY
TIMES OF KNOX.
PER YEAR.
THE MOBILE SOURCE REGULATIONS
CANNOT BE ADOPTED OR IMPLEMENTED
FAST ENOUGH TO MEET THE FEDERAL
DEADLINES.
AND THE ONLY WAY TO ACHIEVE
THESE EMISSION REDUCTIONS.
IS TO INCENTIVIZE A MASSIVE
TURNOVER. TWO ZERO AND YEARS
ZERO EMISSION ENGINES FOR MOBILE
SOURCES THROUGH EXACTLY DRUDGERY
OF A OUT THIRTY SECONDS JUST ADD
APOLOGIZE BUT IT'S ONE MAKE IT
MAKE SURE YOU'RE ABLE TO FINISH
THAT UP.
THANK YOU.
SO THE DISTRICT CANNOT SUBMIT
THESE MEASURES BY TWENTY TWENTY
USEPA MUST IMPOSE SANCTIONS.
INCLUDING CREATING EXPENSE OF
HURDLES FOR NEW BUSINESS
ACTIVITY.
CUTTING OFF FEDERAL HIGHWAY
FUNDING THAT'S REPRESENTING
ALMOST A HUNDRED ELEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS.
AT RISK IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS.
THE TASTE PLAN.
FURTHER THE EPA COULD INSTITUTE
A FEDERAL TAKEOVER OF STATE AND
LOCAL AIR POLLUTION EFFORTS IN
THE SOUTH COAST.
WE URGE YOU TO PASS SB SEVEN
THIRTY TWO TO ENSURE A PATHWAY
FOR SUFFICIENT FUNDING. TO
ATTAIN FEDERAL AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS.
TECH PUBLIC HEALTH AND AVOID
FEDERAL SANCTIONS THAT WOULD
HURT THE LOCAL ECONOMY AND
JEOPARDIZE LOCAL TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING.
THANK YOU NOT BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND AGAIN WE TRULY APPRECIATE
YOU HANGING WITH US TODAY IT'S
BEEN A LONG ONE CAN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY SIR.
HIS NAME WE WELCOME YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF YOUR WORK THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AND HAVE
YOU TURN THE MICROPHONE IF YOU
DON'T MIND.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS DAN IS AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF MOVE LA.
YOU HAD BEFORE YOU A LETTER OF
SUPPORT FROM A NUMBER OF
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS I
LIKE TO ADD.
PLANNING CONSERVATION LEAD TO
THAT AS WELL -- BUT I PREFER TO
SPEAK TODAY AS THE FATHER OF A
TWENTY THREE YEAR OLD WHO'S
QUITE WORRIED ABOUT THE FUTURE.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE ARE
THREE REASONS REALLY WHY THIS --
SHOULD BE APPROVED BY THE
COMMITTEE THE FIRST.
AS MR NASH TREE HAS STATED IS
REALLY DIESEL AIR POLLUTION IN
THE SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT WHICH IS A
NON TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANT THE
DOMINANT SOURCE.
OF AIR POLLUTION IN THE DISTRICT
WHICH RESIST REGULATION BECAUSE
ONLY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN
REGULATE IT WE NEED IN THE
CENTER PROGRAM ON SCALE THEY'VE
ESTIMATED BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
FOR THAT PROGRAM.
THE SECOND PURPOSE REALLY IS TO
JOIN YOU IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE. TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS WE KNOW
NOW THAT THERE ARE WAYS TO ROLL
BACK GLOBAL WARMING.
HOWEVER IT WILL TAKE A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT THERE'S
ONLY TWO PLACES WITHOUT
INVESTMENT CAN REALLY COME FROM
ON SCALE THAT'S EITHER FROM YOU
FOLKS THE SENATE CALIFORNIA OR
FROM THE VOTERS.
PROBABLY IN THE SOUTH COAST AIR
DISTRICT WHERE CAN WHERE IT CAN
REALLY VOTE ON SIGNIFICANT SCALE.
THE THIRD REASON THOUGH I THINK
IS THE OPPORTUNITY OF REGIONAL
MEASURE CAN PRESENT. FOR
CREATING A TRULY CLEAN AIR RAIL
SYSTEM THROUGHOUT THE REGION THE
METAL EXISTENCE IS A NORMAS
OPPORTUNITY IS NOT YET IN THE
BILL WE BELIEVE IT BECOMES AN
OPPORTUNITY GOING FORWARD WE
URGENT.
I THINK THE DISTRICT IS BECOMING
RECEPTIVE TO THAT BUT THOSE
THREE REASONS REALLY CLEAN AIR.
CLIMATE CHANGE AND A VAST
REGIONAL -- TRANSIT SYSTEM.
ONLY SIGNIFICANT DOLLARS CAN
ACHIEVE THAT LET'S SEE THEY'RE
GONNA BE SACRAMENTO -- IS GOING
TO BE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MRS ANGRY FOR
OF YOUR COMMENTS AND THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR HANGING WITH US TODAY
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO OPEN UP TO
ANYONE ELSE WHO IS IN SUPPORT IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD
STATE YOUR FIRST AND LAST NAME
AS WELL AS YOUR ORGANIZATION.
OR IN SUPPORT WELCOME BACK SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN MATTHEW
BAKER JUST WANNA.
RESERVE THAT PCL WE RELATE TO
THE TABLE WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON MY
CHECK OF PACIFIC MERCHANT
SHIPPING ASSOCIATION REPRESENT
OCEAN CURRENTS MARINE TERMINAL
OPERATORS AT THE PORTS OF LA
LONG BEACH -- WE ARE
TREMENDOUSLY INTERESTED IN THE
ROSAL -- WE WERE TO START THIS
PARTICULAR MATTER BY OVER 90%
WERE LAST TWELVE YEARSOUR SOCKS
ARE DOWN 98% OVER LAST TWELVE
YEARS AE NOT SPENT 60% ALMOST
TEN THOUSAND TIMES.
WE CAN'T GO MUCH FURTHER WITHOUT
ASSISTANCE.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO WORKING
WITH THE THE DISTRICT ON THEIR A
CAMPY BUT IT REQUIRES FUNDING
AND AND THAT GOES ACROSS THE
BOARD FOR VESSELS FOR TUGS FOR
TRANSFER EVERYTHING SO WE
APPRECIATE -- LOOK FOR TO WORK
WITH THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
FOR COMMENTS WELCOME BACK SIR.
CARE MEMBERS ROBERT HARRIS ON
BEHALF VERY THE LA THAT THE
CLEAN AIR ADVOCATES FOR CLEAN
LUNGS AND HEALTHY CHILDREN LOS
ANGELES AND FULL SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH WELCOME BACK SIR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN F THE COMMITTEE
BRING RCM HAVE CAL STAR ALWAYS
SUPPORTIVE OF REDUCE HERE --
PROVING A QUALITY REDUCING
EMISSIONS I THINK IT WAS GARCIA.
SHOTS BACK BACK SYLVIA SOLUTION
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE IN SUPPORT OF CLEANERS
IN THIS IN.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
SHE IS WITH US IN THE MORNING
AND AND HANG WITH US THIS
EVENING THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
LIKELY TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THOSE WERE IN
SUPPORT.
SUPPORT ALL RIGHT.
NOW LACKEY LIKE TO WELCOME AND
ANYONE WHO'S IN OPPOSITION WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT MISTER WOLF IS
HERE.
WE'RE GONNA ASK WHATEVER
WITNESSES TO BE TO MAKE ROOM IF
THAT WORKS FOR YOU BECAUSE WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THOSE WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION AND
WILL WELCOME YOU BACK UP.
AS SOON AS THE OPPOSITION HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE -- FREE YET.
AN EQUITABLE WE LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE TO INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL
BE OUR SECONDARY WITNESSES IN
ONE IS OUR PRIMARY.
SO -- ENSURE THAT WE HAVE FAIR
AND EQUITABLE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
BE TO BE A PRIMARY WITNESS YOU
CAN ON TALKING TO YOURSELVES
[inaudible]
MY NOMINATION [inaudible]
OKAY.
IF THAT'S POSSIBLE.
BY NOMINATION -- THE MAN THE
MYTH ALLEGE MR WILL BACK FIVE TO
BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT SIR YOU.
HAVE THE FLOOR AND WE'LL GO TO
OUR SECONDARY WITNESSES WELCOME
BACK HERE MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU -- MEMBERS -- GOOD AFTERNOON
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY BUT AND
UNFORTUNATELY NOT IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IS TO HAVE THAT GOING
FOR ME AND JUST AND STRAIGHT.
SO -- WE ARE DEFINITELY OPPOSED
SB SEVEN THIRTY TWO TODAY AND I
WANT TO MENTION TWO THINGS THAT
I MISTER NOW ACTUALLY MENTIONED
IN HIS VERY ABLE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS -- TWO POINTS THAT HE
RAISED THE FIRST ONE BEING
PRECEDENCE OKAY THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME AN AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
HAS AUTHORIZED A TAX OF THIS
NATURE THIS IS A SENATOR ALLEN
MENTION ATTACKS THAT ENCOMPASSES
TWENTY MILLION PEOPLE ACROSS
FOUR OF THE BIGGEST COUNTIES IN
THE STATE THIS IS NEVER BEEN
DONE BEFORE -- SO THERE'S
PRECEDENT SETTING NUMBER ONE
NUMBER TWO WERE TARGETING
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES
THERE ARE DOZENS OF COMMUNITIES
MEMBERS WITH SALES TAXES.
PARTICULARLY NOW I COUNTY OF ACT
OR OVER 10%.
AND YOU KNOW THIS WOULD ADD AT
LEAST 1% TO THAT AMOUNT -- AND
THAT RAISES CONCERNS BECAUSE
SALES TAXES ARE OBVIOUSLY VERY
REGRESSIVE.
AND ARE GONNA MAKE THE COST OF
GOODS MORE EXPENSIVE --
ESPECIALLY FOR LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS.
AND FINALLY MEMBERS WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT AND EVEN
BOUNDARIES.
KIND OF FOR THE REASON THAT I
MENTIONED AT THE TOP THIS IS A
ESSENTIALLY FOR COUNTY TAX
SPENDING TWENTY MILLION PEOPLE --
TAXES OF SALES TAXES OF THIS OF
THIS KIND TEND TO BE CONSTRUCTED
AMONG CITIES AND COUNTIES
PRIMARILY AND NOT ACROSS
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS AND I
THINK THAT CREATES -- THE
PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS AND
MAKES TAX COMPLIANCE MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT SO FOR ALL THOSE
REASONS ASPIRIN ABOUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER WOLF WE
WELCOME OUR SECOND WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
SIR THE FLOOR IS YOURS ALL RIGHT
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
PETER BLOCKER WITH CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION WERE ALSO
IN OPPOSITION.
ECHO MANY THE COMMENTS THAT I
MISS ROTH MADE I'D ALSO ADD THAT --
IN ADDITION TO AUTHORIZE IN THE
DISTRICT TO IMPOSE A SALES AND
USE TAX OR TREES TRANSACTION CAN
USE TAX -- IT WOULD ALSO ALLOW
THEM TO GO ABOVE -- 1% ABOVE THE
2% CAP ON LOCAL TAXES.
AND THIS 2% CAPS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA HAS A ONE OF
THE REASONS WE HAVE THAT CAP IS
NOT ONLY TO EASE COMPLIANCE BUT
THE PROTECT ACT FAIRS REGRESSIVE
TAX BECAUSE CALIFORNIA AT SOME
POINT 25%.
STATE IMPOSE RATE IS THE HIGHEST
IN THE COUNTRY -- AND ALSO JUST
ADD THAT -- WE URGE CAUTION IN --
INSTEAD IN THIS PRESIDENT OF
ALLOWING THE DISTRICT LIKE THIS
TO HAVE THIS ABILITY -- TO
INFLOWS ATTACKS LIKE THIS -- AS
THE ANALYSIS POINTED OUT.
WELL WE'RE THIS IF THIS WERE
ADOPTED -- THERE WERE COULD
THERE WAS THE IS THE POTENTIAL --
FOR PARTS OF UNDER DISTRICT TO
HAVE A SALES AND USE TAXES HIGH
IS A LOT OF ELEVEN POINT 25%.
WHICH IS VERY HIGH AND THIS
WOULD KIND OF CREATED A ANOTHER
BLANKET OF TRANSACTIONS NEW
TAXES ON TAXPAYERS IN THOSE.
IN THOSE AREAS SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE OPPOSE THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIR AND OUR FINAL PLEASE
SIR WELCOME YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
THANKS FOR BEING HERE THANKS FOR
HANGING WITH US THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I HAVE TO SAY IS ONE OF
THOSE DAYS WHERE I GOT SPEND THE
ENTIRE.
DAY ONE COMMITTEE AND IT IS VERY
REFRESHING TO WATCH THE
MULTITUDINOUS OF THE ISSUES
BEFORE YOU SO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY NOT THANK YOU SO
MUCHYOU'RE VERY MY NAME.
I'M SORRY MY NAME IS MARK WHAT'S
AND I'M REPRESENTING RIVERSIDE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
TODAY.
AND I JUST EXPRESSED OF TO THE
AUTHOR OF THE THE THE FACT THAT
WE'RE NOT HERE IN OPPOSITION.
SO MAKE SURE THAT THE COMMITTEE
UNDERSTANDS SEPARATE RIVERSIDE-COUNTY TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
HAS ASKED ME TO CONVEY A SERIES
OF CONCERNS ABOUT THE PROCESS
THE REST OF THIS BILL TO THIS
POINT TIME.
AS WELL AS TO CONCLUDE WITH A
COUPLE OF POINTERS. TO FOR THE
AUTHORS EXPOSITOR ISN'T OTHERS
TO CONSIDER GOING FORWARD.
SO FIRST OF ALL -- THERE ARE CTC
RECYCLING TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION IS WELL KNOWN I THINK
IN THIS CAPITAL T'S DONE
MIRACULOUS THINGS OVER THE YEARS.
THERE WELL REGARDED THE VERY
CAPABLE AS A LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY.
THERE ARE AN INTEGRAL PART OF
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA MOBILITY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
AND THEY'RE VERY ADEPT AT
WORKING WITH OUR COUNTERPARTS
YET THEY'VE ASKED ME TO STEP
FORWARD HERE TODAY. TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
BILL.
WAS AT A FAR REACH FROM THE
FOLKS WITHIN OUR CTC THAT
INCLUDES SEVERAL SUPERVISORS AND
TWENTY NINE CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS.
SO THERE SHOULD HAVE BEEN MUCH
MORE INTERACTION BETWEEN THE
SPONSORS OF THIS LEGISLATION AND
FOLKS WHO HAVE AN AFFILIATION
WITH OUR CTC.
ARE WE BINS SINCE THE BILL WAS --
VIA HEARD ABOUT AND LAUNCHED IN
THE FALL WE'VE BEEN REPEATEDLY
ASKING FOR INFORMATION.
ARE SUCH THINGS AS WHAT PROGRAMS
WILL BE FUNDED SUCH THINGS AS
WELL HOW WOULD BE ENSURE THAT.
THE INLAND EMPIRE RESIDENTS WILL
SEE A FAIR SHARE RETURNED
DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE DEALT WITH
IN THE BILL.
AND ONCE THE LANGUAGE IS FINALLY
AVAILABLE WITH UNDERSTAND FOUND
THAT THERE'S A 6% EXPENSE
ALLOWANCE WHICH IS VERY UNUSUAL
FOR THE SELF HELP COUNTY.
LEGISLATION I WILL POINT OUT AND
NUMBER SHOULD SHOW MY AGE HI
HELP RIGHT THE FIRST TO SELF
HELP COUNTY.
BILLS IN MID EIGHTIES EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHTY SIX AND IN BOTH
CASES THEY HAVE 1%.
CAPS ON ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS SO
I JUST PUT PASSED ON AS A
SOMETHING FOR YOU TO CONSIDER.
ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS OKAY A THE
LAST TWO KEY CONCERNS ARE FIRST
THAT ON BEHALF OF OUR CTC ANYONE
EMPIRE AT LARGE.
THERE IS A GREAT POTENTIAL THAT --
WE COULD BE LEFT OUT BECAUSE OF
THE MAKE UP OF THE BOARD IN
TERMS OF MAKING PROJECT
DECISIONS AND PROGRAM DECISIONS
SO THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT WE THINK
NEEDS TO BE THOUGHT OUT AND
TAKEN. TO AND HAVE SOMEONE TAKE
A LOOK AT AND FINALLY WE HEARD
RUMORS ABOUT THE METROLINK.
A LANGUAGE.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY.
PERSPECTIVE ONE WAY THE OTHER
FACT I REPRESENT METROLINX IT'S
KIND OF AN ODD POSITION VIçT.
BUT THE POINT HERE IS.
THAT SEE HEARING ABOUT
AMENDMENTS THAT AFFECT.
METROLINK AND YOU HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE OUR CTC IS ONE
OF THE FIVE FOUNDING MEMBERS OF
THE GPA BOARD AND HAS NOT BEEN
TALKED TO AT ALL IN ADVANCE OF
THE LANGUAGE BEING PUT ON THE
TABLE.
IS HIGHLY IRREGULAR SO WITHOUT I
CONCLUDE.
AND BEG YOUR INDULGENCE FOR MY
PRESENTATION THANK YOU SIR THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND AS THE DISTANCE
MAJORITY LEADER CAME OVER WAS
JUST SAYING -- THINKING YOU FOR
YOUR YEARS SERVICE HERE IN THE
BUILDING AND BEYOND TO THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MA'AM THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE
WELCOME YOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION.
I'VE BEEN IN THIS ROOM SINCE
NINE AM.
ARE YOU ARE YOU THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE A DREAM.
DALY HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY I WOULD ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF MR WHAT'S
MY FORMER BOSS.
I'M AND OUR FRIENDS AT OUR CTC
AGAIN WE DON'T HAVE QUALMS ABOUT --
ABOUT THE LAUDABLE GOALS OF THE
BILL AND WE THANK SENATOR ALLEN
HIS ABLE STAFF FOR WORKING HARD
ON THIS ISSUE WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THE FUNDING
SOURCE.
AND WE THINK THAT THE ACTIONS
NEED TO BE -- COMBINED
TRANSPORTATION AIR GO HAND IN
HAND.
COMING TOGETHER AROUND HOW TO
MAKE THESE ISSUES WORK TOGETHER
IS WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
A SOME YOU KNOW THERE IF WE PUSH
TOWARDS.
AND OVER DOING IT BOARD OF OLD
CLOTHES THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
GRATEFUL.
WE LIKE TO BE A YOU LAST CALL
FOR THOSE WERE IN OPPOSITION
WE'RE JUST LOOKING FOR FIRST AND
LAST ORGANIZATION.
TIME WELCOME BACK SIR REX ON
BEHALF CALIFORNIA'S PROBABLY
CESSATION ALSO POST THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
ASK OFFER THOSE WERE OPPOSED.
HEARING TINO WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE TO BE
AN ISSUE.
WITH SENATOR HERTZBERG.
ELSA CEREBELLUM THERE ALSO A
STARK.
I HAD A MEETING I DON'T KNOW
MISTER SAYING WHEN WAS THAT MY
OFFICE WITH THE IT'S JUST SAYING
ONE OF THE PROPONENTS AND ONE OF
MY BEST FRIENDS IN LIFE AND ONE
OF THE GREATEST POLITICAL MINDS
I KNOW VICTOR GRAY GO --
SOMETIME AGO WHICH PROBABLY
SPENT AN HOUR AND A HALF OR TWO
HOURS AND AT THAT TIME.
I SAID THIS WAS THE DUMBEST
THING IN THE WORLD.
I OVER JUDGE A LITTLE BIT BUT
WE'VE ACTUALLY DO THAT'S A LONG-DAY.
I I WAS REALLY UNHAPPY HE WAS MY
THINKING AND I SURE BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT PUT IN THE
RECORD FOR THIS PURPOSE.
YOU KNOW WE'VE WATCHED OVER THE
YEARS HOW THESE EBBS AND FLOWS
WORK IT'S EASY FOR US TO
GOVERNMENT WHERE EVERYBODY
ALWAYS THE LIST OF PEOPLE THAT
WANT MONEY IN NEW REVENUE STREAM
IS EASY.
RIGHT IT'S ALWAYS THE TAXPAYER
GROUPS THAT ALL WE CAN PUSH
THOSE OFF OF MY PARTY.
BUT WE GOT A STEP BACK FROM IT
LOOK AT THE LARGER FRAMEWORK
WHICH I'VE BEEN TRYING TO DO NOW
FOR THE LAST NINE YEARS NOT
SUCCESSFULLY.
BUT IN EARNEST.
THE LOS ANGELES WE JUST SPENT ON
IN CALIFORNIA WE JUST RAISED A
HUNDRED TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS
LOWER LA WE PASSED MEASURE ARE
AND WHATEVER IT WAS FRONT AND
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS IN
TRANSPORTATION.
WE ADDED ON THE TAX FOR MR
BELL'S MEASURE FIVE POINT FOUR
BILLION A YEAR WHATEVER THE
NUMBER IS HE KNOWS BETTER THAN I
FOR TRANSPORTATION SUBSEQUENT TO
THAT.
WE JUST DID STORMWATER EVERYBODY
SAYS THE ROTATION OF THE EARTH
GONNA STOP UNLESS USED WITH
THESE NPDES PERMITS AND ALL
THESE COASTAL CITIES IN THEIR
FINES BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
STORM WATER.
WE NOW HAVE A MEASURE FOR A
PARTIAL TAX ANOTHER PARTIAL TAX
AFTER STORM WATER FOR EDUCATION
BECAUSE THE H. SCHOOLS ARE GOING
TO FALL APART.
WE HAD HOUSING MEASURE H. IN LOS
ANGELES HHH THE COUNTY ONE OF
THE CITY FOR MONEY FOR HOUSING I
HAVEN'T SEEN A STICK BEING BUILT
YEAH.
THE POINT IS THAT AND THERE'S
MORE AND MORE AND MORE IN THIS
YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT SPLIT ROLE
COMING UP IN NOVEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY THAT'S
OFFICE ALREADY ON THE BALLOT.
AND SO HERE YOU'VE GOT AN
AGENT'S AN ENTITY THAT SAYS OKAY.
WE WE WE JUST HAD THE SILO THESE
THINGS -- QUOTE YOU KNOW AIR
QUALITY IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING WAS TRANSPORTATION WHICH
AFFECTED AIR QUALITY FOR THE
STANDARDS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING I DON'T KNOW.
WHAT THE ISSUE IS IN A RAISE
THIS IS THE THIS WHOLE BALLOT
BOX BUDGETING WE JUST SAW THIS
THIS BOND ISSUE ON THE BALLOT
WERE PEOPLE KIND OF ROLLED THE
TRUCK UP TO THE BACK OF THE
TREASURY FOR CONTINUES
APPROPRIATION?
OF FOUR FOUR WATER PROJECTS AND
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS.
IT'S NOT SUSTAINABLE WE NEED TO
SIT BACK AND HAVE A LARGER WE
WERE TALKING WITH CENTER MORLOCK
ABOUT THIS FOR A LONG TIME.
AND I DON'T WANT TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION IN THIS YEAR OR NEXT
YEAR BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH
MONEY ON HIS PROPERTY TALK ABOUT
TAXES IN THIS YEAR BUT THE POINT
IS THAT.
LOOK I HAVE NO OBJECTION SENATOR
TO THE AND I'M GONNA SPORTS BILL
WATCH IT OUT BECAUSE I'M GOING
TO ALL THIS STUFF BECAUSE I
BECAUSE I THINK YOU'RE A DECENT
FELLOW AND I THINK YOU'RE AN
HONEST GUY AND I THINK YOU'RE
GONNA WORK HARD TO FIGURE THIS
OUT.
BUT I THINK SUPPORT FOR THE
RECORD YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF THE
CONCERT IT'S EASY I THINK YOU'RE
GONNA WORKING HARD AND WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE THE STUFF FOR
GRANTED I GET IT.
I JUST THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
FRAME IT OUT.
THAT.
MAN WE JUST GOTTA CUT THIS OUT.
EVERYBODY HAS AN INTEREST GROUP
AND ALL THEIR LITTLE OCC SILOS
OF INTEREST GROUPS TO GET
TOGETHER TO SUPPORT A REVENUE
STREAM WE GONNA LOOK AT THE BIG
PICTURE.
THE VOLATILITY PIECE OF
CALIFORNIA THE UPS AND DOWNS
IT'S NOT SUSTAINABLE WE'VE GOT
GREAT CHALLENGES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE DOING
BRILLIANTLY WE JUST SAW THE
REVENUE NUMBERS ARE GREAT.
AND I'VE SEEN THESE PATTERNS
WHERE THINGS ARE FANTASTIC EVERY
WOULD BE GOING INTO THE BLOWS UP
AND THEN ITS SHUTDOWN FOR TEN
YEARS.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT WE NEED
MONEY FOR AIR QUALITY IS NO
QUESTION THESE THINGS HAVE TO BE
DONE.
EN EN ALL OF YOU YOU KNOW I'M
GONNA VOTE FOR THIS SIX TO GET
IT OUT SO YOU CAN WORK ON IT AND
CONTINUE TO HAVE A DISCUSSION
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
APPROPRIATE IN GIVEN THE
SITUATION.
BUT I REALLY THINK THAT HERE'S
ANOTHER GROUP COMING IN SAYING
HERE'S THE DEAL YOU KNOW AND I I
BY THE WAY WAS IT WAS A
CONTRIBUTOR TO THIS.
THE ALL THE BOND ISSUES THAT FOR
BOND ISSUESI DID FOR BILLIONS
AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
SCHOOLS TAKING MONEY.
OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND THAT
ABOUT A PROP.
NINETY EIGHT PAPER SCHOOLS
BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS SO.
I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT THAT THE
PEOPLE ARE RIGHT BUT I JUST
THINK AT SOME POINT WE NEED TO
SIT DOWN AND I KNOW YOUR
THOUGHTFUL PERSON.
AND YOU WILL TAKE THIS FOR WHAT
IT MEANS THAT WE GONNA SIT BACK
AND FIGURE THIS THING OUT YOU'RE
GOING TO GO OUT.
CITIES AT LA'S LIKE JAHLEEL
USERS IT'S GONNA PUT DOWN
ANOTHER BOND ANOTHER PARTIAL TAX
FOR EDUCATION THEN THE PEOPLE
OVER HERE ON ON SPLIT RIGHT TO
SAY WE MONEY FOR EDUCATION
PEOPLE SO WE JUST BY THE MONEY.
HERE THEY'RE GONNA PUT THIS ON
THE BALLOT HOW'S HAT GOING TO
AFFECT A LARGER DYNAMIC WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IF IT PASSES AND
GET SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR IS
GIVE YOU AUTHORITY WITH MY
REQUEST IS AS A AS A CITIZEN IN
THE PATRIOT.
IS IS TO STOP FOR A MINUTE AND
FIGURE OUT THE LARGER
ARCHITECTURE.
OF HOW WE REINVENT THIS STUFF
AND AND THIS BALLOT BOX
BUDGETING IS JUST GOING TO KILL
US.
IT'S JUST GOING TO KILL US EAT
IT IT'S ALWAYS EASY FOR THE BEST
CAUSES.
BUT WE WE JUST NEED TO THINK
ABOUT IT SO I HAVE BEEN SUPPORT
HAPPY TO MOVE IF YOU WANT ME TO
DO THAT -- IN TERMS OF THAT
DISCUSSION BUT I CAN'T STRESS
ENOUGH HOW MUCH WE'RE GOING OVER
THE CLIFF AND WE JUST GONNA BE
MORE THOUGHTFUL ABOUT A LARGER
COMPREHENSIVE VIEW.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
POSSIBLE OF ORGAN FOR NINE YEARS
AND HAVE NOT BEEN SUCCESSFUL AND
I'VE BEEN A CONTRIBUTOR
DEUTSCHES SOME OF THE PROBLEMS.
SO BUT BUT I JUST.
WANT TO SHARE THAT VIEW WITH THE
COMMITTEE AT AND WITH THE AUTHOR.
HAVE CENTER ALLEN BEER TO
RESPOND I JUST WANNA REMIND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE HAVE THREE BILLS IN FRONT OF
US IN ONE IS GOING TO BE RATHER
IN DEPTH.
SO -- SO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE -- FOLKS IN OUR COMMENTS
IN THE CENTER ALLEN PLEASE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO RESPOND TO CENTER
HERTZBERG AS WELL AS IN IN THE
OPPOSITION WILL GO TO SENATOR
BALLOT IN THE VICE HAIR.
YEAH I I WILL I WILL JUST SEE
YOU WITH RESPECT AT CENTERS FOR
HIM IT YOU KNOW WHEN YOU SAY NOT
AS A STICK IS GONE AND I I THINK
YOU KNOW SEVEN THOUSAND UNITS
ALREADY BROKE GROUND HHH THE
TARGET IS.
TEN I'M YOU MEASUREMENTS MEASURE
ARE WE GOT THE EXPO LINE WE'VE
GOT THE FOOTHILLS GO ONLINE --
YOU GOT THE CRENSHAW CRYSTALLIZE
NEARLY DIED YOU GUIDE THE
REGIONAL CONNECTOR NEARLY DONE
DOWNTOWN THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING
WITHOUT MONEY AND YOU KNOW IT WE
CAN ALWAYS STRETCH IT FURTHER
AND OR MEASURE OUR MEASURE YEAH.
AND THE ONE THING I WILL SAY I I
I DON'T DISAGREE WITH YOU BUT
BUT ULTIMATELY IT'S UP TO THE
PEOPLE RIGHT AND AND IF YOU LOOK
AT PAGE THREE OF YOUR HOUSE IS A
TALK ABOUT HOW NOT ONLY WILL THE
BOARD HAVE TO PROVE.
PLACING THAT MEASURE ON THE
BALLOT THESE ARE ALL PUBLICLY
ELECTED PEOPLE WHO ACCOUNTABLE
THE VOTERS BUT THEN THE VOTERS
HAVE TO VOTE FOR IT BY TWO
THIRDS VOTE -- SO.
IT OUT OUR AYE AYE I GUESS THE
QUESTION YEAH AND IT ON LIKE
LIKE A BEHIND THIS IS NOT -- IS
NOT DEAD FINANCE THIS IS
ACTUALLY FINANCED BY THE PEOPLE
THE PEOPLE MAKE THE DECISION
WITH THE DO IT OR NOT THE PEOPLE
CAN ACTUALLY.
PETITION PUT SOME ON THE BALLOT
TO RESCIND IT IF IF THEY WANT TO
AND EVERYBODY KNOWS HOW HARD IT
IS TO PASS TAXES.
JUSTIFIABLY RIGHT AND NOBODY
WANTS TO PAY MORE -- SOLD HIM
LIKE THIS IS ABOUT KEEPING FAITH
WITH THE PUBLIC AND IF THE
PUBLIC.
YOU KNOW THAT'S A LOOK THIS IN
THE EYE AND MAKE A DECISION
WHETHER TO SUPPORT OR NOT AND
HOW TO DO IT A TWO THIRDS LEVEL.
THAT'S A HIGH BAR TO MEET AND
AND YOU KNOW IF OUR FOLKS WANT
TO VOTE FOR IT AND THEN THEN
THEY KNOW IF THEY THINK THAT
THIS IS WHERE THE IF THEY THINK
THE BOARD IS COME TO THEM AND
REALLY MADE THE CASE.
THEN I THINK.
YOU KNOW THE WE OUGHT TO BE ABLE
TO MOVE FORWARD -- YEAH IT'S
HIGH BAR TO MEET.
AS A POSSIBLE TOOK TIME.
OUT BUT IF PEOPLE WANT TO VOTE
FOR IT AND THEN THEY REJECTED
AND WE DON'T HAVE IT.
WELL EXCELLENT SAID COURSE
THAT'S THE CASE IT SHOULD EVERY
CASE BUT IT'S WE WE DON'T LIVE
IN A VACUUM.
IF YOU'RE ASKING VOTER CHOOSE
BETWEEN HOUSING -- A CLEAN AIR
THIS THAT THIS THAT THIS ND
UNDERSTANDING IN OTHER
CONSEQUENCES WHAT ENDS UP
HAPPENING IN THESE PROCESSES IN
OUR ABILITY TO MANAGE THE LARGER
FRAME.
OF CREATING A THEY DON'T KNOW
THAT THERE MIGHT BE A DOWN TURN
IT ALL OF A SUDDEN ALL THESE
FINDINGS ARE GONNA BE CUT LIKE
WE SAW IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
WHEN THE ECONOMY WENT DOWN BY 3%
THE BUDGET THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WAS CUT BY 23%.
THEY DON'T KNOW THAT AND SO THE
QUESTION IS IT SEEMS TO ME IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON US A LITTLE BIT
IN THIS LARGER DISCUSSION AGAIN.
OBSERVATION BUT JUST TO BE ABLE
TO INFORM IT IN THE GREATER
DEBATE THAT'S RIGHT TO ALL I
WILL SAY IT IF THAT HAPPENS ALL
THE MORE REASON WHY YOU NEED
LOCAL FUNDING STREAM WHEN WE
HAVE THE BUDGET CUT MY SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
THANK GOD WE HAVE LOCAL LOCALLY
SOURCED MONEY TO BE ABLE TO KEEP
OUR DISTRICT ALIVE BECAUSE THE
STATE MONEY GOT CUT SO
TREMENDOUSLY DURING THE LAST
DOWNTURN MOVE THE BILL.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
WE HAVE A COUPLE WEEKS A COUPLE
FOLKS WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
MAKE SOME COMMENTS WE HAVE I
CENTER BELL IN THE VICE CHAIR
CENTER ABOUT WE MISSION -- FOR
OKAY MIGHT MY ISSUE IS THE SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY STRICKEN HAVE
THERE IT IS THERE ANY OTHER AIR
DISTRICTS THAT SALES TAX.
REVENUE SOURCES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
MR EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
THANK YOU I'M CENTER VALVE
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BAY AREA HAS A PARCEL TAX.
BUT THAT THERE ARE NO OTHERS.
TAX.
MEASURES MOST OF THE DISTRICTS
ANSWER LEGISLATIVE CREDIT DON'T
AVE THE AUTHORITY. TO EVEN
PLACE THAT MEASURE ON THE BALLOT
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEKING SO
THAT'S THE PRESIDENT.
ESSENTIALLY WOULD THIS BE
FOLLOWED UP BY.
SO MY QUESTION WOULD BE WOULD
THIS BE FOLLOWED UP BY OTHER
DISTRICTS GO MAN.
ESPECIALLY MINE.
I MADE AN HOUSING FOR SALE
STARTS.
A NO YOU KNOW LIKE WHAT THE WAY
WE WOULD PUT IT THE YOU KNOW
ANOTHER REGRESSIVE TAX.
I HOPE SO SO CAN YOU RESPOND TO
THAT ISSUE YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE
RAISED THIS ISSUE WITH THAT
CALIFORNIA POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE ASSOCIATION
THAT TIME.
WAS TO WAIT AND SEE WHAT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN -- LOOK AT
PARCEL TAXES OPPOSE A SALES TAX
WHAT AREA ONE I THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT -- WE ARE
CONSIDERED BUT WHEN WE HAD
ACTUALLY DONE A OF PUBLIC
SURVEYS.
WE FOUND THAT THERE WAS GENERAL
SUPPORT FOR SALES TAX EASY PEASY.
SALES TAX IS ALWAYS THE ONE THAT
SHOWS EYES OPEN POLLS.
ARE YOU HAVE YOU HAVE -- THE
OTHER QUESTION IS -- IS THIS
BUILDING -- IT IS THE IS THE
ATTENTION OF THIS BILL TO BE
AMENDED THAT WILL.
INVOLVE -- FUNDING OF
TRANSPORTATION -- FACILITIES WE
ARE.
WE'RE CERTAINLY WILLING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS.
TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES AND
CLEARLY TRANSPORTATION AND
TRANSIT GOODS MOVEMENT ALL HAVE
IMPACTS ON AIR QUALITY WE
CERTAINLY SEE.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS AIR
QUALITY IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
LIFE IMPROVE THE OVERALL ECONOMY
[inaudible]
OKAY -- I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT YOU KNOW I LIKE.
THEY MUCH PREFER A WILL NOT TO
SET A PERSON SALES TAX
[inaudible]
BUT OVER THE BILL THE DAY -- IF
IT INVOLVED IN HIS AMENDED TO
INVOLVE TRANSPORTATION I THINK
IT'S FAIR TO TALK TO OUR
COMMITTEE.
YOU KNOW IT ALSO JUST POINT THAT
OUT.
IT BECOMES A TRANSPORTATION BILL
AS OPPOSED TO JUST AN AIR
QUALITY BILL.
SO SO.
THAT'S NO SIR BY CALLING ON THAT
SO -- I THINK THAT -- WE'D LIKE.
TO FOLLOW THE BILL CLOSELY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN SO I JUST.
THINK OF MY STATEMENT HERE RIGHT
NOW SO WE'RE WE'RE AWARE.
IS AMENDED TO BECOME MORE OF A
TRANSPORTATION BILL THAT'S A
CHANGE OF THE AND RUSSIAN SO.
THANK YOU NO I APPRECIATE THAT --
INDIA AS THE CHAIR OF
TRANSPORTATION.
I KNOW THAT -- SHE CHAIR WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SOME
INPUT IN SOME GUIDANCE ON THAT
IS WELL -- AND I DON'T PUT WORDS
IN YOUR MOUTH MISTER CHAIRMAN
PROBABLY EARLIER RATHER THAN
LATER WELL I REALLY I I THINK
IT'S NOT JUST ME BUT MY THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THAT ARE
FROM.
ESPECIALLY FROM THE SOUTH COAST
AREA.
WOULD LIKE TO PROBABLY HAVE SOME
INPUT IN THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE IF THAT HAPPENS THANK
YOU SO MUCH MR EXECUTIVE OFFICER
DIRECTORS FUND THAT.
AS I SAID WE'RE CERTAINLY
WILLING TO WORK WITH THE OTHER
TRANSIT AGENCIES --
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
ON THAT THERE IS ISSUES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NO THEY TO BE TO TURN THE FLOOR
OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIRS IN A
ROCK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I
THINK.
CENTER HERTZBERG KATIC COVERED
MOST OF THINGS I WANTED TO SAY.
JUST THINKING POLITICALLY TRYING
TO GET A TWO THIRDS.
VOTE ACCOMPLISHED IN THESE FOUR
COUNTIES -- IT'S GONNA BE VERY
HARD -- ORANGE I DON'T THINK
COULD BE VERY RECEPTIVE THEIR
SELF HELP COUNTY AND IT WAS HARD
ENOUGH TO GET OUR MEASURE IN.
PAST -- I'M I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THE INLAND EMPIRE -- JUST A LOT
OF OUR YOUNG KIDS ARE MOVING OUT
THERE AND THEN COMING AND ORANGE
COUNTY TO WORK -- BUT SO JUST
JUST THE TO TO PUT THAT OUT
THERE WHATEVER BOWLING YOU HAVE.
A GOOD POINT -- I AM JUST
CURIOUS SINCE THE GOVERNOR HAD.
GIVEN HIS BUDGET SPEECH AND TALK
ABOUT A TWENTY ONE AND A HALF
BILLION OUR SURPLUS.
DID YOU GET A CHANCE TO TALK TO
HIM BECAUSE YOU'RE LOOKING
YOU'RE TO MY NOTES ARE YOU WANT
TO GIVE FOUR HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION ANNUALLY RIGHT.
I'M COMING UP WITH FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION SOME OF THE
NUMBERS I'M LOOKING AT BUT YOU
KNOW DID YOU DID YOU ASK HIM.
FOR FIVE HUNDRED MILLION A YEAR
TO TAKE CARE OF THIS MY EYES AS
YOU KNOW CENTER THAT THE
SURPLUSES OF WAS A ONE TIME
THING RIGHT SO SO WE'RE LOOKING.
FOR I HAVE LONG TERM ONGOING --
EXPENDITURES -- BUT THERE'S
CERTAINLY A LOT OF GOOD STUFF
IT'S IN THE BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT
RELATES TO THIS SORT OF WORK BUT
THE THE ONLY THINK I MAKE A
COMMITMENT THEY'RE ONLY WHAT
THEY'RE ONLY GOING TO MAKE A
COMMITMENT OF OF A YEAR TO I
MEAN.
THERE'S THERE'S NOT THE KIND OF
LONG TERM COMMITMENT BECAUSE OF
THE VOLATILITY OF OUR BUDGET.
THE I GUESS WHAT I'M TRYING TO
COMMUNICATE IS SOMETHING SIMILAR
TO WHAT CENTER HERTZBERG DATA
THAT IS.
NOT LA LOOK AT LA AND AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT A PARTIAL TAX REALLY
UNIFIED.
THERE'S FOUR MILLION VOTERS FOR
YOU RIGHT THERE IT'S GOING TO
HAVE TO TACK THAT ON SO I'M JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO YOU
EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE WE THE TAX
INCREASE. ONE OF THAT TWENTY ONE
AND A HALF BILLION OR SURPLUS
AND SO THE DICHOTOMY -- JUST
YEAH BUT YOU'RE YOU'RE THE ARE
BUDGET GURU RAM YOU KNOW THAT
THE SURPLUS IS A IS IT IS IT
TEMPER IS AN EPHEMERAL THING
RIGHT.
RIGHT BUT IT'S ALSO A TOOL AND I
I DON'T SEE A TEN YEAR PLAN. FOR
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO THE YOU KNOW
GOING OUT BUT IF IT DID YOU TAKE
IT THIS IS A CRITICAL PRIORITY
WHICH STARRED MAYBE START WITH
ONE HUNDRED MILLION AND WORK OUR
WAY UP TO SOMEWHERE TO DEAL WITH
THESE ISSUES.
AND I'M NOT SEEING THAT AT ALL I
EITHER SO I THAT'S WHY I ASK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
THIS PROJECT OFFICER QUICKLY
PLEASE THANK YOU -- UNDER EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN THE STATE IS
PROVIDED.
A TWO ENGINE FIFTY TWO ENGINE
FORTY FIVE MILLION THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET IS
TWO HUNDRED MILLION.
MUCH OF THOSE FUNDS GOES TO THE
CLEAN AIR TYPE OF PROJECTS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT MONEY IS NOT
SUFFICIENT FOR THE SOUTH COAST
AIR QUALITY DISTRICT COMING TO
ATTAINMENT.
WE HAVE TO KEY DATES TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY THIRTY
ONE AND THE ESTIMATED.
OF FUNDS NECESSARY TO COME INTO
ATTAINMENT FOR THAT IS ESTIMATED
OVER BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
SO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR.
ON SIX SEVENTEEN FOR THE SOUTH
COAST AREA IS INSUFFICIENT WE
ALSO OPPOSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WERE LOOKING AT PART
OF AN INFRASTRUCTURE BILL. TO
DEVELOP A CLEANER FIND THAT
WOULD GO TO AREAS WHERE YOU HAVE
EXTREME NON ATTAINMENT OR NON
ATTAINMENT.
YOU KNOW WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT ASPECT AGAIN.
WE ARE ONE OF ONLY TWO AREAS IN
THE NATION THAT HAVE THIS
EXTREME NON ATTAINMENT.
AND SO I THINK WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THAT.
THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD REASON TO
TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND AND AND WOULD NOT ATTAINMENT
A FEDERAL GOVERNMENT COULD
WITHHOLD BILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL HIGHWAY FUNDS IT COULD
IMPOSE STRICT EMISSIONS
REGULATIONS WITHOUT A PENNY OF
INCENTIVES. TO AID IN REGIONAL
COMPLIANCE AND AND ADD YOU KNOW
GIVEN THE VOLATILITY WITH THE
RELATIONS FELL GOVERNMENT I I
WOULD BE IRONIC BUT BUT ACTUALLY
TOTALLY POSSIBLE AND LIKELY.
THAT THE THESE KINDS OF HOW
THESE MIGHT BE ASSESSED -- IF IF
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO RETURN OUR OUR
OUR STANDARDS.
HIS THRILLING I HEAR MORE LIKE
ANY FOLLOW UP ON THAT NO NO.
YEAH NO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THAT IS IN GERMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY SENATOR WIENER.
WE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONVERSATIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE BEFORE WE TURN IT
OVER TO SENATOR ALLEN FOR
CLOSING COMMENTS.
TINA FROM COMMITTEE SURROUNDED
CLOSE PRETTY THE COMES AGREE TO
I DO WAS REALLY WANNA TALK TO
MISTER JERRY LEADER ABOUT HOW TO
HOW TO REALLY MAKE THIS BETTER I
FOR FOLKS I I GET I GET I HEAR
YOU I HEAR YOU -- I I DO THINK
THE TEACHERS A HIGH BAR BUT
EIGHTY NINE PIE PART OF MAKING
THIS ACTUALLY MEANS SOMETHING IS
CONVINCING OUR RESIDENTS YOUR
RESIDENTS EVERYBODY.
THIS IS A WORTHWHILE ENDEAVOR --
BY THE WAY IF THAT KIND OF
REQUIREMENT AS REQUIRED SHOWING
EVERYBODY THAT IT'S GONNA SERVE
EVERYBODY I YOU KNOW THERE'S A
COMMA MADE THE WITH WHAT I
RIVERSIDE WELL.
NO WE WE GET TWO THIRDS VOTE OF
RIVERSIDE IS FEEL SILLY CUT OUT
OF THE DEAL SO -- YOU KNOW
THAT'S A GOOD THING IT'S A IT'S
A BIT THE PROTECTIONS A BARBER
YOU KNOW -- BUT BUT ULTIMATELY
WERE WE HAVE SERIOUS PAYMENT
ISSUES THAT THEY COULD END UP
COSTING THE REGION EIGHT
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF MONEY LET
ALONE ALL THE POLLUTION ISSUES
THAT WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING --
KNOCKS HIM TODAY -- SO I I DO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS IT'S A
IT IS A DIFFICULT ISSUE -- BUT I
I THINK IF YOU HAD A THINK IS A
LOT OF WORTHINESS TO TO WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE AND AND
I ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SO I SENT AROUND
MOTION THE FLOOR BY CENTER
WIENER THIS IS A DO PASSES A
MINUTE TO APPROPRIATIONS MISSING
CHESTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FLYER HI WHY I'M MORE LOCKED.
WARLOCK NOBEL.
YEAH I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
[inaudible]
NIELSEN.
WIENER.
WIENER ITF WORLD.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR ONE
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS IN A WIENER --
I THINK WE HAVE A NEW CENTER
LARA AWARD WINNER TODAY
[inaudible]
YES -- YES.
DE I THINK DEVOTED AND NOW WE
HAVE -- YEAH IT'S BEEN GREAT
THROUGH GOOD STUFF THANK YOU SO
MUCH ZSA HOUSING TRUST.
I DO BELIEVE.
I BELIEVE CENTER WE WE HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
EVERYBODY LOOK AT THAT YOU KNOW
I HAVE A MOTION ON THIS WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR HERTZBERG AN
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY WE'RE GONNA
ASSN RUBIO TO BE A TO GIVE US A
TRUNCATED.
VERSION EVER STATEMENT AS WELL
AS HER WITNESS.
I'M CENTER THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
ALL TODAY I'M REALLY HAPPY TO
PRESENT TO AS BE SEVEN FIFTY ONE
WHICH IS A BILL THAT WOULD
ADDRESS THE GROWING HOMELESS
CRISIS IN THIS ANGER -- VALLEY
BY SUBMITTING A THANK YOUR
VALLEY REGIONAL HOUSING TRUST --
THIS BILL WILL ADDRESS THE
CRISIS IN THE SAME YEAR VALLEY.
AND DIE GIVEN ACCORDING TO THE
LOS ANGELES HOMELESS SERVICES
AUTHORITY THE OVERALL NUMBER OF
ON SHELTER HOMELESS PERSONS IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY HAS DECREASED
BY 3%.
HOWEVER THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS
PEOPLE IN A TANGLE VALLEY
CONTINUES TO GROW.
I ACCORDING TO THE LAST COUNT ON
SHELTER HOMELESS PERSONS IN THE
SINGLE VALLEY INCREASED BY 29%
BETWEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AT THEN LATER
INCREASED -- BY 19% BETWEEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SO THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW PUBLIC AND PRIVATE FUNDS
TO BE USED RESPONSIBLY TO
ADDRESS THIS CRISIS BY
INCORPORATING.
AN ANNUAL FINANCIAL REPORT AND
AND AND AUDIT A REQUIREMENT INTO
THE REGION A HOUSING TRUST.
OP TODAY I HAVE SOMEONE HERE
TODAY HIS NAME IS JOE ALLIANCE
OFF FORMER COUNCILMEMBER CARMEN
CITY COUNCIL AND BOARD MEMBER AT
THE SAME YOUR VALUE COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS JUST TRANSFER A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS -- IF HE CAN
SEE A FEW WORDS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR MIND YOUR
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
YOU'RE VERY LUCKY TO HAVE CENTER
RUBIO -- AS YOUR CENTER SHE DOES
A FANTASTIC JOB.
THE LINES OF FLOOR IS YOURS IF
YOU HAVE A WHAT I SAY.
WE ACTUALLY I AM AND MOVED TO
BILLS.
OR IF YOU GO.
AND I I DID ONE JUST THAT WHILE
I HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY CHAIR AND
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK GOD
THIS OF THE SENATOR FOR
ADVANCING THIS BILL ON OUR
BEHALF.
AGAIN I THINK IT WILL -- ADD TO
OUR ABILITY TO ADDRESS THE
CRISIS IN THAT CALIFORNIA
CERTAINLY IN THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
AND HOMER SEPARATE SO AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR WHAT I PAID WHAT
APPEARS TO BE -- THE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THE THE BILL WILL GET
AND I CAN'T THANK YOU MUCH.
JOINT YOU'VE BEEN A TROOPER
TODAY IN GRATEFUL EVEN WITH US
FOR SO LONG THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THERE ISN'T GENERALLY NOW LIKE
TO OPEN IT UP TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE WHO IS IN SUPPORT IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD AT
THIS TIME LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT.
THIS IS GONNA BE LAST CLL FOR
SUPPORT WE NOW LIKE TO TURN OVER
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO TAKE
PLEASE COME FORWARD LOOKING FOR
OPPOSED.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSED.
HERE AND SEE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BE TO BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE AT
THIS TIME.
HEARING SEEN -- QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG THIS IS A DO
PASSED THE SENATE FLOOR BETTER
CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
JUST REALLY QUICKLY HE HE'S BEEN
WAITING HERE FOR A COUPLE HOURS
EVEN MOVED HIS FLIGHT ONCE FOR
ME SO I'VE HELPED FELT COMPELLED
TO LET HIM SAY A FEW WORDS BUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND WITH THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR I THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY HARD WORK ON THIS BILL --
MEN CENTER THIS IS REALLY GOOD
BILL IN MISALIGNED THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HANGING WITH US FOR SO
LONG TODAY -- MISSING CHESAPEAKE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OF WIRES HI.
I'M MORE LONG MORE LIKE I DEL.
VALLE AYE HERTZBERG BY FIRST
REGARD HER TITLE.
NIELSEN.
WIENER WIENER ON THE RUBIO
ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO VOTE OR KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN -- AND WILL HAVE
OTHER MEMBERS AT ALL AS THEY
COME BACK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GREAT JOB [inaudible]
ALREADY ALL.
WE HAVE THREE BILLS LEFT. ONE
THAT WILL TAKE ABOUT SIX HOURS --
I'M KIDDING I WE ARE NOW TO BE
JOAQUIN WHAT MEAN.
MADAM SENATOR CENTER SKINNER
FROM THE GOOD CITY OF BERKELEY.
WE WHEN I TAKE A MOMENT.
THERE IS SKINNER HAS TWO BILLS
THAT ARE IN FRONT OF US TODAY --
IF IT WORKS FOR THE SENATOR WILL
START WITH ITEM NUMBER TEN SB.
TWO NINETY THREE WHICH IS IN
REGARDS TO THE OAKLAND
WATERFRONT IN A REVITALIZATION
PRIOR RIGHT.
AND THEY WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO
GO TO ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN SB --
FOUR SEVENTY FIVE PRIOR TO THE
SENATOR STARTING I WANT TO TAKE
LONG TO SAY THANK YOU TO CENTER
SKINNER FOR HER WORK.
ON WHAT IS A COMPLICATED BILL --
AND SHE'S BEEN TRYING TO THREAD
THE NEEDLE -- IN IT HAS BEEN
WORKING THIS EXTREMELY HARD IN A
ONE OUT PUBLICLY SAY THANK YOU
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK.
BETTER CENTER THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AN ITEM TEN SB -- TWO NINETY
THREE THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS --
FIRST I WANT TO SAY I'M
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND WHAT I'M GONNA DO.
BECAUSE THE IS JUST VERY BRIEFLY
GO OVER THEM FROM THE ANALYSIS.
SO ON PAGE FIVE I'M ACCEPTING.
THE THE AMENDMENT THAT WOULD.
ALLOW LOCAL AGENCIES A SEAT ON
THE BOARD IF THEY DECIDE TO OPT
IN AND PROVIDE PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE TO THE DISTRICT.
I AM ALSO ACCEPT BEING THE TOP
OF A PAGE SIX WHERE -- WERE
ALLOWING A PUBLIC PROTEST
PROCESS IN THE DISTRICT
FORMATION -- I AM ALLOWING -- OR
FOR ACCEPTING ON PAGE SEVEN
NUMBER.
EIGHT THE ISSUE OF CLARIFYING
THAT ITS POTENTIAL THIS FOR THIS --
THE USE FOR THISINFRASTRUCTURE
IN SUPPORT OF THE STADIUM IT'S
AND I WILL CLARIFY LEADER THIS
IS NOT.
A PUBLIC FINANCING OF THE
STADIUM AND I WILL CLARIFY THAT
SWITCH JUST LANGUAGE THAT MAKES
IT CLEAR.
WHAT THIS PROJECT IS?
AND THEN -- THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS IN ITEM NINE OF THE
ANALYSIS BUT ADDITIONALLY.
I AM MORE THAN WILLING TO
INCLUDE AN AMENDMENT THAT
CLARIFIES THAT THE INTENTION OF
THIS -- PROJECT IN THIS BILL IS
NOT TO OVERRIDE ANY A
JURISDICTION OR AUTHORITY OF
EITHER STATE LANDS OR BE CDC.
THREE THANK YOU SO MUCH AND IF
THAT WORKS FOR YOU BETTER CENTER
SINCE THAT'S NOT IN FROM THE
COMMITTEE TODAY IT IS ON YOUR
YES IT IS.
WELL IT'S ON YOUR PAGE -- NO
IT'S IN THE NOW STATUS ARE HAVE.
YES YES IT IS A WOMAN WHO IS
WHAT WILL TAKE IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE AND ALL THE ITEMS
PRIOR TO THAT WILL TAKE OKAY DAY
GREAT THAT WORKS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YEAH RIGHT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS MA'AM IF YOU'D
LIKE TO GIVE YOU SEE OKAY SO --
THE I WON'T GO THROUGH THE
STREETS IN THE ANALYSIS OF ARE
WE THE LEGISLATURE'S
ESTABLISHMENT OF THESE --
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS -- WE HAVE MADE MANY
MODIFICATIONS TO THEM.
OVER THE YEARS I TO STREAMLINE
THEM TO SOME DEGREE AND THIS
BILL IN EFFECT -- IS SOMEWHAT OF
A STREAMLINING FOR THE CITY OF
OAKLAND TO ESTABLISH THE AN
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICT THAT WOULD SUPPORT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY FOR ALL
THE COMPONENTS OF A PROJECT THAT
WOULD INCLUDE A A BASEBALL
STADIUM.
NOW THE FINANCING ITSELF WOULD
ABSOLUTELY NOT BE USED FOR THE
STADIUM THAT IS NOT GOING TO BE
PUBLICLY FINANCED -- SO
SPECIFICALLY WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS PERMITS THE CITY OF OAKLAND
TO FORM THE I FD FOUR AT THE
HOWARD TERMINAL EXPANDS THE TERM
FOR THE TAX AND PERMIT.
FRUIT FORTY FIVE YEARS VERSUS
THE THIRTY DEBTS IN THE ORIGINAL --
AUTHORIZING LEGISLATION FOR E.
I. F. THESE -- ALLOWS FOR THE
FINANCING OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED BUT NOT THE FINANCING OF
THE STADIUM.
AND REMOVES THE VOTER APPROVAL
FOR THE ISSUING OF BONDS AND
OTHER ASPECTS OF THE I FD.
NOW INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH
GOVERNOR NEWSOME IN HIS --
BUDGET PROPOSAL IS RECOMMENDED
THAT WE LEFT THE VOTER APPROVALS
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE IN -- DIE
IF THESE AND WE HAVE THERE IS
THIS -- MULTIPLE OTHER
PRESIDENTS OF LEGISLATION WORD
THESE VOTER APPROVALS WERE
ELECTED -- AND WITH THAT I WILL
ALLOW MY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO
SPEAK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER SKINNER
WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF LEAVE.
I YES MY SERVER THE ETS AND I
THINK WE HAVE THE CITY WONDERFUL
YES SO MUCH.
SIR YOU HAVE A TWO MINUTES IN
ROOM AND CITY BROKEN AS WELL THE
FLOOR SHORES AND WELCOMED
COMMITTEE YES THANK YOU SO MUCH
REALLY APPRECIATE THE TIME AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE.
ON THIS IS A BIG BILL FOR THE
OAKLAND A STABLE TO PRIVATELY
FINANCE BALLPARK AT THE
WATERFRONT JACK IT'S WHERE.
YOU WHERE THE LAST PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS TEAM LEFT IN OAKLAND HOW
WE'RE MAKING A BIG FINANCIAL
CONTRIBUTION A COMMITMENT TO THE
CITY WE'VE BEEN THERE FIFTY ONE
YEARS WANT TO DO EVERYTHING WE%
CAN TO MAKE SURE MANY ADDITIONAL
GENERATIONS OF FANS.
CAN GROW UP WATCHING THE OAKLAND
ETS IN THE EAST BAY AND WHEN
MANY MORE WORLD CHAMPIONSHIPS
THE PROJECT HAS PLENTY I'VE NOT
A FAN OF THEIR WE HAVE NINE
WORLD CHAMPIONSHIPS AS YOU KNOW
WE GOT A RECALL HOW MANY YEARS
THE JOBS.
WERE COMPLETELY SIR ARE SO YEAH
YEAH YEAH.
SO HE SAID WEDNESDAY WE WANT IN
A WALK OFF TODAY HAVE TO FEEL
BAD.
ABOUT FOR ME IS A DODGERS FAN
ITSELF YEAH YEAH THEIR PROGRAM
THROUGH.
THAT'S TRUE THAT'S TRUE THAT
THOUGH BUT NONE THE LESS THERE'S
A LOT OF BENEFITS TO THIS
PROJECT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE.
THAT WERE WORKING HAND IN HAND
WITH THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
AND THE BAY CONSERVATION
DEVELOPING COMMISSION TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PROJECT -- FITS
THEIR GUIDELINES AND AND NOTHING
WE DO YOU SERVICE THEIR
AUTHORITY SO THAT'S REALLY
CRITICAL AND I KNOW THAT WAS
ADDED TO THE BILL I ALSO WANT TO
STRESS THIS IS THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC IMPACT. FIVE
THOUSAND NEW JOBS AND ALSO A
PROGRAM THAT COULD REALLY
ENHANCE THE CAPABILITY THE
MARITIME CAPABILITY OF THE PORT.
BY DIVERSIFYING THEIR REVENUE
STREAMS AND PROVIDING THE MONEY
TO REINVEST AND SO THAT'S REALLY
AN IMPORTANT PART OF THIS WE
THINK THAT THERE CAN BE A
PRIVATELY FINANCED BALLPARK.
AND A GREAT PORT OPERATING
OAKLAND AT THE SAME TIME AND SO
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU FOR JOINING WITH US.
GOOD EVENING WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'RE HERE IF YOU JUST GIVE US
YOUR FIRST AND LAST.
MY NAME IS MOLLY MAE BROWN AND
THE CHAIR PERSON MCGUIRE AND
LIKE TO START AS A GRADUATE OF
HEALDSBURG ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
HEALDSBURG JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL.
HIGH SCHOOL.
I AM SAYING GO GREYHOUND HI DAN.
BUT I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT A
DIFFERENT SPORT.
I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE CITY
OF OAKLAND THE MAYOR.
OF OAKLAND AND THE CITY
ADMINISTRATOR APOLOGIZE THAT
THEY COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY BUT
THEY HAVE ASKED ME TO COME AND
CONVEY THEIR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL -- OUTS DAVE STATED
THE CITY THE ETS IN THE PORT OF
BEEN WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP TO
BUILD A NEW WORLD CLASS FACILITY
FOR OUR LAST REMAINING MAJOR
LEAGUE SPORTS FRANCHISE IN THE
CITY OF OAKLAND.
OUT HOWARD TERMINAL.
OF THE CITY OF PLUGS THE ETS
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO
PRIVATELY FINANCE THE BALLPARK.
THIS PROJECT WILL PROVIDE
ECONOMIC AND COMMUNITY BENEFITS
THE CITY AND PEOPLE OF OAKLAND
INCLUDING OPENING THE WATERFRONT
TO PUBLIC ACCESS AND ENJOYMENT --
THIS AYE IF ANDY WILL GIVE THE
CITY ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO CAPTURE
BUT FOR TAX INCREMENT CREATED BY
THE PROJECT TO FUND MUCH NEEDED
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE. TO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED PROJECT
WHICH WILL BE BUILT OUT OVER
DECADES NOT YEARS.
THIS AYE IF HE WILL ALLOW BUT
NOT REQUIRE THE CITY TO CREATE
SUCH AN INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICT AND THE ABILITY TO
CREATE THE DISTRICT --
ULTIMATELY RESIDES IF THIS
LEGISLATION PASSES WITH OUR CITY
COUNCIL.
WE'RE HERE TO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE FROM LIKE
MANY THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE WE
NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE AN OPENING
UP TO ANYONE WHO THANK YOU VERY
SPEAK -- IN SUPPORT OF WE DO WE
HAVE HEARD FROM OUR PRIMARY
WHICH IS A SENATOR AND WE ARE TO
SECONDARY -- WITNESSES SIR -- SO
WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR FIRST AND
LAST AS WELL AS ORGANIZATION A
GOOD EVENING.
SENATOR MCGUIRE ROB STOKER AYE
BRETT PRESENT THE ALAMEDA
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL AND ITS
FORTY THOUSAND HARD WORKING MEN
AND WOMEN AND WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS PROJECT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GRATEFUL
HERE MISTER STOKER PLEASE SIR
GOOD AFTERNOON.
REQUIRED JUST QUICKLY NEAGLE
DELUCA HERE AND THEY HAVE THE
CITY OF OAKLAND IS YOU KNOW
WHERE THE SPONSOR THINK THE
CENTER FOR OUR WORK ALSO REALLY
WANT THANK YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK SO GREATLY
APPRECIATE IT SO THANK YOU WHEN
EXACTLY.
DID YOU SEE SIR THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
COULD YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANKS
FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SCOTT SAID ON
BEHALF OF THE PORT OF OAKLAND IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH GOT.
WE THANK YOU VERY SEE IF THERE
IS ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORTH THIS
TIME.
ASK OFFER THOSE IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WHAT WE LIKE TO REALLY
DO IS WELCOME THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED TO BE A TO KEEP THE
HEARING FAIR AND EQUITABLE WE'RE
GONNA WELCOME ONE PRIMARY.
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION INTO
SECONDARY WITNESSES.
SO WE WILL INVITE THOSE WHO HAVE
JOINED SENATE SKINNER BACK.
WE WELCOME YOU SIR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE IF YOU
PLEASE GIVE US FOR SOME LASSEN
ORGANIZATION THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SOMEWHERE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU GETTING MISTER CHAIRMAN --
MEMBERS MIGHT SHAPE WITH THAT
MARCH HAVING SENSATION ADDITION
OF REPS AND IN THE SAME BRING
TERMINAL OPERATORS OF THE PORTS
FELL IN LONG BEACH WE DO IN
OAKLAND AS WELL -- AND THANK YOU
FOR THE THE OPPORTUNITY AS THE
COMMITTEE THE SEVEN AND MARK I
BELIEVE THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
WE'VE EVER OPPOSE THE BILL BY MY
SENATOR -- SO -- IT IS WHAT IT
IS -- WE HAVE SOME SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH THE PROJECT ITSELF
IS BEING FINANCED UNDER WRITTEN --
ARE -- COLLEAGUES FROM MILD TO
BE ABLE TO DRESS AT A LITTLE BIT
MORE SPECIFICALLY WITH OUR
OBJECTION TO THE STADIUM PROJECT
IN THE HOUSING COMPLEXES
ASSOCIATED WITH IT BUT SUFFICE
TO SAY.
VERY BRIEFLY THE SAME THING THAT
MAKES THE WATERFRONT DESIRABLE
FOR DEVELOPERS INCLUDING THE
OAKLAND DAYS IN THE CITY OF
OAKLAND IN THIS INSTANCE -- IS
THE SAME -- MOTIVATION REQUIRES
A TO BE PROTECTED FOR THE
BENEFIT OF EVERYONE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S THE
WATERFRONT -- DESIRABILITY OF
THE WATERFRONT AND THE USES IN
THE PROTECTIONS OF THE
WATERFRONT STATE LAW WITH
RESPECT TO THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION.
GO TO THE THE PREMISE THAT ONCE
THE WATERFRONT IS GONE IT'S GONE --
WE NEED THE WATERFRONT FOR WATER
DEPENDING USES -- AND SO IN THE
CONTEXT OF THIS BILL IN OUR
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY IT UNDERMINES US
SOME THE PROTECTIONS THAT --
WERE WRITTEN INTO LAW WHEN --
SENATOR HALL TWO SESSIONS AGO
OFFERED SB SIXTY THREE WHICH WAS
SPONSORED BY OR TO OUR
ORGANIZATION TO CREATE SEAPORT A
HALF DAYS -- THIS PROPERTY IS
ACTUALLY.
MANAGE UNDER THE SILENCE TRUSTS
THROUGH GRANT BY THE STATE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT -- UNDER SB
SIXTY THREE WHEN YOU'RE TAKING
THESE TYPES OF PROPERTIES IN
YOUR USING A INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICT MECHANISM
WHERE INVOLVING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TAX REVENUE.
WE'VE ASKED FOR CLARIFICATIONS
THAT THE REVENUE GOES BACK INTO
THE TRUST THE GETS MANAGED BY
THE TRUST -- AND THAT IT'S DONE
INCONSISTENCY WITH -- PORT
MASTER PLANNING OR AT PORT
REQUEST FOR THAT DOCUMENT -- TO
JUSTIFY THE IFP.
AT FIRST GOING TO THE CITY
COUNCIL BEFORE IT GETS APPROVED
SO REGARDLESS OF THAT PROCESS
THAT'S A CHECKED IT'S BUILT INTO
OUR SYSTEM.
THAT CHECK DOES NOT EXIST HERE --
THE CITY COUNCIL OF THE CITY OF
OAKLAND IS PLACED IN A DIRECT --
CONTROL OVER WHAT'S OCCURRING IN
THIS PROCESS WITH RESPECT TO
THIS PROJECT ON PORT PROPERTY
WHICH IS LIKELY TO RETAIN IN THE
TRUSTS THE HEARD FROM A IS --
AND SO WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE THE SENATOR HAS -- HAS
OUTLINED -- LOOK FOR TO WORK
WITH THE STAFF ON MAKING SURE
THAT THE FINDINGS IN HERE -- ARE
CONSISTENT WITH WITH WHAT SHE
OFFERED AND AGAIN THANK HER FOR
THAT -- THE WILL AND MAKE IT
REALLY CLEAR THAT WE HAVE ISSUES
WITH THE UNDERLYING PROJECT BUT
WE ALSO HAVE SOME SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES WITH THE THE PROCESS
MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE GONNA WELCOME YOU TO BE
ABLE TO STAY THERE FOR THE
DURATION THE MORE THAN WELCOME.
TO CENTER SCARES WITNESSES BACK
UP AS WELL WE WELCOME YOU SIR
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE FOR SOME LASSEN
ORGANIZATION MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AND SORRY CENTERS CAN
FOR NOT SUBMITTING A LETTER.
HI TO YOU ARE OUR MAIN CONCERN
ON BEHALF OF THE I. O. W. IS
THAT.
THESE ARE -- WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT
STUDYING THE IMPACTS TO THE POOR
ACTIVITIES WERE NOT LOOKING AT
THE IMPACTS FOR JOBS.
THAT ARE NOT GONNA BE LOST --
THESE ARE WELL PAYING JOBS THAT
ONE'S -- ECONOMIC ACTIVITY STOPS
ARE ACTORS OR SLOW DOWN AT THE
PORT -- WE WE STARTED LOSING
THOSE JOBS AT E. WE HAVE THAT
THERE THIS IS THE THIRD LARGEST --
POOR AND CALIFORNIA THE POOR
WILL CLEAN CONTINUES TO BREAK
RECORDS AND THAT'S SOMETHING TO
CONSIDER FOR THE COMMITTEES.
THIS IS A PORT WHERE THERE'S A
LOT OF GOODS MOVEMENT COMING AND
GOING AND NOW HI.
HIS BILL SAID UP TO
INFRASTRUCTURE I DO BILL -- NOT
A STADIUM BUT HOUSING THERE'S
NOTHING THAT SPECIFICALLY SAYS
THIS WILL BE FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSING IN ANYTHING THAT I'VE
SEEN IN THE BILLS -- INCLUDING
THIS ONE SO WHAT I WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT WE OPPOSE THE BILL IT
DOES CREATE JOBS BUT IT ALSO I
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO ELIMINATE
JOBS AND THAT'S WHAT WE ASK FOR
WE ASK FOR THAT. FOR TO SLOW
DOWN AND LOOK AT THE IMPACT THAT
THAT THAT THAT NOT ONLY THE
STADIUM BUT HOUSING IN A
RECREATIONAL ACTIVITY WILL HAVE --
ON THE POOR ACTIVITY THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
TUNING IN THANK YOU BOTH FOR
HANGING WITH US HERE TODAY FOR
SO LONG.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
ANYONE ELSE WHO IS IN OPPOSITION
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD.
IN THIS PORTION OF THE HEARING
WERE LOOKING FOR YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME OF COURSE YOUR
ORGANIZATION.
WE APPRECIATE EVERYONE -- IT
HANGING WITH US IT'S BEEN A LONG
DAY -- IN KNOW THAT MANY OF YOU
BEEN HERE SINCE THIS MORNING.
GOOD EVENING SIR WE WALK
COMMUTER GAVE IN.
THE ARE YOU BUT IT WAS NOT FROM
THE K. IN THE PRESIDENT I'LL
GIVE YOU LOCAL.
TEN THAT -- REPRESENTS THE
MEMBERS THAT WORK ON THE
WATERFRONT IN OPEN.
THANK YOU I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY.
THAT EVEN FRANK ASK THE LOCAL
TEN VISAGE OF SECOND GENERATION
LONGSHOREMEN OPPOSES BILL I
THINK THANKS SO MUCH FRANK FOR
BEING HERE.
WELL [inaudible]
GOOD EVENING -- MY CARRIER AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND I
GUESS WE INTO THE EVENING NOW
BUT MY NAME IS LEE SEND OFF AND
I AM THE LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
FOR THE INTERNATIONAL LONGSHORE
WAREHOUSE AND UNIONS.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
COUNCIL AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE GOOD TO SEE YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH GOOD EVENING SIR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME MY NAME
IS HARLEY KING.
ON LONGSHOREMEN ON OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
OVERALL THE IMPACT FOR
CALIFORNIA WITH REGARD TO
SHIPPING THANK YOU THANKS EARLY
GOOD EVENING SIR WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS KEITH CHECK ON
PRESIDENT LOCAL.
THIRTY FOUR AND I'M OPPOSED HIS
BILL AND I'M ALSO A DODGERS FAN --
AND HOLY HELL [inaudible]
EXACTLY.
WELL IT WAS ANDRE DAWKINS.
ALLOWED W. LOCAL TO MEMBER OUR
POLLS.
THIS BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING WITH US THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING SIR GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS JOSH FOR LIKE ON A LONG
TERM AND FROM LOCAL FIFTY FOUR I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US TONIGHT GOOD
EVENING.
I GUESS NOT MANY MISSING SMITH.
AND I'M A LONGSHOREMAN OPPOSES
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH IT IS
WORTH GETTING UP RAFAEL JIMENEZ
FLOWING SHERMAN AYE OPPOSED HIS
BILL THE COMMISSION MINUTES.
GOOD EVENING SIR MEETING.
I'M IS ACREE OVERLANDER I'M A
LONGSHOREMAN FRAUD W. LOK TEN
AND I'M I'M OPPOSING THIS BILL
WE APPRECIATE BEING HERE TONIGHT
THANK YOU GOOD EVENING.
MY NAME IS TIMOTHY GO BACK A
MEMBER OF LOCAL TEN AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
SIR GOOD EVENING SIR THAT EVEN
WHEN I WAS SMALL BAILEY -- A
MEMBER -- I'LL W. LONGSHOREMEN
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU MISTER
BAILEY JOBS IMPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
YES GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
DAVID PATTERSON OHIO W. YOU
LOCAL TEN AND I OPPOSE THANK YOU
SPECIAL GOOD EVENING.
THAT EVENING MY NAME IS CLAUDIA
TATUM WITH I'LL W. YOU AN APPLES
IS BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD EVENING MA'AM I'M CLOSE
AREAS.
WELL I'LL TO BE YOU.
KNOW PUESTO THIS STUDY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD EVENING
GOOD EVENING EMILY PETERSON LW.
SACRAMENTO CASUAL ID AND I
OPPOSE THIS THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH US
TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING AMY MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE FLORA'S I'M FROM.
LOCAL MELANIE.
GREETINGS SERVINGS RANG WITH A
CITY NAME MY NAME IS MOST OF THE
BEST LOCAL TEN WAS THE BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD EVENING SIR WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE.
YES GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS EVER
BROUGH SEMI O. W. LOCAL TEA HI
POSES FEEL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR.
GOOD EVENING AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS MISS EMMA
DANIELS ON BEHALF OF I HAD TO BE
LOCAL.
TEN AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD EVENING SIR GOOD EVENING
THE FREDDIE HAD A MEAL LOCAL TEN
I'LL W. AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD EVENING THANKS FOR YOUR
PATIENCE SIR.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS YVONNE
FELLOWS LOCAL TEN I'LL W..
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
GOOD EVENING SIR EVEN JOVIAL
JOTTING LW LOCAL.
TEN I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE GOOD
EVENING THE WITH THE ALONG
SHAUNA OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
GOOD EVENING WELCOME THE
COMMITTEE IN THE CENTER MANY
SHARPER LONG TERM IN LOCAL.
TEN THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD EVENING WELCOME THE EVENING
THANK YOU -- LAURA NO MAN LOCAL
EIGHTEEN FROM WEST SACRAMENTO
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
READING READING WILFREDO LOPEZ --
I'LL W. LOCAL TEN NOW FORTY FIVE
YEAR.
RESIDENT OF OAKLAND AYE OPPOSED
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SOME
OF HIS.
GOOD EVENING SIR.
GOOD EVENING CURT SMITH.
LW LOCAL TEN OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
GOOD EVENING SIR GIVING STEVEN
HOW TO ME A LONG TIME MAYES FAN
BUT I HIGHLY OPPOSE.
AND THERE WE GO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
BOB [inaudible]
A LAZY GERMAN WE'D LIKE TO BE TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WHO
WOULD LIKE YOU TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
WE'RE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MOMENT.
GOING TO A LAST CALL LAST CALL
FOR OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT WHAT WOULD I DO HAVE
TO DO IS BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE.
WE LIKE TO BE TURNED OVER TO
CENTER SKINNER TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS -- THE CONCERNS.
ABOUT THE PROJECT AND THE ISSUE
OF JOBS SO WHAT WE'RE INTERIOR
JUST AS THOSE ITEMS CAME UP IN
OPPOSITION.
THERE'S CARE THE FLOOR'S YOURS
AND WE ALSO WOULD WELCOME
ANOTHER ONE OF YOUR FIRST
WITNESSES TO BE TO COME JOIN IF
YOU'D LIKE.
SO -- MADAM SENATE FORESHORES.
THANK YOU -- I APPRECIATE THE
CONCERN OF DIAL W. IN TERMS OF A
LOSS OF POTENTIAL LOSS OF PORT
RELATED JOBS -- AND IT WOULD NOT
BE MY INTEREST IN WHAT SO EVER
TO HAVE ANY PORT RELATED JOBS
LOST.
THE PORT THE PORT OF OAKLAND IS.
NOT ONLY THE CITY OF OAKLAND BUT
ALMOST THE ENTIRE MY ENTIRE
DISTRICT THAT STRIP FOR THE I AD
CORRIDOR.
THE ECONOMIC ENGINE FOR THAT
ENTIRE AREA -- WE ARE AS WAS
MENTIONED THE THIRD LARGEST PORT --
WE MOVE A PHENOMENAL AMOUNT OF
GOODS THE AMOUNT OF CONTRACTS
RELATED TO THE DIFFERENT.
WORK AFFECTED BY THE THAT YOU
KNOW GENERATED BY THE PORT IS I
SAID IT'S A VERY SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMIC ENGINE.
AND VERY SIGNIFICANT NUMBER JOBS
AND IT WOULD BE -- IT WOULD BE
CUTTING YOUR NOSE OFF TO SPITE
YOUR FACE IF YOU'RE THE CITY OF
OAKLAND TO IN ANY WAY.
LESSEN THE JOBS AT THE PORT OF
OAKLAND SO.
IT IS CERTAINLY MY COMMITMENT IN
INTERACTING WITH THE CITY OF
OAKLAND TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO ENSURE THAT IF THIS PROJECT
PROCEEDS AND CLEARLY THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE I FD DOES
NOT GUARANTEE THIS PROJECT THERE
ARE SO MANY LEVELS.
THIS PROJECT STILL HAS TO GO
THROUGH -- BUT AS YOU NOTICED IN
THIS IS NOT I'M SURE MIKE MY
FRIENDS FROM I'LL W. YOU THE
FACT THAT THE PORT OF OAKLAND
SUPPORTS THE BILL DOESN'T
NECESSARILY GIVE THEM -- THE
ASSURANCE THAT THEIR JOBS WOULD
BE AFFECTED SO I DON'T MEAN TO
SAY THAT THE PORT OF OAKLAND
SUPPORT GIVES THEM THAT
ASSURANCE.
BUT CERTAINLY -- IT IS MY INTENT
AS I WORK WITH THE CITY OF
OAKLAND IF THIS PROJECT MOVES
FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
DOES NOT IMPACT PORT OPERATIONS
IN A WAY THAT WOULD.
LESSEN JOBS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WOULD LIKE TO OPEN UP TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF THE SENATOR
[inaudible]
CENTRE BELL [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
JUST RECRUITED IS A SINGLE
PURPOSE FOR THIS PURPOSE RIGHT.
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THIS BILL [inaudible]
AND THE CURRENT.
CURRENT LAW FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS.
AND WE DID MENTION A REPORT WE
HAVE A BILL -- THAT THE
COMMITTEE APPROVED AND WAS
APPROVED ON THE FLOOR OF THE
SENATE [inaudible]
RECENTLY. TO ELIMINATE THE VOTE
REQUIREMENT FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS IS -- SB.
ONE TWENTY EIGHT SO SO -- THAT'S
GOING TO ASSEMBLY NOW SO -- SO I
WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S --
DIFFERENCE SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO DIFFERENTLY HERE CERTAINLY
THIS BILL.
WOULD -- SO IF IF THE BILL THAT
WOULD ELIMINATE THE VOTING
REQUIREMENTS WHICH IS A
STANDALONE IS SUCCESSFUL -- THEN
OBVIOUSLY IT WOULD BENEFIT THIS
PROJECT BUT NOT KNOWING -- YOU
KNOW YOU DON'T KNOW WHICH ONE
WILL MAKE IT AND SO WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS.
ELIMINATE THAT VOTING
REQUIREMENT FOR THIS PROJECT
CONSISTENT WITH THE BILL THAT
WOULD DO THAT FOR EVERYONE AND
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
RECOMMENDATION THAT SUCH VOTING
REQUIREMENTS BE ELIMINATED --
BUT AT LEAST THIS ASSOCIATES
WITH THIS PARTICULAR
ESTABLISHMENT BUT ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW FOR A
FORTY FIVE YEAR PERIOD FOR THE
TAX INCREMENTS VERSUS JUST
THIRTY SO THOSE OF THE KEY
REASONS WHY WE NEED A BILL RIGHT
NOW.
AND I'LL JUST MENTION IT IS THAT
THE PROCESS.
THAT IS BEING PROPOSED -- FOR
THE AMENDMENT IN THE BEGINNING
IT IS IDENTICAL TO THE TO WHAT
WAS IN SENATOR BELLS BILL --
WHEN IT CAME THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE DIFFERENT SECTIONS A
LAW BUT IDENTICAL PROCESS --
THAT'S BEING PRESENTED HEARING
COMMITTEE.
CENTER ABOUT.
OKAY SO -- THE JOB LOSS ISSUE
YOU SAID NO JOB LOSSES AT SOME
KIND OF BOYS THOUGH AS FOR THE
AS SO MANY THINGS -- MY SO THIS.
THE HOWARD TERMINAL IS ON THE
WATERFRONT.
BUT IT IS NOT DIRECTLY A PORTION
OF THE PORTS OPERATIONS NOW
THERE'S CONCERN CLEARLY
EXPRESSED BY -- W. AND EXPRESSED
BY THE PACIFIC MARITIME SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION THAT IF THE CITY
WERE TO PROCEED WITH THIS
DEVELOPMENT THAT DATE IT WOULD
IMPACT PORT OPERATIONS.
NOW CLEARLY AS I STATED BEFORE
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
DISTRICT DOES NOT.
IT'S ESTABLISHMENT OF FINANCING
DISTRICT DID NOT GIVE A GREEN
LIGHT TO THE PROJECT AND THERE
WILL BE -- THERE WILL BE
MULTIPLE OPPORTUNITIES IN
ADDITION TO THE CITY COUNCIL
HAVING TO VOTE.
THAT CAN ADD ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS -- TO TO THE PORT
OPERATION OFF AND I WOULD
CERTAINLY EXPECT THEM I WOULD I
I CAN ALMOST GUARANTEE THAT THEY
WILL BE INCLUDED IN IT IF THIS
THING MOVES FORWARD.
AND N. WORD WERE INVESTING -- A
LOT OF THE STATE SB ONE FUNDS
AND THE REGIONAL TOLL BRIDGE.
INCREASE THERE WAS PASSED IN THE
BAY AREA IS PUTTING A LOT OF
MONEY INTO THE PORT ACCESS.
AS WELL SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
OF GOOD CHUNK OF MONEY.
TO DO THE PORT AND DOES THE CITY
OF OAKLAND.
CONTEMPLATE -- DOING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HAS BEEN
DISTRICT ACTIVITY OR SOME KIND
OF OTHER.
FINANCING IN THE PORT OF OAKLAND.
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS BRAND
NEW.
IT HAS ACCESS TO THE PORT OR THE
YOU KNOW IF THERE'S ANY PLANS --
FOR I'M NOT SURE THOUGH THE THE
ACTUAL PORT LANSING PORT
OPERATIONS ARE WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OF THE PORT
AUTHORITY -- BUT I'M NOT REALLY
TALK TO ABOUT -- LIKE TO KNOW
BECAUSE OF A BUT A LOT OF FUN TO
FIND OUT. FOR YOURSELF YEAH BEST
THING A LOT OF MONEY AND THE
RIGHT NOT WITH OUR
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS -- YOU KNOW
WE WANT TO MAKE THE PORTS
SUCCESSFUL THAT'S WHERE WERE PUT.
REPORT LIKE TRUCKING OVERPASSES
SO THEY GO RIGHT INTO THE BOARD
BUT THE OTHER THE ALL KINDS OF
OTHER IMPROVEMENTS SO THE PORT.
CAN FUNCTION -- MORE EFFICIENTLY
SO THAT'S THE POOL.
SO YOU KNOW I JUST YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THAT WITHIN YOU
HAVE IN THE WORK THE SHIPPERS SO
BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE.
AND UNION HAS BEEN VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT.
WE ALL WORK TOGETHER ON SB ONE
SO WE KIND OF WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT HAPPENS. FOR A PORT.
IT WILL ENSURE BY A COMMITTEE
WILL WORK WITH TENNIS SKINNER'S
OFFICE TO BE ABLE TO FOLLOW UP
WITH.
A CENTER ABOUT THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE ON THAT SUBJECT AS
WELL.
LET ME TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
IF THERE IS A MOTION.
ON SENATE BILL.
TWO NINETY THREE RIGHT WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR HER TITLE --
I'M GONNA PROVIDE SENIOR SKINNER
WITH AN OPPORTUNITY OF DO
CLOSING STATEMENT I'D LIKE TO
RECESS -- FOR THIRTY SECONDS TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN
SAME PAGE ON THE LEDGER ON THE
LANGUAGE. FOR PERFORATIONS JUST
BEFORE WE MOVE ON THAT BUT LIKE
TO BETTER TURN OVER TO THE COULD
SENATOR FOR INFRASTRUCTURE. ONE
QUICK QUESTION.
ARE THERE ANY RESIDENTS IN THIS.
I'M ASSUMING NO RESIDENTS IN ME
IN THE AREA WHERE THIS PROJECT
TO BE NO BUT LITERALLY ACROSS
THERE'S TRAIN TRACKS RIGHT ALONG
THERE WHICH OF COURSE SERVICE
SUPPORT.
YEAH RIGHT ACROSS FROM THE TRAIN
WRECK LITERALLY ALMOST ON THE
TRAIN TRACKS WELL NOT ON BUT
VERY VERY CLOSE FIGHT IS HOUSING.
YEAH.
YOU MIGHT.
PLEASE THERE'S TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND PEOPLE LIVE WITHIN A
MILE OF THE LOCATION WHERE THE
BALLPARK IS PROPOSED SO THERE IS
A NEIGHBORHOOD THERE ARE READY.
THANK YOU THANK.
MIKE.
SO I'M JUST GONNA ASK FOR FOLKS
WHO ARE HERE IN THE AUDIENCE AND
I DO APOLOGIZE RISK CAN ASK --
WE HAD PUBLIC COMING.
ANDERSON THERE MAY BE SOME
CONCERN OR DISAGREEMENT BUT I'M
JUST GONNA ASKED WE CAN ALL BE
RESPECTFUL.
I THINK JUST TO CLARIFY WITH.
CERTAINLY WITHIN THE PROJECT
AREA AND PROXIMATE TO THE
PROJECT AREA -- IMMEDIATELY
CONTINUOUS.
THAT IS AN INDUSTRIAL BUFFERS ON
WE HAVE SOME SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH RESPECT TO THE
INTRODUCTION OF HOUSING IN THIS
PROJECT -- AND THAT IS PRIMARILY
THE ISSUE WITH RESPECT TO THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION
COMPLIANCE -- INCONSISTENCY
CRITERIA WITH RESPECT TO THE
EXISTING REINVESTMENT OF FUND.
SO THAT WILL BE A A CONTINUING
ISSUE -- CENTER MORE LOCK -- AND%
CIVIL CENTER SKINNER -- AND
MISTER KELLER CORRECT WITH IN
THE JACQUELINE SQUARE AREA THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF RESIDENCES.
BUT WE HAVE AN EXPLICIT.
A BUFFER ZONE IN THIS TERMINAL
IS PART OF THE BUFFER ZONE -- IN
IN AND PASS IT'S BEEN OPERATING
MARINE TERMINAL FOR SIP TO
SHORE BUT NOW IT'S STILL AN
OPERATING MARINE TERMINAL
ALTHOUGH IT DOES NOT HAVE SHIP
TO SHORE -- WE HAVE A THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DIFFERENT TRUCK
TRANSACTIONS A YEAR ON THE
TERMINAL.
SO IT'S USED FOR DIFFERENT
THINGS THERE'S A MIX OF USES
HOUSING IS NEARBY ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF IT AS A SANDERS SAID ON
THE TRACKS AND JACQUELINE SQUARE --
BUT WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
THE THE EXPANSION OF HOUSING
USES INTO OUR INDUSTRIAL AREA.
AND TOSE ARE WHAT WE FEEL ARE
INCOMPATIBLE WITH WITH THE
PROJECT MOVING [inaudible]
FOR REALLY.
REASON I ASK IS.
THE CURRENT LAW REQUIRES TWO
THIRDS OF VOTERS WITHIN THE
DISTRICT APPROVED BY INSURANCE
BUT IF YOU HAVE NO VOTERS.
SO THE AVERAGE JUST.
RIGHT YEAH AND THAT THAT'S A
NATION ARSENAL TYPE TAX.
THAT'S RIGHT OKAY MISTER
CHAIRMAN THAT'S THAT'S AN ISSUE
THAT'S ACTUALLY SPECIFICALLY
CONTEMPLATED IN THE SEAPORT AYE
IF THESE -- SO.
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE HOW THAT WORKS
OUT WITH THE CHANGES WITH
RESPECT TO THE VOTE REQUIREMENTS
BUT IN THE SEAPORT I HAVE TO USE
THE POSSESSORY INTERESTS HOLDERS.
ACTUALLY ACT AS THE THE VOTING
BODY WITH RESPECT TO THE
UNDERWRITING OF DIE OFF THE
APPROVAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS VICE CHAIR.
WE LIKE TO BETTER PROVIDE
SEAMLESS CARE WITH AN ABILITY TO
CLOSE.
I APPRECIATE DISCUSSION AND WITH
THE AMENDMENTS AS I LAID OUT NOT
THE ONE THAT WE WOULD TAKE AN
APPROACH I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU SO MUCH LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE COMMITTEE WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO TAKE A THIRTY
SECOND RECESS SO -- CENTER
SKINNER NIKE'S LOOK AT THE
LANGUAGE IN THIS ONE MAKE SURE
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH YOUR
THINKING AS ELL.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK
[inaudible]
THE
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE SO
AGAIN AT CENTER SKINNER OPENLY
OUTLINED THE LIMITS THAT ARE
BEING TAKEN.
IN COMMITTEE TODAY WHICH WERE
NOT GOING TO REPEAT.
THIS BILL -- IT HAS A MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR.
AND A CENTER SKINNER WILL BE
TAKING THE FOLLOWING AMENDMENT
ON THE FLOOR I'M GONNA READ IT
IT IS NOT IN FRONT OF THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY IN THIS
COMMITTEE IS NOT CONSIDERING --
THIS AMENDMENT IT WILL BE ON THE
FLOOR IT IS THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE THAT THIS DISTRICT
IS NOT OVERRIDE THE AUTHORITY OF
THE BAY CONSERVATION DEVELOPMENT --
COMMISSION IN THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION.
SO -- THAT WILL BE TAKEN ON THE
FLOOR WE DO HAVE AND THEN MEANS
IN FRONT OF US AS COMMITTEE
MOVEMENTS WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH AT TO THE SENATOR FOR
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING THIS ISSUE.
THANK -- BOTH THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT TODAY FOR ALL THE WORK
IN FOR THE IMPORTANT FEEDBACK
RECEIVED FROM THOSE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO KNOW THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE CONTINUED
CONVERSATION.
WITH ALL INVOLVED WE HAVE A
MOTION HI IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
ITS INFORMANTS LANCASTER ROLL
CALL PLEASE.
HI MCGUIRE I'M MORE WORK.
BELL.
I HERTZBERG BUY EXTRA GUY HER
CONDO.
HELLO I NIELSEN.
WIENER WIENER AYE.
FIVE CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE
ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THIS
ON CALL AIMED AT THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH WE ONE
MORE ITEM FOR SENATOR SKINNER
AND THAT'S SB.
FOUR SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
MANY OF YOU TRAVEL FAR AND WIDE
TO BE ABLE TO JOIN US AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR FEEDBACK
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
YEAH.
YEAH YEAH GIVE US JUST A FEW
SECONDS SO OUR FOLKS TO BE A
CLEAR OUT AND WE'RE GOING TO GO
STRAIGHT INTO SB FOUR SEVENTY
FIVE IN JUST A MOMENT.
THIS IS A VERY HIGH
.
THE CONTENT AND NOT TO BE FOR
RENTERS CAN EMERGE -- YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU. FIVE SO WE'RE GONNA
ASK YOU DON'T MIND PROVIDING US
A TRUNCATED VERSION CERTAINLY
EGGMAN AS WELL AS YOURTO
WITNESSES THE FLOOR IS YOURS I
THINK OUR PRIDE OF RECORD FOR
THE SHORTEST STATEMENTS IN THE
FIRST PLACE BUT BASICALLY THIS
FIX IS SOMETHING WHERE WE DOES
NOT.
GIVE SAMPLES TO CONSUMERS IT
JUST ALLOWS FOR TREAT SAMPLE SO
WHEN YOU'RE THE SELLER YOU GO
INTO A RETAILER YOU'RE ALLOWED
TO GIVE SMPLES NOW IN ALMOST
EVERY OTHER INDUSTRY BUT THIS
WAS AN ANTICIPATED FOR CANVAS
INDUSTRY THAT'S WHAT THE BILL
DOES.
WITH THAT I ASK YOUR SUPPORT NOT
ALLOW ME WITNESSES SB THANK YOU
SO MUCH CENTER GOOD EVENING.
FLOORS YOURS YOU NEED TAKEN SOME
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND NUMEROUS CANNABIS CLIENTS IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH GOOD EVENING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OR
SEVEN COURT ON BEHALF OF
CONTINUING ONE CO SPONSORS THE
BILL.
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF YOU AND
YOUR STAFF AND OUR AUTHOR ON
THIS AND AT THE END OF THE DAY
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A PROCESS. FOR
CONDUCTING TRADE SAMPLES
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS AND THIS IS
WHAT THIS BILL DOES OFFER US
THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH MA'AM
CENTER I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES MOMENTS SO GOOD THANK
YOU SO MUCH WELCOME.
THANK YOU MAX SURPLUS ON BEHALF
OF FLOW CON OF THE THIRD CO
SPONSOR IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE WELCOME ANYONE ELSE
WHO'S IN SUPPORT IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD THIS TIME
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT.
OF THE GREATEST WITH KING TUNNEL
IT'S AN HERB AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HANGING WITH US SO LONG.
IT IS YOUR TURN MEMBERS TRACY
STEVENS ON BEHALF OF NOR CAL
CANNABIS ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU TRACY.
BIGELOW DELIVERY HERE WE HAVE OF
TWO GREAT CITIES AND SENATORS
DISTRICT OAKLAND AND EMERYVILLE
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MARIN BUT NOW WE HAVE THE NAY
CAM AS HIS POSITION IN SUPPORT
OF THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME.
NOW I WOULD LIKE TO BE RECEIVED
AS ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IF YOU
COULD PLEASE ADVANCED WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
LAST CALL WITH A BETTER BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WE WELCOME
THE MOTION.
SOME OF HEY IT'S DEL BY HAIR
LAZY GENEROUS.
SIZE SO THIS IS A DO PASSES A
MANAGER PREPARATIONS ORDER
TURNED OVER TO THE SENATOR. FOR
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS THE SHADER
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS I
JUST ROLL CALL PLEASE MCGUIRE.
WHY I'M MORE A LOT MORE LIKE I
DOWN?
I HERTZBERG BY CHRIS FOR GOD
RICARDO [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
WIENER.
WE ARE AYE.
LAYS GENERATE GET THE SAMPLES WE
ARE -- ZERO FIVE ZERO WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE.
WE LIKE TO KEEP THEME EVERYBODY.
TALKING ABOUT ALL ISSUES.
OF CANNABIS. ONE OF BIGGEST
CHALLENGES THAT THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY HAS IS BEING ABLE TO
BANK THAT CASH -- IN AND WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO SENATOR
HERTZBERG FOR HIS WORK ON THIS --
THIS IS BEEN A CHALLENGING ISSUE --
IT SENATOR OR WE CAN JUST HOLD
FOR ONE MOMENT.
MISTER SENATOR.
THE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT -- SO
WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR A TRUNCATED
VERSION -- AND GOOD PROP HERE
TODAY SIR -- VERY GRATEFUL FOR
YOU -- YEAH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
BERMAN AS FOR TRUNCATED VERSION
YOUR STATEMENT ON FROM FROM YOUR
WITNESSES AS WELL.
AS RETURNING LATER AND WE HAVE
MOTION ON THE FLOOR MR MAJORITY
LEADER.
TOGETHER WITH THE STATE
TREASURER.
WE'VE PUT FORTH THIS MEASURE THE
PROP THAT WE HAVE HERE SHOWS THE
EXAMPLE OF THE CHECK THAT WOULD
BE DONE.
THIS PROCESS FOR JUST SIMPLY
TRYING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC SAFETY
GETTING ACCOUNTING PRINCIPLES.
FOR PURPOSES OF THIS
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGE WE HAVE --
WITH THE CASH IN THE CANNABIS
BANKING SYSTEM WITH THAT --
TURNED OVER THE TREASURES OFFICE
FOR TWO SECONDS SUPPORT POSITION
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BUT JOHNSON ABOUT STATES
AS A FIELD AHMAD HERE TO BE THE
PROUD SPONSOR OF THE BILL THEN
LIKE TO THINK THROUGH HERTZBERG.
YOU SEE ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
THE SERGEANTS JOHNSON THEY TRAIN
WITH US.
IT'S SAYING GIVEN THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH AS
JINKINS WE KNOW WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME ANYONE ELSE'S FORTY
PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME WE'RE
LOOKING FOR FIRST LAST NAME IN
YOUR ORGANIZATION.
MEMBERS TRUST BUCKLEY ON PATH TO
SEE SACRAMENTO'S SPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING GOING BACK AS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT
THINGS CLEAN.
GOOD EVENING.
EVAN QUARTER ON BEHALF ORIGIN
HOUSE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH WELCOME BACK.
MONICA'S ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU WELCOME BACK.
THE STEVENS ON BEHALF OF NOR CAL
CANNABIS ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
HI THIS THE LEGACY OF KINGS ON
BEHALF OF THE EAST AND SUPPORT
WE ALWAYS LOVE HAVING WRESTLING
COMMITTEES COULD NOT YOU THE
SERVERS ARE WE HAVE AMENDMENTS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS JOB.
THANKS VERY LAST CALL FOR THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF PLEASE
COME FORWARD LOW'S IS.
FOR NOW LIKE TO BE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IS SUPPOSE IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORTH WITH A
PROPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
REVIEW LAST CALL PROPOSITION.
FOR BRINGING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE AND SEE IF WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM COMMITTEE WE
HAVE A MOTION BY THE VICE CHAIR.
HONESTY -- FIFTY ONE IN JUST
WANNA SAY AGAIN SINNERS FORGIVEN
DOG.
ON THIS ISSUE IT IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES ARE THAT WE
HAVE TWO BILLION DOLLARS IS
ESTIMATED TO BE BURIED ON THE
NORTH COAST HILLS BECAUSE FOLKS
CAN'T BANK IT'S TRUE -- IN ITS
ONE MOST DANGEROUS ASPECTS TO
THIS BUSINESS AND IT SHOULDN'T
BE A AND IT'S RIDICULOUS WHAT
THE SCHEDULE ONE BUT WE DON'T
TALK ABOUT THAT HERE TODAY I
HAVE TO CLOSE.
AS FOR AYE BOTH THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION BY THE VICE CHAIR THIS IS
DO PASSES AMENDED TO
PREPARATIONS THE SAME JUST ROLL
CALL PLEASE INQUIRE.
WHY I'M MORE A LOT MORE LIKE GOD?
KNOW I AM HERTZBERG POINT
REGARDLESS.
HELLO I NIELSEN.
THE NO WINNER.
WIENER. SIX ONE SIX ONE LAYS IN
GERMAN THIS IS JUST A PLEASE
CENTER THANKS TO THE TREASURY
AND FOR ALL OF HER WORK AS WELL.
ALL RIGHT.
BASINGER BUT IS OUR SIX FIFTEEN
THE NOW DOES GOOD WORK.
I AND I DO BELIEVE SOMEBODY SAID
SIX O'CLOCK HERE -- JUST MAKING
SURE THAT -- IF ANYONE.
ALL RIGHT NOW. SIX I THINK YOU
SAID [inaudible]
NINE I WAS.
GIVEN.
GIVEN ONE MOMENT -- WE'RE GONNA
GET OURSELVES ORGANIZED
LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN NOT BEFORE WE OPEN
THE ROLE I WE HAD A FORMER
MEMBER.
WHO -- IS SPECIALLY LOVED IT TO
COME OUT LATE AT TO COMMITTEE I
WE HAVE TO SAY WE'VE HAD SOMEONE
FILL THEIR SHOES QUITE WELL AND
THAT HAS BEEN CENTER WIENER --
BUT WE HAVE AN INTERNET WE HAVE
A WEEKLY AWARD CALLED THE
SENATOR LARA AWARD -- AARON DO
CENTER WIENER -- IT FOR THE LAST
TWO WEEKS IT HAS NOT BEEN THE
WINNER BUT I THINK WE HAVE A NEW
CHAMPION AND OTHER GOOD SAN
FRANCISCO WHO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESENT THE WAR TO TODAY --
ALRIGHT WELL I THINK THE CHAIR
WAS GETTING THE AWARD FOR AWHILE
TODAY BECAUSE HE WAS OUT OF THE
HIS IDEA.
INDEED I FOR AWHILE SENATOR BELL
DID YEOMAN'S WORK AND MOVING THE
COMMITTEE ALONG.
BUT I THINK I'M GONNA HAVE TO
HAND OFF THE BATON TO OUR
WONDERFUL NEW COLLEAGUES SITTING
TO MY RIGHT FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
CENTER MELISSA HER TADO
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THANKS FOR NOTHING HER TITLE.
HEY THERE YOU GO ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH ADVOCATES IN RETURN
CISCO IN CENTER TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
OPEN UP ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THIS CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE
ZERO VOTE ITEM SIX ITEM ELEVEN
TWELVE SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE MISLIM CHESTER
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
RICARDO.
ALL RIGHT NIELSEN THIS MESSAGE.
SEVEN ZERO THE CONTENT COUNTER
IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE
FOR NOW MOVING TO OUR SPECIAL
ORDER HEARING SB FIFTY LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IS FOLKS KNOW AS
BEFORE WAS PULLED.
FROM CONSIDERATION IN BLENDED
WITH SB FIFTY TODAY THIS
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO
VOTE MISSING CHESTER PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS.
HELLO HERTZBERG NOW HER TITLE.
I SIX ONE THERE IS A SIX ONE
VOTE WE ARE LOSING THE ROLE
THAT BILL IS OUT.
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM.
NUMBER ONE S. BEFORE.
NO WE'RE NOT BECAUSE THAT HE
HELD IN COMMITTEE SORRY ABOUT
THAT WE'RE NOW MOVING TO ITEMS
THREE THIS IS SB FORTY THREE DO
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A TWO ONE
MISSING CHEST.
HERTZBERG RECRUIT GRANT RICARDO
[inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN KNOWN WIENER.
WIENER IDEA FOR TWO THAT IS --
OUR FINAL VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE WITH THE
FOUR TWO CURRENTLY WE NEED A
MOTION FOR ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB.
FORTY FIVE WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR WIENER THIS IS A DO
PASSED YOU APPROPRIATIONS
MESSENGER SIR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MCGUIRE BY WHY I'M MORE A
LOT.
MORE LIKE NOBEL.
I HERTZBERG BY CHRIS REGARD FOR
TOM.
HELLO I NIELSEN.
THIS IS NO WINNER.
WE ARE ALL RIGHT.
RAISING GERMAN AT THAT IS THE
FINAL VOTE FIVE TWO THAT BILL IS
OUT OPPOSE THE ROLE WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE
FIFTY FIFTY ONE THIS CURRENT AND
IT'S OUT EXCUSE ME -- WE'RE
CLOSING THE ROLE AND ITEM NUMBER
FIVE IS.
TWO FIFTY ONE WE'RE NOW MOVING
TO ITEM SB WELL I'VE NEVER SEVEN
SP ONE THIRTY NINE CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A FOR TWO HAS A DO PASSES
IMAGE APPROPRIATIONS MISSING
CHESTER RICARDO.
RICARDO I BY FIVE TO THAT BILL
IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB ONE SEVENTY
FIVE CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE
ZERO THIS IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS MISSING CHESTER
MORLOCK.
MOORLACH NO.
HERTZBERG HIGH REGARD HER TITLE
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
OKAY NIELSEN.
NO NO NO YOU HAVE A TWENTY ONE
THAT IS A FOUR TO VOTE FINAL
VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT WORKERS A
ROLL ITEM NUMBER NINE SB. TWO
FORTY ONE TWO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENTLY ENJOYS
A FOUR ZERO MUSLIM CHESTER
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG GUY WHO TARA.
HELLO I NIELSEN.
THIS AND I SEVEN SEVEN ZERO
BIPARTISAN VOTE THERE YOU GO
MISTER VICE CHAIR THAT BILL IS
OUT AND WE'RE CLOSED THE ROLE.
ITEM NUMBER HìNH SB TWO NINETY
THREE DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR -- ALONG WITH A
FLOOR AMENDMENT THAT WILL BE
TAKEN ON THE SENATE FLOOR --
MISSING CHESTER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL TO FIVE YOUR VOTE CURRENTLY
MORLOCK.
NIELSEN.
YES I SIX SIX ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT WE'RE CLOSE IN THE ROLE.
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN SB FIVE THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN DO PASSES THE
MANAGER PREPARATIONS CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A THREE ZERO MISS
LANCHESTER WARLOCK.
WARLOCK GUIDE HERTZBERG.
AS FOR GUY HER CONDO.
HELLO I NIELSEN.
THIS IS NICE AND SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSE.
AND IN THE FOURTEEN IS BEFORE
SEVENTY FIVE DO PASSES AMENDED
TO PREPARATIONS CURRENT ENJOYS A
FIVE ZERO VOTE MISS WINCHESTER
[inaudible]
RICARDO.
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NOW.
THEN.
BY ONE FIVE ONE VOTE THAT BILL
IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN SB FIVE
THIRTY ONE DO PASSES AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR CURRENT ENJOYS
A THREE ZERO VOTE MISS LANCASTER
MARLATT.
MORLOCK GUY HERTZBERG FIRST
REGARDING HER TITLE.
I DON'T KNOW NIELSEN.
THIS IS ANOTHER BY TWO FIVE TWO
VOTE.
THAT BILL IS OUT WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE WHEN I WAS GOING TO SB SIX
NINETY NINE CURRENTLY JOYS A
THREE ZERO VOTE.
THIS IS DUE PASS APPROPRIATIONS
MISSING JUST MORE WHAT.
MOORLACH GUY HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
GUY HER TITLE.
I NIELSEN.
IS THE NINE SEVEN SEVEN ZERO
VOTE THAT BILL IS THAT WERE
CLOSE THE ROLE NOW MOVING ON TO
ITEM.
NINETEEN SB SEVEN THIRTY TO DO
PASSES MANY TO PREPARATIONS
CURRENT ENJOYS A FOUR ONE VOTE
MISS LANCASTER FOR CARGO.
YOUR TOTAL NO NIELSEN.
JUST A NOTE OF THAT SO. THREE
FOUR THREE THAT WAS A SQUEAKER
EVERYBODY.
MY GOODNESS FOUR THREE THAT BILL
IS OUR CLOSING THE ROLE.
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER. TWENTY NUMBER EYES SB
SEVEN FIFTY ONE TO PASS
[inaudible]
HI. SEVEN ZERO VOTE BIPARTISAN
THERE WE GO.
THAT BILL IS OUT WILL CLOSE IN
THE ROLE.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE SB SEVEN
SEVENTY TWO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENTLY ENJOYS
A THREE ZERO SITE JESTER WARLOCK.
WARLOCK GUY HERTZBERG RECEBER
GUY HER TITLE.
HELLO I NIELSEN.
YES NINE SEVEN LOOK AT
BIPARTISAN THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE.
I REMEMBER TWENTY SIX SCA THREE
BE A JOB MOTIONS TO BE TOUGH TO
DO ELECTIONS A CONSTITUTIONAL
LIMITS CURRENT ENJOYS A THREE
ZERO SITE CHESTER MARK.
MOORLACH NO.
HERTZBERG HIGH RIDGE ROAD I I
NIELSEN.
THIS IS NO FIVE TWO FIVE EIGHT
TWO THAT BILL IS OUT WE ARE.
CLOSING THE ROLE.
FINALLY -- ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN SCA FIVE YOU -- TO MOTION
IS B. DOT TO DO ELECTIONS A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ZERO
INTEREST MORE A LOT.
MORE WORK NOW HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG GUY HER TITLE.
YOUR TOTAL NO NIELSEN.
YES AND NO FOUR THREE FOUR THREE
ANOTHER SQUEAKER EVERYBODY THAT
BILL IS ALOT IT WE ARE CLOSE IN
THE ROLE.
I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE TEAM FROM
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE THIS WAS
A A LOT OF HEAVY LIST HERE THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
JUST A REMINDER TO THE COMMITTEE --
WE GOT ALONG ONE ACTUALLY GOT
BETTER IT GOT BETTER EARLIER
TODAY SO -- IT'S PROBABLY GONNA
BE LIKE A SIX OR A SIX HOUR --
HEARING -- IT NEXT WEEK SO --
BUT NOT AS BAD AS THE NINE THAT
WE THOUGHT THIS MORNING FACING
GERMAN THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU TO THE SERGEANTS FOR ALL THE
WORK T